welcome aspiring ethical hackers and
curious minds to the ultimate journey
into the fascinating world of cyber
security in this comprehensive ethical
hacker full course we will delve into
the realm of ethical hacking where we
will learn the art of securing digital
Landscapes while keeping the digital
world safe from malicious intent whether
you are a beginner or an experienced
Tech Enthusiast this course is designed
to equip you with the skills and
knowledge needed to become a proficient
ethical hacker so let's embark on this
adventure together as we unravel the
secrets of ethical hacking and Empower
ourselves with the tools to protect and
defend and before we begin if you're
someone who is interested in building a
career in cyber security or to become an
ethical hacker by graduating from the
best universities or a professional who
elicits to switch career with cyber
security or ethical hacker by learning
from the experts then try giving a short
to Simply Lars postgraduate program in
cyber security with with modules from
MIT schwarzman College of computing the
course link is mentioned in the
description box below that will navigate
you to the course page where you can
find a complete overview of the program
being offered now let's take a minute to
hear from our Learners who have
experienced massive success by opting
out these courses hi I'm Phillip I'm 61
years old and last year I upskill with
simply learns postgraduate program in
cyber security after working 30 years in
the it sector and various different
profiles I'm happy to tell you that I
was able to clear and pass my cissp and
ccsp certification exams on the first
attempt after taking the course course I
must say was packed with practical
examples it was led by highly skilled
certified instructors with many
companies before security analyst and
the architect on a contract basis but I
needed some stability which I got with
the job I just started with infosis as a
cyber security consultant happened on
the first and if these are the types of
videos you would like to watch then hit
the Subscribe button like and press on
the Bell icon to never miss on any
future content so stay tuned with us
until end of this video and don't forget
to register your opinion in the comment
section below meet an she often shops
from www. shoppingcart
docomo free shopping experience the
required information is stored in a
server one day an received an email
which stated her eligibility for a
special discount voucher from shopping
cart.com in order to receive the coupon
code she was asked to fill in her
shopping cart.com account credentials
this didn't seem fishy to her at the
time as she thought it was just an
account verification step little did she
realize the danger she would be facing
she was knocked off her feet when a
substantial amount of money was wiped
off her account how do you think this
happened well yes the email she received
was fake ANS shopping cart.com account
witnessed unauthorized access from a
third party this type of attack is known
as a Cyber attack and the person who
carries it out is called a hacker could
an have prevented this attack indeed she
could have with the help of cyber
security cyber security involves
techniques that help in securing various
digital components networks data and
computer systems from unauthorized
digital access there are multiple ways
to implement cyber security depending on
the kind of network you are connected to
and the type of cyber attacks you are
prone to so let's take a look at the
various cyber attacks that an could have
been exposed to one of the most common
types of cyber attacks is a malware
attack like Trojan adwar and spyware to
name a few had Anne downloaded any
suspicious attachments online her sister
could have gotten corrupted by certain
malicious viruses embedded within the
attachments next is a fishing attack the
type of Cyber attack which an
experienced here the hacker usually
sends fraudulent emails which appear to
be coming from a legitimate Source this
is done to install malware or to steal
sensitive data like credit card
information and login
credentials another type of attack is
the man in the middle attack here the
hacker gains access to the information
path between Ann's device and the
website server the Hacker's computer
takes over Ann's IP address by doing so
the communication line between an and
the website is secretly intercepted this
commonly happens with unsecured Wi-Fi
networks and also through malware
password attack is one of the easiest
ways to hack a system here an's password
could have been cracked by using either
common passwords or trying all possible
alphabetical combinations to prevent
future cyber attacks an sought to
implement a few cyber security practices
first she installed a firewall as the
name suggests it is a virtual wall
between Ann's computer and the internet
firewalls filter the incoming and
outgoing traffic from your device to
safeguard your network and they can
either be software applications or
Hardware reinforcements secondly and
implemented honeypots just like how
flowers attract bees dummy computer
systems called Honeypot
are used to attract attackers these
systems are made to look vulnerable in
order to deceive attackers and this in
turn defends the real system in addition
to these she also decided to use unique
alpha numeric passwords antivirus
software and started avoiding males from
unknown senders that was Ann's story
cyber attacks are not just confined to
individuals but also to public and
private organizations the cyber attacks
carried out in such places Es are more
deadly and they result in colossal
losses motives of such attacks are many
starting from tampering with crucial
data to monetary gains let's have a look
at a few of the cyber attacks that
companies are subjected to various
public sector organizations and large
corporations face the advanced
persistent threat a in this form of
attack hackers gain access to networks
for a prolonged period in order to
continuously gain confidential
information
companies also witness the denial of
service attack where networks are
flooded with traffic which in turn
leaves legitimate service request
unattended a variant of this is the
distributed denial of service DDOS
attack when multiple systems are used to
launch the attack when a hacker
manipulates a standard SQL query in a
database driven website it is known as a
SQL injection attack by doing so hackers
can view edit and delete tables from
databases amidst a plethora of cyber
attacks it is indeed a challenge for
organizations with several networks and
servers to ensure complete Security this
is not an easy task and to help with
this cyber Security Professionals are
hired to work on identifying cyber
threats and securing a company's Network
there are multiple job roles in the
field of cyber security if hacking
fascinates you then the role of an
ethical hacker is something to be
explored such professionals try to exp a
Network's vulnerabilities just like how
a hacker would do but only to identify
those vulnerabilities and resolve them
for protection against an actual Cyber
attack but if you are looking to design
robust security structures then the role
of a security architect is more apt a
chief information security officer ciso
plays a crucial role in Enterprise
security and is entrusted with the
overall safety of the information in an
organization so here's a question for
you identify the type of Cyber attack
where the hacker system takes over the
client's IP address a DDOS attack B man
in the middle attack c fishing attack d
password attack give it a thought and
leave your answers in the comments
section below three lucky winners will
receive Amazon gift vouchers with the
increase in the production of global
Digital Data it is anticipated that
cyber attacks will quadruple in the near
future organizations are going to need
cyber security professionals who can
prevent these attacks a career in the
field of cyber security is lucrative and
a very smart decision for professionals
now we humans are highly tech-savvy in
today's times with the extensive use of
the internet and modern Technologies
there is a massive challenge in
protecting all our Digital Data such as
net banking information account
credentials and medical reports to name
a few have you heard about the Dead want
a cry ransomware attack the attack
happened in May 2017 in Asia and then it
spread across the world within a day
more than 230,000 computers were
infected across 150 countries the oneac
cry crypto worm encrypted the data and
locked the users out of their systems
for decryption of the data the users
were asked for a ransom of $ 3 to $600
in Bitcoin the users who used the
unsupported version of Microsoft Windows
and and those who hadn't installed the
security update of April 2017 were
targeted in this attack the one a cry
attack took a tool on every sector top
tier organizations like Itachi Nissan
and FedEx had to put their businesses on
hold as their systems were affected too
now this is what you call a Cyber attack
to prevent such attacks cyber security
is implemented we can Define cyber
security as the practice of protecting
networks programs computer systems sys
and their components from unauthorized
digital attacks these illegal attacks
are often referred to as hacking hacking
refers to exploiting weaknesses in a
computer network to obtain unauthorized
access to information a hacker is a
person who tries to hack into computer
systems this is a misconception that
hacking is always wrong there are
hackers who work with different motives
let's have a look at three different
types of hackers black hat hackers are
individuals who illegally hack into a
system for a monetary gain on the
contrary we have white hat hackers who
exploit the vulnerabilities in a system
by hacking into it with permission in
order to defend the organization this
form of hacking is absolutely legal and
ethical hence they are also often
referred to as ethical hackers in
addition to these hackers we also have
the grey hat hackers as the name
suggests the color gray is a blend of
both white and black these hackers
discover vulnerabilities in a system and
report it to the system's owner which is
a good act but they do this without
seeking the owner's approval sometimes
greyh hat hackers also ask for money in
return for the spotted
vulnerabilities now that you have seen
the different types of hackers let's
understand more about the hacking that
is legal and valid ethical hacking
through an interesting story Dan runs a
Trading Company he does online training
with the money his customers invest
everything was going well and Dan's
business was booming until a hacker
decided to hack the company's servers
the hacker stole the credentials of
various trading accounts he asked for a
lump some Ransom in exchange for the
stolen credentials Dan took the Hacker's
words lightly and didn't pay the hacker
as a result the hacker withdrew money
from various customers accounts and Dan
was liable to pay back the customers Dan
lost a lot of money and also the trust
of his customers after this incident Dan
man gave a lot of thought as to what
could have gone wrong with the security
infrastructure in his company he wished
there was someone from his company who
could have run a test attack to see how
vulnerable systems were before the
hacker penetrated into the network this
was when he realized he needed an
employee who thinks like a hacker and
identifies the vulnerabilities in his
Network before an outsider does to do
this job he hired an ethical hacker John
JN was a skilled professional who worked
precis icely like a hacker in no time he
spotted several vulnerabilities in Dan's
organization and closed all the
loopholes hiring an ethical hacker
helped Dan protect his customers from
further attacks in the future this in
turn increased the company's
productivity and guarded the company's
reputation so now you know hacking is
not always bad JN in this scenario
exposed the vulnerabilities in the
existing Network and such hacking is
known as ethical hacking ethical hacking
is distributed into six different phases
let us look at these phases step by step
with respect to how John our ethical
hacker will act before launching an
attack the first step Jon takes is to
gather all the necessary information
about the organization's system that he
intends to attack this step is called
reconnaissance he uses tools like inmap
and hping for this purpose JN then tries
to spot the vulnerabilities if any in
the Target system using tools like in
map and Expos this is the scanning phase
now that he has located the
vulnerabilities he then tries to exploit
them this step is known as gaining
access after JN makes his way through
the organization's networks he tries to
maintain his access for future attacks
by installing back doors in the Target
system the Metasploit tool helps him
with this this phase is called
maintaining access JN is a brilliant
hacker hence he tries his best not to
leave any evidence of his attack this is
the fifth phase clearing tracks we now
have the last phase that is reported in
this phase Jon documents a summary of
his entire attack the vulnerabilities he
spotted the tools he used and the
success rate of the attack looking into
the report Dan is now able to take a
call and see how to protect his
organization from any external cyber
attacks don't you all think John is an
asset to any organization if you want to
become an ethical hacker like John then
there are a few skills that you need to
acquire first and foremost you need to
have a good knowledge of operating
environments such as Windows Linux Unix
and Macintosh you must have reasonably
good knowledge of programming languages
such as HTML PHP python SQL and
JavaScript networking is the base of
ethical hacking hence you should be good
at it ethical hackers should be well
aware of security laws so that they
don't misuse their skills finally you
must have a global certification on
ethical hacking to successfully bag a
position of an ethical hacker like John
few examples of ethical hacking
certification are certified ethical
hacker certification C CompTIA pentest
plus and licensed penetration tester
certification to name a few simply learn
provides a cyber security expert master
program that will equip you with all the
skills required by a cyber security
expert you could have a look at it by
clicking the link in the description so
here's a question for you in which phase
of ethical hacking will you install back
doors in the Target system a scanning B
maintaining access C clearing tracks D
reconnaissance give it a thought and
leave your answers in the comment
section below three lucky winners will
receive Amazon gift vouchers the endless
growth of Technologies in this area is
directly proportional to the number of
cyber crimes cyber crimes are estimated
to cost $6 trillion in 2021 hence to
tackle these cyber crimes organizations
are continuously on the lookout for
cyber Security Professionals the average
annual salary of a certified ethical
hacker is $91,000 in the US and
approximately rupes 7 lakhs in India so
what are you waiting for get certified
and become an ethical hacker like John
and put an end to the cyber attacks in
the world data is the new goal imagine
how much data is generated by just your
smartphone every single day be the
pictures you click or the messages you
send nearly 41 million messages are sent
worldwide via WhatsApp every single
minute so safeguarding your personal
data against hackers has now become a
top priority did you know that India
leads the world when it comes to ethical
hackers with 23% of the world worldwide
hacking population from India the top
ethical hackers earn more than twice of
what software engineers in India do but
what makes ethical hacking such a
demanding industry ethical hacking is
the process of taking security measures
to safeguard data and networks from
malicious cyber attacks the hackers use
every tool at their disposal to try and
breach the security barrier and find any
potential vulnerabilities the ethical
and ethical hacking denotes the lack of
malicious intent since these sessions
are often permitted by the system owner
or the Network that is being hacked into
to fix any compromised entry points
before black hat hackers discover and
exploit them so what is a black hat
hacker you may ask a hacker who exploits
security vulnerabilities from monetary
gains like stealing or destroying
private data altering disrupting or
shutting down websites and networks is
known as a blackhead hacker on the other
end of the spectrum we have whad hackers
who help people secure the networks by
stress testing the platform against the
most dangerous of cyber attacks that is
with their consent of course but the
most neutral of the bunch are grayhead
hackers who may not ask for consent
before snooping on a foreign system but
they do inform the owner if they find
any vulnerabilities sometimes in
exchange for a small fee the security
breaches have become less and less
prevalent thanks to rigorous ethical
hacking campaigns and corporate
awareness programs the ability to fix
critical security issues before blackout
hackers leverage them has saved
organizations billions of dollars Google
IBM Microsoft and virtually every major
corporation are looking to protect the
data so it shouldn't come as a surprise
that ethical hacking and information
security job market is set to rise by
nearly 28% by 2026 with salaries going
as high as
$225,000 perom so that's ethical hacking
wrapped up in 2 minutes to catch more
bite size and detailed videos on
different Technologies subscribe to
Simply learn and stay updated in today's
digital age where cyber threats Loom
large understanding ethical hacking is
crucial by developing into the world of
ethical hacking you gain a deep
comprehension of hacker techniques and
vulnerabilities which will enable you to
strengthen your security measures with
the demand for cyber Security
Professionals soaring learning ethical
hacking opens doors to wide range of
exciting career opportunities moreover
it empowers you to protect your personal
data and privacy while staying one step
ahead of evolving cyber threats by
embracing ethical hacking responsibility
you contribute to a safer digital
environment enhance problem solving
skills and Foster continuous growth get
ready to embark on an exciting journey
into the realm of ethical hacking and
discover its immense value in today's
interconnected world and if you are
someone who's interested in building a
career in cyber security by graduating
from the best universities or a
professional who elects to switch
careers with cyber security by learning
from the experts then try giving a shot
to Simply learns postgraduate program in
cyber security from Schwan's College of
computing in collaboration with EC
counil the link in the description box
page where you can find a complete
overview of the program being offered
take action up skill and get ahead but
before we begin if these are the type of
videos you would like subscribe button
and click on the Bell to never miss an
update from Simply Le without further
Ado let's get started with understanding
why you must learn ethical hacking there
are a wide variety of reasons of why to
learn ethical hacking let's discuss the
important ones firstly cyber security
awareness next strengthen security
measures career opportunities protection
of personal data awareness of cyber
threats ethical use of skills problem
solving and continuous learning now that
we have few important reasons let's
discuss each one of these important
reasons in a bit more detail firstly
cyber security awareness learning about
ethical hacking provides you with a deep
understanding of the techniques and
methods used by hackers this knowledge
helps you identify vulnerabilities in
your computer systems networks and
applications enabling you to better
protect them the next one is
strengthening security measures by
learning ethical hacking you can
actively contribute to improving the
security of computer systems ethical
hackers often identify weaknesses in
organizations networks and provide
recommendations for enhancing security
measures followed by that we have career
opportunities the field of cybering and
there is a high demand for skilled
professionals by acquiring knowledge of
ethical hacking you can open up various
career opportunities in Industries such
as it security Consulting penetration
testing and incidence response next
ahead we have protection of personal
data understanding ethical hacking
techniques empowers you to safeguard
your personal data with privacy you can
Implement security measures to protect
your devices online accounts and
sensitive information from potential
attacks awareness of cyber threats is
the next one on the list the digital
landscape is constantly evolving and new
threats emerge regularly learning
ethical hacking helps you stay up toate
with the latest cyber threats attack
vectors and vulnerabilities enabling you
to proactive your measures to mitigate
the risks followed by that we have
ethical use of skills ethical hacking
emphasizes the responsible and legal use
of hacking techniques by learning
ethical hacking you gain the knowledge
of the ethical guidelines and legal
boundaries associated with cyber
security this ensures that your skills
are utilized for positive purposes
protecting individuals and organiz I
ations from malicious attacks next on
the list is problem solving skills
ethical hacking requires critical
thinking problem solving and analytical
skills through learning ethical hacking
you develop a systematic approach to
identifying and solving complex security
issues which can be valuable in various
aspects of life and other technical
domains next and the L is continuous
learning and growth cyber security is a
dynamic field that demands continuous
learning to keep up with evolving cyber
threats learning ethical hacking ensures
that you remain engaged on ongoing
education and skill development
fostering personal and professional
growth now let's get into the important
aspect of today's tutorial that as
salary details for a certified ethical
hacker in the United States of America
the salary of an ethical hacker can be
based on various factors such as
experience skill level Loc ation
industry and the organization they work
for generally ethical hackers in USA
tend to earn higher salaries than other
countries due to the demand for cyber
Security Professionals entry-level
positions may start around $60 to
$80,000 perom while experienced
professionals with Advanced
certifications and specialized skills
can earn salaries exceeding
$150,000 per Anum the salary of fical
hacker in India can vary depending on
factors as experience skill set location
and organization they work for on an
average a beginner level ethical hacker
in ending from 3 lakhs to six lakhs per
anom as they gain more experience and
expertise their salary can increase
significantly experien ethical hackers
with several years of experience and
advanced certifications can earn
salaries ranging from 8 to 20 lakhs or
more annually now proceeding with the
company's hiring ethical hackers several
companies hire ethical hackers to
enhance their cyber security defenses
and protect their systems here are some
prominent companies known for hiring
ethical hackers Google Facebook
Microsoft Apple Amazon IBM Cisco Intel
deoe and evi are the most prominent ones
the topics that we are going to discuss
in this video are what exactly hacking
is the types of hackers the
classifications what is ethical hacking
the skills that are required of an
ethical hacker the process that is
utilized by ethical hackers in their
daily activities and then lastly we're
going to discuss cryptography so let's
talk about hacking and what exactly
hacking is hacking refers to exploiting
weaknesses in a computer network to
obtain unauthorized access to
information a hacker is a person who
tries to hack into computer systems now
here there are some key words that we
need to understand first and foremost
exploit when you're exploiting
weaknesses weaknesses are technically
called vulnerabilities which are
basically design flaws misconfiguration
errors usage of default usernames and
passwords which have not been modified
so any misconfiguration or anything that
has been left behind by a Security
administrator that can be misused which
means exploited by a hacker to gain
unauthorized access so the next term is
unauthorized access something that you
not allowed to do and when you say a
hacker is a person who tries to hack
it's basically a person with m intent
trying to gain access to a system or a
resource that they are not authorized to
access in the first place how do they do
it they find a avability that is a
weakness or a flaw and then they misuse
it to gain access to that particular
Network so here in the diagram you can
see that a sender on the left hand side
is trying to send some data to the
receiver on the right hand side the
hacker would try to gain unauthorized
access to the transmission that is being
sent and would try to capture the data
packets and read the secrets within
let's look look at a business case
scenario into hacking now there is an
organization uh everybody is going
around their own business when they
realize that their systems may have been
compromised now they're trying to look
at the customer data to ensure that that
has not been compromised and trying to
assure the customers however they do
realize that some customer data has been
lost and even the company reports have
been modified as well now this is the
scenario where there have been some
security controls in place and those
controls have been identified they
realized that there's an attack that has
happened and based on that attack they
have realized that the data has now been
compromised and the records have been
modified by the hacker which means that
the data is no longer trustworthy and
thus cannot be used by the business for
any legal transactions so then the
hacker gives a call to the organization
or gets connected to the organization
demanding a ransom for the data to be
replaced to be taken back into the
original state where it was trusted and
thus the organization can utilize it for
business transactions the organization
has probably no backup so they decide
that they want to pay the lumpsum to the
hacker to restore that data so that they
can continue on with the business does
money exchanges and the hacker is able
to restore that data and the business
continues as usual however the activity
here of a hacker trying to Leverage The
misconfiguration of the weaknesses in
the organizations security thus being
able to hack them and uh make these
Ransom demands so the company then wants
to figure out even if having a security
system in place how was the hacker able
to hack their systems thus one of the
employees comes up with a brilliant idea
of identifying vulnerabilities in the
network uh to proactively search for any
flaws that have been left behind uh so
that they can plug those flaws and
nobody can misuse them thus they figure
out that they want to hire ethical
hacker who would help them identify the
security posture of the organization
identify the weaknesses vulnerabilities
and flaws and help them remedy those
flaws so that in future scenarios these
scenarios will not happen so before we
go into an ethical hacker let's
understand what are the types of hackers
so what are the types of hackers hacker
is a technically skilled person uh who
is very Adept with computers they have
good programming skills they understand
how operating system works they
understand how networks work they
understand how to identify flaws and
vulnerabilities within all of these
aspects and then they
understand and know how to misuse these
flaws to get a outcome which would be
detrimental to the health of the
organization so there's six type of
hackers that have been identified black
hat hackers white hat hackers gray hat
script kitties Nations sponsored hackers
and a activists so blackhead hackers are
Bas basically uh the malicious hackers
who have malicious intent and have
criminalistic Tendencies they want to
harm the organization by hacking into
their infrastructure by by destroying
their infrastructure by destroying their
data so that uh they can gain from it
from a monetary perspective uh these
guys are also known as crackers the main
aspect of these uh people are that they
have malicious intent they try to do
unauthorized activities and they try it
for personal gain another important
aspect to remember is that a black hat
hacker will always try to hide their
identity uh they will spoof their online
digital identity by masking it by
spoofing their IP addresses Mac
addresses and try to remain anonymous on
the network why hacker on the other hand
is also an ethical hacker or a security
analyst who's an individual who will do
exactly the same thing that a blackhead
hacker would do minus the malicious
intent plus the intent of helping the
organization identifying the flaws and
remedying them so that nobody else can
misuse those vulnerabilities so they are
authorized to act on the company's
behalf they are authorized to do that
activity which would help the company
identify those flaws and thus help the
company mitigate those flaws improving
on their security posture so these uh
these kind of Security Experts or
ethical hackers would help organizations
defend themselves against unauthorized
attacks gry hat hackers is a blend of
both white hat and black hat hackers so
here they can work defensively and
offensively both they can accept
contracts from organizations to increase
their security posture at the same time
they can also get themselves involved in
malicious activities towards other
organizations to personally gain or
benefit from them by doing unauthorized
activity script kitties are people uh
who are technically not much aware about
what hacking is uh they rely on existing
tools that have been created by other
hackers they have no technical knowledge
of what they're doing it's just a hit or
miss for them so they just get their
hands on a tool they try to execute
those tools uh if the hack works it
works otherwise it doesn't so these
people are basically who are noobs or
newbies who are trying to learn hacking
or uh just uh people who with malicious
intent who just want to have some fun or
trying to impress people around then we
have the nation or the state sponsored
hackers as the name suggest these
hackers are sponsored by their
government now this may not be a
legitimate job but most of the
governments do have hackers uh enrolled
in their pay on um on their uh
organizations to spy on their enemies to
spy on various countries and try to
figure out uh the aspirations of those
countries so this is basically a spying
activity where you technically trying to
get access to other Count's resources
and then try to spy on them to figure
out what their activities have been or
what their future plans have been and
then we have the activists who is an
individual who has a political agenda to
promote and they promote it by doing
hacking so uh these guys what is the
difference between a black hat hacker
and a activist the blackhe Hat hacker
may try to hide their identity a
activist will claim responsibility of
what they have done so for them it's a
political agenda political cause and
they will try to hack various
organizations to promote their cause
they would probably do this by defacing
the website and posting the messages
that they want to promote on these
websites so what exactly is ethical
hacking then we have discussed the types
of hackers we have identified a
malicious hacker as a black hat hacker
with the intent uh of doing harm to an
organization's Network for personal gain
we have discussed what the ethical
hacker is so an ethical hacker would be
doing the same activity but in a
authorized manner so they would have
legal contracts that they would be
signing with the organization it would
give them a definite scope of what
they're allowed to do and what they are
not allowed to do and the ethical
hackers would function within those
Scopes would try to execute those test
scenarios where they would be able to
identify those flaws or those system
vulnerabilities and then they would be
submitting a report to the management of
what they have found they would also
help the management to mitigate or to
resolve those weaknesses so that nobody
else can misuse them later on they might
use the same techniques and the same
tools that blackhe hat hackers do
however the main difference here is that
these guys are authorized to do that
particular activity they're doing it in
a controlled manner with the intent of
helping the organization and not with
the intent of personal gains so who's an
ethical hacker again ethical hacker is a
highly intelligent Highly Educated
person who knows how computers function
how programming languages work how
operating systems work they can
troubleshoot they're technically very
Adept at Computing they understand the
architecture they understand uh how
various components in a computer work
they can troubleshoot those components
and they can basically be uh very good
with programming as well now when I say
programming we don't want the ethical
hacker to be a good developer of
applications we want them to understand
programming in such a way that they can
create scripts they can write their own
short programs like viruses worms
Trojans or exploits which would help
them achieve the objective that they
have set out for so uh here you can see
the ethical hacker they individuals who
perform a security assessment of their
companies with the permission of cons
concerned authorities so what is a
security assessment a security
assessment is finding out the exact
security posture of the organization by
identifying what security controls are
in place how they have been configured
and if there are any gaps in the
configurations themselves so an
organization will hire an ethical hacker
they they would give the ethical hacker
the information about what information
is or what security controls what
firewalls what idss ipss Inogen
detection or intrusion prevention
systems antiviruses are already in place
and then they will ask the ethical
hacker to figure out a way to to bypass
these mechanisms and see if they can
still hack the organization what is the
need of an ethical hacker the need of an
ethical hacker is proactive security the
ethical hacker would identify all the
existing flaws in an organization and
try to resolve those flaws to help
secure the organization from blackhe hat
hackers so ethical hackers would prevent
Hackers from cracking into an
organization's Network by securing the
organization by improving on their
security on a periodic basis and they
would also try to identify if system
vulnerabilities Network vulnerabilities
or application Level vulnerabilities
that would have been missed or have
already been missed and then tried to
figure out a way of plugging them or uh
resolving them so that they cannot be
misused by other hackers they would also
analyze and enhance an organization
security policies now what are policies
policies are basically documents that
have been created by an organization of
rules that all the employees need to
follow to ensure that the security of an
organization is maintained for example a
password policy a password policy would
help users in an organization to adhere
to the standards the organization has
identified for a password complexity for
example a password when a user is
creating them should adhere to standards
where they are using random words they
are they contain the alphabet A through
Zed uppercase and lowercase 0 through 9
as numerics and special characters and
they're randomized so that the password
becomes more more stronger to prevent
from Brute Force attacks so what would
an ethical hacker do at the at this
point in time they would try to test the
strength of the passwords to see if
Brute Force attacks or dictionary
attacks are possible and if any of these
passwords can be cracked they would
ensure that all the employees are
following the policies and all the
passwords are are as secured as the
policies want them to be if there are
any gaps in the policies or the
implementation of the policy it is the
ethical hacker responsibility to
identify those gaps and want the
organization about it similarly they
would also try to protect any personal
information any data that is by the
organization that is critical for the
functioning of the organization and
they'll try to protect it by from
falling into the Hacker's hands now what
are the skills that are required of an
ethical hacker these are the following
skills so first and foremost they should
have good knowledge with operating
systems such as Windows Linux Unix and
Mac now when we say knowledge about
operating systems it's not only about
how to use those operating systems but
how to troubleshoot those operating
systems how these operating systems work
how these operating systems need to be
configured how can they be secured for
example securing an operating system is
not only installing a firewall and an
antivirus but you need to configure
permissions on an operating system of
what users are allowed to do and what
users are not allowed to do for example
limiting the installation of
applications how are we going to do that
we need to go into the system center the
security Center of Windows and we need
to configure security parameters over
there of what are acceptable softwares
and what are not same with Linux and uh
Mac softwares operating systems so we
need to know how we can secure these
operating systems similarly all of these
would have desktop versions and server
versions of operating systems as a
ethical hacker we need to know the
desktop and server versions both how to
configure them and how to provide
services within the organization on
these servers so that they can be
consumed in a secure manner by all the
employees at the same time they should
also be knowledgeable of programming
languages or scripting languages such as
PHP python Ruby HTML for programming if
you will because web servers come into
the picture so again they should not be
great developers where they can create
huge applications but they should be
able to develop scripts understand those
scripts analyze those scripts and figure
out what the output should be of those
scripts to achieve the hacking goals
that they have set out for an ethical
hacker should have a very good
understanding about networking no matter
whether you're in application security
you're in network security or you're in
host Bas security since a computer will
always be connected to a network Network
either a local area network like a lan
or the internet we should know how
networking works we should know the
seven layers of the OSI model we should
know which protocols work on those seven
layers we should identify the tcpip
model and how OSI model can be mapped to
the tcpip model we should understand how
TCP and UDP work how uh how each and
every protocol is crafted how they are
supposed to behave for us to analy and
understand any network-based attacks we
should be very good in security measures
so we should should know where those
vulnerabilities would lie what are the
latest exploits available in the market
and we should be able to identify them
we should be able to know the techniques
and the tools of how to deal with
security how to analyze security and
then how to implement security to
enhance it as well along with that it is
important that a security analyst or
ethical hacker is aware of the local
security laws and standards why is that
because an organization cannot do any
illegal activity whatever responses that
they have whatever security me
mechanisms whatever security controls
they will Implement they need to be
adhering to the local law of the land
they should be legal in nature and
should not cause undue harm to any of
the employees or any of the third party
clients that they are dealing with so
the ethical hackers should be aware of
what security laws are before they
Implement security controls or even
before they start testing for security
controls and all of these should be
backed up by having a global
certification or a globally valid
certification related to networking
related to security it ethical hacking
the law of the land anything and
everything maybe even programming uh
it's good to have a certification in PHP
Pearl python Ruby and so on so forth why
because most of the organizations when
they hire ethical hackers look out for
these certifications especially globally
valid certifications so that they can be
sure or they can be assured that the
person that they are hiring has the
required skill set so let's talk about a
few of the tools that a ethical hacker
would utilize uh in their testing
scenarios to be honest there are
hundreds of tools out there what you see
on the screen are just a few examples of
them uh nessus is a vulnerability
scanner what is a vulnerability scanner
it is an automated tool that is designed
to identify vulnerabilities within hosts
within uh operating systems within
networks so they come with their rade
databases of all the vulnerabilities
that have already been identified and
they scan the network against that
database to find out any possible flaws
or any possible vulnerabilities that
currently exist exist on the host or the
operating system or on the network
similarly there would be application
scanners like actic or Arachne that
would help you scan applications and
identify flaws within those applications
as well now all of these are automated
tools the essense of ethical hacker is
when these tools churn out the reports
the ethical haer hacker can understand
these reports analyze them identify the
flaws and then craft their own exploits
or use existing exploits in a particular
manner so that they can get access or
they can bypass the access security
controls mechanisms that are already in
place how can they do that with the tool
called metas sploid you see that Big M
there on the right hand side that M logo
is for a tool called Metasploit which is
a penetration testing tool what is a
penetration testing tool it is that tool
that will allow a ethical hacker to
craft their exploits or choose their
exploits for the vulnerabilities that
have been identified by nessus since we
are interacting with computers we will
always be interacting using tools right
so the first tool NS identifies the
flaws and the possible list of
vulnerabilities we do a penetration test
using Metasploit to validate those flaws
and to verify that those flaws actually
exist and try to figure out the
complexity of those flaws and that's
where metas helps us do that wire Shar
would be used in the background while
you're are doing both the activities
using nessus or metas sploit to keep a
track of what packets are being sent and
by received on the network which will
help us analyze those packets so
whenever I run NS scanner I would run a
y shock in the background it will
capture the data packets and I can go
through those data packets and analyze
that data packets to identify what
nesses is actually trying to do
similarly when I try to attack a machine
using exploit on metas exploit I will
keep on wire shock running in the
background to capture the data packets
that have been sent and the responses
that I've received from the victim so
that I can also go through those packets
and analyze the responses and analyze
the attack whether it was successful to
what extent was it successful and
basically will also give me a validation
a proof of the activity that has
happened nmap is another automated tool
that allows me to scan for open ports
and protocols so why would I use nmap
because Pro ports and protocols become
an entry point for a hacker to gain
access to devices for example when we
connect to a web server we connect
through a web browser but we
automatically connect to Port 80 using
HTTP and Port 443 using https so if I'm
connecting to a web server using https
it is safe to assume that Port 443 on
the web server is open to accept those
connections similarly there would be
other services that may be left open on
the web server because nobody thought
about configuring it or they
misconfigured the web server and they
left unwanted Services running so nmap
will allow me to scan those ports and
services and allow me to understand what
services are being offered on that
server so then I can start analyzing
that server identify those flaws within
those services and then try to attack
them if the application that I'm
analyzing is connected to a database and
I want to do a SQL injection attack or
if I if nessus tells me that there's a
SQL injection attack that may be
possible on that particular application
I can use an automated tool called SQL
map or SQL map that would allow me to
automatically craft all the queries that
are required for a SQL injection attack
and help me do that attack at the same
time so here I do not have to manually
create my own queries uh the SQL map
tool would automatically create them for
me what I would do is I would use nessus
to identify that particular flaw if
nessus reports that flaw I would then go
use the tool SQL map configure it to
attack that particular web server and
when I fire off the tool it will then
automatically start directing queries
SQL injection queries to the database to
see if those uh databases are vulnerable
and if yes what data can be retrieved
from those databases so all of these
tools in a nutshell would help me hack
networks applications operating systems
and host devices and this is what
ethical hacker does they use these kind
of tool sets they identify what attacks
they need to do they identify the right
tool for that particular attack and they
write their exploits they create those
attacks and then they start attacking
analyze the response and then give a
report to the management uh providing
them feedback about how the attack was
created or crafted what was the response
to that attack and whether the attack
was successful or not if successful
would also give recommendations of what
to do to prevent these attacks from
happening in the future so when we are
doing these attacks or when we want to
launch these attacks what is the process
that that we would follow so there are
six steps that we would do as a ethical
hacker if you are a just a hacker you
probably wouldn't do the sixth step
which is a reporting step so the first
step that would be done is the
recognizance phase which is the
information gathering phase which is
very important from ethical hacker
perspective or a hacker's perspective
because if I want to attack someone or
something as a digital device I need to
know what I'm attacking I need to know
the IP address of the device the MAC
address of those devices I need to know
the operating system the build or the
version of that operating systems
applications on top the versions of
those applications so I know what I'm
attacking for example if I if I want to
attack a server I assume it's a Windows
based server and I use a particular tool
to attack it but it actually turns out
to be a Linux based server my attacks
are going to be unsuccessful so I need
to focus my attack based on what is
there at the other end so in my
information gathering phase I want to
identify all of that information once I
have that information done I'm going to
scan those servers using tools like nmap
that we just talked about and we're
going to try to see the open ports open
services and protocols that are running
on that server that can give me possible
entry points within the network or
within the device or within the
operating system at the same time along
with the scanning with nmap I would run
a vulnerability scanner the NS
vulnerability scanner we talked about or
acun etics for applications and then I
would try to identify vulnerabilities in
those applications operating systems or
networks once I've identified those
vulnerabilities in the scanning phase I
would then move on to the gaining phase
where I would then craft my exploits or
choose existing exploits and start
attacking the attacking the victim at
this point in time if my attack is
successful I will probably have gained
access by either cracking passwords or
escalating privileges or exploiting a v
ability that I I found during the
scanning phase once I have gained my
access I want to maintain my access why
because the vulnerability may not be
there for long maybe somebody updated
the operating system and hence the flaw
was no longer exist uh existing or
somebody changed the password that we I
may have cracked does I no longer have
access so what do I do to maintain my
access I install Trojans or backd door
entries to those systems using which I
can secretly in a covert manner get
access to those devices at my own will
at my own time as long as those devices
are available over the network so that's
where I maintain my access I have hacked
them now I want to maintain my access so
I install a software which would give me
a backd door entry to that device no
matter what once I've done this I want
to clear my track so whatever activity
that I've been doing for example
installing a Trojan a Trojan is also a
software that would create directory
directories and files once installed on
the victim's machine so I want to hide
that if I have access data stores if I
have modified data I want to hide that
activity because if the victim comes to
know that something has happened they
would start they would start increasing
their security parameters they might
start scanning their devices they may
take them offline thus my hack would no
longer be efficient the reason I'm
clearing my tracks is that the victim
doesn't find out that they have been
hacked or they have been compromised or
even if they do find out that they've
been compromised they cannot trace the
compromise back to me so I would be
deleting references of any of the IP
addresses or Mac addresses that I may
have used to attack that particular
device and the this is where I will be
able to identify where those logs were
created where those traces are once I
take off those traces the victim would
not be any visor of whether they have
been compromised or who compromised
their system and if I am successful at
all of these stages or what to whatever
extent the success that I've achieved in
any of these stages I would then create
a report based on that and I would
report to the management about the
activities that we have been able to do
and whatever we have been able to
achieve out of those activities for
example we have identified 10 different
flaws there were 20 different attacks
that we wanted to do what attack did we
do what was the outcome of that attack
what was the intended or or the expected
output of that attack I'll create a
report which would give a detailed
analysis of all the steps that were
taken along with screenshots and
evidences of what activity was conducted
what was the output what was the
expected output and I would submit that
report to the management giving them an
idea of what vulnerabilities and flaws
exist in their environment or their
devices that need to be mitigated so
that the security can be enhanced so
these are the six steps that the ethical
hacking process would take uh just going
through this the uh recognizance is
where you're going to use hiking tools
like nmap hedp to obtain information
about targets there are hundreds of
tools out there depending on what
information you want then in scanning
again n map next POS these kind of tools
to be utilized to identify open ports
protocols and services in gaining access
you're going to exploit the
vulnerability by using the metas sploit
tool that we talked about in the
previous slides in the maintaining
access you're going to install back
doors you can use metas spit at the same
time uh you can craft your own scripts
to create a Trojan and install it on the
victim's machine once you have achieved
that clearing tracks is where you're
going to clear all evidences of your
activity so that you do not get caught
or the victim doesn't even realize that
they have been hacked and once you done
all of this we going to create reports
that are going to be submitted to the
management to help them understand the
current security evaluation of their
organization so now let's see how we can
hack using social engineering now what
is social engineering social engineering
is the art of manipulating humans into
revealing confidential information which
they otherwise would not have revealed
so this is where your social skill and
your people skills come into the picture
if you're able to communicate
effectively to another person they would
probably give up more information that
they intended to give out let's look
look at examples right if you see on the
screen fishing activity what is fishing
we receive a lot of fake mails on a
regular basis we have always received
those emails where we have won a lottery
of a few million dollars but we have
never realized that we didn't purchase a
lottery to win a lottery in the first
place we have always had those Nigerian
frauds where a prince died in some South
African country and you out of 7 billion
people on the planet have been
identified where they want to transfer a
few hundred million dollar through your
account and they want to give you 50% of
that money in return as thank you so
some very basic attacks where you go on
to websites and there's a banner
flashing at you saying congratulations
you're the 1 millionth visitor to this
website click here to claim your prize
all of these are social engineering
attacks fishing attacks fake websites
fake Communications being sent out to
users to pray on their Gully Bley most
of humans always have that dream of
striking it rich winning a huge Lottery
once and for all and living their life
lavishly ever after but sadly in the
real world that's not that doesn't
happen that often and if you're
receiving those mails it is very
important that you first research the
validity of those those Communications
before you even want to act upon them so
why are humans susceptible to social
engineering because humans have emotion
machines do not try pleading with a
machine to give you access to a account
that you have forgotten a password to
the machine wouldn't even know what
you're doing try pleading with a human
sympathy or empathy where you could try
to create a social inuring attack where
you can plead with them saying if I do
not get access to this account
immediately I might lose my job and then
that would put my family into problems
somebody would feel empathy or sympathy
towards you and help you reset that
password and give you access to that
account it's how good the attack is and
how convincing you are for the success
of this attack to happen so what is a
familiarity exploit attackers interact
with victims to gain information which
will benefit the attackers to crack
credentials as passwords if we want to
reset our passwords what do we have as a
mechanism to resetting passwords we have
some security questions that we set up
those questions are nothing but personal
information that we would know but
through a social engineering attack it
would be easily be able to uh gather the
information that you have set for your
security questions the security
questions can be as simple as the first
school that you attended you probably
have that listed on your LinkedIn
profile where person can just go in
there and see your academic
qualifications and identify the school
that you in right similarly it might
also be a question what was your
mother's maiden name that's a very good
attack and that's uh I mean if a person
can interact with you let's let's say
they're trying to take a survey and they
approach you for a feedback on a
particular product that you have been
utilizing and they ask you these
questions you wouldn't think twice
before giving those answers as long as
the request sounds legitimate to us we
are able to justify that request we do
answer those queries so it's upon us to
verify the authenticity of the request
coming in before we answer it fishing as
discussed would be fraudulent emails
which appear to be coming from a trusted
source so email spoofing uh comes into
mind uh fake websites and so on so forth
exploiting human curiosity curiosity
killed the cat right so there was
there's so many physical attacks where
hackers just keep pen drives lying
around in a parking lot now this is a
open a generic attack whoever Falls
victim will fall victim so if I just
throw around a few USBS in the parking
lot obviously with Trojans implemented
on them some people who are curious or
who are looking for a couple of freebies
might take up those pen drives plug them
in the computers to see what data is on
the pen drives at the same time once
they plug in their those pen drives on
their computers the virus or the Trojan
would get infected and cause harm to
their machine then exploiting human
greed uh we just talked about the
Nigerian frauds and the lotteries those
kind of attacks the fake money-making
gimmicks now basically this is where you
pray upon the persons agreed kicking in
and they clicking on those links in
order to uh get that money that has been
promised to them in that email so one of
the safest mechanism to keep data
private and to keep yourself secure is
using encryption now encryption can
happen through cryptography what is
cryptography cryptography is the art of
scrambling data using a particular
algorithm so that the data becomes
unreadable to the normal user the only
person with the key to unscramble that
data would be able to unscramble it and
make sense out of that data so we're
just making it unreadable or
non-readable by using a particular key
or a particular algorithm and then we're
going to send the key to the end user
the end user using the uh same key would
then decrypt that data if anybody
compromises that data while it is being
sent over the network since it is
encrypted they would not be able to read
it so the encryption algorithm would be
something like this now if you see uh
the computer word once made into
unreadable format would look like EQ o r
XV GT for a end user it wouldn't make
any sense but the person who has a key
to unscramble that would be able to
convert it back to computer and
understand the meaning of that word so
this is just a substitution Cipher that
is being shown on the screen so what is
the alphabet the key is alphabet plus
three so C plus three alphabets that
becomes e o becomes q m becomes o so the
key that is utilize to scramble the data
is the character that you are at the
third character from there would be the
corresponding key so the encrypted
message is also known as a cipher the
decryption is just the other way around
where you know the key now and you can
now figure out what that e corresponded
to by going back three characters in the
alphabet most of the times a certified
ethical hacker must decrypt a message
without knowing the secret key so let's
say a ransomware has affected your
organization or has affected a device
and you want to figure out uh or you
want to decrypt that data now as ethical
hacker you wouldn't be for paying a
ransom uh to the hacker would you so it
is now your prerogative of how you're
going to work around and how you're
going to try to crack the encryption
mechanism how to crack the cipher to
decrypt that message and see what's
within it right decryption without the
use of a secret key that is known as a
crypt analysis Crypt analysis is the
reversing of an algorithm to figure out
what the decryption was uh without using
a key so Crypt analysis can be done
using various formats the first one is a
Brute Force attack second is a
dictionary attack third one is a rainbow
table attack a Brute Force attack is
trying every combination permutation and
combination of of the key to figure out
what the key was it is 100% successful
but may take a lot of time a dictionary
attack is where you have created a list
of possible encryption mechanisms a list
of possible cracks and then you tried to
figure out whether those cracks work or
not rainbow tables are where you have an
encrypted text in hand and you're trying
to figure out uh the similarities
between the text that you have and the
encrypted data that you wanted to
decrypt in the first place so in the
Brute Force attack you're trying every
possible combination permutation of what
the key would be in dictionary attack
you have a word list that would
tantamount to the key and if you're
you're trying to match all the words
listed in the text file or the word list
to see if any of those words are going
to work to decrypt that data here in the
rainbow table the cipher text is
compared with another Cipher text you
find out similarities and then you try
to work a reverse engineer your way
accordingly so let's have a quick demo
on cryptography before we be end this
session so to begin with the demo of
cryptography graphy we are on a website
called spam mic.com which will help us
scramble the message that we created
into a completely uh a format which
would be unrelated to the topic at hand
so if I say I want to encode a message
turn a short message into spam so what
this does is you want to send across a
secret message you type in The Secret
Message a short one it will convert that
into a spam mail you send it across so
whoever is reading that spam mail would
never get an idea of the embedded
message within it so if I want to type
in a message here hi this is a secret
message the password is ASD at1 234 and
I want to send this out to people or to
one of my colleagues but I want to send
it out in a secret manner so that others
are not aware of this so when I press on
encode what the algorithm would do is it
will convert this message into a spam
mail so my message hi this is a secret
message the password is atate 1 1234 or
ASD atate 1 23 before gets converted
into this now if you read it dear
e-commerce professional this letter was
specially selected to be sent to you
this doesn't make sense there is nowhere
or no reference to the actual message
that I've already said so if I copy this
entire message and I send it let's say
via email to the recipient now the thing
is that the recipient needs to know that
I've encoded it using spam mimic the
algorithm needs to remain the same so
once they know that it is Spam mimic
what they can do is now in this instance
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
open up a new browser and I'm going to
go to the same website and at this point
in time I'm going to click on decode
when I click on decode I'm going to
paste the message that I have just
copied there we are and this message is
now being copied into a different
browser and if I decode this you will
see that it will convert it back to the
original message that there was so the
key is there at spam mimic and it is
embedded within the message so whenever
we we paste the message in the decode
Factor it knows knows what the key was
and it can decrypt that message and give
me the actual message that was embedded
within it there we are the entire
message this is what we created in the
Google Chrome browser and in the Firefox
browser we decoded similarly if I want
to protect these kind of messages there
is an aspen
encrypt.me ASD at 1 2 3 4 and then I
give it a password to protect this
message let's say the word password and
I use the cipher to scramble this by
using let's say AES which is the
strongest Cipher right now and I say
encrypt so this is what the encryption
would look like and basically uh if I
don't have the password over here if I
decrypt it you would see that the error
has occurred now if I type in the
password over here and then decrypt it
it will be able to convert that back
into the unscrambled text and it will
give me what the original message was
this is a secret message the password is
ASD at the1 1234 so if I want to keep my
data secure from hackers I want to
scramble it in such a way that they
would not be able to crack it or it
would be very difficult for for them to
crack it and this is one of the first
mechanisms that would be recommended by
any ethical hacker and before we begin
if you're someone who is interested in
building a career in cyber security or
to become an ethical hacker by
graduating from the best universities or
a professional who elicits to switch
career with cyber security or ethical
hacker by learning from the experts then
try giving a short to Simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from MIT schwarzman College
of computing the course link is
mentioned in the description box below
that will navigate you to the course
page where you can find a complete
overview of the program being offered
hello everyone and welcome to this video
on the hackers road map at the simply
land YouTube channel as vast as the
field of cyber security is there's often
an overflow of information about it at
the same time for people who wish to
know more about about how to venture
into the cyber security or ethical
hacking space it is very important for
them to know what's the career
progression what are the skills needed
and how a person with no or bare minimum
knowledge can take the first step in
this amazing career well this video is
for all those individuals who wish to
pursue a career in the field of cyber
security and ethical hacking whether you
are an entry-level professional a
college graduate or an experienced
professional looking to understand how a
career in the field of cyber security
progresses and what additional skills
and responsibilities would you need as
you grow in the field then you are at
the right place so let's get started
with our topic the hackers road map and
before we begin if you are someone who
is interested in building a career in
cyber security by graduating from the
best universities or a professional who
El sits to switch careers with cyber
security by learning from the experts
then try giving a short to Simply lar
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from MIT shortsman College
of Engineering the course link is
mentioned in the description box that
will now get you to the course page
where you can find a complete overview
of the program being offered and if
these are the types of videos you would
like to watch then hit the Subscribe
button like and press on the Bell icon
to never miss on further content so stay
tuned with us until the end of this
video and don't forget to register your
opinion in the comment section below and
now we will start with what is ethical
hacking and how is it different from
hacking so in the world of cyber
security hacking can be broadly
categorized into two types ethical
hacking and unethical hacking ethical
hacking involves using the same tools
and techniques as malicious hackers to
identify and fix security
vulnerabilities before they can be
exploited and these expert known as
Whitehead hackers work with a focus on
security rather on theft and on the
other hand we have unethical hacking
that refers to unauthorized access to
digital devices or networks with
malicious intent performed by black hat
hackers and additionally there are gray
attackers who possess knowledge in
offensive and defensive computer use
sometimes working as Security
Consultants during the day and engaging
in blackhe hat activities at night it is
important to understand these
distinctions to protect against cyber
threats effectively now we'll see the
objective or roles of an ethical hacker
ethical hackers also known as whad
hackers use their skills and expertise
to identify vulnerabilities in system
and network before malicious hackers can
exploit them their primary objective is
to simulate real world attacks and help
organization strengthen their security
measur
the role of an ethical hacker involves
several key phases and we'll see those
roles and key phases so they are
responsible for reconnaissance scanning
can and maintain access clear their
tracks document their findings and
compile detailed reports so firstly they
conduct thoro Recon gathering
information about the target system or
organization this includes understanding
the organization structure Network
infrastructure and potential weak points
and through scanning they identify the
easiest and quickest methods to gain
access to the network and gather further
information and once acccess is gained
ethical hackers maintain it allowing
them to exercise their Privileges and
control the connected systems this step
helps them identify any potential
security flows and weaknesses within the
network they also work to clear their
tracks covering their footsteps to evade
detection and ensuring the security
personal cannot Trace their activities
and throughout the entire process
ethical hackers document their findings
compile detailed reports on the
vulnerabilities discovered and provide
recommendations to address and mitigate
the identified security issues their
vulnerability goal is to help
organizations strengthen their defenses
prevent data breaches and protect
sensitive information from falling into
the wrong hands ethical hacking is a
crucial aspect of cyber security as it
allows organizations to stay one step
ahead of cyber threats by leveraging the
skills of ethical hackers businesses can
proactively identify and address
vulnerabilities ensuring the overall
security and integrity of their digital
infrastructure so now we'll see the
skills that needed to be an ethical
hacker so now we'll see the skills so
the first skill is knowledge of computer
networks then it's the programming
languages then the knowledge of web
applications databases ethical hacking
tools and knowledge of Comm attack
vectors and techniques then what
certificates that are required for an
ethical hacker now we'll start with
knowledge of computer networks
understanding computer networks is
fundamental for ethical hackers this
includes Concepts such as IP addressing
Network protocols example TCP IP routing
switching and firewalls a strong grasp
of how networks function will enable you
to identify vulnerabilities and
potential entry points the next is
programming languages Proficiency in
programming languages is essential for
Effective ethical hacking languages like
python Java C++ and scripting languages
such as Pearl or ruik are widely used in
this field programming skills enable you
to write custom scripts and tools
automate task and exploore
vulnerabilities and the next we have is
web applications in today's digital
landscape web applications are often the
target of attacks therefore a solid
understanding of web application
architecture protocols example HTTP and
security mechanisms example SSL TLS is
crucial knowledge of web programming
languages like HTML CSS JavaScript and
Frameworks like PHP or asp.net is also
beneficial then we have databases so
databases store and manage sensitive
data making them attractive targets for
hackers familiarize yourself with
database Management systems dvms such as
MySQL Oracle or Microsoft SQL Server
learn about database security including
access control encryption and
vulnerability assessment then we should
focus on the skill to have a knowledge
on ethical hacking tools so to perform
ethical hacking task efficiently you
should be familiar with various hacking
tools these include Network scanners
example and map vulnerability scanners
example nessas password crackers joone
the riper packet snipers wi shock and
exploitation Frameworks metas sploit
mastering these tools will enhance your
Effectiveness as an ethical hacker then
you should have knowledge of common
attack vectors and techniques that is
understanding common attack vectors and
techniques is vital for an ethical
hacker this includes knowledge of
different types of malware social
engineering Network attacks that is DDOS
and web application vulnerabilities
example crite scripting staying up to
date with the latest threats and attack
methodologies is crucial for Effective
defense the next is certificates so
obtaining relevant certifications
demonstrates your expertise and
commitment to the field certificates
like certified ethical hacker CH
offensive security certificate
professional OSP or coma Security Plus
are highly regarded within the industry
they validate your skills and can boost
your credibility when seeking ethical
hacking opportunities the CH
certification is a multiple choice exam
that evaluates your understanding of the
penetration testing structure and the
tools that are utilized inside it it
gives job Seekers the information
security field Head Start by ensuring
that the certificate holder understands
the fundamentals such as information
gathering attacking computers or servers
Wireless attacks and social engineering
so the objective of CHS inform the
public that credentialed individuals
need or exceed the minimum standards
second establish and govern minimum
standards of
credity third professional information
security specialist in ethical hacking
so now we'll have an exam overview so so
the exam name is EC Council certified
ethical hacker and the exam duration is
240 minutes and you will get questions
that is 125 questions you will get in
the exam and it is a multiple choice
question exam and the passing score you
need is
70% and to register for the exam you
should go to peon view or ECC Exam
Center and eligibility criteria for CHS
there are two ways to satisfy the
eligibility criter IIA that is attend
official CH training and this can be in
any format example instructor Le
training computer Based training or live
online training as long as the program
is approved by EC Council and attempt
without official training in order to be
considered for the EC council
certification exam without attending
official training you must have two or
more years of documented information
security experience remit a
non-refundable eligibility application
fee of $100 submit completed CH exam
eligibility form including verification
from an employer upon approval EC
Council will email your voucher number
to register for the CH exam so this was
all about the CH exam and now we'll move
to the steps to become ethical hacker so
ethical hacking is an exciting and
rapidly growing field that requires a
combination of technical skills
knowledge and a strong sense of Ethics
by following these steps you can begin
your journey towards becoming an ethical
hacker and contribute to enhancing cyber
security so step one that is knowledge
of computer systems and networks step
two you should have Proficiency in
programming languages step three
networking and security Concepts you
should have a knowledge of it third
knowledge of web application and
database fifth understanding of
operating systems step six familiarity
with ethical hacking tools step seven
problem solving and analytical thinking
step eight knowledge of common attack
vectors and techniques step nine
certifications so now we'll elaborate
all the the steps one by one so we'll
start with knowledge of computer systems
and networks so to become an ethical
hacker it is crucial to have a deep
understanding of computer systems and
networks this involves familiarizing
yourself with the inner workings of
computer system Network protocols
operating systems and how different
components interact within a network
environment by gaining this knowledge
you will be better equipped to identify
vulnerabilities and assess potential
security risk and the next is
proficiency in programming languages so
programming languages are an essential
tool for ethical hackers by gaining
Proficiency in programming languages
such as python C++ Java JavaScript SQL
per and Ruby you will be able to develop
your own scripts automate task and
create exploit codes these programming
languages provide the foundation for
writing secure and efficient code as
well as manipulating and analyzing data
the next step is networking and security
Concepts to effectively assess and
secure net networks it is important to
have a solid understanding of networking
and security concept this includes
familiarizing yourself with topics such
as Network protocols network security
principles encryption techniques and
firewall configurations understanding
how data is transmitted secured and
protected in a network environment will
enable you to identify potential
vulnerabilities and Implement
appropriate security measures step four
knowledge of web application and
database knowledge so in today's
interconnected World web applications
and databases are common targets for
hackers therefore it is crucial to
develop a strong understanding of web
application architectures web protocols
and database systems pay special
attention to Common vulnerability
specific to web applications such as SQL
injection crite scripting xss and crite
request forgery csrf by gaining
expertise in these areas you will be
able to effectively assess the security
of web applications and databases and
provide approp rate recommendations for
securing them and the next step is
understanding of operating systems so
operating systems form the backbone of
computer systems and are often targeted
by hackers it is important to gain a
comprehensive understanding of different
operating systems such as Windows Linux
or Mac OS this includes understanding
system configurations file permissions
user management and security mechanism
specific to each operating system this
knowledge will enable you to identify
vulnerabilities apply patches and secure
operating systems effectively step six
familiarity with ethical hacking tools
ethical hackers rely on a variety of
tools to assess and secure systems and
networks familiarize yourself with
popular ethical hacking tools such as
met spotti wi shock and map BB suit Ki
Linux canas SQL ninja and B these tools
provide functionalities for
vulnerability scanning Network sniffing
exploit development and penetration
testing understanding how to use these
tools effectively will enhance your
capabilities as an ethical headform now
we'll see the step seven that is problem
solving and analytical thinking so being
an ethical hacker requires strong
problem solving skills and the ability
to think analytically you will often
encounter complex systems and face
intricate security challenges developing
your problem solving abilities and
analytical thinking will help you
approach these challenges systematically
identify vulnerabilities and device
effective strategies to mitigate risk it
is essential to stay updated with the
latest security Trends and Technologies
to enhance your problem solving skills
and the step it is knowledge of common
attack vectors and techniques so to
defend against potential threats you
must familiarize yourself with common
hacking techniques and attack vectors
used by malicious hackers this include
social engineering fishing attacks
password cracking network based attacks
and more understanding how these attacks
work and the methodologies used will
enable you to prove proactively identify
and prevent potential security breaches
and now the step nine that is
certifications while certifications are
not mandatory to start a career in
ethical hacking they can provide a
structured learning path and validate
your skills and knowledge consider
pursuing certification such as certified
ethical hacker CH offensive security
certified professional OSP certified
information system security professional
cissp certified penetration Testing
Engineer cpte and certified security
analyst ecsa these certifications
demonstrate your expertise and
dedication to the field enhancing your
credibility as an ethical hacker now
we'll see the job roles in ethical
hacking field so starting with like
there are several job roles in ethical
hacking such as here's an elaboration on
each job role in ethical hacking and
we'll see some of the major ethical
hacker job Roes so starting with ethical
hacker so an ethical hacker is a skilled
professional who legally attempts to to
penetrate computer system and networks
to identify vulnerabilities and
weaknesses they use their knowledge to
strengthen the security infrastructure
and protect against cyber threats and
the next is network security engineer
network security Engineers specialize in
securing and maintaining computer
networks within an organization they
Implement and manage security measures
such as firewalls intrusion detection
systems and virtual private networks
that is vpns to protect sensitive data
then we have cyber security anal
so cyber security analyst Monitor and
analyze systems for potential security
breaches or incidents they investigate
threats develop security protocols and
Implement measures to protect against
attacks the next is penetration tester
penetration testers also known as
ethical hackers simulate real world
attacks to identify vulnerabilities in
computer systems networks and
applications they conduct thoro
assessments and provide recommendations
for improving security the next is
information security manager information
security managers are responsible for
overseeing an organization's overall
security strategy and ensuring the
protection of sensitive data they
develop and Implement security policies
manage security teams and handle
incident response and the next is cyber
security engineer so cyber security
Engineers design and Implement security
systems including firewalls encryption
protocols and intrusion detection
systems they also conduct risk
assessments and perform security audits
to maintain a security environment and
the next is security consultant Security
Consultants provide expert advice and
guidance on security strategies and
solutions they assess vulnerabilities
develop security plans and assist
organizations in improving their overall
security posture in the United States
these requirements are very high and
this was all for this tutorial did you
know that in August this year Google
openly admitted that some of its Gmail
accounts were hack ban Iranian group
fortunately the event was isolated and
was taken care of but rarely are
security breaches this easy to stop with
more and more data moving to the cloud
the prospects of hacks like these have
grown in the past decade exponentially
consequently organizations have now
discovered the need to secure the
digital infrastructure against various
attack vectors fueling the need for
ethical hackers in the IT industry so
today's video is all about how you can
learn the ins and outs of hacking and
cyber security irrespective of your
learning background so welcome to our
video on how to become an ethical hacker
by simply learn before we get started
ensure you subscribed to the channel so
you always stay updated with the latest
Technologies and Trends let's first
clear the air on an ethical Hacker's
role the term hacking has inherently
negative connotations however this will
only be applicable until the duty of an
ethical hacker is properly understood
ethical hackers are the good people in
the hacking field wearing the white hat
so what exactly is the responsibility of
an ethical hacker instead of utilizing
the extensive computer expertise for
criminal purposes ethical hackers find
gaps in data and computer security for
businesses and organizations worldwide
to defend themselves against hackers
with less than noble intentions ethical
hacking is a subcategory of cyber
security that involves lawfully breaking
a system security mechanisms in order to
discover possible threats and data leaks
on the network ethical hackers can work
for cooperation as independent
Freelancers inh house security staff for
its website or its applications or as
simulated offensive cyber Security
Professionals as well all of these
careers need knowledge of current attack
methodologies and tools
albe the in-house expert may need to be
knowledgeable about a single kind of
software or digital asset but how can
you hone your ethical hacking skills
let's take a look at few steps one can
take while starting a career in this
field the first step is getting
comfortable with Linux there are
operating systems catered specifically
to ethical hackers like kly Linux and
parad security both are based on Linux
derivatives and have a plethora of tools
to make your hacking workflow easy and
relatively stressfree the better versed
you are with Linux and its terminal the
quicker you can achieve things when
hacking the next would be to master the
mother of all programming languages
which is the C programming language
since Linux and a lot of backend code I
written in C having a strong hand over
this programming language is very
important it's always helpful to learn a
couple more relevant languages like
python or JavaScript which will help you
dissect giant pieces of server code like
butter remaining Anonymous is vital in
the hacking sphere since giving a
malicious actor news of your existence
on a Target Network can cause him then
to flee or attack your device in
the usage of Mac address randomizers and
proxy chains is highly beneficial and
recommended when monitoring networks for
criminal activity and speaking of
proxies ethical hackers must understand
networking fundamentals and exactly how
they are established learning about
various networks and protocols might
help you exploit flaws an ethical hacker
with an extensive understanding of
networking tools such as wire shock nmap
and others can overcome field incidents
relatively unscathed the fifth skill in
our list is traversing the darkware
using the famous store browser most of
the internet is hidden behind the Tor
networks and getting a closer look at
the people who often are at the
Forefront of the hacking industry in the
dark web directly can help you
familiarize yourself with a certain
domain Secrets while keeping you updated
with the latest happenings in the cyber
crime World A major advantage that can
tip the skills in the famor of an
ethical hacker is the knowledge of
cryptography or encryption encryption is
used in various elements of information
security including authentication data
Integrity anonymity and others passwords
and other sensitive information are
always encrypted on our Network a hacker
must understand how to recognize and
break these encryption standards
exploring vulnerabilities make you a
better ethical hacker simply keeps you
aware of the security measures that are
kept in place as industry standards
while handing you the most advanced
penetration testing tools on the market
learning how to scan networks and
systems for vulnerabilities that might
result in a security Beach ethical
hackers may also attempt to write
vulnerabilities to exploit the system in
question as a final tip join forums for
conversations with other hackers
worldwide to trade share expertise and
collaborate Discord Reddit Telegram and
other platforms all have communities
where you can join and collaborate with
fellow Learners to broaden your learning
Spectrum now that we understand some
basic skills ethical hackers need to
excel in this domain let us look at the
road map one can follow to get started
many ethical hackers begin their careers
by studying computer science you can
also acquire an A+ certification from
comp tiia by appearing for and passing
two additional tests these test assess
an individ ual's understanding of PC
components and their ability to
disassemble and reassemble a PC however
before advancing in your profession you
must gather experience and obtain a
network Plus or a ccns certification the
network plus certification certifies
fundamental Network expertise such as
Network Administration maintenance
deployment and troubleshooting the CCN
certification guarantees the same skills
and Stripes of foundation level
proficiency once qualified you can
advance to the next level of your career
in network support you'll be responsible
for monitoring and upgrading installing
security software and testing for
vulnerabilities you'll obtain expertise
in network security and your goal should
be offered as a position as a network
engineer as a network engineer you will
build and plan networks rather than
simply maintain them your focus should
now be on the security part of your
journey to becoming an ethical hacker
this is the time to focus on earning a
security certifications such as Security
Plus or cissp the US Department of
Defense has approved the Security Plus
accredition which covers testing on
critical areas such as Access Control
identity authentication and cryptography
the cissp certification is a worldwide
recognized security accredition that
validates the expertise of risk
management Cloud technology and
application development The Next Step
would be to start working in the
information security division an
information security analyst studies
systems and network security engages
with security breaches and strives to
implement Security Solutions for this
profession you should focus on
penetration testing to gain hand hands
on experience is some of the most
essential tools of the trade getting the
certified ethical hacker or the C
certification should be your top
priority the training will teach you all
you must understand to become a
productive and ethical hacker you will
be engaged in a Hands-On environment
where you will be guided through
breaking into a network and finding any
security flaws after obtaining this
certification you can begin marketing
yourself as a professional ethical
hacker we have already covered some
skills one needs to learn when starting
their Journey however an ethical hacker
has certain roles and responsibilities
that must be carried out ously the first
of which is threat modeling threat
modeling is optimizing network security
by identifying vulnerabilities and
determining counter measures for
avoiding or reducing an attack's impact
on the system a threat is a real or
projected negative incident jeopardizing
the organization's assets the role of an
ethical hacker is to give a thorough
assessment of potentially harmful
assaults and their potential
consequences they can also conduct
information security audits or a
risk-based evaluation of a company
security
these regular exercises assess
Security's Readiness identify it system
weaknesses and offer strategies for
reducing future attack threats they also
assess how successfully security related
policies are implemented resulting in a
report that includes discovered flaws
and appropriate Solutions ethical
writers must be able to collect data
detect vulnerabilities and correlate
risks to create clear and unambiguous
professional reports these evaluations
are frequently used to justify
finalizing security asset expenditures
the market for train ethical hackers has
never been this expensive according to
various surveys the job outlet for
ethical hackers and information security
analyst is supposed to grow by 33%
between 2020 and 2030 companies like IBM
Google and Microsoft are always on the
lookout for train cyber security
Personnel in this climate of data
breaches and security vulnerabilities we
hope this video has cleared some doubts
regarding where to start and what to
learn during this
journey when it comes to web app hacking
it generally refers to the exploitation
of applications by HTTP which can be
done by manipulating the applications
via its graphical user interface this is
done by tampering with the uniform
resource identifier also known as a URI
or tampering with the HTTP elements
directly which are not a part of the URI
the hacker can send a link via an email
or a chat and may trick the users of a
web application into executing actions
in case the attack is on an
administrator account the entire web
application can be
compromised anyone who uses a computer
connected to the internet is susceptible
to the threats that computer hackers and
online Predators post these online vain
typically use fishing scams spam email
or instant messages and bogus websites
to deliver dangerous malware to your
computer and compromise your computer
security computer hackers can also try
to access your computer and private
information directly if you're not
protected by a firewall they can monitor
your conversation a s or produce the
back end of your personal website
usually disguised with a bogus identity
Predators can lure you into revealing
sensitive personal and financial
information a web server which can be
referred to as the hardware the computer
or the software which helps to deliver
content that can be accessed through the
internet the primary function of a web
server is to deliver these web pages on
the request to clients using the
hypertext transfer protocol or
HTTP so hackers attack the web server to
steal credential information passwords
and business information by using
different types of attacks like GS
attacks syn flooding ping flood port
scan and social engineering attacks in
the area of web security despite strong
encryption on the browser server Channel
web users still have no Assurance about
what happens at the other
end although wireless networks offer
great flexibility they have their own
security problems a hacker can sniff the
net Network packets without having to be
in the same building where the network
is located as wireless networks
communicate through radio waves a hacker
can easily sniff the network from a
nearby location most attackers use
Network sniffing to find the SSID and
hack a wireless network an attacker can
attack a network from a distance and
therefore it is sometimes difficult to
collect evidence against the main
hacker social engineering is the art of
manipulating users of a Computing system
it to revealing confidential information
which can be later used to gain
unauthorized access to a computer system
the term can also include activities
such as exploiting human kindness greed
and curiosity to gain access to
restricted access buildings or getting
the users to installing backdoor
software knowing the tricks used by
hackers to trick users into releasing
vital login information is fundamental
in protecting computer
systems coming to our main focus for
today let us have a look at the top five
most essential ethical hacking tools to
be used in
2021 at the top of the chain lies
nmap nmap which stands for network
mapper is a free and open-source utility
for network discovery and security
auditing many systems and network
administrators also find it useful for
tasks such as Network inventory managing
service upgrade schedules and monitoring
host or service up time it is most
beneficial in the early stages of
ethical hacking where a hacker must
figure the possible entry point to a
system before running the necessary
exploits thus allowing the hackers to
leverage any insecure openings and thus
breach the
device nmap users raw IB packets in
novel ways to determine what hosts are
available on the network what service
they are running what operating systems
are installed what type of packet
filters and firewalls are in used and
dozens other character characteristics
it was designed to rapidly scan large
networks but works F against single host
as well since every application that
connects to a network needs to do so via
a port the wrong port or a server
configuration can open a can of worms
which lead to a thorough breach of the
system and ultimately a fully hacked
device next on our list we have
Metasploit the Metasploit framework is a
very powerful tool that can be used by
cyber criminals as well as ethical hack
to probe systematic vulnerabilities on
both networks and servers because it's
an open source framework it can be
easily customized and used with most
operating
systems with Metasploit the ethical
hacking team can use readymade or custom
code and introduce it into a network to
probe for weak spots as another flavor
of threat hunting once the flaws are
identified and documented the
information can be used to address
systemic weaknesses and prioritize
Solutions
once a particular vulnerability is
identified and the necessary exploit is
fed into the system there are a host of
options for the hacker depending on the
vulnerability hackers can even run root
commands from the terminal allowing
complete control over the activities of
the compromise system as well as all the
personal data stored on the
device a big advantage of Metasploit is
the ability to run full-fledged scans on
the target system which gives a detailed
picture of the security index of the
system along with the necessary exploits
that can be used to bypass the antivirus
softwares having a single solution to
gather almost all the necessary points
of attack is very useful for ethical
hackers and penetration testers as
denoted by its high rank in the
list moving on we have the acuns
framework actic is an endtoend web
security scanner which offers a 360°
view of an organization security it is
an application security testing tool
that helps the company address
vulnerability across all their critical
web
assets the need to be able to test
application in depth and further than
traditional vulnerability management
tools has created a market with several
players in the application security
space actic can detect over 7,000
vulnerabilities including SQL injections
cross-site scripting misconfigurations
weak passwords exposed database and
other out of band
vulnerabilities it can scan all pages
web apps and complex web applications
running HTML 5 and JavaScript as well it
also lets you scan complex multi-level
forms and even password protected areas
of the
site actic is a dynamic application
security testing package which has
definite perks over status application
security testing Frameworks which are
also known as sast scanners sast tools
only work during development and only
for specific languages and have a
history of reporting lot of false
positives whereas Dynamic testing tools
also known as D have the ability to
streamline testing from development to
deployment with minimal
issues next H our list we have
airgeddon this is a multi-use bash
script used for Linux systems to hack
and audit wireless networks like our
everyday Wi-Fi router and its
counterparts along with being able to
launch denial of service attacks on
compromised networks this multi-purpose
wi-fi hacking tool has very rich
features which support multiple methods
for wi-fi hacking including WPS hacking
modes WP attacks handshake captures evil
twin and so much
more it usually needs an external
network adapter that supports monitor
mode which is necessary to be able to
capture Wireless traffic that Traverse
the air
channels thanks to its open-source
nature air Garden can be used with
multiple Community plugins and add-ons
thereby increasing its Effectiveness
against a wide variety of routers both
in the 2.4 GHz and the 5 gz
band finally at number five we have John
the Ripper John the Ripper is an
open-source password security auditing
and the password recovery tool which is
available for many operating
systems John the Ripper jumo supports
hundred of hash and Cipher types
including for user passwords of
operating systems web apps database
servers encrypted keys and document
files some of the key features of the
tool include offering multiple modes to
speed up the password cracking
automatically deselecting the hashing
algorithm used by the passwords and the
ease of running and configurating the
tool to make it password cracking
easier it can use dictionary attacks
along with regular brute forcing to
speed up the process of cracking the
correct password without wasting
additional resources the word list being
used in these dictionary attacks can be
used by the users and allowing for a
completely customizable
process we also have a few honorary
mentions in our list that just miss the
cut net sparker for instance is an
automated yet fully configurable web
application security scanner that
enables you to scan websites web
applications and web services the
scanning technology is designed to help
you secure web applications easily
without any fuss so you can focus on
fixing the reported vulnerability
the burp suit professional is one of the
most popular penetration testing and
vulnerability finder tools and it's used
for checking web application security
the term burp as it is commonly known is
a proxy based tool which is used to
evaluate the security of web- based
application and to do Hands-On testing
moving away from websites and
applications yashar is a free and open-
Source packet analyzer which was
launched in 2006 it is used for Network
troubleshooting analysis software and
Communications protocol development and
education it captures Network traffic on
the local network and stores data for
offline analysis ysha captures Network
traffic from ethernet Bluetooth wireless
networks and frame relay
connections now that we learn about the
different types of tools that can be
used when conducting an ethical hacking
audit let's learn about some potential
benefits of such campaigns and why
organizations prefer to pay for such
audits being able to identify defects
from an attacker's perspective is
game-changing since it displays all the
potential Avenues of a possible hack one
can only prepare for the known
vulnerabilities as a defensive
specialist but proactively trying to
breach a network or device can make
hackers think of techniques that no
defense contractors can account for this
kind of unpredictability goes a long way
in securing a network against malicious
actors
another advantage of hiring ethical
hackers is the ability to preemptively
fix possible weak points in a company's
Network infrastructure as seen on many
occasions a real breach will cause loss
of data and irreparable damage to the
foundation of an
organization being able to gauge such
shortcomings before they become public
and can be used exploited is a benefit
most organizations make use of this is
not to imply that such security audits
are only beneficial to the organization
paying for it when coming across
companies that provide certain Services
a reliable thirdparty security audit
goes a long way in instilling trust and
confidence over their craft if the
ethical hackers cannot find any major
vulnerabilities that can be leveraged by
hackers it just accentuates the
technical bence of the organization and
its Engineers thereby increasing the
clientele by a substantial amount in
this we are going to discuss ethical
hacking and penetration testing so we
going to talk talk about the concepts
about what constitutes an ethical hack
and what is a penetration test we're
going to talk about the different types
of penetration test and how they can be
done we're going to talk about an
operating system called K Linux and
we're going to talk about its usage and
its importance in cyber security we'll
also be discussing the different phases
of penetration test and how people or
hackers would utilize these phases uh to
gain their objectives we will also be
discussing in what areas can we do a
penetration test how to do those
penetration tests we'll be discussing
quite a few bit of penetration testing
tools that are available in the Ki Linux
space and then we'll be looking at a
couple of demos at the end of the
session to understand how these tools in
the operating system can be utilized for
various hacks so let's started with what
is ethical hacking now plainly defined
ethical hacking is locating weaknesses
or vulnerabilities of computers and
information systems using the intent and
actions of a malicious hacker the major
difference is here that we are are hired
to discover those weaknesses in a legal
and ethical manner that means first and
foremost our intent should not be
malicious we do not wish any harm to the
organization and whatever we discover is
reported back and not misused once we
report back we would also be trying to
help them out to mitigate or remove
those weaknesses or vulnerabilities to
enhance the company security posture so
essentially we would have the same
training or the same knowledge as that
of a malous hacker except that the
intent is going to be different the
intent is going to help the organization
achieve security to protect themselves
against malicious hackers and the second
most important thing about ethical
hacking is that we authorized to do that
activity I cannot in good faith hack
somebody and then tell them you know
what I just I just wanted to help you
out and uh here are your vulnerabilities
and uh this is the way you can prevent
them I first need the authorization from
the other party and only then can I
perform an ethical hack so in in this
example hacker attacks an individual
with malicious intent and makes misuse
of whatever information they have gotten
they steal the data they maybe fry the
operating system Hardware destroy it and
thus uh they leave the victim without uh
a device with authorization an ethical
hacker can also attack the same
individual minus the destruction of
course and the intent is good so they're
willingly finding out the
vulnerabilities and helping the victim
plug them out so that they would be a
victim of a malicious attack now here
the first thing is authorization from
the victim and the second thing is the
good intent where we do not misuse those
vulnerabilities and we report them back
to the victim or to the client and help
them uh patch those vulnerabilities
that's the main difference between a
white hat and a black hat so Security
Experts are normally termed as white hat
hackers malitia hackers are termed as
black hats now the responsibilities of
ethical hacker are multiforce first and
foremost you have to create scripts test
for vulnerabilities first have to
identify those in the first place so
there's vulnerability assessment
identifying those vulnerabilities and
then you're going to test them to see
the validity and the complexity of those
vulnerabilities so your one of your
responsibilities would be to develop
tools to increase security as well or to
configure Security in such a way that it
would be difficult to breach performing
risk assessment now what is a risk risk
is a threat that is posed to an
organization by a possibility of getting
hacked so let's say I as a ethical
hacker run a vulnerability scanner on a
particular client I identify 10
different vulnerabilities within those
10 vulnerabilities I do a risk
assessment to identify which
vulnerability is critical would have the
most impact on the client and what would
be the
once they get hacked and the loss could
not only be loss of data it could be
Financial losses it could be loss of
reputation penalties they have to pay to
the client for breaches or penalties
that they may have to pay for pay the
governments in case of breaches that
happen that uh couldn't be controlled
another responsibility of the ethical
hacker is to set up policies in such a
way that it becomes difficult for
hackers to get access to devices or to
protected data and finally train the
staff for network security so uh we got
a lot of employees in an organization we
need to train the staff of what is
allowed and what is not allowed how to
keep themselves secure so that they
don't get compromised thus becoming a
vulnerability themselves to the
organization the policies that we have
talked about are administrative policies
to govern the employees of the
organization for example password
policies most of the organizations will
have a tough password policy where they
say you have to create a password that
meets a certain level of complexity
before that can be accepted and till you
create that password you're not allowed
to log in or you're not allowed to
register so let's move on to understand
what is penetration testing now for
penetration testing there's a phase
called vulnerability assessment that
happens before this vulnerability
assessment is nothing but running a
scanning tool to identify a list of
potential flaws or vulnerabilities
within the organization once you have
identified the list of those
vulnerabilities you would then move on
to penetration test this is the part of
ethical hacking where it specifically
focuses on penetration only of the
information systems so you have
identified that flaw maybe it could be a
database with a SQL injection or it
could be uh a buffer over overrun flaw
or it could be a simple password
cracking attempt your idea is to create
those tools create those attacks and try
to penetrate into those areas where
security is weak uh the essense of
penetration testing is to penetrate
Information Systems using various
attacks the attacks could be anything
like a fishing attack a password
cracking attack a denal of service
attack or any other vulnerabilities that
you have identified uh during the VAB
scan so what is K Linux and why is it
used K Linux is an operating system
oftenly used by hackers and ethical
hackers both because of the tool sets
that the operating system contains it is
a Operating System created by
professionals with a lot of embedded
tools it is a dbn based operating system
with Advanced penetration testing and
security auditing features there are
more than 600 plus OD tools on that
operating system that can help you
leverage any of the attacks man in- the
middle attacks sniffing password
cracking any of these attacks would be
possible with all the tools available
you just need to know how to utilize the
operating system and its tools contains
like I said 100 of hundreds of tools
that are used for various information
security tasks like uh computer
forensics rever reverse engineering
information finding even uh getting
access to different machines and then uh
creating viruses work Trojans anything
that you will 600 plus tools in the Kali
Linux operating system there are
periodic updates that are given out to
the operating system as well it is open
source that means it is free to utilize
you can even have the source code you
can modify it if you want to there's
customizations available for all the
tools you can download third party tools
and install them if you want there's a
white support for wireless uh network
cards multiple languages are being
supported at the time at the same time
as well and you can create a lot of
attacking uh scripts you can create
attacking tools and you can write your
own exploits as well on Ki Linux so this
all all in all helps you create a very
robust system where you can create your
own attacks and then launch them against
unsuspecting victims now that is illegal
so as far ethical hack is concerned once
you have authorization you're going to
identify which tools to be utilized
you're going to get the appropriate
permissions and only then are you going
to attempt those attacks let's talk
about the phases of penetration testing
now there are five different phases the
first one is the recognizance phase also
known as the information gathering phase
this is the most important phase for any
hacker this is where the hacker or the
ethical hacker if you will will gather
as much information about the target's
victim or V vers the V the victim right
so once you have that information you
would then be able to identify what tool
sets to include and how to attack the
victim for example you want to find out
the IP addresses the domains subdomains
the network architecture that is being
utilized you want to identify operating
systems that are being utilized the
network IP ranges that are being
utilized and so on so forth you might
want to identify employees within an
organization for social engineering
attacks in the future email addresses
telephone numbers anything and
everything that will help you validate
and give you information about the
target is something that you want to do
in the recognizance phase at this point
in time we are not going to question
whether whatever information we are
getting is useful or not only time will
tell depending on the various attacks
that we will be building up later on
this becomes your Baseline this becomes
your database with all the information
about the victim so that you can come
back from later stages back to the
recognizance phase to look at the
information that You' have gathered and
then you can find tune your attacks once
you have done that you're going to uh
then start the scanning phase based on
the information that you have gathered
you're going to identify live machines
within the network one once you have
identified the life machines you'll scan
them for open ports protocols and
procedures any processes that are
running and then we going to identify
vulnerabilities Within These processes
and Within These open ports so in the
scanning phase uh why do we need to find
live machines because we want to find
out the machines that have booted up
have an operating system and are running
on the network if an machine is not
available on the network or is in a
shutdown mode that machine cannot be
hacked through a technical attack then
it will be a physical attack attack
where you physically go to the machine
and then do whatever you want to do with
it for a technical attack you will have
to identify the machines that have
booted up then you're going to scan the
open ports because that's going to be
our entry point and on the port would be
a service that is running so you scan
the service as well identify the version
of the service and then do a
vulnerability scan to identify if there
are any vulnerabilities on those
services that are running and then based
on all of this information we are going
to develop our attacks as we go on so
once we have this we go onto the gaining
access phas where we are going to attack
and try to get access to our victims
machines could be a social engineering
attack based on the information
gathering we have done in the technical
assessment in scanning phase if you have
identified a vulnerability you're going
to identify a relevant exploit and then
use that exploit to try to gain access
or we might just craft a Trojan and try
to uh execute that Trojan on the victims
machine to uh check if we can get access
through that particular manner once we
have the access could could be even a
simple password cracking attack which we
have been able to accomplish and we have
cracked the password of the person and
now we have gained access to that
person's computer right but these
attacks would be temporary for example
we have cracked a password somebody
changes the password every 30 days after
that period our attack would be useless
if a Trojan is executed we get a
connection to that machine for once but
then how do we get get a repeated
connection over and over again if we
want to reconnect to that machine so
that's where we come into the main ining
access phase where we install uh root
kits key loggers sniffers and things
like that where we could get a back door
entry to the victim's machine if we have
already been successfully installed a
Trojan we would want to add the Trojan
to the startup menu so that every time
the operating system starts the Trojan
gets automatically executed and thus we
maintain the back door entry to that
victim's machine once we have done all
of this all these activities are going
to leave a trace in the victim's machine
so if you install a Trojan a Trojan
being an application would create
directories and files a virus would be
destructive in nature if you're
executing a script it will leave some
logs behind if we even login through the
cracked password that we have it will
create a login entry at for that
particular time stamp along with the IP
address that we utilized in the covering
tracks we are essentially trying to
avoid detection by deleting traces of
our activity that means that we need to
identify where logs are been stored we
need to address those logs and we need
to delete them or modify them in such a
way that our activity is not traceable
so these are the five main phases of a
penetration test gather as much
information as you can scan for machines
ports protocols and services running on
the victim's device try to gain access
by password cracking inions exploits for
the V lities if any maintain that access
by installing further software which
will allow you to get back door access
to that particular system and then try
to cover your tracks by deleting all
traces of your activity once successful
the victim will have no idea and you
have a backd door entry and you can
monitor the victim to the extent that
you want now in an ethical Hacker's
perspective this penetration test can be
done in multiple aspects so again
understand the fact that we are doing an
authorized activity we have identified
the tools that we have to use identified
the attacks we have got the appropriate
authorization and based on that
authorization we are conducting a
penetration test the penetration test
may be asked to be done in one of these
map maners first is the blackbox test
the blackbox test is where no
information is given to the ethical
hacker about the it infrastructure so
they have no idea what it is they start
right from the first phase of the
information gathering gather as much
information they can and based on the
gathered information they try to create
and launch attacks to see if they are
going to be successful now not only does
it test the knowledge of the penetration
tester it would also test the security
implementations that the organization
has done to see whether they can
identify the attack and prevent it in
the first place so this is the
simulation of a malicious hacker
scenario where a malicious hacker having
no idea about the organization first
tries to gather information and then
tries to attack that organization so no
source code knowledge no technological
knowledge nothing they're just going to
try to gather information scan those
devices and then try to gain access the
second test is a gray box test where
some information is given or some
knowledge of the it infrastructure is
given think of it from a employes
perspective a regular employee in
organization who doesn't have extra
privileges like an administrator but is
just a regular employee does that means
that they got limited access within the
organization based on which they get
some knowledge of the it infrastructure
so this is an attempt of an Insider uh
simulation attack where a regular user
may want to try to misuse the access
that they've been given and then try to
gather information or try to gain access
to other devices which they are not
authorized to the third test is white
box where there's full knowledge of the
it infrastructure that has been given so
this is again a simulation of an Insider
attack a malicious Insider if you will
but at this point in time the person has
complete knowledge of the infrastructure
could be in an administrative position
and then they are trying to leverage
their access to see if they can get
information or they can compromise any
stuff any of the data so the three
attacks would be the first one blackbox
where we are simulating a external
threat a hacker sitting outside the
organization trying to gain access the
gray box is an Insider threat where
there is a regular employee who is
trying to get access to infrastructure
that they are not authorized for and
then the third audit is a white box
audit where there's an administrator who
has all the leverage all the access and
the visibility within the infrastructure
and then they're trying to misuse their
access to see what else they can get
from whatever access has been authorized
to them now let's look at the areas of
penetration testing where all could we
do a penetration test thus compromising
the security of the application or of
the server or of of the user so first
and foremost Network Services it finds
vulnerabilities and weaknesses in the
security of the network infrastructure
so for example we have switches routers
firewalls in the network all of these
are devices that need a configuration if
they have been not correctly configured
or if they have not been correctly
secured they would leave some V lities
behind if we as ethical hackers are able
to identify these flaws these
misconfigurations these vulnerabilities
we could then try to exploit them and
try to gain access to the network and
devices within that Network by uh
getting access to the network in the
first place then we have the web
applications web applications are
nothing but softwares that are developed
over or deployed over a web server and
are made available over the intranet or
the internet for example uh websites
that we visit or web applications like
Facebook if you will right so if these
applications have vulnerabilities within
them we then try to attack the web based
applications and thus try to bypass
authentication or get access to database
or try to leak information through those
applications if not then we try to
attack the client side now web
application is at the server level and
is hosted by the deployer so that's at
the server side the client side is where
we as users are using a computer with a
browser and trying to interact with the
web application now the browser and the
operating system that we are utilizing
would have its own vulnerabilities thus
identifying a client side viability and
then exploiting it to either either hack
the client or then piggy back on the
client connection and try to get access
to the server so either you could attack
the network the web application or the
client side itself or you could attack
wireless networks this test would
examine all the wireless devices which
are used in a corporation most of the
wireless would have laptops smartphones
tablets faets all of those connected to
them if you're able to access any of
these devices through the wireless it
would help you gain access to other
devices on the wireless as well and then
social engineering so this is where your
trying to attack humans you're tracking
an employee of a corporation to reveal
some confidential information knowingly
or unknowingly by tricking them with
fake Mals or fake websites or malicious
emails that you have sent to them uh
which they have failed to recognize as
malicious and they click on it thus
getting victimized social engineering
attacks are always uh successful because
of the gullibility of humans empathy
sympathy humans basically have emotions
emotions can be toyed with and then
taken advantage of if the person is not
careful enough for example the most
common social engineering attack that we
see is the Nigerian fraud where we
receive an email that someone somewhere
has died and has left a huge estate
behind a few hundred million doar and we
have been identified as the person
through whom they want to transfer the
money to a foreign land to save on taxes
what are the chances of that happening
on a daily basis right how many princes
are there so that's something that we do
not verify it's just the I guess the
greed if you will of striking it rich
quickly that makes us believe these kind
of emails uh we have also received
emails of lottery tickets that we have
won over a period of time without even
having bought a lottery ticket so if you
haven't bought one what did you win but
we don't ask these questions we just get
excited about the amount of money that
we have won and then we try to bet on
our luck and try to see if that uh email
is going to fructify or is it just
another the scam so social inuring
attacks are dime a dozen these days and
we need to be very careful on what we
trust on the internet let's look at the
penetration testing tools there are
hundreds and thousands of tools out
there most of these have been concised
and collected together and hosted on a
operating system known as Kali Linux
that we have talked about earlier now
the predecessor to K Linux was backtrack
backtrack is no longer continued it has
been discontinued and K Linux has taken
uh the place of backpack within which
are all the tools that you see on your
screen Metasploit is one of the most
favorite penetration testing tools of
hackers and ethical hackers there are a
lot of inbuilt exploits over there and
we'll be doing a demo at the end of the
session on this nmap is the information
gathering tool which will scan for live
devices scan for open ports protocols
and services beef would be an
application testing tool that would help
us uh find exploits within applications
nessus vulnerability scanner is a
network and a host based scanner that
would help you identify viabilities
within such hosts wi shock is a network
sniffer which allows you to capture
Network packets and and analyze them to
see if there are there is any
information worth capturing within those
packets SQL map is a automated tool used
for SQL injection attacks so you don't
even have to craft your queries for SQL
injection it will be done by the SQL map
tool you just need to identify whatever
is possible through the queries that
this SQL is going to create and then
based on the activity that you've
identified you just need to redefine
your search parameters to get access to
the database we'll be doing a demo on
SQL map or SQL map as well and then
there is John the Ripper John the Ripper
is a tool that is used for password
cracking so dictionary attacks Brute
Force attacks are done using John the
Ripper what is a dictionary attack a
dictionary attack is an attack where we
create list of all probable passwords
store them in a txt file and run that
list against the password tool to see if
any of those passwords are going to
match a Brute Force attack is trying the
same attack but with every permutation
and combination of the alphabet that we
have and we're going to try to figure
out uh if we are able to crack the
password at all so these are just some
of the tools for every tool there are
another supporting 100 tools or more
than that uh like for NS vulnerability
scanner you'll have callus vulnerability
scanner you have uh GFI lanard and there
are other lots of other softwares out
there but these are some of the most
commonly utilized tools let's look at
the metas sploit attack Metasploit is a
framework of penetration testing that
makes in very simple you just need to
know how to utilize the tool you need to
identify the vulnerability associate it
with a particular exploit and then run
the exploit on Metasploit we'll be
demoing this during the Practical so
there are active exploits and passive
exploits in active exploits exploits a
specific computer runs until execution
and then exits uses brute force and
exits when an error occurs in a passive
exploit these exploits wait for incoming
requests and exploit them as soon as
they connect they can also be used in
conjunction with emails and web browsers
so in passive exploits we create a
payload we uh like a reverse connection
payload we send it to the victim once
the victim installs that software the
machine will then initiate a connection
to us our machine will be in a listen
mode and then we will once the software
is executed at there and we would then
try to connect and exploit that
particular vulnerability this is the uh
practical that we'll be doing on
Metasploit so let's move on with the
demos and then we'll see uh what we can
discuss amongst them all right let's
have a look look at some of the demos
that we had uh talked about in the
ethical hacking and penetration testing
module we are going to look at three
different demos the first one is going
to be a SQL injection attack that we're
going to perform on this tool that we
have the second one is a password
cracking attack on Windows 7 and a third
one is a meta based or a metas sploid
based shell shock attack on a Linux
based web server so let's get cracking
I've powered on this virtual machine uh
which is the ovas broken web application
it is a tool that is provided for a
people who want to enhance their skills
and they can practice uh how to do these
attacks in a legal manner so we are
going to go to this site I'm just going
to open up my browser the IP address is
7113 to and that's the OAS broken web
application that we want to utilize
we're going to head off to mutil Day 2
and we are going to look at a SQL
injection attack where we want to bypass
authenication now this takes us to the
login screen so we can just try our luck
here and see that the authentication
mechanism works the account does not
exist so the username and password that
we have supplied is not the correct one
so we want to ensure that there's a SQL
database and uh we can uh try to attack
it and see uh if we can bypass the
authentication now uh what we want to do
is we want to create a SQL based
malformed query that can give us a
different output so I'm just going to
type in a single quote over here and
type login and you can see that this is
now suddenly recognized as a operator
and there's a error that is given out
compared to the login that we tried
earlier when we used a proper text based
login mechanism it gave us the account
does not exist but here the single code
gave us a error and it shows us how SQL
works this is the query that we had
created now in the trainings that you
have for ethical hacking there would be
explanations of what these queries are
all about how the syntax works here we
just going to see if we can create a
malform query to log in as a user in
this case so what I'm going to do is uh
create the query over here and we're
going to give it a comparison so we're
going to give it R oneals one space
hyphen hyphen space and if you now click
login you should be able to bypass
authentication and you can see user has
been authenticated and we now have admin
access to this application now here the
SQL queries need to be crafted in such a
perspective that they're going to work
so there would be a lot of exercise in
identifying what the database is there's
a Microsoft database Oracle database and
so on so forth and then you have to
choose those proper commands but
identifying that would come in the
training right now we're just looking at
at a demo this is how a SQL injection
attack works now let me log out here
similarly now we are in a login page the
same query worked wonders where it
allowed us to bypass authentication so
it also depends on what kind of a page I
am and what query would be accepted at
this point in time so here application
understanding would also come into the
picture where uh which function we
calling up on when we connected to a
particular page now this is a user
lookup function right so again here we
try the same method test test that's not
going to work authentication error bad
user or password and if you type in the
same query over here single quote or and
give it a condition single quote r 1
equals 1 space hyphen hyphen space now
here it is not going to log Us in
because this is not a login page this is
a user lookup form so here it will
instead give us a dump of all the
databases that it has so you can see all
the usernames and passwords coming in
that are stored in the user lookup field
so this is where the understanding comes
in of which query to create at what page
we are depending upon the function that
is being called right so that's the SQL
uh injection attack that we wanted to
look at let's move on to password
cracking now this is a Windows 7 machine
that we have I'm just going to do a very
basic password cracking example we're
just going to log in now here the
assumption is that we are able to log in
we have access to a computer and we want
to check out out other users who are
using this computer and see if we can
find out their passwords so that uh we
can log in as a different user steal
data if required and we wouldn't be to
blame if there are any lcks that are
created so here we've got a tool called
can enable that is installed right here
now I'm already an administrator on this
machine I'm checking out other
administrators who share the same
privileges or any other user who may be
on this system whose password I can
crack and thus I would be able to get
access through their account and then do
any malicious activity right so this
allows me to go into a cracker tool and
it allows me to enumerate this machine
and identify all the users and passwords
that are there in this particular
machine right so I'm just going to click
on the plus sign and I'm going to import
uh hashes from a local system so where
are these files stored where does
Windows store its passwords in what
format are they stored and what this
tool does to retrieve those that's
something that we all need to know and
as ethical hacker right so import the
hashes from the local system click on
next it's going to enumerate that file
and it is going to give you a list of
all the users that are there so you can
see the users are hacker admin test the
one that we are logged in as and then
there's a user called virus as well and
you can see that this is the hash value
of the password that is being utilized
now there's a particular format uh for a
hash value for Windows and how it stores
but once we have these hash values let's
say if I want to crack this password
there are various attacks that we can do
for example a dictionary based attack or
a Brute Force attack let's try a Brute
Force attack right ntlm is the hashing
mechanism that is used by windows so
we're going to try to create an llm hash
attack and here we're going to use a
predetermined rule set for example we
not sure what characters are being
utilized over here so we just create an
attack like this using all characters
and uh lower case a through Zed
uppercase a through Zed numeric 0
through 9 and all the special characters
let's say the password is between 7 and
16 characters and this is the character
set that you want to try the Brute Force
attack on what is a Brute Force attack
it is an attack where the computer is
going to try each and every permutation
and combination out of this character
set and try to figure out if the
password is going to be correct so if we
click Start it's going to start with a
particular characters and then it is
going to identify if that ntlm hash is
going to work against this character and
you can see the time is going to be
phenomen Al over here so it's not
necessary that this attack would be
viable it will be 100% successful given
the time frame however the time frame is
huge enough for this attack to become a
little bit redundant there are other
attacks that we can do which can easily
identify this data for us as well but
that is something that we will look on
in future videos so that's how we can
get access to users and passwords uh
there are different mechanisms where
let's say we don't have login access
then what are we going to do how we can
create a fake use user login or how we
can remotely access a machine and then
try to get the same access and that is
what we going to try to do in the next
demo on a Linux machine so what we are
doing in a Linux machine could also be
doable on the Windows machine with a
different exploit so what I'm going to
do is this is the Linux web server that
I have that I'm going to power on I'm
going to use a Kali Linux machine to
hack that device and I'm going to just
power off my Windows 7 machine give it a
minute till it boots up now this is also
a demo machine that we have which has
its own preconfigured vulnerabilities so
here we've got something from the
pentesters lab uh and has a shell shock
vulnerability imp implemented inside
shell shock vulnerability affects Linux
Mac and Unix based operating systems for
a particular version of The Bash shell
bash is the bone again shell which is
the command line interface in these
operating systems so what we are trying
to do here is we're going to use the Ki
Linux machine try to find out the
vulnerability over here and if it exist
we going to use metas sploit to attack
this machine now the first and foremost
thing is we want to identify the IP
address we have no idea what the IP
addresses we are in the same subnet so
we are assuming that we able to connect
to this machine so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to open up a tool called
zenmap I'm going to open up a command
line interface find out what my IP
address is and my IP address is this
with a subnet mask of 2555 255 25.0 so I
want to see if there are any other
machines that are live in the same
subnet and we are doing a ping Swip over
here to identify which machines are live
in a minute we'll get all the IP
addresses 71.1 2 133 254 and 128 we know
that we are 128 at this point in time uh
254 is the DHCP server so we assuming
that 133 is the machine that we want to
look at and let's then try to see if we
can scan that machine 133 and we're
going to do an intense scan to find out
which ports are open what services are
running over there and if it is we the
pintest machine that we were looking for
you can see of the start Port 22 and
Port 80 and somewhere here it's going to
give us the ports that are open and the
details about those ports and somewhere
here it will tell us that this is the
pentester lab machine that we wanted
which is correct so now we want to do a
vulnerability analysis on this what
we're going to do is I'm going to use
another GUI based tool called Sparta
which I can just find out from here
Sparta uses two tools in the background
uh nmap tool and a tool called ncto so
we just going to start scanning 192 168
71133 was the IP address add to scope
and over a period of time you can see
all of these will start populating with
information there we are that's the ncto
tool coming in scanning on Port 80 which
is uh which means that it's a web server
using HTTP it tells us it's an Apache HT
httpd
2.2.2 and gives us the 22 port number as
well if we head over to the tab of ncto
or let's look at the screenshot first
this is what the website would be
looking like and ncto gives us the
options over here it tells us that there
is a vulnerability over here for shell
shock and this is the path where the
vulnerability is going to exist so what
we going to do we go back to the command
line sorry we open up a new one minimize
all these other windows and we going to
open up Metasploit metas flit is a
penetration testing tool that is used by
most hackers and ethical hackers to test
applications and test uh existing
exploits and vulnerabilities so just
give it a minute till it starts you can
see there are already around 1,700
exploits right here uh we're going to
see all those exploits with these
commands there we are sorry for the typo
and it will just give us a list of all
the exploits that are stored in metasite
in this version so all of these are
windows based if we scroll up we will be
looking at other vulnerabilities as well
or exploits the unique exploits LX OSX
multi exploits and we're looking for for
uh exploit for um multi- based Apache or
HTTP let's go up uh let's look at so
this is the one that we're looking for
Apache mod CGI bash environmental
executable so what we're going to do is
we're just going to copy it go back to
the bottom say use exploit and paste the
one that we wanted press enter say show
options so it will ask us to configure
this I'm just going to configure it
based on the knowledge that we have so
our host which is the remote host the
victim's machine so we put in the IP
address it asks us for the Target URI so
that's the path that we saw set Target
URI to CGI hyphen bin SL status enter
now with the exploit we need to find a
payload that is going to give us the
output that we want so we say show
payloads and it will give us a list of
all the compatible payloads with this
exploit and we want to create a reverse
TCP con connection which is this so we
know it's a Linux operating system we
want this uh payload to be set so set
payload press enter that's the payload
coming in show options now that we have
set the payload this is the options for
the exploit and now we want to set our
options for the payloads as well so we
are creating a reverse TCP connection
which means we are remotely executing
code at the victim side and making the
victim connect back to our machine which
means we need to set up a listener so I
need to put my IP address over here set
local host or lhost 192
16871 1228 which was our IP address show
options again just to ensure everything
is fine which looks like it is and we
then type in the word exploit so that it
will start this attack I can see that it
has created a metor session at the
victim site and it has opened up a
session so if I do a PWD now PWD is a
Linux command for present working
directory and it will show us that we'll
connected to where dub dub du sub CGI
hyphen bin do an LS it will list all the
files that's the status file over there
do a CD backs slash it will take us to
the rout of this machine and if you're
someone who is interested in building a
career in cyber security that is by
graduating from the best universities or
a professional while sits to switch
careers with cyber security by learning
from the experts and try giving a short
to Simply Lars postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from the MIT
schwarzman College of Engineering and
the course link is mentioned in the
description box that will navigate you
to the course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered Jude is waiting at the airport
to hop on her flight back home when she
realizes that she missed making an
important Bank payment she connects her
laptop to the public Wi-Fi at the
airport and goes ahead to carry out the
bank transaction everything goes well
and Jude completes her
transaction after a couple of days she
was wiped off her feet when she learned
that her bank account was subjected to a
Cyber attack attack and a hefty amount
was wiped from her account after getting
in touch with the bank Authority she
learned that her account was hacked at
the airport she then realized that the
public Wi-Fi she used might have caused
her this trouble Jude wishes that had
her bank transfer escape the Hacker's
eyes she would not have been a victim of
a Cyber attack Bank officials advise her
to use a bpn for future transactions
especially when connecting to an open or
public network like most of us Jude had
come across the term VPN several times
but didn't know much about it and little
did she think that the repercussions of
not using a VPN would be this bad let's
understand how the hacker would have
exploited Jude's transaction in the
absence of a VPN in this process judee's
computer first connects to the internet
service provider ISP which provides
access to the internet she sends her
details to the bank server using her IP
address Internet Protocol address or IP
address is a unique address that
recognizes a particular device be it a
laptop or a smartphone on the internet
when these details pass through the
public network the hacker who passively
watches the network traffic intercepts
it this is a passive Cyber attack where
the hacker collects judee's Bank details
without being detected more often or not
in such an attack payment information is
likely to be stolen the targeted data
here are the victim's username passwords
and other personal information such an
unsecured connection exposed Jude's IP
address and Bank details to the hacker
when it passed through the public
network so would Jude have been able to
secure her transaction with the help of
a VPN well yes picture Jude's Bank
transaction to be happening in a tunnel
that is invisible to the hacker in such
a case the hacker will not be able to
spot a transaction and that is precisely
what a VPN does a virtual private
Network more of often known as VPN
creates a secure tunnel between your
device and the internet for using a VPN
judee's First Step would be to install
software-based technology known as the
VPN client on her laptop or smartphone
that would let her establish a secure
connection the VPN client connects to
the Wi-Fi and then to the
ISP here the VPN client encrypts judee's
information using VPN protocols data is
encrypted to make sure it is secure next
the VPN client establishes a VPN tunnel
within the public network that connects
to the VPN server the VPN tunnel
protects Jude's information from being
intercepted by the hacker judee's IP
address and actual location are changed
at the VPN server to enable a private
and secure connection finally the VPN
server connects to judee's bank server
in the last step where the encrypted
message is decrypted this way judee's
original IP address is hidden by the VPN
and the V VPN tunnel protects her data
from being hacked this explains how VPN
makes your data Anonymous and secure
when it passes through the public
network and the difference between a
normal connection and a VPN connection
after learning about this Jude was
certain that she should start using a
VPN to carry out her online transactions
in the future this is also applicable to
each one of us even if you work remotely
or connect to public Wi-Fi using a VPN
is the safest option in addition to
providing a secure encrypted data
transfer vpns are also used to disguise
your whereabouts and give you access to
Regional web content VPN servers act as
proxies on the internet this way your
actual location cannot be established
VPN enables you to spoof your location
and switch to a server to another
country and thereby change your location
for example by doing so you can watch
any content on Netflix that might be
unavailable for your region
meet Jonathan he is an investigative
journalist who occasionally researches
and publishes news articles contrary to
the government's ideologies on one such
occasion he could not access a Global
News website dealing with uncensored
information it seemed his IP was blocked
from visiting the news website with his
IP blocked Jonathan turned to a popular
proxy service that was able to unblock
the news website thereby allowing an
open internet to all users just like how
your friend gives a proxy attendance for
you a proxy server serves as a standin
user to keep the real client private but
what is a proxy let's understand its
working by taking a look at how Jonathan
was able to access geoblock content
without much hassle a proxy server acts
as a Gateway or intermediary server
between a user and its destination
website when Jonathan wasn't able to
access the news website he connected his
system to a global proxy server once
connected the proxy server assigns a new
IP address to Jonathan's system an IP
address of a different country where the
website is not censored following this
process whenever Jonathan visits that
website the website administrators see
the new IP address assigned via proxy
server and sees no reason to deny access
to their account once the proxy server
is able to access the website it's
passed on to Jonathan's system via the
same channel regarding accessibility to
proxy servers you must first set it up
on your computer device or network next
check the steps required for your
computer or network as each operating
system has its setup procedures in most
cases however setup entails using an
automated configuration script there are
plenty of free proxy services available
on the internet however the safety of
such proxies is rarely verified most
free proxies will provide an IP address
and a relevant port for connection
purposes reputed proxy providers like
smart proxy and write data that run on
subscription models will most likely
provide credentials to log into when
establishing the connection this extra
step acts as authentication that
verifies an existing subscription on the
proxy provider server unlike free
providers that are open to all when it
comes to hiding IP addresses many people
consider a VPN to be the primary
solution while that's true up to some
exent there are a few things proxies do
differently in the case of vpns extra
encryption is also carried out to create
a secure tunnel between the user's
device and a VPN server a VPN is usually
much faster more secure thanks to
multiple layers of encryption and has
little to no downtime proxies tend to be
comparatively unsafe with the service
owners having the exact IP address of
the enduser and having no guarantees
regarding downtimes and reliability
if you want to know more about how vpns
work do watch how Jude could have
protected her banking credentials using
vpns in our detailed video linked above
now let's take a small quiz to check how
much we have learned what can a VPN
connection provide that a proxy service
cannot a new IP address B multiple
layers of encryption C access to
geoblock content D authentication
credentials think about it and leave
your answers Below in the comment
section and three lucky winners will
receive Amazon gift vouchers what about
the benefits of a proxy service though
besides allowing access to blocked
content proxies can serve as an
efficient firewall system they can also
filter content from thirdparty websites
allowing control over internet usage in
many cases browsing speeds are
stabilized compared to vanilla Internet
thanks to proper optimization on the
base proxy server the element of privacy
proxies provides is highly lucrative to
people looking to hide their actual IP
address from as many crying eyes as
possible one can easily argue the
benefits of using vpns over proxies for
added security measures however a few
basic tasks don't warrant maximum
privacy for the user side as in other
cases for example many consumers
worldwide find proxy Services more
convenient since all major operating
systems starting from Windows to Android
allow proxy configuration
without the hassle of installing new
applications as is in the case of a VPN
in addition there are services online
that function as web proxies allowing
users to access block content without
any setup from there end they can enter
the target URL and the web proxy will
route data from its physical server this
level of freedom is hard to come by in
the case of vpns making proxies an ideal
solution for casual browsing with the
next generation of Internet exchanges
Focus focused on maximum privacy and
security a variety of ways have been
enforced to maintain them as such
censorship has been shifted from the
streets to the digital domain it forces
the standard citizen to derive
alternative ways to maintain anonymity
major weapon in this battle for privacy
and security is the T browser an
independent browser meant to browse the
internet while reing information through
the tour Network it serves as a
meaningful alternative to the standard
internet browsing habits to better
understand the purpose of this browser
and such we must learn about the work of
the to network featuring its own routing
protocol the to browser is an easy way
to maintain anonymity while browsing
without emptying one's wallet let's take
a look at the topics to be covered
today we start at the explanation of
what is the T Network and its
significance in the working of the to
browser we take a look at the onion
routing protocol and how it transmits
the data from the client devices to the
Tor directories in order to circumvent
government sens
censorship moving on we learn a few
features of the to browser and the
distinct advantages the to network
provides next we learn the difference
between using a VPN and a t to anonymize
internet usage and finally we have a
live demonstration of the T browser
anonymization features in
action let's move on to learning about
the T
Network T short for the onion router
it's an open Source privacy Network that
permits users to browse the web
anonymously the tour was initially
developed and solely used by the US Navy
to protect sensitive government
Communications before the network was
made publicly available the digital era
has disrupted the traditional way of
doing things in every sector of the
economy the rapid RIS in development and
innovation of digital products has given
way to frequent data breaches and cyber
thefts in response consumers are
increasingly opting for products that
offer data privacy and cyber security T
is one such underground Network that was
implemented for the purpose of
protecting users identities the Tor
Network is one example of the many
emerging technologies that attempt to
fill a data privacy void in a digital
space plagued by cyber security
concerns the T Network intercepts the
traffic from your browser and bounces a
user's request of a random number of
other user IP addresses then the data is
passed to the user requester Final
Destination these random users are
volunteer devices which are called as
nodes or relays the T Network disguises
your identity by encrypting the traffic
and moving it across different T relays
within the network the T Network uses an
onion routing technique for transmitting
data hence the original name of onion
router to operate within the T Network a
user has to install the T browser any
address or information requested using
the browser is transmitted through the T
Network it has its own feature set which
we will will be goinging over later in
this
video as we discussed already the data
passing through the to network must
follow a unique protocol known as The
Onion routing protocol let us learn more
about its unique
characteristics in our normal Network
usage the data is transmitted directly
the sender has data packets to transmit
which is done directly over a line of
communication with either a receiving
party or a server of some kind however
since the data can easily be captured
while being transmitted the security of
this exchange is not very reliable
moreover it becomes very easy to trace
the origin of such requests on many
occasions websites with questionable and
controversial content are blocked from
the ISP this is possible since the ISP
is able to detect and spy on user
information passing through the network
apart from isps there is a steady chance
of your private information being
intercepted by hackers unfortunately
easy detection of the source and
contents of a web request make entire
network extremely vulnerable for people
who seek anonymity over the
Internet however in the onion routing
protocol things take a longer route we
have a sender with the to browser
installed on the client system the
network sends the information to node
one's IP address which encrypts the
information and passes it on to node 2's
address which performs another
encryption and passes it on to node 3
address this is the last address which
is also known as the exit node this last
node decrypts the encrypted data and
finally relays the request to the Final
Destination which can be another device
or a server end this final address
thinks the request came from the exit
node and grants access to it the
encryption process across multiple
computers repeats itself from the exit
node to the original user the to network
obfuscates user IP addresses from
unwanted surveillance by keeping the
user's request untraceable with multiple
servers touching the data it makes the
tracking very difficult for both isps
and malicious
attackers now that we understand the way
T Works let us learn more about the T
browser the to browser was developed by
a nonprofit organization as a part of
the T project in 2008 and its first
public release was announced the to
browser is a browser Fork from the
popular Firefox that anonymizes your web
traffic using the to network if you're
investigating a competitor researching
an opposing litigant in a legal dispute
or just think it's creepy for your ISP
or the government to know what websites
you visit the to browser might be the
right
solution before the to browser were
developed using that Network to maintain
anonymity was a huge task for everyday
consumers starting from the setup to the
usage the entire process demanded a lot
of knowledge and practice the to browser
managed to make it easy for users to
Traverse the relay servers inour and
guarantee the privacy of the data
exchange a major major feature of the
Tor Browser is the ability to delete all
browser history cookies and tracking
data the moment it is closed every new
launch of the browser opens an empty
slate having a usage habits from being
tracked and singled out a major feature
that is the highlight of the Tor Network
is the availability of onion links only
a small portion of the worldwide web is
available to the general public we have
the Deep Web that contains links that
are not allowed to be indexed by
standard search engines like Google and
Bing the dark web is a further subset of
the Deep Web which contains onion links
to browser gives you access to these
onion websites which are only available
within the to network onion is a special
used top level domain which designates
an anonymous onion service which is also
known as a hidden service similar to The
Links of the Deep Web these onion links
provide services like online shopping
cryptocurrency and many other products
not available in the consumer Internet
space often being considered as a Haven
for illegal activ activities and sales
onion links provide both information and
Assets in a private manner without the
risk of spying by
authorities browsing the web over T is
slower than the clear net due to the
multiple layers of
encryption some web services also block
to users T browser is also illegal in
authoritarian regimes that want to
prevent citizens from Reading publishing
and communicating anonymously
journalists and dissidents around the
world have embraced store as a
Cornerstone of democracy and researchers
are hard at work at improving TOS
anonymity
properties let us take a look at some of
the advantages of using the T browser
over standard web
browsers the highlight of using the T
browser is to maintain anonymity over
the Internet the cause for such requests
can differ from person to person but all
of these concern are answered by the to
network doubting the information via
multiple nodes and relay servers make it
entirely difficult for the ISP to keep a
track of of usage
data the entire to project is designed
to be completely free and open source
allowing the code for the browser to be
inspected and audited by Third parties
helps in the early detection of faulty
configurations and critical bugs it is
present for multiple operating system
starting from laptops to mobile
devices a number of websites are blocked
by governments for a variety of reasons
journalists under authoritarian regimes
have difficulty in getting the word out
regarding the situation since the onion
routing protocol transfers data between
multiple servers of random countries the
domains being blocked become available
when used via T usage of these
encryption messaging platforms is easily
enforced using the T browser which
otherwise would have been a difficult
task under oppressive
circumstances many people believe that a
VPN offers the same benefits as the top
browser let's put both of them to the
test and see the differences between
them coming to the first point of
difference to is completely free and
open source all of the code for the
browser and the network can be audited
and has been cleared for security
concerns when it comes to VPN there are
many different brands which have
open-source clients but the same cannot
be said for their counterparts some have
partly open source while some have
completely locked up their code so that
they cannot be stolen
further moving on T has multiple relay
points in his data transfer protocol
between the server and the receiver
there are three different IP nodes that
number can increase but it'll always be
more than two once the data is passed
from the sender it goes through all of
those delay points while in the case of
a VPN the connection is made from the
client device to the VPN server and then
to the requested destination there is no
other IP node that comes into work here
thereby making the connection a one to
one between the client and a
VPN as a next Point since store handles
multiple layers of encryption and the
data passes through multiple systems
along the way the performance is slow
compared to a VPN where the performance
is relatively fast due to the less
number of nodes the data passes
through similarly the multi-layer
encryption of T is consistent if you use
T browser every single request passes
through the same layer of encryption and
follows the same routing protocol in the
case of a VPN different companies offer
different levels of encryption some have
multihop some prefer a single onetoone
connection and these kind of differences
make the choice much more
variable finally the nodes and relays
being used in the Tor Network are
volunteer there is no company holding
over them so jurisdiction becomes
relatively straightforward for in in the
case of vpns many such vpns are hosted
by adware companies or are being
monitored by Central governments to note
the usage
information now that we have a better
understanding of of the T browser and
its routing let us take a look at how
the T browser can anonymize and protect
our internet
usage on opening up the T browser for
the first time this is the page that
you're going to be welcomed with you
have the option of connecting to the T
Network before we start our
browsing so let's press
connect and we can see that it is
connected coming to the
anonymization let's check my current
location on Google
Chrome
currently is showing as Navi Mumbai in
Maharashtra if you check the same link
on the T browser we should get a
different
address now every link that we open in
the tour browser will be little delayed
and the speed will be hampered because
of the multiple layers of encryption
like we discussed now as you can
see it's showing a German IP and the
state of
Bavaria this is how the anonymization
works the there is no VPN configured
there is no proxy attached it's straight
up the out of the box settings that come
inbuilt with the T browser similarly we
have an option of cleaning up the data
let's say if you want to refresh your
location and you want to use a different
ID for the next browsing session if you
just restart it once and we can have to
check it
again we should be seeing a different
country this time as you can see we have
Netherlands right now so this is how you
can keep refreshing your address you can
keep refreshing your host location so
that you cannot be tracked when in
browsing the internet like we discussed
we have some onion links that can only
be used on the tour
Network as you can see these kind of
links do not open in the Google Chrome
browser but once we copy these over to
the T
browser
as you can see we have opened the hidden
wiki which is available only on the tour
Network this is kind of an alternative
Wikipedia website where we can find
articles to read and more information to
learn similarly we have another onion
link over
here which is once again available only
for the toall
browser now these kind of are expected
but they are a valid compromise because
they maintain the anonymity that many
people desire similarly we have found a
hidden wallet which is a cryptocurrency
wallet which is specifically for dark
web
members this operates over the Tor
Network and this is used by mostly
journalists and people who want to
anonymize their internet transactions
when it comes to dealing
money all of the transactions that occur
over the T Network are almost impossible
to track therefore these kind of
cryptocurrency wallets are very big on
the Deep Web this is just one example
while having multiple different wallets
for every single cryptocurrency
available imagine our houses without a
fence or boundary wall this would make
our properly easy accessible to
trespassers and robbers and place our
homes at Great risk right hence fencing
our property helps safeguarded and keeps
trespassers at Bay similarly imagine our
computers and networks without
protection this would increase the
probability of hackers infiltrating our
networks to overcome this challenge just
like how boundary walls protect our
houses a virtual wall helps Safeguard
and secure our devices from Intruders
and such a wall is known as a firewall
firewalls are security devices that
filter the incoming and outgoing traffic
within a private Network for example if
you were to visit your friend who lives
in a gated community you would First
Take permission permission from the
security guard the security guard would
check with your friend if you should be
allowed to entry or not if all is well
your access is granted on the other hand
the security guard would not Grant
permission to a trespasser looking to
enter the same premises here the entry
access depends solely on your friend the
resident's discretion the role of the
security guard in this case is similar
to that of a firewall the firewall works
like a gatekeeper at your computer's
entry point which only welcomes incoming
traffic that it has been configured to
accept firewalls filter the network
traffic within your network and analyzes
which traffic should be allowed or
restricted based on a set of rules in
order to spot and prevent cyber attacks
your computer communicates with the
internet in the form of network packets
that hold details like the source
address destination address and
information these Network packets enter
your computer through ports the firewall
works on a set of rules based on the
details of these Network packets like
their sour Source address a destination
address content and port numbers only
trusted traffic sources or IP addresses
are allowed to enter your network when
you connect your computer to the
internet there is a high chance of
hackers infiltrating your network this
is when a firewall comes to your Rescue
by acting as a barrier between your
computer and the internet the firewall
rejects the malicious data packet and
thus protects your network from hackers
on the other hand traffic from trusted
websites is allowed access to your
network this way the firewall carries
out quick assessments to detect malware
and other suspicious activities thereby
protecting your network from being
susceptible to a Cyber attack firewalls
can either be Hardware or software
software firewalls are programs
installed on each computer this is also
called a host firewall meanwhile
Hardware firewalls are equipments that
are established between the Gateway and
your network linksy routers are a good
example of a hardware firewall
besides this there are other types of
firewalls designed based on their
traffic filtering methods structure and
functionality the firewall that compares
each outgoing and incoming Network
packet to a set of established rules
such as the allowed IP addresses IP
protocols port number and other aspects
of the packet is known as a packet
filtering firewall if the incoming
Network traffic is not for the
predefined rules that traffic is blocked
a variant of the packet filtering
firewall is the fful inspection firewall
these types of firewalls not only
examine each Network packet but also
checks whether or not that Network
packet is part of an established network
connection such firewalls are also
referred to as Dynamic packet filtering
firewalls our next type of firewall is
called a proxy firewall this draws close
comparison to how you give proxy
attendance for a friend like how you
take the authority to represent your
friend the proxy firewall pretends to be
you and interacts with the internet
they come between you and the internet
and thereby prevents direct connections
this protects your device's identity and
keeps the network safe from potential
attacks only if the incoming data packet
contents are protected the proxy
firewall transfers it to you they're
also known as application Level Gateway
the firewall can spot malicious actions
and block your computer from receiving
data packets from harmful sources in
addition to preventing cyber attacks
firewalls are also used in educational
institions
and offices to restrict users access to
certain websites or applications it is
used to avoid access to unauthorized
content it's the year 2015 and Richard
has just finished playing games on his
computer after a long gaming session
Richard tries to shut it down but finds
some random text file on the desktop
that says Ransom note the text file
mentioned how a hacking group had
encrypted Richard's game files and
private documents and he had to pay a
ransom of $5 $500 worth of bitcoin in a
specified Bitcoin address Richard
quickly checked his files only to see
them being encrypted and unreadable this
is the story of how the Tesla Crypt
ransomware spread in 2015 which affected
thousands of Gamers before releasing the
master key used for encrypting the files
so what is ransomware for Richard to be
targeted by such an attack you must have
installed applications from untrusted
sources or clicked an unverified link
both of them can function as gateways
for a ransomware breach ransomware is a
type of malware that encrypts personal
information and documents while
demanding a ransom amount to decrypt
them this Ransom payment is mainly done
using cryptocurrency to ensure anonymity
but can also employ other routes once
the files are encrypted or locked behind
the password ATT text file is available
to the victim explaining how to make the
ransom payment and unlock the files for
it just like Richard found the ransom no
text file on his desktop even after the
money has been paid there's no guarantee
that the hackers will send the
decryption key or unlock the files but
in certain sensitive situations victims
make the payment hoping for the best
having never been introduced to
ransomware attacks before this gave
Richard an opportunity to learn more
about this and he began his research on
the topic the spread of ransomware
mostly starts with fishing attacks to
know more about fishing attacks click
the link in the button B users tend to
click on unknown links received via
emails and chat applications promising
rewards of some nature once clicked the
ransomware files installed on the system
that encrypts all the files or blocks
access to computer functions they can
also be spread via malware transmitted
via untrusted application installation
or even a compromised wireless network
another way to breach a system with
ransomware is by using the remote
desktop protocol or RDP access a
computer can be accessed remotely using
this protocol allowing a hacker to
install malicious software on the system
with the owner unaware of these
developments coming to the different
types of ransomware first we have Locker
ransomware which is the type of malware
that blocks standard computer functions
from being accessed until the payment to
the hackers is complete it shows a log
screen that doesn't allow the victim to
use the computer for even basic purposes
another type is crypto ransomware which
encrypts the local files and documents
in the computers once the files are
encrypted finding the decryption key is
impossible unless the ransomware variant
is old and the keys are already
available on the Internet scareware is
fake software that claims to have
detected a virus or other issue on your
computer and directs you to pay to
resolve the problem some types of
scareware lock the computer While others
simply flood the screen with popup
alerts without actually damaging files
to prevent getting being affected by
ransomware Richard could have followed a
few steps to further enhance his
security one must always have backups of
their data cloud storage for backup is
easy but a physical backup in a hard
drive is always recommended keeping the
system updated with the latest security
patches is always a good idea apart from
system updates one must always have
reputed antivirus software installed
many antivirus software like kasperski
and Bit Defender have anti- Ransom
features that periodically check for
encryption of private documents when
browsing the internet a user must always
check for the lock symbol on the address
bar which signifies the presence of
https protocol for additional security
if a system is infected with ransomware
already there's a website Noor ransom.
org it has a collection of decryption
tools for most well-known ransomware
packages it can also help decrypt
specific encrypted files if the list of
anti-ransomware tools didn't help the
victim malware is a malicious software
that is programmed to cause damage to a
computer system Network and Hardware
devices many malicious programs like
prion viruses bombs and Bots which cause
damage to the system are known as
malware most of the malware programs are
designed to steal information from the
targeted user or to steal money from the
Target by stealing sensitive
data let's take a look at the
introduction for two different types of
malware virus and
Trojan firstly let's take a look what
exactly is a virus
program a computer virus is a type of
malicious program that on execution
replicates itself they get attached to
different files and programs which are
termed as host programs by inserting
their code if the attachment succeeds
the targeted program is termed as
infected with a computer virus now let's
take a look at the Trojan Horse Trojan
Horse program is a program that
disguises itself as a legitimate program
but harms a system on installation they
hide within the attachments and emails
then transfer from one system to another
they create back doors into our system
to allow the cyper criminal to steal our
information let's take a look how they
function after getting install into our
system firstly we have virus programs
the computer virus must contain two
parts to infect the system first is a
search routine which locates new files
and data that is to be infected by the
virus program and the second part is
known as the copy routine which is
necessary for the program to copy itself
into the targeted file which is located
by the search routine now let's take a
look at the troan horse
functioning for troan horses entry way
into our system is through emails that
may look legitimate but may have unknown
attachments and when such files are
downloaded into the device the tro
program gets installed and infects the
system they also infect the system on
the execution of infected application or
the executable file and attacks the
system now that we understand what virus
and rions are let's understand different
types of virus and
rions let's take a look at different
types of viruses the first one is known
as as the boot sector virus this type of
virus damages the booting section of the
system by infecting the master bought
record which is also known as MBR this
damages the boot sector section by
targeting the hard disk of the
system then we have the macro virus
macrovirus is a type of virus that gets
embedded into the document related data
and is executed when the file is open
they also are designed to replicate
themselves and infect the system on a
larger scale and lastly we have the
direct action
virus this type of virus gets attached
to executable files which on execution
activates the virus program and infects
the system once the infection of the
file is completed they exit the system
which is also the reason it is known as
a non-resident virus let's take a look
at different types of
troan the first type of troan is the
back door troan
they are designed to create a back door
in the system on execution of an
infected program they provide remote
access of our system to the hacker this
way the Cyber criminal can steal our
system data and may use it for illegal
activities next we have cricos verion
they enter the system by clicking the
random popups which we come across on
the internet they ATT the user to give
their personal details for different
transactions or schemes
which may provide remote access of a
system to the Cyber
criminal and the last troan type is
Ransom troan this type of troan program
after entering the system blocks the
user from accessing its own system and
also affects the system
functioning the Cyber criminal Demands a
ransom from the targeted user for the
removal of the Trojan program from the
device now that we understand some
details regarding viruses andion let's
solve a
question the question is Jake was denied
access to his system and he wasn't able
to control the data and information in a
system now the actual question is what
could be the reason behind his system's
problem option a macrovirus option b
Ransom troen option C backd Door troan
give your answers in the comment
section now let's understand how to
detect the activity of viruses and TR in
our
system to detect virus or troan activity
in our system we can refer to the
following points for viruses we have
slowing down of the system and frequent
application freeze shows that the
infection of the virus is present in the
system then we have the viruses can also
steal sensitive data including passwords
Account Details which may lead to
unexpected log out from the accounts or
Corruption of the sensitive data
and lastly we have frequent system
crashes due to virus infection which
damages the operating system for Trojan
we have frequent system crashes and
system also faces slow reaction time
then we have there are more random
popups from the system which may
indicate troan activity and lastly we
have modification in the system
application and change of the dektop
appearance can be also due to the
infection of a troan program next let's
take a look at a famous Cyber attack for
virus and a Trojan
hor for virus we have the maom virus
which was identified in the year 2004
which affected over 50 million systems
by creating a network of sending spam
emails which was to gain back or access
into our
systems next for the Trojan Horse we
have the emot troan program which is a
specific designed for financial theft
and for stealing Bank related
information next we have few points for
how to prevent virus entry or troan
attack for a
system the most basic way of virus
protection is to using antivirus and do
regular viruses scan this will prevent
virus entry in the system and also
having more than one antivirus provides
budge better
protection then avoid visiting
uncertified websites can also prevent
virus entry into our
system then we have using regular driver
updates and system updates to prevent
virus entry for troan we have using
certified softwares from legal sites to
prevent any troan activity in our
system and also avoid clicking random
popups that we often see on the internet
and lastly using antivirus and firewalls
for protection against troan horses is a
good
habit now that we have reached the end
of the video Let's Take a look what we
learned for the first part we saw the
main objective of the virus is to harm
the data and information in a system
whereas for the troan we have stealing
of the data files and information effect
of viruses is more drastic in comparison
to the troan
horses then we have viruses which are
non remote programs whereas froan horses
are remote accessed and lastly viruses
have the ability to replicate itself to
harm multiple files where as strojan
does not have the replication ability so
let's begin with what is SQL
injection as the name suggest SQL
injection vulnerability allows an
attacker to inject malicious input into
a SQL statement so SQL stands for
structured query language which is a
language used by an application to
interact with the database now normally
this attack is targeted towards a
database to extract uh the data that is
stored within however the vulnerability
does not lie in the database itself the
vulnerability will always lie in the
application it is the developers
prerogative of how to develop the
application how to configure it to
prevent SQL injection queries from
happening a database is created to
answer questions and if a question is
asked it is supposed to answer it
database needs to be configured for some
amount of security but the vulnerability
the flaw here for SQL injection will
always lie in the application itself it
is how the application interacts with
the database that needs to be modified
that needs to be maintained by the
developer rather than just configuring
the database itself so the attacker at
this point in time when they send a
query to the application will form a
malformed query by injecting a
particular command or an operator that
is recognized by the SQL language and if
that operator is passed through the
application to the database then the
database basically gets cracked or does
a data dump because of that unwanted
character coming in so this character
needs to be filtered at the application
Level itself now let's look at a quick
demo so what we have done here is I have
this virtual machine called oasp broken
web applications virtual machine version
1.2 I'm going to power power this
on till this power is on I'm going to
show you where we can download this uh
utility from so you can just look for
OAS broken web application project
download you'll find it on
sourceforge.net click on the
link you can download the broken web
application project from here this is a
1.9gb download and you can have a zip
machine Direct for VMware or Oracle
virtual box now this is an application
that has been developed by oasp which
stands for open web application security
project which is a not for-profit
organization and uh periodically uh
releases the most top 10 risks that an
application uh will face for that
particular
year so they have given a web
application uh with inbuilt
vulnerabilities for professionals like
us to practice upon to develop our our
skills upon because doing this in the
real world is illegal I cannot go onto a
website to demonstrate how a SQL
injection attack Works uh neither should
you try your hands on it till you become
very well rehearsed with it so till to
upgrade your skills to upskill yourself
please download this machine hosted in a
vmw workstation or Oracle virtual box
and you can uh then try your skills on
it right so just going back to the
browser here if I open up uh a new tab
you'll see that this machine has booted
up and has an IP address called 71. 132
so if I just go on to that IP address
and I type in
19268 7113 to and you'll see the oasp
broken web application project and there
are lot of training applications
realistic intentionally vulnerable
applications old versions of real
applications and so on so forth so there
is a lot of applications in built over
here that you can try your skills upon
we are going to try to use the ovas
mutil day over here uh this gives you
the uh o top 10 risks for 2010 2013 2017
is the latest one so far uh but the
difference between 2013 and 2017 is that
some of these have changed but not all
of them uh the order has changed a
little bit but you can see that SQL
injection is on the top A1 amongst the
injection attacks right and you can see
there are multiple types that have been
given here the SQL injection for
extracting data or SQL injection for
bypass authentication or insert your
injection uh attacks blind SQL injection
and then there is a tool called SQL map
which is available freely on your Linux
machines Ki Linux or parot Linux
whichever you want to use uh for your
practice targets and so on so forth so
if I just take you here for bypass
authentic appliation and this is a
regular login page that an application
may have right you look at a username
you look at password you type that in
and you log in so let's say I don't know
a password here I'm just going to type
in the username test password is PSS WD
I try to log in and it shows me that the
account does not exist so the
authentication mechanism does work the I
did typ type in a username and password
it wasn't recognized so the account does
not exist now let's try to type in a SQL
query here I'm going to just give it a
single quote which is an operator that
is recognized by the SQL language which
when the database tries to execute uh
will cause the database to uh dump some
data or to bypass authentication in this
case and I'm going to give it a
condition single
quote or 1 equals 1 space hyphen hyphen
space and I'm going to click on Lo log
in now right now I'm not logged in at
all and we tried our username and
password and we weren't able to log in
so now if I log in you will see that it
give me a status update saying the user
has been authenticated and I'm logged in
as admin got root so that is what these
SQL queries can achieve I'm going to log
out right now and uh we're going to look
at the basics of SQL injection so
looking at that small demo looking now
let's look at what types of SE
injections are available so the first is
inband SQL injection the there are two
subtypes within inband error based
injection attack and a union based
injection attack the second type is
blind SQL injection attack where there's
a Boolean based and a Time based attack
and the third one is outof bound SQL
injection attack now what is inband SQL
injection attack inband is where you're
either attempting the error based or the
union based what is error based uh we
send a query to the dat database we
craft a query to the database and uh it
generates an error M message and it
dumps the error message right in front
of us on the screen that uh makes us
realize that there is a flaw and there
there is some information that is dumped
on the screen which we can then further
utilize to craft our further queries as
we go ahead whereas Union base is the it
is where we combine multiple statements
at the same time so if you look at the
URL uh earlier in the URL uh you would
see a large structure in that URL uh we
can try to add more two or more
statements within the URL itself to
combine them and then confuse the
database into executing both the
statements together and giving a data
dump at the same time right so what
would a error based uh SQL injection
look like if I go back to the same
database uh which is here right and if
you remember in the username we gave it
a single quote r 1 equal 1 space hyphen
hyphen space we give it the condition
right so basically what it did was this
a single code is an operator that goes
to the database selects the default uh
table uh in the user tables in this
database column and then Compares it to
the condition that is given so the
condition that we gave was 1 equals 1
which is always true so what it did was
it selected the default uh user table
that was available in the database and
instead of comparing it to a password it
compared it to the condition so if I
give it 1 equals 2 where the condition
is false and if I log in you will see
that the account doesn't exist comes
back again because the condition was
false and instead of comparing the user
account to the password it basically uh
compared the user account to the
condition so if I give it a single quote
or 1 equals 1 hyphen hyphen space uh and
log in you can see that this is a
correct condition and thus we are able
to log in now before we even go to that
extent if I just forget the condition
over here and I just give it a single
code the operator and I send this
operator to the database and I click on
login you will see that it generates an
error which is right on top and it tells
us the line the uh file where the error
happened and you can see it happened in
the MySQL handler. PHP file right and
then it give us the message you have an
error in your SQL syntax check the
manual that corresponds to your MySQL
server version for the right syntax to
use now why would a hacker want to do
this in the first place because there
are different types of databases so
there is a MySQL msql or Microsoft SQL
Oracle SQL IBM db2 all of these are
variations of the SQL database uh they
use the SQ language however every
database has its own Command right they
they have have their own syntax they
have their own uh specific commands that
are utilized for the database so in this
scenario the hacker wants to identify
what database is being currently
utilized so they can craft those
particular queries so now with this
injection with just me sending the quote
and the error getting generated I now
come to know that we are using a MySQL
server and the version of that server is
5.1.7 3 and uh the rest of the
information about uh where the handlers
are located and so on so forth right
this gives the information to the hacker
of how they want to proceed next what
kind of queries they want to create what
kind of syntax they want to utilize so
error based attack is where you generate
these kind of Errors uh and you get this
information the union base is where you
craft your queries within the URL uh you
can try to combine multiple statements
within the input fields and try to
generate a response from that then we
come to Boolean based SQL injection uh
sends a SQL query to the database which
forces the application to return a
different result depending on whether
the query returns a true or a false
result so basically if the input is
false the input both the inputs are
false the output would be false uh
there's one input that is false the
other input that is true input be the
output would be true and so on so forth
right so depending on the result from
the inputs that attack will come to to
know which input is true with this he
can then access the database of the
website so you're trying to figure out
by sending out multiple inputs uh and
then analyzing the output to see what
exactly uh which command exactly worked
what was the resultant output of that
command thus from this kind of an
information the hacker can infer their
next step forward then you have time
based SQL injections uh now there are
times when a database administrator an
application administrator has done some
security configuration and does have
disabled verbos error messages now what
is a verbos error message the error
message that we saw right here is a
verbos error message that means that the
message gives out details the message
gives out details about what the
database is the version and whatnot so
if they have sanitize these
errors and you no longer can generate
these errors and thus you cannot figure
out what database is then what do you do
right for example if I just take you to
Simply
learn
and take you to a URL that is supposedly
not accessible you can see that it gives
a generic error oops like it looks like
you have crash landed on Mars it doesn't
give you a verbose error that we saw
here so this gives us a detail error of
what went wrong where it gives us the
database the version of the database and
uh where the query went wrong and etc
etc etc whereas on this side where
there's some there's a lot of security
that goes in here so you can see that it
doesn't generate a error it just get a
generic page in front of you so in that
case what does a hacker do so the hacker
then injects a Time
based uh query in the URL which allows
us to verify whether the command is
being executed or not so uh we put in a
time
weit let's say 10 seconds of time weit
so if we the moment we inject the query
if the query times for 10 seconds and
then gets executed that means that the
SQL injection is possible however if we
inject the query and uh it just gets
executed without the delay that means
that the time uh injection attack would
not be uh possible on that particular
site out of bound is not a very common
attack it depends on the features being
enabled on the database management
system that is being used by the web
application so this can be a somewhat of
a misconfiguration error uh by the
database administrator where you have
enabled functions and not sanitized them
so you have not done in access controls
properly you have not given account
control so queries should never be
executed at an administrative level they
should always be uh executed at a user
level with minimum privileges that are
required for that query to be executed
now if you're allowing these kind of
functions to be uh to be enabled at the
dbms and there's an administrative
account that can have access to them at
that point in time an outof bound
injection attack is possible so let's
look at how a website works right uh how
SQL works on a website now the website
is constructed of HTML hypertext markup
language uh which would include
javascripting for functionality
cascading stylesheet for the mapping of
the website right and then reactjs and
whatnot uh for further functionality now
when we send a query to the website it
is normally using the HTTP protocol or
https protocol when the query reaches
the application the application would
then go ahead and generate the SQL query
uh at the client side you'll have uh all
these scripting languages coming in uh
on the front end uh that we can utilize
to craft queries and then send them
across at the server side you'll have uh
databases like Oracle MySQL Ms SQL and
so on so forth that will then execute
those queries right so just to give you
an example if I use a tool called
Postman what we generally do uh when we
craft a query is we send out a uh get
request to the website and then we
receive a response from the site uh with
the HTML code and everything so this is
a tool that is utilized by software
testers to test the responses that
you're going to get from various
websites so on the left hand side you
can see I've uh used it on quite a bit
uh here we have a example for gmail.com
so let's continue with that so this is a
get request being sent to Gmail the
moment I send it it's going to create an
HTTP request and send it across the
response that I get is this this is the
HTML code for
gmail.com right these are the cookies uh
these are the headers uh that include
information so you can see this is a
text HTML character set utilized is
utf8 and the configuration uh that has
been done with the application right so
this is where uh everything comes in
this is the cookie that has been sent
with that particular uh request that I
had sent out now if you Analyze This
query right so when we went onto this
application and I typed in that single
quote and we generated this error right
uh you can see that the application
converted this into a SQL query so the
query was select username from accounts
where the username in quotes single
quotes and we use the quote right the
single quote right there so uh that's
where we use that operator and that's
where the exception error occurred so
these are the kind of queries that are
structured by the application and then
taken onto the database for execution
when we type in uh it is a HTTP get
request with the username and password
within that query uh that is sent to the
application the application converts it
into a SQL query sends it to the
database and the database responds with
the appropriate response so how do we
prevent SQL injection in the first place
you use prepared statement and
parameterized queries uh these
statements make sure that the parameters
passed into SQL statements are treated
in a safe manner so for example we saw
that the single code was an operator
this shouldn't be allowed to be utilized
in the first place right so here what we
are doing here is a secure way of
running a SQL query in the jdbc using a
parameterized statement Define which
user we want to find so there's a string
the email comes in connection to the
database we are going to figure out how
the connection is going to be passed how
it is going to be created construct the
SQL statement we want to run specifying
the parameter right so we Define how is
it going to be uh created what is going
to be created what can be passed to the
database and what should not be passed
to the database so that is one way of uh
utilizing prepared statements and
parameterized queries then we have
object relational mapping most
development uh teams prefer to use OB
object relational mapping Frameworks to
the trans translation of SQL results set
into code objects more seamless so this
is an example of object relational
mapping uh where we map certain objects
and allow that to be executed and then
escaping inputs it a simple way to
protect against most SQL injection
attacks many languages have standard
functions to achieve this right so you
need to be very careful while using
Escape characters in your code base when
a SQL statement is constructed not all
injection attacks rely on abuse of code
characters so you need to know what
characters are being utilized uh in the
configuration that you have created in
the structure that you have created in
the code that you have created uh which
characters are being recognized as
operators you need to sanitize those
operators and you need to uh basically
ensure that these operators cannot be
accepted as user input if they are they
feed out by the application and they
never reach the database other methods
of uh pre bring SQL injection are uh
password hashing so that passwords
cannot be bypassed the passwords cannot
be recovered passwords cannot be cracked
uh third party authentication you use o
or uh some other service for a single
sign on mechanism does uh you rely on a
third party to maintain the security of
authentication and uh what kind of
parameters are passed for example uh
using LinkedIn logins or Facebook login
right uh for the Layman you normally go
onto Facebook and you allow if you're
using a game right if you start playing
a game you're allowed to log into the
game using your Facebook credentials or
your Google credentials now that is not
just for ease of use but the game user
the developer has outsourced the
authentication mechanisms to third party
such as Facebook or Google because they
understand that that authentication
mechanism is as safe as can be Facebook
and Google are wealthy organizations uh
hire a lot of Security Experts and the
development for their authentication
mechanisms is topnotch small
organization cannot spend that kind of
money on security itself right so you
use a third party authentication
mechanism to ensure that these kind of
attacks may not happen then web
application firewalls uh having a web
application firewall and configuring it
properly uh for SQL injection attacks is
one of the shhot method of uh mitigating
or minimizing the uh threat in the first
place so at this point in time you have
realized that the application has some
vulnerabilities for SQL injection and
instead of recoding or restructuring the
application uh you want to take the
easier way out or the cheaper way out so
what you do is you uh you install a web
application firewall and you configure
the web application firewall to identify
malicious queries and stop them uh at
the firewall level itself so they never
reach the application and thus the word
abilities on the application don't get
executed buy better
software and keep on updating the
software so it's not necessary that once
you have a software you install it it's
going to be safe for Life new V
abilities are discovered every day every
hour and it may so happen what is secure
today may be completely insecure
tomorrow or the day after right so you
need to keep on upgrading the software
if there are no upgrades available and
the varability still exist you might
want to migrate to a better software and
does uh ensure that you don't get hacked
right always update and use patches
organizations keep on sending out
updates and patches as and when they are
released you need to install them to uh
enhance your security postures and then
continuously monitor SQL statements and
databases use protocol monitors uh use
different softwares use the firewalls to
keep on monitoring what kind of queries
you uh getting and based on those
queries you want to to ensure the inputs
and the queries that are creating uh are
not detrimental to the health of the
software that you have Jane is relaxing
at home when she receives an email from
a bank that asks her to update her
credit card pin in the next 24 hours as
a security measure judging the severity
of the message Jane follows the link
provided in the email on delivering her
current credit card pin and the
supposedly updated one the website
became unresponsive which prompted her
to try sometime later however after a
couple of hours she noticed a
significant purchase from a random
website on that same credit card which
she never authorized frantically
contacting the bank Jane realized the
original email was a counterfeit or a
fake message with the malicious link
that entailed credit card fraud this is
a classic example of a fishing attack
fishing attacks are a type of social
engineering where a fraudulent message
is sent to a Target on the premise of
arriving from a trusted Source its basic
purpose is to trick the victim into
revealing sensitive information like
passwords and payment information it's
based on the word fishing which works on
the concept of baits if a supposed
victim catches the bait the attack can
go ahead which in our case makes Jane
the fish and the fishing emails the bait
if Jane never opened the malicious link
or was cautious about the email
authenticity an attack of this nature
would have been relatively ineffective
but how does the hacker gain access to
these credentials a fishing attack
starts with a fraudulent message which
can be transmitted via email or chat
applications even using SMS
conversations to impersonate legitimate
sources is known as smishing which is a
specific category of fishing attacks
irrespective of the manner of
transmission the message targets the
victim in a way that coaxes them to open
a malicious link and provide critical
information on the requisite website
more often than not the websites are
designed to look as authentic as
possible once the victims submit
information using the link be it a
password or credit card details the data
is sent to the hacker who designed the
email and the fake website giving him
complete control over the account whose
password was just provided often carried
out in campaigns where an identical
fishing mail sent to thousands of users
the rate of success is relatively low
but never zero
between 2013 and 2015 corporate giants
like Facebook and Google were tricked
off of $100 million due to an extensive
fishing campaign where a known common
associate was impersonated by the
hackers apart from credit access some of
these campaigns Target the victim device
and install malware when clicked on the
malicious links which can later function
as a botn net or a target for ransomware
attacks there is no single formula for
there are multiple categories of fishing
attacks tax the issue with Jane where
the hacker sto her bank credentials
falls under the umbrella of deceptive
fishing a general email is sent out to
thousands of users in this category
hoping some of them fall prey to this
scam spear fishing on the other hand is
a bit customized version the targets are
researched before being sent an email
for example if you never had a Netflix
subscription sending you an email that
seems like the Netflix Team sends it
becomes pointless this is a potential
drawback of deceptive fishing techniques
on the other hand a simple screenshot of
a Spotify playlist being shared on
social media indicates a probable point
of entry the hacker can send counterfeit
messages to the Target user while
implying the source of such messages
being Spotify tricking them into sharing
private information since the hacker
already knows the target uses Spotify
the chances of victims taking the bait
increase substantially for more
important targets like CEOs and people
with a fortune on their back the
research done is 10 full which can be
called a case of wailing the hackers
prepare and wait for the right moment to
launch their fishing attack often to
steal industry secrets for rival
companies or sell them off at a higher
price apart from just emails farming
focuses on fake websites that resemble
their original counterparts as much as
possible a prevalent method is to use
domain names like Facebook with a single
o or YouTube with no e these are
mistakes that people make when typing
the full URL in the browser leading them
straight to a counterfeit web page which
can fool them into submitting private
data a few more complex methods exist to
drive people onto fake websites like ARP
spoofing and DNS cash poisoning but they
are rarely carried out due to time and
resource constraints now that we know
how fishing attacks work let's look at
ways to prevent ourselves from becoming
victims while the implications of a
fishing attack can be extreme protecting
yourself against these is relatively
straightforward Jane could have saved
herself from credit card fraud had she
checked the link in the email for
authenticity and that it redirected to a
secure website that runs on the https
protocol even suspicious messages
shouldn't be entertained one must also
refrain from entering private
information on random websites or pop-up
Windows irrespective of how legitimate
they seem it is also recommended to use
secure anti- fishing browser extensions
like cloudfish to sniff out malicious
emails from legitimate ones the best way
to prevent fishing is browsing the
internet with care and being on alert
for malicious attempts at all times
start by learning about cross-site
scripting from a Layman's
perspective cross-site scripting also
known as xss is a type of code injection
attack that occurs on the client side
the attacker intends to run harmful
scripts in the victim's web browser by
embedding malicious code in a genuine
web page or online application the the
real Attack takes place when the victim
hits the malicious code infected web
page or online application the web page
or application serves as a vehicle for
the malicious script to be sent to the
user's browser forums message boards and
online pages that enable comments are
vulnerable vehicles that are frequently
utilized for cross scripting
assaults a web page or web application
is vulnerable to xss if the output it
creates contains unsanitized user input
the victim's browser must then parse
this user input in VB script ActiveX
Flash and even CSS cross-side scripting
attacks are conceivable they are
nevertheless most ubiquitous in
JavaScript o to the fact that JavaScript
is most important to most browser
experiences
nowadays the main purpose of this attack
is to steal the other users identity be
it via cookies session tokens and other
information in most of the cases this
attack is being used to steal the other
person's cookies as we know cookies help
us to log in automatically therefore
with the stolen cookies we can log in
with other identities and this is one of
the reasons why this attack is
considered as one of the riskiest
attacks it can be performed with
different client side programming
languages as
well cross-side scripting is often
compared with similar client side
attacks as client side languages are
mostly being used during this however an
xss attack is considered riskier because
of its ability to damage even less
vulnerable
Technologies most often this attack is
performed with JavaScript and HTML
JavaScript is a programming language
that runs on web pages inside your
browser the client site code adds
functionality and interactivity to the
web page and is used extensively on all
major applications and CMS platforms
unlike servers side languages such as
PHP JavaScript code runs inside your
browser and cannot impact the website
for other visitors it is sandboxed to
your own Navigator and can only perform
actions within your own browser window
while JavaScript is client side and does
not run on the server it can be used to
interact with the server by performing
background requests attackers can then
use these background request to add
unwanted spam content to a web page
without refreshing it they can then
gather analytics about the client's
browser or perform actions
asynchronously the manner of attack can
range in a variety phase it can be a
single link which the user must click on
to initiate a JavaScript piece of code
it can be used to show any piece of
images that can be later used as a front
end for malicious code being installed
as malware but the majority of Internet
users unaware of how metadata works or
the ways in which web requests are
called the chances of victims clicking
on a redirecting links is far too high
cross-side scripting can occur on the
malicious script executed at the
client's side using a fake page or even
a form that is displayed to the user on
websites with displayed advertisements
malicious emails can also be sent to the
victim these attacks occur when the
malicious user finds the vulnerable
parts of the website and sends it as
appropriate malicious
input now that we understand the basics
of cross-side scripting let us learn
more about how this kind of attack
works in the first place we have the
website or the web browser which is used
to show content to the victim or which
is the user in our case whenever the
user wants to grab some content from the
website the website asks the data from
the server the server provides this
information to the website and the web
browser which ultimately resist the
victim how the hacker comes into play
here it passes on certain arguments to
the web browser which is can be then
forwarded back to the server or to the
user at hand the entire cross-site
scripting attack Vector means sending
and injecting malicious code or script
this attack can be performed in
different ways depending on the type of
attack the malicious script may be
reflected on the victim's browser or
stored in the database and executed
every time when the user calls the
appropriate function the main reason for
this attack is in appropriate users
input validation where the malicious
input can get into the output a
malicious user can enter a script which
will be injected onto the website's code
then the browser is not able to know if
the executed code is malicious or not
therefore this malicious script is being
executed on the victim's browser or any
faked form if that is being displayed
for the users there are many ways to
trigger an xss attack for example the
execution could be triggered
automatically when the page loads or
when a user hovers over specific
elements of the page like hyperlinks
potential consequences of cross-site
scripting attacks include capturing
keystrokes of a user redirecting a user
to malicious websites running web
browser based exploits obtaining cookie
information of a user who is logged into
a website and many more in some cases
cross-side scripting attack leads to
complete compromise of the victim's
account attackers can trick users into
entering credentials on a fake form
which can then provide all information
to the attacker with the basic working
of a cross-side scripting attack out of
the way let us go over the different
ways hackers can leverage vulnerable web
applications to gather information and
eventually breach those system
the prime purpose of Performing xss
attack is to steal the other person's
identity as mentioned it may be cookies
session tokens
Etc xss may also be used to display
faked Pages or forms for the victim
however this can be performed in several
ways we have a reflected attack this
attack occurs when a malicious script is
not being saved on the web server but is
reflected in the website results reflect
accss codee is not being saved
permanently in this case the malicious
code is being reflected in any website
result the attack code can be included
in the faked URL or in the HTTP
parameters it can affect the victim in
different ways by displaying faked
malicious page or by sending a malicious
email in a reflected cross-side
scripting example the input of a search
form is reflected on the page to show
what the search key was an attacker May
craft a URL that contains malicious code
and then spread the same URL via email
or social media a user who clicks on
this link opens the valid web
application which then runs the
malicious code in the browser the script
is not stored in the web application and
malicious code is shown only to one user
the user that opens the link executes
the script and the attack is not
necessarily visible on the server side
or to the app owner
itself the next variant is a stored
cross-side scripting attacks this occurs
when a malicious script is being saved
on the web server
permanently this can be considered a
riskier attack since it has leverage for
more damage in this type of attack the
malicious code or script is being saved
on the server for example in the
database of the website it is executed
every time the users call the
appropriate
functionality this way stored xss attack
can affect many users also as the script
is being stored on the web server it
will affect the website for a longer
time
in order to perform stored xss attack
the malicious scripts should be sent
through the vulnerable input form for
example can be a commment field or a
review
field this way the appropriate script
will be saved in the database and
evaluated on the page load or
appropriate function
calling in a stored xss example the
script might have been submitted by an
input field to the web server which did
not perform a sufficient validation and
stores the script permanently in the
data database the consequence of this
might be that the script is now being
delivered to all users visiting the web
application and for example able to gain
access to the user session
cookies in this attack the script is
permanently stor in the web app the
users visiting the app after the
information retrieve the script the
malicious code then exploits the flaws
in the web application and the script
and the attack is visible on the server
side or to the app owner as
well the third variant is Dom based
cross-site scripting attacks this type
of attack occurs when the Dom
environment is being changed but the
client side code does not change when
the Dom environment is being modified in
the victim's browser the client side
code executes differently in order to
get a better understanding of how xss
Dom attack is being performed Let Us
analyze the following example if there
is a website called texting.com we know
default is a parameter therefore in
order to to perform xss Dom attack we
should send a script as
parameters a Dom based xss attack may be
successfully executed even when the
server does not embed any malicious code
into the web page by using a flaw in the
JavaScript executed in the browser for
example if the client side JavaScript
modifies the Dom tree of the web page it
can be based on an input field or the
get parameter without validating the
input this allows the malicious code to
be
executed the malicious quote the
exploits flaws in the browser on the
user side and the script and the attack
is not necessarily visible on the server
side or to the app
owner by now it is clear that cross-side
scripting attacks are difficult to
detect and even tougher to fight against
there are however plenty of fears one
can Safeguard against such attacks let's
go through some of these preventive
measures like mentioned earlier xss
attacks are sometimes difficult to
detect however this can be changed if
you get some external help a way to
prevent xss attacks is using automated
testing tools like crash test security
suit or actic security
suit still manual testing is highly
timec consuming and costly and therefore
not possible to be done for every
iteration of your web
application consequently your code
shouldn't be untested before any release
using automated security you can scan
your web application for cross-side
scripting and other critical
vulnerabilities before every release
this way you can ensure that your web
application live version is still
secured whenever you alter or add a
feature input fields are the most common
point of entry for xss attack script
therefore you should always screen and
validate any information input into data
fields this is particularly important if
the data will be included as HTML output
this can be used to protect against
reflected accss
attacks validation should occur on both
the client site and server site as an
added precaution this helps validating
the data before it's being sent to the
servers and can also protect against
persistent xss scripts this can be
accomplished using JavaScript accss
attacks only appear if any user input is
being displayed on the web page
therefore try to avoid displaying any
untrusted user input if possible if you
need to display user data restrict the
places where the user input might appear
any input displayed inside a JavaScript
tag or a URL shown on the site is much
more likely to be exploited than the
input that appears inside a division or
a span element inside the HTML body
protecting against accss vulnerabilities
typically requires properly escaping
user provided data that is placed on the
page rather than trying to determine if
the data is user provided and could be
compromised we should always play it
safe and Escape data whether it is user
provided or not unfortunately because
there are many different rules for
escaping you still must choose the
proper type of escaping before settling
on a final
code encoding should be applied directly
before user controllable data is written
to a page because the context you're
writing into determines what kind of
encoding you need to use for example
values inside a JavaScript string
require a different type of escaping to
those in an HTML context sometimes
you'll need to apply multiple layers of
encoding in the correct order for
example to safely embed user input
inside an event handler you need to deal
with both JavaScript context and the
HTML context so you need to First uni
code escape the input and then HTML
encoded content security policy or CSP
is a computer security standard
introduced to prevent cross-side
scripting clickjacking and and other
code injection attacks resulting from
the execution of malicious content in
The Trusted web page context it is a
candidate recommendations of the w3c
working group on web application
security it's widely supported by modern
web browsers and provides a standard
method for website owners to declare
approved origins of content that browser
should be allowed to load on that
website HTTP only is an additional flag
included in a set cookie HTTP response
header using the HTTP only flag when
generating a cookie helps mitigate the
risk of client side script accessing the
protected cookie that is if the browser
supports it if the HTTP only flag is
included in the HTTP response header the
cookie cannot be accessed through a
client side script again this is if the
browser supports this flag as a result
even if a cross-side scripting flaw
exists and a user accidentally accesses
a link that exploits this flaw the
browser will not reveal the cookie to a
third
party if a browser does not support HTTP
only and a website attempts to set an
HTTP only cookie the HTTP only flag will
be ignored browser browser thus creating
a traditional script accessible cookie
as a result the cookie becomes
vulnerable to theft of modification by
any malicious script next on our docket
is a live demonstration where we solve a
set of cross-side scripting problems
starting from the basic level to the
topmost level six we're going to start
at level
one in this verb application it
demonstrates the common cause of cross
side scripting where user input is
directly included in the page without
proper
escaping if you interact with the
vulnerable application window here and
find a way to make it execute JavaScript
of our choosing we can take actions
inside the vulnerable window or directly
edit its URL bar this task needs only
basic knowledge let's see why the most
primitive injections work here right
away let's do a simple query and inspect
the resulting HTML
page I'm going to use this
phrase with a single quod as a special
character we can now inspect the HTML
page we can see here in this
line the special character single code
appears in the result over
here the provided query text is placed
directly in a b tag as in a body element
we need to perform a reflected xss into
the web application because they are
non-persistent xss attacks and the P
load should be included in the URL to
perform successful
exploitation we can use any payload but
we're going to use the simple one to
perform an alert in this web application
it's simple and can be shown
easily we just going to write the script
over
here I'm going to press search
as you can see we have successfully
launched our first cross-site scripting
attack we can see an alert box pop up
with the necessary message and a similar
process can be used to steal browser
cookies and passwords albeit with
different
commands now we have the option to move
to level
two in this web application it shows
that how easily xss bugs can be
introduced in complex chat applications
chat app conversations are stored in a
database and retrieved when a user wants
to see the conversation therefore if a
malicious user injects some JavaScript
code all visitors will be infected this
kind of cross-site scripting attack is
more powerful and it is more riskier
than reflected cross scripting attacks
and that's why is known as stored
xss I posted my
query with a special character of a
single quote and this is what I get
whatever I typed in simply appeared on
the page right after I click on share
status let's see the
source you can see here the text I
posted seems directly put inside a block
code tag so even a simple script tag we
used in level one should work here but
it will not let us examine the code to
understand why
we're going to toggle the code of here
and check the index.html
file important
part is line
32 the generated HTML fragment which is
the HTML variable in the code is added
to the male HTML using the inner HTML
method so when the browser passing this
HTML fragment it will not execute any
script tag defined within that HTML
fragment HTML parer will not execute a
script tag when it passes htmls via this
method this is why the script tag like
we used in level one is not going to
work here our solution is to use events
events will execute the defined
javascripts we're going to use an image
over
here
and when we press on share
status in the above injection we are
loading an image that doesn't exist
which causes to trigger an on error
event in on error event the it will
execute our alert
method with that we are able to beat
level two and we can now move up to the
next level in our
challenge as you can see clicking on any
tab causes the tab number to be
displayed in the URL
fragment this hints that the value after
the hashtag controls the behavior of the
page that is it is an input variable to
confirm let's analyze the
code as you can see in line 43 inside
the event
handling the value provided after the
hash in the
URL is directly passed onto the chew tab
method no input validation is being
performed the value passed to the choose
tab method is directly injected into the
IMG tag in line
17 this is an unsafe assignment and it
is the vulnerable part of the code now
all we have to do now is to craft a
payload that would adjust the IMG tag to
execute our JavaScript remember the
script tag from level one would not work
here since the variable HTML is used to
add the Dom dynamically hence the events
are ases here once again I will choose
to use use the existing IMG tag and
change the source to something that
doesn't exist hence forcing it to fall
into to execute an on error even which I
will pass the
URL
once we visit that URL we can see that
our Java popup has opened up here with
the same message of xss level 3 has been
completed with this we can now move on
to level four which is going to present
a different kind of attack
in this application there is a timer on
the page that means whatever numbers we
put in the Box a countdown starts and
then when it finishes the application
alerts that the countdown is
finished and we can see the time is a
popup appearing over here and this
resets the timer again now it is obvious
that the value entered in the text box
is transferred to the server over the
timer parameter in the UR
L let us examine the code to see how the
timer parameter is being
handled we're going to visit timer. HTML
over
here and we're going to check over
here in line
21 the start timer method is being
called in the onload event however the
timer parameter is being directly passed
to the start timer method we need to
perform a popup Alert in the web
application which escapes the content of
the function start timer without baking
the JavaScript code the parameter value
is directly added to the start timer
method without any filtering what we can
try to do here is to inject an alert
function to be executed inside the on
loone event along with the start timer
method we're going to remove this
argument and put our script over
here
now when me press on create
timer and we have a popup with xss level
completed we can now move on to level
five in this web application this
application xss is different cuz this
challenge description says cross-side
scripting isn't just about correctly
escaping
data so sometimes attackers can do bad
things even without injecting new
elements into the Dom it's kind of open
redirect cuz the attack payload is
executed as a result of modifying the
Dom environment in the victim's browser
this environment is used by the original
client side script so that the client
side code runs in an unexpected manner
the vulnerability can be easily detected
if the next Link in the signup page is
inspected
the href attribute value of next link is
confirm which is exactly the value of
the next URL query
parameter as you can see over here this
means using the next query parameter can
be used to inject a JavaScript code to
the href attribute of the next link the
following is the best way to do it as
soon as the user clicks on the link the
script script will be
triggered
going to press anything random and now
that we click next we can see the xss
level 5 that we had provided in the URL
as a parameter to the next
variable since the value of next
provided appears on a popup we can
consider the attack a success and move
on to the final level
six in this we application it show some
of the external Javascript is
received if you analyze the URL you can
see that the script is loaded already
the vulnerability lies within how the
code handles the value after the
hashtag if you check on line 45 the
value right after the hashtag is taken
as the gadget name and then in line
48 the value is directly passed on to
the include Gadget method another the
include Gadget method that we can see
over
here you can see in line 8
18 a script tag is created and the URL
Gadget name parameter value is directly
used as the source attribute of the
script tag in line
28 this means we can completely control
the source attribute of the script tag
that is being
created that is with this vulnerability
we can inject our own Javascript file
into the code we can inject a URL of our
own hosted JavaScript into the web
application's URL after the hashtag and
the URL should not be using using https
but anything like that to bypass the
regular expression for security
checking going to remove the pre-stored
URL and we're going to load our own
Javascript
file
finally we have reached the end of our
challenge we completed six different
varieties of cross scripting attacks and
used different solutions for all of the
six questions with work from home being
the norm in today's era people spend
considerable amount of time on the
internet often with without specific
measures to ensure a secure session
apart from individuals organizations
worldwide that host data and conduct
business over the internet are always at
the risk of a DS attack these dos
attacks are getting more extreme with
hackers getting easy access to bot net
farms and compromised devices as can be
seen in the graph three of the six
strongest DDOS attacks were launched in
2021 with the most extreme attack
occurring just last year in 2020 lately
cyber criminals have been actively
seeking out new services and protocols
for amplifying these DS attacks active
involvement with hacked machines and
botet allow further penetration into the
consumer space allowing much more
elaborate attack campaigns apart from
General users multinational corporations
have also had their fair share of
problems GitHub a platform for software
developers was the target of a DS attack
in 2018 widely suspected to be conducted
by Chinese authorities this attack went
on for about 20 minutes after which the
systems were brought into a stable
condition it was the strongest DS attack
to date at the time and made a lot of
companies reconsider the security
practices to combat such attacks even
after years of experimentation dedos
attacks are still at large and can
affect anyone in the consumer and
corporate space hey everyone this is B
from Simply learn and welcome to this
video on what is a DS attack let's learn
more about what is a Dos
attack a distributed denial of service
attack or dos is when an attacker or
attackers attempt to make it impossible
for a service to be delivered this can
be achieved by thating access to
virtually anything servers devices
Services networks applications and even
specific transactions within
applications in a Dos attack it's one
system that is sending the malicious
data or requests a detos attack comes
from multiple systems generally these
attacks work by Drowning a system with
requests for data this could be sending
a web server so many requests to serve a
page that it crashes under the demand or
it could be a database being hit with a
high volume of queries the result is
available internet bandwidth CPU and RAM
capacity become
overwhelmed the impact could range from
a minor annoyance from disrupted
services to experiencing entire websites
applications or even entire businesses
taking offline more often than not these
attacks are launched using machines in a
botnet a botnet is a network of devices
that can be triggered to send requests
from a remote Source often known as the
command and control center the bots in
the network attack a particular Target
thereby hiding the original perpetrator
of the DS campaign but how do these
devices come under a botnet and what are
the requests being made to the web
servers let's let's learn more about
these and how dos attack
work a DS attack is a two-phase process
in the first phase a hacker creates a
bot net of devices simply put a vast
network of computers are hacked via
malware ransomware or just simple social
engineering these devices become a part
of the botn net which can be triggered
anytime to start bombarding a system or
a server on the instruction of the
hacker that created the botn net the
device in this networks are called Bots
or zombies in the second phase a
particular Target is selected for the
attack when the hacker finds the right
time to attack all the zombies in the
botnet network send these requests to
the Target thereby taking up all the
servers available bandwidth these can be
simple ping requests or complex attacks
like SN flooding and UDP flooding the
aim is to overwhelm them with more
traffic than the server or the network
can accommodate the goal is to render
the website or service
inoperable there's a lot of wiggle room
when it comes to the type of DS attack a
hacker can go with depending on the
target's vulnerability we can choose one
of the three broad categories of DS
attacks volume based attacks use massive
amounts of bogus traffic to overwhelm a
resource it can be a website or a server
they include icmp udap and spoofed
packet flood attacks the size of volume
based attack is measured measured in
bits per second these attacks focus in
clogging all the available bandwidth for
the server thereby cutting the supply
short several requests are sent to the
server all of which warrant a reply
thereby not allowing the target to cater
to the general legitimate
users next we have the protocol level
attacks these attacks are meant to
consume essential resources of the
target server they exhaust the load
balances and firewalls which are meant
to protect the system against the dors
attacks these protocol attacks include
SN floods and Smurf DDOS among others
and the size is measured in packets per
second for example in an SSL handshake
server replies to the Hello message sent
by the hacker which will be the client
in this case but since the IP is spoofed
and leads nowhere the server gets stuck
in an endless loop of sending the
acknowledgement without any end in
sight finally we have the application
Level attacks application layer attacks
are conducted by flooding applications
with maliciously crafted requests the
size of application layer attacks is
measured in request per second these are
relatively sophisticated attacks that
Target the application and operating
system level
vulnerabilities they prevent the
specific applications from delivering
necessary information to users and hog
the network banded up to the point of a
system crash examples of such an attack
are HTTP flooding and bgp hijacking
a single device can request data from a
server using HTTP post or get without
any
issues however when the requisite botnet
is instructed to bombard the server with
thousands of requests the database
bandwidth gets jammed and it eventually
becomes unresponsive and
unusable but what about the reasons for
such an attack there are multiple lines
of thought as to why a hacker decides to
launch a DS attack on unsuspecting
targets let's take a look at a few of
them
the first option is to gain a
competitive Advantage many ds attacks
are conducted by hacking communities
against Ral groups some organizations
hire such communities to stagger their
Rivals resources at a network level to
gain an advantage in the playing field
since being a victim of a dets attack
indicates a lack of security the
reputation of such a company takes a
significant hit allowing the rivals to
cover up some
ground secondly some hackers launched
these seos attacks to hold multinational
corporations at Ransom the resources are
jammed and the only way to clear the way
is if the target company agrees to pay a
designated amount of money to the
hackers even a few minutes of inactivity
is detrimental to a company's reputation
in the global market and it can cause a
spiral effect both in terms of market
value and product security index most of
the time a compromise is reached and the
resources are freed after a while tto
attacks have also found use in the
political segment certain activists tend
to use dedos attacks to voice their
opinion spreading the word online is
much faster than any local Rally or
Forum primarily political these attacks
also focus on online communities ethical
dilemas or even protest against
corporations let's take a look at a few
ways that companies and individuals can
protect themselves against redos
attacks the company can employ load
balance and firewalls to help protect
the data from such attacks load
balancers reroute the traffic from one
server to another in a DS attack this
reduces the single point of failure and
adds resiliency to the server data a
firewall blocks unwanted traffic into a
system and manages the number of
requests made at a definite rate it
checks for multiple attacks from a
single IP and occasional slowdowns to
detect a Dos attack in
action early detection of a Dos attack
goes a long way in recovering the data
lost in such an event once you've
detected the attack you will have to
find a way to respond for example you
will have to work on dropping the
malicious D dos traffic before it
reaches your server so that it doesn't
throttle and exhaust your bandwidth
here's where you will filter the traffic
so that only legitimate traffic reaches
the server by intelligent routing you
can break the remaining traffic into
manageable chunks that can be handled by
a cluster resources the the most
important stage in DOS mitigation is
where you will look for patterns of Dos
attacks and use those to analyze and
strengthen your mitigation techniques
for example blocking an IP that's
repeatedly found to be offending is a
first
step Cloud providers like Amazon web
services and Microsoft Azure who offer
high levels of cyber security including
firewalls and threat monitoring software
can help protect your assets and network
from DS criminals the cloud also has
greater bandd than most private networks
so it is likely to fail if under the
pressure of increased TS
attacks additionally reputable Cloud
providers offer Network redundancy
duplicating copies of your data systems
and equipment so that if your service
becomes corrupted or unavailable due to
a Dos attack you can switch to a secure
access on backed up versions without
missing a beat one can also increase the
amount of bandwidth available to a host
server being targeted since GS attacks
fundamentally operate on the principle
of overwhelming systems with heavy
traffic simply provisioning extra
bandwidth to handle unexpected traffic
spikes can provide a measure of
protection this solution can prove
expensive as a lot of that bandwidth is
going to go unused most of the
time a Content delivery Network or a CDN
distributes your content and boost
performance by minimizing the distance
between your resources and end users it
stores the cach fors of your content in
multiple locations and this eventually
mitigates dos attacks by avoiding a
single point of failure when the
attacker is trying to focus on a single
Target popular CDN include aomi CDN
Cloud flare AWS cloudfront
Etc let's start with our demo regarding
the effects of DS attacks on a system
for our demo we have a single device
that will attack a Target making it a
Dos attack of sorts once a bot net is
ready multiple devices can do the same
and eventually emulate a DS attack to do
so we will use the virtualization
software called VMware with an instance
of parad security operating system
running for a Target machine we will be
running another VMware instance of a
standard Linux distribution known as
Linux light in a Target device we can
use wire shockk to determine when the
attack begins and see the effects of the
attack
accordingly this is Linux SL which is a
target machine and this is parot
security which is used by the hacker
when trying to launch a DS attack this
is just one of the dros that can be
used to launch the attack we must first
find the IP address of our
Target so to find the IP address we open
the
terminal we use the command if config
and here we can find the IP address now
remember we're launching this attack in
VMware now the both the instances of
parro security and Linux light are being
run on my local network so the address
that you can see here is
192.168
72129 which is a private address this IP
cannot be accessed from outside the
network basically anyone who is not
connected to my Wi-Fi when launching
attacks with public servers or public
addresses it will have a public IP
address that does not belong to the
subnet once we have the IP
address we can use a tool
called hping
3 hping 3 is an open- Source package
generator and analyzer for the TCP IP
protocol to check what are the effects
of an attack we will be using wire shark
yock is a network traffic analyzer you
can see whatever traffic that is passing
through the Linux light drro is being
displayed over here with the IP address
the source IP and the destination IP as
to where the request is being
transferred to once we have the Dos
attack launched you can see the results
coming over here from The Source IP
which will be par security Now to launch
the hping 3 command we need to give PSE
sudo access to the console which is the
root
AIS now we have the root axis for the
console the hping 3 command will have a
few arguments to go with it which are as
you can see on the
screen minus s and a
flood a hyphen
V hyphen p80 and the IP address of the
target which is is2 168
72129 in this command we have a few
arguments that such as the minus s which
specifies SN packets like in an SSL
handshake we have the SN request that
the client sends to the server to
initiate a connection The Hyphen flood
aims to ignore the replies that the
server will send back to the client in
response to the SN packets here the par
security OS is the client and Linux
slide being the
server minus v stands for verbosity as
in where we will see some output when
the requests are being sent the hyphen
p80 stands for Port 80 which we can
replace the port number if we want to
attack a different port and finally we
have the IP address of our
Target as of right now if we check wire
shock it is relative ly clear and there
is no indication of a DS attack incoming
now once we launch the attack over
here we can see the requests coming in
from this IP which is 192 168 72.1
128 till now even if the network is
responsive and so is Linux
light the request keep on coming and we
can see the http
flooding has started in flood
mode after a few seconds of this attack
continuing the server will start
shutting down now remember Linux light
is a drro that can focus on and that
serves as a
backend now remember Linux light is a
drro and such Linux dros are served as
backend to many servers across the world
for example a few seconds have passed
from the attack now the system has
become completely irresponsive this has
happened due to the huge number of
requests that came from par
security you can see whatever I pressed
nothing is responded even the wire shark
has stopped capturing new request
because the CPU usage right now is
completely 100% and at this point of
time anyone who is trying to request
some information from this Linux drro or
where this Linux Destro is being used as
a backend for a server or a database
cannot access anything else the system
has completely stopped responding and
any request any legitimate request from
legitimate users will be
dropped once you stop the attack over
here it takes a bit of time to settle
down now remember it's still out of
control but eventually the traffic dies
down and the system regains its strength
it is relatively easy to gauge right now
the effect of a Dos attack now remember
this Linux light is just a VM instance
actual website servers and web databases
they have much more bandwidth and are
very secure and it is tough to break
into that is why we cannot use a single
machine to break into them that is where
a DS attack comes into play what we did
right now is a Dos attack as in a single
system is being used to penetrate a
Target server using a single request now
when a Dos attack multiple systems such
as multiple pirat it instances or
multiple zombies or bots in a bot nut
Network can attack a Target server to
completely shut down the machine and
drop any legitimate request thereby
rendering the service and the target
completely unusable and
inoperable as a final note we would like
to remind that this is for educational
purposes only and we do not endorse any
attacks on any domains only test this on
servers and networks that you have
permission to test on cyber security has
become one of the most rigid Industries
in the last decade while simultaneously
being the most challenged with every
aspect of corporate culture going online
and embracing cloud computing there is a
plethora of critical data circulating
through the internet all worth billions
of dollars to the right person
increasing benefits require more complex
attacks and one of these attacks is a
Brute Force attack a brute force or
known as boot Force cracking is the
Cyber attack equivalent of trying every
key on your key ring and eventually
finding the right one boot Force attacks
are simple and reliable there is no
prior knowledge needed about the victim
to start an attack most of the systems
falling prey to Brute Force attacks are
actually well
secured attackers let a computer do the
work that is trying different
combinations of usernames and passwords
until they find a one that works due to
this repeated trial and error format the
strength of password matters a great
deal although with enough time and
resources brute force will breaker
System since they run multiple
combinations until they find the right
passcode hey everyone this is B from
Simply learn and welcome to this video
on what is a Brute Force attack let's
begin with learning about Brute Force
attacks in
detail a Brute Force attack also known
as an exhaustive search is a
cryptographic hack that relies on
guessing possible combinations of
targeted password until the current
password is discovered it can be used to
break into online accounts and crypto
documents or even Network peripheral
devices the longer the password the more
combinations that will need to be tested
a br Force attack can be time consuming
and difficult to perform if methods such
as data aisc are used and at times
downright
impossible however if the password is
weak it could merely take seconds with
hardly any effort dictionary attacks are
an alternative to Brute Force attacks
but the attacker already has a list of
usernames and passwords that need to be
tested against the target it doesn't
need to create any other combinations on
its own dictionary attacks are much more
reliable than brute force in a real
world context but the usefulness depends
entirely on the strength of passwords
being used by the general
population there is a three-step process
when it comes to brute forcing a system
let's learn about each of them in
detail in step one we have to settle on
a tool that we are going to use for
brute forcing there are some popular
names on the market like
hashcat Hydra and John the Ripper while
each of them has its own strength and
weaknesses each of them perform well
with the right configuration all of
these tools come pre-installed with
certain Linux distributions that cater
to penetration testers and cyber
security analysts like K Linux and parro
security after deciding what tool to use
we can start generating combinations of
alpha numeric variables whose only
limitation is the number of characters
for example while using Hydra a single
six-digit password will create 900,000
passwords with only digits involved add
alphabets and symbols to that sample
space and that numbers grows
exponentially the popular tools allow
customizing this process let's say the
hacker is aware of the password being a
specific eight-digit word containing
only letters and symbols this will
substantially increase the chances of
being able to gu the right password
since we remove the time taken to
generate the longer ones we omit the
need for including digits in such
combinations these small tweaks go a
long way in organizing an efficient
Boost Force attack since running all the
combinations with no filters will
dramatically reduce the odds of finding
the right credentials in time in the
final step we run these combinations
against the file or service that is
being broken we can try and break into a
specific encrypted document a social
media account or even devices at home
that connect to the internet let's say
there is a Wi-Fi router the generated
passwords are then fed into the
connection one after the other it is a
long and arduous process but the work is
left to the computer other than someone
manually clicking and checking each of
these
passcodes any password that doesn't
unlock the router is discarded and The
Brute Force tool simply moves on to the
next one this keeps going on until we
find the right combination which unlocks
the router
sometimes reaching the success stage
takes days and weeks which makes it
cumbersome for people with low computing
power at their disposal however the
ability to crack any system in the world
purely due to bad password habits is
very appealing and the general public
tends to stick with simple and easy to
use
passwords now that we have a fair idea
about how Brute Force Works let's see if
we can answer this question we learned
about how complex passwords are tougher
to crack by Brute Force
among the ones listed on the screens
which one do you believe will take the
longest to be broken when using Brute
Force tools leave your answers in the
comment section and we will get back to
you with the correct option next
week let's move on to the harmful
effects of getting a system compromised
due to Brute Force
attacks a hack laptop or mobile can have
social media accounts logged in giving
the hackers free access to the victim's
connections it has been reported on
multiple occasions where compromised
Facebook accounts are sending malicious
links and attachments to people on their
friends
list one of the significant reasons for
hacking malware infusion is best done
when spread from multiple devices
similar to Distributing spam this
reduces the chance of circling back the
source to a single device which belongs
to the hacker once brute for a system
can spread malware via email attachments
sharing links file upload via FTP
Etc personal information such as credit
card data usage habits private images
and videos are all stored in our systems
be it in plane format or root folders a
compromised laptop means easy access to
these information that can be further
used to impersonate the victim regarding
Bank verification among other
things once a system is hacked it can
also be used as a mail server that
distributes spam across lists of victims
since the hack machines all have
different IP addresses and Mac addresses
it becomes challenging to trace the spam
back to the original hacker with so many
harmful implications arising from a boot
Force attack it's imperative that the
general public must be protected against
such let's learn about some of the ways
we can prevent ourselves from becoming a
victim of Brute Force
attacks using passwords consisting of
alphabets letters and numbers have a
much higher chance of its standing Brute
Force attacks thanks to the sheer number
of combinations they can produce the
longer the password the less likely it
is that a hacker will devote the time
and resources to bruteforce them having
alpha numeric passwords also allows the
user to keep different passwords for
different websites this is to ensure
that if a single account or password is
compromised due to a breach or a hack
the rest of the accounts are isolated
from the
incident two- Factor authentication
involves receiving a one-time password
on a trusted device before a new login
is allowed this OTB can be obtained
either via email SMS or specific 2fa
applications like Ai and agis email and
SMS based otps are considered relatively
less secure nowadays due to the ease
with which SIM cards can be duplicated
and mailboxes can be hacked applications
that are specifically made for T CES are
much more reliable and
secure captur are used to stop Bots from
running through web pages precisely to
prevent brute forcing through their
website since Brute Force tools are
automated forcing the hacker to solve
capture for every iteration of a
password manually is very challenging
the capture system can filter out these
automated Bots that keep refreshing the
page with different credentials thereby
reducing the chances of Brute Force
considerably a definite rule that locks
the account being hacked for 30 minutes
after a specific number of attempts is a
good way to prevent Brute Force attempts
many websites lock account for 30
minutes after three failed password
attempts to secure the account against
any such attack on an additional note
some websites also send an email
instructing the user that there have
been three insecure attempts to log into
the
website let's look at a demonstration of
how Brute Force attacks work in a real
world situation the world has gone
Wireless with Wi-Fi taking the re in
every household it's natur natur that
the security will always be up for
debate to further test the security
index and understand Brute Force attacks
you will attempt to break into the
password of a Wi-Fi router for that to
happen you first need to capture a
handshake file which is a connection
file from the Wi-Fi router to a
connecting device like a mobile or a
laptop the operating system used for
this process is parot security a Linux
distribution that is catered to
penetration testers all the tools being
used in this demo can easily be found
pre-installed in this operating system
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scaleup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more to start our demo we're going to
use a tool called airgeddon which is
made to hack into wireless network
specifically at this point it's going to
check for all the necessary scripts that
that are installed in the
system to crack into a Wi-Fi and to
capture the handshake file we're going
to need an external network card the
significance of the external network
card is a managed mode and a monitor
mode for now the WL X1 named card is my
external network adapter which I'm going
to select to be able to capture data
over the air we're going to need to put
it in monitor mode as you can see above
it's written it is in manage mode right
now so we're going to select option two
which is to put the interface in monitor
mode and it name is now dou land zero
monitor the monitor mode is necessary to
capture data over the air that is the
necessary reason why we need an external
card since a lot of inbuilt cards that
come with the laptops and the systems
they cannot have a monitor mode
installed once we select the mode we can
go into the fifth which which is the
handshake tools
menu in the first step we have to
explore for targets and it is written
that monitor mode is necessary to select
a Target so let's explore for
targets and press
enter we have to let this run for about
60 seconds to get a fair idea about the
networks that are currently working in
this locality for example this ESS ID is
supposed to be the Wi-Fi name that we
see when connecting to a network go24
recover me these are all the names that
we see on our mobile when trying to
search for the Wi-Fi this BSS ID is
supposed to be an identifier somewhat
like a MAC address that identifies this
network from other devices the channels
features on one or two or there are some
many channels that the networks can
focus
on this here is supposed supposed to be
a client that is connected to one such
Network for example the station that you
can see 56 26 this is supposed to be the
MAC address of the device that is
connected to a router this BSS ID is
supposed to be which wi-fi it is
connected to for example 5895 d8 is this
one which is the go24 router so we
already know which router has a device
connected to it and we can use our
attack to capture this
handshake now that we it has already run
for 1 minute now that we press contrl
C we will be asked to select a Target
see it has already selected the number
five which is the ge24 router as the one
with clients so it is easy to run an
attack on and it is easy to capture a
handshake
for select Network 5 and we run a
capture
handshake it says we have a valid WPA
WPA2 Network Target selected and that
the script can
continue now to capture the handshake we
have a couple of attacks a do or a do
air replay attack what this attack does
is kick the clients out of the network
in return when they try to reconnect to
the Wi-Fi as they configured that way
that when a client is disconnected it
tries to reconnect it immediately it
tries to capture a handshake file which
in turn contains the security key which
is necessary to initiate the
handshake for our demo let's go with the
second option that is the do air replay
attack select a timeout value let's say
we give it 60
seconds and we start the
script we can see it capturing data from
the ge24 network and here we go we have
the WPA handshake
file once the handshake file is captured
can actually close this and here we go
congratulations in order to capturing a
handshake it has verified that a pmk ID
from the target network has successfully
been captured this is the file that is
already stored a DOT cap file for the
path we can let's say we can keep it in
a
desktop okay we give the
path and the hand shap file is generated
we can already see a Target over here
same ge24 router with the BSS
ID now now if we return to its main
menu we already have the handshake file
captured with us now our job is to Brute
Force into that handshake capture file
the capture file is often encrypted with
the security key of the Wi-Fi network if
we know how to decrypt it we will
automatically get the security key so
let's go to the offline WPA wp2 decrypt
menu since we'll be cracking personal
networks we can go with option one
now to run the Brute Force tool we have
two options either we can go with the
air crack or we can go with the
hashcat let's go with airack plus crunch
which is a Brute Force attack against a
handshake file we can go with option
two it can already detect the capture
file that we have
generated so we select
yes the BSS ID is the one which denotes
the go24 router so we're going to select
yes as well the minimum length of the
key for example it has already checked
that the minimum length of a Wi-Fi
security key which is a WPA2 psk key
will always be more than eight digits
and Below 64 digits so we have to select
something in between this range so if we
already know let's say that the password
is at least 10 digits we can go with the
minimum length as 10 and as a rough
guess let's say we put the maximum
length as
20 the character set that we're going to
use for checking the password will
affect the time taken to Brute Force for
example if you already know that or we
have seen a user use the password while
connecting to the router as something
that has only numbers and symbols then
we can choose accordingly let's say if
you go with only uppercase characters
and numeric
characters go with option
seven and it's going to start
decrypting
so how aircrack is working right here
you can see this pass phrase over here
the first five or six digits are a it
starts working its way from the end from
the last character it keeps trying every
single combination you can see the last
the fourth character from the right side
the D it'll eventually turn to
e because it keeps checking up every
single character from the end this will
keep going on until all the sing SK
characters are tested and every single
combination is tried out since the
handshake file is encrypted using the
security key that is the WPA2 key of the
router whichever pass phrase is able to
decrypt the handshake key completely
will be the key of the Wi-Fi router this
is the way we can Brute Force into Wi-Fi
routers anywhere in the world cyber
attacks are frequently making headlines
in today's digital environment at any
time everyone who uses a computer could
be become a victim of a Cyber attack
there are various sorts of cyber attacks
ranging from fishing to password attacks
in this video we'll look into one such
attack that is known as botet but before
we begin if you love watching Tech
videos subscribe to our Channel and hit
the Bell icon never to miss an update to
begin with let's take a look at some of
the famous bot attacks the first one is
miray botman which is a malicious
program designed to attack vulnerable
iot devices and infect them to form a
network of bots that on command perform
basic and medium level denial of service
attacks then we have the zoos bot is
specifically designed for attacking the
system for Bank related information and
data now let's see what exactly a botnet
is botnet refers to a network of
hijacked interconnected devices that are
installed with malicious codes known as
malware each of these infected devices
are known as Bots and the hijack
criminal known as bot harder remotely
controls them the Bots are used to
automate large scale attacks including
Data Theft server failure malware
propagation and denial of service
attacks now that we know what exactly a
bot net is let's dive deeper into
learning how botn net works during the
preparation of a botnet network the
first step involves preparing the bot
net Army after that the connection
between the botnet Army and the control
server established and the end the
launching of the attack is done by the B
hter let's understand through a
illustration firstly we have a bot Herer
that initiates the attack according to
the control server commands the devices
that are infected with the malware
programs and begins to attack the
infected system let's see some details
regarding the prepar of the bot net
Army the first step is known as the
prepping the bot net Army the first step
is creating a bot net is to infect as
many as connected devices as possible
this ensures that there are enough Bots
to carry out the attack this way it
creates Bots either by exploiting the
security gaps in the software or
websites or using fishing attacks they
are often deployed through Trojan
horses for the next step we have
establishing the connection once it
hacks the device as per previous step it
infects it with the specific malware
that connects the device back to the
control bot server a bot Herer uses
command programming to drive the bot's
actions and the last step is known as
launching the attack once infected a bot
allows access to admin level operation
like Gathering and stealing of data
reading and rewriting the system data
monitor ing user activities performing
denial of service attacks including
other cyber
crimes now let's take a look at the B
architecture the first type is known as
client server model the client server
model is a traditional model that
operates with the help of a command and
control center server and communication
protocols like
IRC when the B hearder issues a command
to the server it is then related to the
clients to perform malicious
actions then we have peer-to-peer model
here controlling the infected Bots
involves a peer-to-peer Network that
relies on a decentralized approach that
is the BS are topological interconnected
and acts as both C and C servers that is
the server and the client to the hackers
adopt this approach to avoid detection
and single point
failure in the end we will see some
points on some countermeasure against
bot net
attacks
the first step is to have updated
drivers and system updates after that we
should avoid clicking random popups or
links that we often see on the internet
and lastly having certified antivirus
anti- spyware softwares and firewall
installed into a system will protect
against malware attack the internet is
an endless source of information and
data still in some cases we come across
some occurrences like cyber attacks
hacking force entry which may affect a
time on the web hi everyone and welcome
to the simply La Channel today we will
discuss a topic that secretly records
our input data that is known as key
loggers but before we begin if you like
watching Tech videos subscribe to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss an
update to understand the key logging
problem better let's take a look at an
example this is June she works in a
business firm where she manages the
company's data regularly this is Jacob
from the information Department who is
here to inform her about some of the
security
protocols during the briefing she
informed him about some of the problems
her system was facing with which
included slow reaction speed and unusual
internet
activity as Jacob heard about the
problems with the system he thinks of
the possibility what could be the reason
behind these problems a system was
facing
with the conclusion that he came across
was the key logging
issue unknown to the problem her system
was facing with she asked him about some
of the details regarding
it for today's topic we learn what
exactly key loggers are and how they
affect our system what are the harmful
effects that key logging can bring into
the system to begin with we learn what
exactly the key logging program
is as the name suggests key logger is a
malicious program or a tool that are
designed to record key strokes that are
typed during data input and record them
into a lock file then the same program
secretly sends these lock files to its
origin where they can be used for
malicious acts by the
hacker now that we know what the key
logging program is let's take a look how
they enter into the
system searching for a suitable driver
for a system can often lead to the
installation of the key loging program
into the system if we often visit
suspicious sites and uncertified
software are installed into our system
then if we use unknown links or visiting
unknown websites which come through
unknown addresses can also be a reason
behind the key logging issue entering
into the system and lastly there are
often cases where different popups that
we often see on social sites or
different media sites can lead to the
installation of key loging program into
our
system now that we know how the problem
gets into the system let's take a look
how to identify whether the system is
infected by the key logging
issue the key logging issue can be
identified if there are often cases when
a keyboard lags behind the system the
data that we enter sometimes is stuck in
between when we type through the
input then there are cas es when the
system freeze occurs unknowingly to what
exactly could be the reason behind them
and also there are delayed reaction time
for different applications that run on
the system and lastly there are
different cases when we often see
suspicious internet activity on the
system that we don't know about this
could lead to the identification of a
problem into the
system now we'll take a look at
different types of key loggers that are
present present on the net which can
harm our system
differently the first problem that key
loggers arounds is API based the most
common key logging case which uses apis
to keep a log of the type data and share
it to its origin for malicious purposes
each time we press a key the key logger
intercepts the signal and logs it then
we have form grabbing based key loggers
as the name suggests
they are based key loggers that store
the form data that is if we often use
web forms or different kinds of forms to
enter different data they can be
recorded into the system by the program
and send it to its
origin then we have kernel based key
loggers these key loggers are installed
deeply into the operating system where
they can hide from different antivirus
if not checked properly and they record
the data that we type on the keyboard
and send it to its
origin and lastly we have Hardware Key
loggers these key loggers are present
directly into the hardware that is they
are embedded into system where they
record the data that we type on the
keyboard now let's take a look how
hackers differentiate different type of
recorded data and exploit
them when hackers receive information
about the target they might use use it
to Blackmail the target which may affect
the personal life of the Target and also
blackmail them for different money
related
issues then in case of company data that
is recorded by the key logging program
can also affect the economic value of
the company in the market which may lead
to the downfall of the
company also in some cases the key
logging program can also log data about
military Secrets which may include
nuclear codes or security protocols
which are necessary to maintain the
security of a
country now let's take a look whether
mobile devices get infected with the key
logging issue or
not in the case of hand devices
infection of key loggers are low in
comparison to the computer systems as
they use onscreen keyboard or virtual
keyboard but in some cases we often see
different kind of malicious programs
getting installed into the hand device
if we often visit different uncertified
websites or illegal websites or torrent
sites and also the device that is
infected with the key logging issue or
different kind of malicious program can
often lead to the exploitation of data
that includes photos emails or important
files by the hacker or the Cyber
criminal that install the particular
malicious program into the
system
now to prevent our system from getting
infected by the key loging program let's
take a look at different
points the first point includes using of
different antivirus softwares or tools
which can prevent the entering of
malicious program into the
system then keeping system security
protocols regularly updated is also a
good habit and lastly using virtual
keyboard to input our sensitive data
which may include Bank details login
details or different passwords related
to different
websites now that we have some
understanding about the topic of key
loggers let's take a look at the demo to
further increase the knowledge about the
topic for the first step we have to
download some of the important libraries
that are required into the
system which
is this library now we'll run
it
the system says the library is already
installed into the
system now let's take a look what
exactly modules are required from the
particular
library from this Library we'll
import the keyboard module which will
help us to record the data that we type
on the
keyboard now from the same we'll also
import key
module and The Listener
module and
also the logging module which will help
us to record the data into a log
file for the next part we'll write a
piece of code that will allow us to save
the data that is recorded by the program
into a text file that will be named as
key log text file along with the date
and time stamp let's take a
look now we'll provide it with the file
name that will be given
as key log do txt
file and also so the part where where
the format of the data is
recorded put the brackets over here to
contain the file name now we'll write
the format in which the data will be
recorded into the log file which will be
given
as the format would be the message and
the time stamp which would be given as
along with the time
stamp as
percentage and ending it with the
bracket now for the next step we'll
design
two of the functions that will be used
into the program that will be termed as
while press function and while release
function let's take a
look while press
function would be a function that will
come into play when the keyboard key has
been
pressed is
pressed
and this would go for the format that we
designed in the above
line
and
logging the Pressed
key
info a string file to be
recorded into the lock file
now now we'll design a function that is
while
release that will come into play
when
the Escape key has been pressed that is
the program will terminate itself and
the program will stop from
running and in the
end we require for the functioning of
the program to Loop these functions that
is while press and while release to
continue its
cycle
that will be going for while press
and
on release will contain while
release
function as
listen
now and now this part would join the
different threads and store them into
the log file now that we have completed
the code for the program let's run
it we have to wait for a moment so the
program runs it
now to verify the program let's open
notepad and on the notepad we'll
write hello
world which will be the basic whether
the program is working or not let's take
a
look and we'll go for the main page on
Jupiter notebook and refresh the page go
to the botton
over here we see the key log text that
is the text file that we created let's
open
it and over here we have the data that
is created as we started with Note then
this is the hello world part that we
created just
now which shows that the program we
created is working properly now that we
have reached the end of the module let's
take a look at the summary firstly we
learn what exactly key loggers are then
we understood what different modes are
present how the system get infected with
the key loging problem then we learned
how to detect the problem into our
system then we learned what different
types of key loggers are present on the
net we also understood how hackers use
the recorded data from the program and
we also learn whether mobile devices get
infected with the key logging problem or
not and lastly we understood what
different points can be taken to prevent
the entering of the key logging problem
into the system and before we begin if
you're are someone who is interested in
building a career in cyber security or
to become an ethical hacker by
graduating from the best universities or
a professional who elicits to switch
career with cyber security or ethical
hacker by learning from the experts and
try giving a short to Simply Larch
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from MIT schi College of
computing the course link is mentioned
in the Des description box below that
will navigate you to the course page
where you can find a complete overview
of the program being offered before we
learn about the Pegasus platform let us
understand what spyware is and it's
working spyware is a category of malware
that can gather information regarding a
user or a device straight from the host
machine it is mostly spread by malicious
links via email or chat applications
when a link with the malware is received
clicking on this link will activate the
spyware which allows the hacker to spy
on all our users
information with some spy systems even
clicking on the link isn't necessary to
trigger the malicious payload this can
ultimately cause security complications
and further loss of privacy one such spy
system that is making the rounds in the
tech industry today is Pegasus the
Pegasus is a spyware system developed by
an Israeli company known as the NSO
group it runs on mainly mobile devices
spanning across the major operating
systems like the Apple's IOS on iPhone
and the standard Android versions this
is not a newly developed platform since
Pegasus has existed since as early as
2016 a highly intricate spy program that
can track user location read text
messages scan through mobile files
access device camera and microphone to
record voice and video Pegasus has all
the tools necessary to enforce
surveillance for any client that wishes
to buy its services initially the NSO
group had designed the software to be
used against terrorist factions of the
world with more and more encrypted
communication channels coming to the
Forefront Pegasus was designed to
maintain control over the data
transmission that can be a threat to
National Security unfortunately the
people who bought the software had
complete control over who how and up to
what level they can put surveillance
limits on eventually the primary clients
became Sovereign Nations spying on
Public Information that is supposed to
stay private became really easy with the
service multiple devices can be affect
With the same same spare system to
create a network information this
network keeps feeding data to the host
to understand how a network can be
created let's know how a mobile device
can be affected by Pegasus we all
communicate with friends and family over
instant messaging applications and email
in some instances if you check your
inbox on a regular basis you must have
noticed that we received some spam
emails that the mail providers like
Gmail and Yahoo can just filter into the
spam folder some of these messages
bypass this filter and make their way
into a person's inbox they look like
generic emails which are supposed to be
safe the Pegasus spyware targets such
occurrences by passing malicious
messages and links which install the
necessary Spy software on the user's
mobile device be it Android or an iPhone
this isn't unique to the email ecosystem
since it's equally likely to be targeted
by SMS text WhatsApp Instagram or even
the most secure messaging apps like
signal and threa once the malicious
links are clicked a spyware package is
downloaded and installed on the device
after the spyware is successfully
installed the perpetrator who sent the
payload to the victim can monitor
everything the user does Pegasus can
collect private emails passwords images
videos and every other piece of
information that passes through the
device Network all this data is
transmitted back to the central server
where the primary spying organization
can monitor the activities at a granular
level this is not even surface level
since complex py software like Pegasus
can access the root files on our mobiles
these root files hold information that
is crucial to the working of the Android
and iOS operating systems leaking such
private information is a massive blow to
the security and the privacy of an
individual the information that may seem
trivial like the name of your Wi-Fi
connection or the last time you ordered
an item from Amazon are indeed all
valuable information this exploitation
is primarily possible due to the zero
day vulnerabilities known as bugs in the
software development process the zero
day bugs are the ones that have just
been discovered by some independent
security company or a researcher once
they are found reporting these
vulnerabilities to the developer of the
platform which would be either Google
for Android or Apple for iOS is the
right thing to do however many such
critical bugs make their way onto the
dark web where hackers can use them to
create exploits these employes are then
sent to innocent users with a link or a
message like we had discussed before
Pegasus was able to affect the latest
devices with the all the security
patches installed but some bugs are not
reported to the developers or just
cannot be fixed without breaking some
core functionality these become the
Gateway for spyware to enter into the
system you can never be 100% safe but
you sure can give it all in protecting
yourself the one thing where Pegasus
stands out is a zero click action
feature usually in spam emails the
malicious code is activated when the
user clicks the malware link a user
doesn't need to click the link in the
new version of the Pegasus and a few
other spyware programs once the message
arrives in the inbox of WhatsApp Gmail
or any other chat applications the
spyware gets activated and everything
can be recorded and sent back to the
central server the primary issue with
being affected by spyware as a victim is
detection unlike Crypt Miners and
Trojans spying Services usually do not
demand many system resources which makes
them tough to detect after they have
been activated since many devices slow
down after a couple of years any kind of
Performance Set due to such spyware is
often attributed to poor software
longetivity by the users they do not
check meticulously for any other causes
that is causing the Slowdown when left
unchecked these devices can capture
voice and video from the mobile sensors
while keeping the owner in the dark
let's take a moment to check if we are
well aware of the causes of such attacks
how do users fall pre to such spyware
programs a by installing untested
software B by clicking on the third
party links from email and messages C by
not keeping the apps and phones updated
or D all of the above let us know your
answers in the comment section below and
we will rev the correct answer next week
but what about the unaffected devices
the vulnerable ones while we cannot be
certain of our security there are a few
things we can do to boost our device be
it against Pegasus or the next big spy
on the market let's say we are safe now
and we have the time to take the
necessary steps to prevent a spyware
attack what are the things we can go for
our primary goal must always be to keep
our apps and the operating system
updated the latest security patches the
vulnerabilities that the exploits Target
are often discovered by developers from
Google and apple which send the security
patches quickly this can be done for
individual apps as well so keeping them
updated is of utmost importance while
the most secure devices have fallen prey
to Pegasus as well a security patch from
developers may help in minimizing the
damage at a later stage or maybe negate
the entire spyware platform altogether
another big factor is the spread of
malware is the trend of sideloading
Android applications using do APK files
downloading such apps from a third party
website have no security checks involved
and are mostly responsible for adware
and spyware in ations on user devices
avoiding the side loading of apps would
be a major step in protecting yourself
we often receive spam emails or texts
from people we may not know on social
medias they are accompanied with links
that allow malware to creep into our
device we should try to follow the
trusted websites and not click on any
links that redirect us to unknown
domains spy is a controversial segment
in governance while the ramifications
are pretty extreme in theory it severely
impacts user private pracy against
authoritarian regimes sufficient
resources and a contingent plan can
alter the false veale of democracy
altogether even if our daily life is
rather simplistic we must understand
that privacy is not about what we have
to hide instead it portrays the things
we have to protect it stands for
everything we have to share with the
outside world both rhetorically and
literally hey everyone do you we look at
the hack which took the World by storm
and affected multiple governments and
corporations the solar wind set
the global statistics indicate that
upward of 18,000 customers have been
affected potentially needing billions to
recover the losses incurred before we
have a look at this hack Make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
notification Bell to never miss an
update from Simply learn the date is
December 8th 2020 fire a global leader
in company specializing in cyber
security released a blog post that
caught the attention of the entire it
Community a software known as Orion
which was developed by solar wison
corporator had become a victim of a
remote access Trojan or a rat the breach
was estimated to be running since the
spring of 2020 and went virtually
unnoticed for months the reveal sent the
developers of the Orion software into a
frenzy as they quickly released a couple
of hot fixes for their platform in order
to mitigate this threat and prevent
further damage but how did this come
into existence we first need to
understand the platform which was
responsible for this breach soloin a
software company based in Texas United
States had developed a management
platform known as Orion Hing to
corporations and governments worldwide
Orion was responsible for the monitoring
and management of it Administration this
included managing the client servers
virtualization components and even the
organization Network infrastructure that
bought the platform solar winds claims
they have more than 300,000 clients
including US government agencies and
several Fortune 500 companies this
entire chain can be classified as a
supply chain attack in this variant of
cyber crime the hackers Target
relatively weaker links in an
organization's chain of control and
delivery these are preferably services
rendered by a third party since there is
no direct jurisdiction over it in this
case the Orion platform was the primary
target the culprit however was software
updates the update server for solar
Orion had a malicious version attached
with malware or a Trojan to be precise
this was made possible since the code
repository that handled the software
updates was breached once the update
server repository was compromised the
source code of the applications became
open to modification and malicious code
found its way onto the software the
remote access troen was attached to a
potential update nicknamed the Sunburst
update this update gave hackers back
door access to any client that uses the
correct version on its release many
clients believe the update to be
legitimate since it came from the right
source and they had no reason to believe
otherwise American government agencies
were supposed ly hit the hardest as the
list of victims included the US
Departments of Homeland Security
treasury and health several private
companies like Cisco Nvidia and Intel
were compromised according to a list
published by the cyber security firm
trusk most of the companies had issued
quick updates to fix this
vulnerabilities introduced by the
software while the actual perpetrators
have never been found it is believed
that this was an act of crossborder
corporate Espionage conducted by state
sponsored hackers either from Russia
Russia or
China before we move forward let's take
a recap of the things we learned what
category of malware was responsible for
the solar winds hack was it one a virus
a remote access Trojan a spyware or a
worm let us know your answers in the
comment section right away and we will
reveal the correct answer in a week
coming to possible reparations the Biden
government has launched a full
investigation on the effects and the
repercussions of this breach there are a
couple of things that we as consumers
must always tend to when working our way
through the worldwide web using a
password manager is highly recommended
which can generate secure alpha numeric
passwords you must also use different
passwords for different accounts thereby
reducing the chances of a single point
of failure should one of those accounts
get breached usage of two-factor
authentication applications is also
encouraged since it acts as a safety net
if hackers directly get a hold of our
credentials clicking on unknown links
transmitted via emails is also a strict
no as is installing applications from
unverified sources the solar wind hack
is estimated to cost the parent company
nearly $18 million as reparations making
it one if not the biggest hacks in
cyberspace history as recently as of
July 2021 the hackers accessed some us
attorneys Microsoft 365 email accounts
as part of the attack criminal
organizations like the FBI and CIA are
determined to figure out the culprits
responsible for this debacle however the
intricacy and the full extent of the
breach makes it a way more complicated
job than it looks on paper the day is
26th February
2022 the world is hit with breaking news
that Russian State tv channels have been
hacked by Anonymous a activist
Collective and movement who have made a
name taking part in multiple Cyber Wars
in the past decade this was in response
to the Russian aggression on Ukrainian
territory in the hopes of annexation
Anonymous hacked the Russian State TV
networks to combat propaganda in Russia
and highlight the damage to life Meed
out by the Kremlin in Ukraine they also
hacked 120,000 Russian troops personal
information and the Russian Central Bank
stealing 35,000 files this served as a
clear indicator of how cyber War can
change the momentum in battle something
which people had never seen so closely
so what is cyber War a digital assault
or series of strikes or hacks against a
country is sometimes referred to as a
cyber War it has the ability to cause
havoc on government and civilian
infrastructure as well as disrupted
cenal systems causing State harm and
even death in this day and age the
internet plays a bigger role than just
watching videos and learning content
it's where you have your personal data
and carry Financial transactions so
rather than resorting to physical
violence cyber War has become the new
means to cause Havoc considering the
vulnerability of the data passing
through the internet in most
circumstances cyber warfare involves the
nation State attacking another in
certain cases the assaults are carried
out by terrorist organizations or
non-state actors pursuing a hostile
nation's aim in June 2021 Chinese
hackers targeted organizations like
Verizon to secure remote access to their
networks stuck net was a computer worm
designed to attack Iran's nuclear
facilities but evolved and expanded to
many other industrial and energy
producing sites in
2010 since the definition of cyber war
is so vague the applying rule rules and
sanctions based on digital assault is
even tougher making the field of cyber
warfare a lawless land not bound by any
rules or policies there are multiple
ways in which these attacks can be
carried out a major category of Cyber
attack is espionage Espionage entails
monitoring other countries to steal
critical Secrets this might include
compromising vulnerable computer systems
with botn Nets or spear fishing attempts
before extracting sensitive data in
cyber warfare the next weapon in cyber
war is sabotage government agencies must
identify sensitive data and its dangers
if it is exploited Insider threats such
as disgruntled or irresponsible
Personnel or government staff with ties
to the attacking country can be used by
hostile countries or terrorists to steal
or destroy information by overwhelming a
website with bogus requests and forcing
it to handle them denial of service
attacks prohibit real users from
accessing it attacking parties may use
this form of assault to disrupt key
operations and systems and prevent
citizens military and security officials
and research organizations from
accessing sensitive websites but what
benefits does Cyber War offer in
contrast to traditional physical Warfare
the most important Advantage is the
ability to conduct attacks from anywhere
globally without having to travel
thousands of miles as long as the
attacker and Target are connected to the
internet organizing and launching Cyber
Wars is relative less tedious Than
Physical Warfare people living in or
battling for a country are subjected to
propaganda attacks in an attempt to
manipulate their emotions and thoughts
digital infrastructure is highly crucial
in today's modern world starting from
communication channels to Secure Storage
servers crippling a country's footprint
and control on the Internet is very
damaging but what are some of the ways
we as Citizens protect ourselves in the
case of a cyber war in the unfortunate
event that your country is in involved
in Warfare be sure to fact check every
piece of information and follow only
trusted sources in that frame of time
even conversations online should be
limited to a need to know basis
considering propaganda campaigns have
the power to influence the tide of War
drastically it is highly crucial to
follow basic security guidelines to
secure our devices like regularly
updating our operating systems
occasionally running full system
antivirus scans Etc if your country or
organization is being act having devices
segregated in a network goes a long way
in bolstering
security try to avoid sharing a lot of
personal data online in this era of
Instagram and Facebook divulging private
information can be detrimental to
keeping a secure firewall for your data
the more information an attacker has
access to the higher his chances of
being able to devise a plan to
infiltrate defenses and if you're
someone who is interested in building a
career in cyber security that is by
graduating from the best universities or
a professional who alits to switch
careers with cyber security by learning
from the experts and try giving a short
to Simply Lars postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from the MIT
schwarzman College of Engineering and
the course link is mentioned in the
description box that will navigate you
to the course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered during data transmission there
are various external factors which can
affect the transmission of data over a
network channel to prevent such cases
from happening we use Internet Protocol
security which we'll be discussing in
the session on IP explain hi guys and
welcome to yet testing video by simply
learn but before we begin if you are
watching Tech videos subscribe to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to miss an
update from us now without further Ado
let's take a look at the agenda for this
session to begin with we will look into
what is IP SEC continuing with why do we
use IPC in a
network followed by components of
IPC modes of Ip security as for the last
topic we will look into working steps
involved in IP security let's begin with
the first heading that is what is IP
SEC IPC Internet Protocol security is
defined as a set of framework and
protocol to ensure data transmission
over a network
channel this protocol was initially
defined of two main protocols for data
security over a network channel which
were authentication header which is
responsible for data integrity and
anti-replay
services and the second protocol is
encapsulating security payload in short
ESP which includes data encryption and
data
authentication now let's move on to the
next setting that is why do we use IPC
in a network
IP SEC is used to secure sensitive data
and information such as company data
clinical data Bank data and various
sensitive information regarding an
institution which are used during data
transmission over a network
channel the use of vpns that are virtual
private networks and apply IPC protocols
to encrypt the data for inin
transmission
let's continue with why do we use IPC
Services IPC is also used to encrypt
data for application layer in the OSI
model and provide security for sharing
data over Network routers and data
authentication let's take a look at the
working of ipx
services to begin with we have two
different system system one and system
to which will establish a network
channel and then the encryption of data
will takes place when one host will
share the data to the second host during
this ipx services will secure the data
that is to be transferred over the
network channel by applying router
encryption and
authentication now let's move on to the
next topic that is components of
IPC the IP Services comprises of
multiple protocols that ensure the data
transmission over the network channel
the first one is encapsulating security
payload protocol in short
ESP this protocol of Ip security
provides data encryption and
authentication
services and it also authenticates and
encrypt the data packet in the
transmission
Channel moving on we have authentication
header in short
ah similar to ESP the authentication
header also provides all the security
services but it does not increase scrip
the data it also protects the IP packet
and adds additional headers to the
packet header the modified IP datagram
looks this way where the IP components
are included at the second position the
seventh position and the sixth position
along with the authentication of data
services over the network
channel moving on we have Internet key
exchange ik
ke this protocol provides protection for
Content data and also changes the
attribute of the original data to be
shared by implementing sha and md5
algorithms they also check the message
for authentication and then only is
forwarded to the receiver side for
example this is the original data packet
we are used to with IP head UPA TCP UDP
and data whereas this is the modified IP
site data packet where ESP header is
added between IP header and the TCP
protocol now let's move on to the next
heading that is modes of
ipse there are basically two types of
ips modes available for data
transmission over the network channel
where the first one is tunnel mode this
mode of transmission is used to secure
gateway to Gateway
data it is applied when the final
destination of the data is to be
connected to a sender site through to a
connection Gateway over the Internet for
example we have two host host a and host
B through the host a we are sending a
message to host B which will pass
through a Gateway at host a point and it
passes through a gateway to host B
then this is a basic format for Gateway
to Gateway data
transmission and the the given IP
datagram format is used for tunnel mode
now let's move on to the second mode of
Ip site that is transport mode this mode
of IPC is used to protect protocols like
TCP or UDP and is used to ensure end to
endend communication unlike tunnel mode
the transport mode data at
authentication header and encapsulating
security payload for security purpose in
the IP
header this is the modified IP datagram
for transport mode the point to be noted
is the IP header is always added between
IP header and TCP
header now let's move on to the last
heading for the session on IP SE that is
the working steps involved in IP
Security in general there are five steps
involved in the working of Ip sec to
ensure data transmission over a network
channel the first step is host poost
recognition in the first step the host
system will check if the packet is to be
transmitted or Not by automatically
triggering the security policy for the
data which is implemented by the sender
side for proper
encryption then the second step is known
as ik Phase 1 in this step the two host
devices the sender and the receiver side
will authenticate each other to
establish a secure network channel
it is comprised of two modes the main
mode this provides much better security
with a proper time
limit and the second mode known as
aggressive mode as the name suggests it
establishes the IPC protocol much faster
in comparison to main mode let's move on
to the third step which is ik Phase 2
after the second step the host decide
the type of cryptography algorithm to a
apply over the session in the network
channel and the secret key for the
algorithm to be used to encrypt the data
for
transmission then we have IP SEC
transmission this step involves the
actual transfer of data over the network
channel using various protocols used in
ipx security which are implemented under
the tunnel
condition and the last step is IPC
termination after the completion of data
exchange or session timeout the IP SEC
tunnel is terminated and the security
key established is discarded by both the
host system network security is a set of
technologies that protects the usability
and integrity of a company's
infrastructure by preventing the entry
or proliferation within a network it
architecture comprises of tools that
protect the network itself and the
applications that run over it effective
network security strategies employ
multiple lines of defense that are
scalable and automated each defensive
layer here enforces a set of security
policies which are determined by the
administrator beforehand this aims at
securing the confidentiality and
accessibility of the data and the
network the every company or
organization that handles a large amount
of data has a degree of solutions
against many cyber threats the most
basic example of network security is
password protection it has the network
the user chooses so recently network
security has become the central topic of
cyber security with many organizations
involving applications from people with
skills in this area it is crucial for
both personal and professional networks
most houses with high-speed internet
have one or more wireless routers which
can be vulnerable to attacks if they're
not adequately
secured data loss theft and sabotage
risk may be decreased with the usage of
a strong network security system your
workstations are protected from
hazardous F thanks to network security
addition Ally it guarantees the security
of the data which is being shared over a
network by dividing information into
various sections encrypting these
portions and transferring them over
separate Pathways network security
infrastructure offers multiple levels of
protection to th man in the middle
attacks preventing situations like
eavesdropping among other harmful
attacks it is becoming increasingly
difficult in today's hyperconnected
environment as more corporate
applications migrate to both public and
private clocks additionally modern
applications are also frequently
virtualized and dispersed across several
locations some outside the physical
control of the IT team Network traffic
and infrastructure must be protected in
these cases since assaults on businesses
are increasing every single day we now
understood the basics of network
security but we need to understand how
network security works in the next
section in slightly more detail network
security revolves around two processes
authentication and authorization
the first process which is
authentication is similar to access
cards which ensure that only those have
the right to enter a building in other
words authentication checks and verifies
that it is indeed the user belonging to
the network who is trying to access or
enter it thereby preventing unauthorized
intrusions next comes
authorization this process decides the
level of access provided to the recently
authenticated
user for example Network admin needs
access to the entire network whereas
those working within it probably need
access to only certain areas within the
network based on the network users role
the process of determining the level of
access or permission level is known as
authorization today's Network
architecture is complex and faces a
threat environment that is always
changing and attackers that are always
trying to find and exploit
vulnerabilities these vulnerabilities
can exist in many areas including
devices data applications users and and
locations for this reason many Network
Security Management tools and
applications are in use today that
address individual
threats when it's just a few minutes of
downtimes can cause widespread
disruption and massive damage to an
organization's bottom line and
reputation it is essential that these
protection measures are in place
beforehand now that you know a little
about network security and it's working
let's cover to the different types of
network
security the fundamental tenant of netw
security is the layering of protection
for massive networks and store data that
ensure the acceptance of rules and
regulations as a whole there are three
types the first of which is physical
security the next being Technical and
the third being
administrative let's look into physical
security first this is the most basic
level that includes protecting data and
network to unauthorized Personnel from
acquiring control over the
confidentiality of the network this
include external peripherals and routers
that might be used for cable connections
the same can be achieved by using
devices like biometric systems physical
security is critical especially for
small businesses that do not have many
resources to devote to security
personnel and the tools as opposed to
large
firms when it comes to technical network
security it focuses mostly on
safeguarding data either kept in the
network or engaged in network
transitions this kind fulfills two
functions one is defense against
unauthorized users the other is a
defense against malevolent
actions the last category is
Administrative this level of network
security protects user Behavior like how
the permission has been granted and how
the authorization process takes place
this also ensures the level of
sophistication the network might need to
protect it through all the attacks this
level also suggests necessary amendments
that have to be done to the
infrastructure I think that's all the
basics that we need to cover on network
security in which our next topic we're
going to go through two mediums of
network security which are the transport
layer and the application
layer so transport layer is a way to
secure information as it is carried over
the Internet with users browsing
websites emails instant messaging Etc
TLS aims to provide a private and secure
connection between a web browser and a
website server it does this with the
cryptographic handshake between two
systems using public key cryptography
the two parties for the connection
exchange a secret token and once each
machine validates this token it is used
for all Communications the connection
employs lighter symmetric cryptography
to save bandwidth and processing power
since the application layer is the
closest layer to the end user it
provides hackers with the largest threat
surface poor app layer security can lead
to Performance and stability issues data
theft and in some cases the network
being taken down examples of application
layer attacks include distributed denal
of service attack attacks or DDOS
attacks HTTP floods hql injections
cross-site scripting Etc most
organizations have an arsenal of
application layer security protections
to combat these and more such as web
application firewalls secure web gway
services Etc now that we have the theory
behind network security has been covered
in detail let us go through some of the
tools that can be used to enforce these
network security
policies the first tool to be covered in
this section is a firewall a firewall is
a type of network security device that
keeps track of incoming and outgoing
Network traffic and it decides which
traffic to allow or deny in accordance
to a set of security rules for more than
25 years firewalls have served as
Network Security's first line of defense
they provide a barrier between
trustworthy internal protected and
regulated networks from Shady external
networks like the internet at some
points the next tool which can be used
to bolster network security is a virtual
private Network or VPN for short it's an
encrypted connection between a device
and a network via the Internet the ened
connection AIDS the secure transmission
of sensitive data it makes it impossible
for unauthorized parties to e stop on
the traffic and enables remote work for
the user the usage of VN technology is
common in both corporate and personal
networks next we cover the importance of
intrusion prision systems in network
secur security or IPS
framework an intrusion prevention system
is a network security tool that
continually scans a network for harmful
activity and response to it when it does
occur by reporting blocking or
discarding it it can be either Hardware
or software it's more sophisticated than
an intution detection system or an IDs
framework which can just warn an
administrator and merely identify
harmful activities while in the case of
an IPS it actually takes against that
activity the next tool in this section
and the final one are going to be
behavioral analytics behavioral
analytics focus more on the statistics
that are being carried over and stored
through months and years of usage once
some kind of similar pattern is noted
where the it administrator can detect
some kind of attack the similar attacks
can be stopped and the security can be
further
enhanced now that we have covered all
that we need to know about network
security the necessary tools it's
different types Etc let's go through the
benefits of network security and as of
four the first which is protection
against external threats the objective
for cyber assaults can be as varied as
the Defenders themselves although
they're typically initiated for
financial gain whether they are
industrial spies activists or cyber
criminals these Bad actors all have one
thing in common which is how quick
clever and covert the attacks are
getting a strong cyber security posture
that considers routine software updates
May assist firms in identifying and
respond responding to the abuse
techniques tools and the common entry
points the next benefit is protection
against internal threats the human
aspect continues to be the cyber
security systems weakest link Insider
risk can originate from current or
former workers third party vendors or
even trusted partners and they can be
unintentional careless or downright even
aside from that the rapid expansion of
remote work and the personal devices
used for business purposes while even
iot devices in remote look ations can
make it easier for these kind of threats
to go undetected until it's too late
however by proactively monitoring
networks and managing access these
dangers may be identified and dealt with
before they become expensive
disasters the third benefit is increased
productivity it nearly impossible for
employees to function when networks and
personal devices are slow to a crawl by
viruses and other cyber attacks during
the operation of website and for the
company to run you may significantly
minimize violations and the amount of
downtime required to fix the breach by
implementing various cyber security
measures such as enhanced firewalls
virus scanning and automatic backups
employee identification of possible
email fishing schemes suspicious Lings
and other malicious criminal activities
can also be aided by Education and
Training another benefit is brand trust
and
reputation customer retention is one of
the most crucial elements in business
development
customers today place a premium on
maintaining brand loyalty through a
strong cyber security stance since this
is the fastest way to get other
businesses back get referrals and sell
more tickets overall additionally it
helps manufacturers get on the vendor
list with bigger companies as a part of
the supply chain which is only as strong
as its weakest link this opens
possibilities for potential future
endeavors and development with the rise
in censorship and general fear over
privacy loss consumer security is at an
all-time high risk technology has made
our life so much easier while putting up
a decent Target on our personal
information it is necessary to
understand how to simultaneously
Safeguard our data and be up to date
with the latest technological
developments maintaining this balance
has become easier with cryptography
taking its place in today's digital
world so hey everyone this is B from
Simply learn and welcome to this video
on cryptography but before we begin if
you love watching Tech videos subscribe
be to our Channel and hit the Bell icon
to never miss an update from Simply
learn so here's a story to help you
understand cryptography meet Anne Anne
wanted to look for a decent discount on
the latest iPhone she started searching
on the internet and found a rather Shady
website that offered a 50% discount on
the first purchase once an submitted her
payment details a huge chunk of money
was withdrawn from a bank account just
moments after devastated and quickly
realized she had failed to notice that
the website was a HTTP web page instead
of an https one the payment information
submitted was not encrypted and it was
visible to anyone keeping an eye
including the website owner and hackers
had she used a reputed website which has
encrypted transactions and employees
cryptography our iPhone Enthusiast could
have avoided this particular incident
this is why it's never recommended to
visit unknown websites or share any
personal information on them now that we
understand why cryptography is so
important let's take a look at the
topics to be covered today we take a
look into what cryptography is and how
it works we learn where cryptography is
being used in our daily lives and how we
are benefiting from it then we will
understand the different types of
cryptography and their respective uses
moving on we will look at the usage of
cryptography in ancient history and a
live demonstration of cryptography and
encryption in action let's Now
understand what cryptography
is cryptography is the science of
encrypting or decrypting information to
prevent unauthorized access we transform
our data and personal information so
that only the correct recipient can
understand the message as an essential
aspect of modern data security using
cryptography allows the Secure Storage
and transmission of data between willing
parties encryption is a primary route
for employee cryptography by adding
certain algorithms to Jumble up the data
decryption is the process of reversing
the work done by encrypting information
so that the data becomes readable again
both of these methods form the basis of
cryptography for example when simply
learn is jumbled up or changed in any
format not many people can guess the
original word by looking at the
encrypted text the only ones who can are
the people who know how to decrypt the
coded word their by reversing the
process of
encryption any data pre- encryption is
called plain text or clear text to
encrypt the message we use certain
algorithms that serve a single purpose
of scrambling the data to make them
unreadable without the necessary tools
these algorithms are called ciphers they
are a set of detailed steps to be
carried out one after the other to make
sure the data becomes as unreadable as
possible until it reaches the receiver
we take the plain text pass it to the
cipher algorithm and get the encrypted
data this encrypted text is called the
cipher text and this is the message that
is transferred between the two parties
the key that is being used to scramble
the data is known as the encryption key
these steps that is the cipher and the
encryption key are made known to the
receiver who can then reverse the
encryption on receiving the message
unless any third party manages to find
out both the algorithm and the secret
key that is being used they cannot
decrypt the messages since both of them
are necessary to unlock the hidden
content wonder what else we would lose
if not for
cryptography any website where you have
an account can read your passwords
important emails can be intercepted and
their contents can be read without
encryption during the transit more than
65 billion messages are sent on WhatsApp
every day all of which are secured
thanks to endtoend encryption there is a
huge Market opening up for
cryptocurrency which is possible due to
blockchain technology that uses
encryption algorithms and hashing
functions to ensure that the data is
secure if this is of particular interest
to you you can watch our video on
blockchain the link of which will be in
the description of course there is no
single solution to a problem as diverse
as explain there are three variants of
how cryptography works and is in
practice they are symmetric encryption
asymmetric
encryption and hashing let's find out
how much we have understood until now do
you remember the difference between a
cipher and Cipher text leave your answ
in the comments and before we proceed if
you find this video interesting make
sure to give it a thumbs up before
moving ahead let's look at symmetric
encryption
first symmetric encryption uses a single
key for both the encryption and
decryption of data it is comparatively
less secure than asymmetric encryption
but much faster it is a compromise that
has to be embraced in order to deliver
data as fast as possible without living
information completely vulnerable this
type of encryption is used when data
rests on servers and identifies
Personnel for payment applications and
services the potential drawback with
symmetric encryption is that both the
sender and receiver need to have the
same secret key and it should be kept
hidden at all times Caesar ER Enigma
machine are both symmetric encryption
examples that we will look into further
for example if Alice wants to send a
message to Bob she can apply a
substitution Cipher or a shift Cipher to
encrypt the message but Bob must be
aware of the same key itself so he can
decrypt it when he finds it necessary to
read the entire message symmetric
encryption uses one of the two types of
ciphers stream ciphers and block ciphers
block ciphers break the plane text into
blocks of fixed size and use the key to
convert it into Cipher text stream
ciphers convert the plane text into
Cipher text one bit at a time instead of
resorting to breaking them up into
bigger chunks in today's world the most
widely used symmetric encryption
algorithm is AES 256 that stands for
advanced encryption standard which has a
key size of 256bit with 128bit and 196
bit key sizes also being available other
primi algorithms like the data
encryption standard that is the dees the
triple data encryption standard 3des and
Blowfish have all fallen out of favor
due to the rise of AES AES chops UPS the
data into blocks and performs 10 plus
rounds of obscuring and substituting the
message to make it
unreadable asymmetric encryption on the
other hand has a double whammy at its
disposal there are two different keys at
play here a public key and a private key
the public key is used to encrypt
information pre-transit and a private
key is used to decrypt the information
post Transit if Alice wants to
communicate with Bob using asymmetric
encryption she encrypts the message
using Bob's public key after receiving
the message Bob uses his own private key
to decrypt the data this way nobody can
intercept the message in between
transmissions and there is no need for
any secure key exchange for this to work
since the encryption is is done with a
public key and the decryption is done
with a private key that no one except
Bob has access to both the keys are
necessary to read the full
message there is also a reverse scenario
where we can use the private key for
encryption and the public key for
decryption a server can sign
non-confidential information using its
private key and anyone who has its
public key can decrypt the message this
mechanism also proves that the sender is
authenticated and there is no problem
with the origin of the
information RSA encryption is the most
widely used asymmetric encryption
standard it is named after its Founders
reest Shamir and Edelman and it uses
block ciphers that separate the data
into blocks and obscure the information
widely considered the most secure form
of encryption albeit relatively slower
than AES it is widely used in web
browsing secure identification vpns
emails and chat applications
with so much hanging on the key secrecy
there must be a way to transmit the keys
without others reading our private data
many systems use a combination of
symmetric encryption and asymmetric
encryption to bolster security and match
speed at the same time since asymmetric
encryption takes longer to decrypt large
amounts of data the full information is
encrypted using a single key that is
symmetric encryption that single key is
then transmitted to the receiver using a
symmetric encryption so you don't have
to compromise either way another route
is using the Diffy Helman key exchange
which relies on a one-way function and
is much tougher to break into the third
variant of cryptography is termed as
hashing hashing is the process of
scrambling a piece of data beyond
recognition it gives an output of fixed
size which is known as the hash value of
the original data or just hash in
general the calculations that do the job
job of messing up the data collection
from the hash function they are
generally not reversible without
resilient Brute Force mechanisms and are
very helpful when storing data on
website servers that need not be stored
in Blain text for example many websites
store your account passwords in a hashed
format so that not even the
administrator can read your credentials
when a user tries to log in they can
compare the entered password's hash
value with the hash value that is
already stored on the servers for
Authentication
since the function will always return
the same value for the same
input cryptography has been in practice
for centuries Julius Caesar used a
substitution shift to move alphabets a
certain number of spaces beyond their
place in the alphabet table a spy can't
decipher the original message at first
glance for example if he wanted to pass
confidential information to his armies
and decides to use the substitution
shift of plus two a becomes c b becomes
D and so on the word attack when passed
through a substitution shift of plus
three becomes DW dfn this Cipher has
been appropriately named the Caesar
Cipher which is one of the most widely
used
algorithms the Enigma is probably the
most famous cryptographic Cipher device
used in ancient history it was used by
the Nazi German armies in the world wars
they were used to protect confidential
political military and administrative
information and it consisted of three or
more rotors that scrambled the original
message depending on the machine State
at that time the decryption is similar
but it needs both machines to stay in
the same state before passing the cipher
text so that we received the same plane
text message let's take a look at how
our data is protected while we browse
the internet thanks to cryptography here
we have a webbased tool that will help
us understand the process of RSA
encryption we see the entire workflow
from selecting the key size to be used
until the decryption of the cipher text
in order to get the plain text back as
we already know RSA encryption algorithm
falls under the umbrella of asymmetry
key
cryptography that basically implies that
we have two keys at play here a public
key and a private
key typically the public key is used by
the sender to encrypt the message and
the private key is used by the receiver
to decrypt the message there are some
occasions when this allocation is
reversed and we will have a look at them
as well in RSA we have the choice of key
size we can select any key from a 512
bit to 1024-bit all the way up to a 496
bit key the longer the key length the
more complex the encryption process
becomes and thereby strengthening the
cipher text although with added security
more complex functions take longer to
perform the same operations on similar
size of data we have to keep a b balance
between both speed and strength because
the strongest encryption algorithms are
of no use if they cannot be practically
deployed on systems around the world
let's take a 1024-bit key over here now
we need to generate the keys this
generation is done by functions that
operate on past freezes the tool we are
using right now generates the sudo
random keys to be used in this
explanation once we generate the keys
you can see the public key is rather
smaller than the private key which is
almost always the case these two keys
are mathematically linked with each
other they cannot be substituted with
any other key and in order to encrypt
the original message or decrypt the
cipher text this pair must be kept
together the public key is then sent to
the sender and the receiver keeps the
private key with himself in this
scenario let's try and encrypt a word
simply
learn we have to select if the key being
used for encryption is either private or
public since that affects the process of
of scrambling the information since we
are using the public key over here let's
select the same and copy it and paste
over
here the cipher we are using right now
is plain RSA there are some modified
ciphers with their own pros and cons
that can also be used provided we use it
on a regular basis and depending on the
use case as well once we click on
encrypt we can see the cipher text being
generated over here
the sudo random generating functions are
created in such a way that a single
character change in the plain text will
trigger a completely different Cipher
text this is a security feature to
strengthen the process from Brute Force
methods now that we are done with the
encryption process let's take a look at
the decryption
part the receiver gets this Cipher text
from the sender with no other key or
supplement he or she must already
possess the private private key
generated from the same pair no other
private key can be used to decp the
message since they are mathematically
linked we paste the private key here and
select the same the cipher must always
be the same used during the encryption
process once we click decrypt you can
see the original plane text we had
decided to encrypt this sums up the
entire process of RSA encryption and
decryption now some people use it the
other way around we also have the option
of using the private key to encrypt
information and the public key to
decrypt it this is done mostly to
validate the origin of the message since
the keys only work in pairs if a
different private key is used to encrypt
the message the public key cannot
decrypt it conversely if the public key
is able to decrypt the message it must
have been encrypted with the right
private key and hence the rightful owner
here we just have to take the private
key and use that to encrypt the plain
text and and select the same in this
checkbox as well you can see we have
generated a completely new Cipher text
this Cipher text will be sent to the
receiver and this time we will use the
public key for
decryption let's select the correct
checkbox and decrypt and we still get
the same
output now let's take a look at
practical example of encryption in the
real
world we all use the internet on a daily
basis and and many are aware of the
implications of using unsafe websites
let's take a look at Wikipedia here
pretty standard htps website with the H
stands for secured let's take a look at
how it secures the
data Y shck is the world's foremost and
most widely used Network protocol
analyzer it lets you see what's
happening on your network at a
microscopic level and we are going to
use the software to see the traffic that
is leing a machine and to understand how
vulnerable it is
since there are many applications
running in this machine let's apply a
filter that will only show us the
results related to
[Music]
Wikipedia let's search for something
that we can navigate the website
with okay once we get into it a little
you can see some of the requests being
populated over here
let's take a look at the specific
request these are the data packets that
basically transport the data from our
machine to the internet and vice
versa as you can see there's a bunch of
gibberish data here that doesn't really
reveal anything that we searched or
watched similarly other secured websites
function the same way and it is very
difficult if at all possible to Snoop on
user data this way to put this in
perspective let's take a look at another
website which is a HTTP web
page this has no encryption enabled from
the server end which makes it vulnerable
to attacks there is a login form here
which needs legitimate user credentials
in order to Grant access let's enter a
random pair of
credentials
these obviously won't work but we can
see the manner of data
transfer unsurprisingly we weren't able
to get into the platform instead we can
see the data
packets let's apply a similar filter
that will help us understand what
request this website is
sending
these are the requests being sent by the
HTTP login form to the internet if we
check here see whatever username and
password that we are entering we can
easily see it with the wire shark now we
used a dummy pair of credentials if we
select the right data packet we can find
our correct credentials if any website
had asked for a payment information or a
legitimate credentials it would have
been really easy to get a hold of these
to reiterate what we have already
learned we must always avoid HTTP
websites and just unknown or not
trustworthy websites in general because
the problem we saw here is just the tip
of the iceberg even though cryptography
has managed to lessen the risk of cyber
attacks it is still prevalent and we
should always be alert to keep ourselves
safe online there are two types of
encryption in
cryptography symmetric
cryptography and asymmetric key
cryptography both of these categories
have their pros and cons and differ only
by the implementation today we are going
to focus exclusively on symmetry key
cryptography let us have a look at its
applications in order to understand its
importance
better this variant of cryptography is
primarily used in banking applications
where personally identifiable
information needs to be encrypted with
so many aspects of banking moving onto
the internet having a reliable safety
net is crucial symmetric cryptography
helps in detecting bank fraud and boost
the security index of these payment
gateways in
general they are also helpful in
protecting data that is not in transit
and rests on servers and data centers
these centers house a massive amount of
data that needs to be encrypted with a
fast and efficient algorithm so that
when the data needs to be recalled by
the respective service there is the
Assurance of minor to no
delay while browsing the internet we
need symmetric encryption to browse
secure https websites so that we get an
allaround protection it plays a
significant role in verifying website
server authenticity exchanging the
necessary encryption Keys required and
generating a session using those keys to
ensure maximum security this helps us in
preventing the rather insecure HTTP
website
format so let us understand how
symmetric key cryptography works first
before moving on to the specific
algorithms symmetric key cryptography
relies on a single key for the
encryption and decryption of information
both the sender and receiver of the
message need to have a pre-shared secret
key that they will use to convert the pl
text into Cipher text and vice versa as
you can see in the image the key used
for encryption is the same key needed
for decrypting the message at the other
end the secret key shouldn't be sent
along with the cipher text to the
receiver because that would defeat the
entire purpose of using crypto
photography key exchange can be done
beforehand using other algorithms like
the defy Helman key exchange protocol
for
example for example if Paul wants to
send a simple message to Jane they need
to have a single encryption key that
both of them must get secret to prevent
snooping on by malicious
actors it can be generated by either one
of them but must belong to both of them
before the messages start flowing
suppose the message I am ready is
converted into Cipher text using in a
specific substitution Cipher by Paul in
that case Jane must also be aware of the
substitution shift to decp the cipher
text once it reaches her irrespective of
the scenario where someone manages to
grab the cipher text mid transit to try
and read the message not having the
secret key renders everyone helpless
looking to snow in the symmetric key
algorithms like the data encryption
standard have been in use since the
1970s while the popular ones like the
EES have become the industry stand
standard
today with the entire architecture of
symmetric cryptography depending on the
single key being used you can understand
why it's of Paramount importance to keep
it secret on All
Occasions the side effect of having a
single key for the encryption and
decryption is it becomes a single point
of failure anyone who gets their hand on
it can read all the encrypted messages
and do so mainly without the knowledge
of the sender and the receiver so it is
the priority to keep the encryption and
encryption key private at all times
should it fall into the wrong hands the
third party can send messages to either
the sender or the receiver using the
same key to encrypt the message upon
receiving the message and decrypting it
with the key it is impossible to guess
its origin if the sender somehow
transmits the secret key along with the
cipher text anyone can intercept the
package and access the information
consequently this encryption category is
termed private key cryptography since a
big part of the data's Integrity is
right iding on the promise that the
users can keep the key secret this
terminology contrasts with asymmetry key
cryptography which is called public key
cryptography because it has two
different keys at play one of which is
public provided we manage to keep the
key secret we still have to choose what
kind of ciphers we want to use to
encrypt this information in symmetric
key cryptography there are broadly two
categories of ciphers that we can employ
let us have a
look stream Cipher are the algorithms
that encre basic information one bit at
a time it can change depending on the
algorithm being used but usually it
relies on a single bit or bite to do the
encryption this is the relatively
quicker alternative considering the
algorithm doesn't have to deal with
blocks of data at a single time every
piece of data that goes into the
encryption can and needs to be converted
into binary format in stream ciphers
each binary digit is encrypted one after
the other the most most popular ones are
the rc4 salsa and Panama the binary data
is passed through an encryption key
which is a randomly generated bit stream
upon passing it through we receive the
cipher text that can be transferred to
the receiver without fear of man in the
middle attacks the binary data can be
passed through an algorithmic function
it can have either X or operations as it
is most of the time or any other
mathematical calculations that have the
singular purpose of scrambling the data
the encryption key is generated using
the random bitstream generator and it
acts as a supplement in the algorithmic
function the output is in binary form
which is then converted into the decimal
or hexadecimal format to give our final
Cipher
text on the other hand block ciphers
dissect the raw information into chunks
of data of fixed size the size of these
blocks depend on the exact Cipher being
used a 128bit block Cipher will break
the plain text into blocks of 128bit
each and encrypt those blocks in instead
of a single digit once these blocks are
encrypted individually they are chained
together to form a final Cipher
text block ciphers are much slower but
they are more tamper proof and are used
in some of the most widely used
algorithms employed
today just like stream ciphers the
original Cipher text is converted into
binary format before beginning the
process once the conversion is complete
the blocks are passed through the
encryption algorithm along with the
encryption key this would provide us
with the encrypted blocks of binary
data once these blocks are combin we get
a final binary
string this string is then converted
into heximal format to get our Cipher
text today the most popular symmetric
key algorithms like AES Dees and 3des
are all block Cipher methodology
subsets with so many factors coming into
play there are there are quite a few
things symmetrically cryptography excels
at while falling short in some
other symmetrically cryptography is much
faster variant when compared to
asymmetric cryptography there is only
one key in play unlike asymmetric
encryption and this drastically improves
calculation speed in the encryption and
decryption similarly the performance of
symmetric encryption is much more
efficient under similar computational
limitations fewer calculations help in
better memory manage agement for the
host
system bulk amounts of data that need to
be encrypted are very well suited for
symmetric algorithms since they are much
quicker handling large amounts of data
is simple and easy to use in servers and
data forms this helps in better latency
during data recall and fewer mixed
packets thanks to its simple single key
structure symmetry key cryptography
algorithms are much easier to set up a
communication Channel with and offer a
much more straightforward maintenance
duties once the secret Keys transmitted
to both the sender and receiver without
any prior mishandling the rest of the
system aligns easily and everyday
Communications becomes easy and secure
if the algorithm is applied as per the
documentation symmetric algorithms are
very robust and can enip vast amounts of
data with very less
overhead Dees algorithm stands for data
encryption
standard it is a symmetric key Cipher
that is used to encrypt and recpt
information in a blogby block manner
each block is encrypted individually and
they're later chained together to form
our final Cipher text which is then sent
to a receiver DS takes the original
unaltered piece of data called the plain
text in a 64-bit block and it is
converted into an encrypted text that is
called the cipher text it uses 48 bit
Keys during the encryption process and
follows a specific structure called the
fistal Cipher structure during the
entire process it is a symmetri key
algorithm which means DS can reuse the
keys used in the encryption format to
decrypt the cipher text back to the
original plane text once the 64-bit
blocks are encrypted they can be
combined together before being
transmitted let's take a look at the
origin and the reason the was
founded DS is based on a fistal block
Cipher called Lucifer developed in 1971
by IBM cryptography researcher host
fistal Dees uses 16 rounds of this
fistal structure using a different key
for each round it also utilizes a random
function with two inputs and provides a
single output variable DS becames the
organization's approved encryption
standard in November 1976 and was later
reaffirmed as a standard in 1983 1988
and finally in 1999 but eventually DS
was cracked and it was no longer
considered a secure solution for all
official roots of
communication consequently triple Ds was
developed triple Ds s is a symmetry key
block Cipher that uses a double Ds
Cipher encrypt with the first key delete
encryption with the second key and
encrypt again with a third key there is
also a variation of the two keys where
the first and second key are duplicate
of each other but triple Ds was
ultimately deemed too slow for the
growing need for fast communication
channels and people eventually fell back
to using DS for encrypting messages in
order to search for a better alternative
a public wide competition was organized
and helped cryptographers develop their
own algorithm as a proposal for the next
global standard this is where the rile
algorithm came into play and was later
credited to be the next Advanced
encryption standard for a long time DS
was the standard for data encryption for
data security its rule ended in 2002
when finally the advanced encryption
standard replaced Dees as an acceptable
standard following a public competition
for a
place to understand the structure of a
fistal Cipher we can use the following
image as a reference the block being
encrypted is divided into two parts one
of which is being passed onto the
function while the other part is exord
with the function's output the function
also uses the encryption key that
differs for each individual round this
keeps going on until the last step until
where the right hand side and the left
hand side are being swapped here we
receive our final Cipher text for the
decryption process the the entire
procedure is reversed starting from the
order of the keys to the block sorting
if the entire process is repeated in a
reverse order we will eventually get
back our plane text and this Simplicity
helps the speed overall This was later
detrimental to the efficiency of the
algorithm hence the security was
compromised a fistal block Cipher is a
structure used to derive many symmetric
block ciphers such as Dees which as we
have discussed in our previous comment
pistol Cipher proposed a structure that
implements substitution and permutation
alternately so that we can obtain Cipher
text from the plane text and vice versa
this helps in reducing the redundancy of
the program and increases the complexity
to combat Brute Force
attacks the fistel cipher is actually
based on the Shannon structure that was
proposed in 1945 the fistel cipher is
the structure suggested by horse feisel
which was considered to be a backbone
while developing many symmetric block
ciphers
the Shannon structure highlights the
implementation of alternate confusion
and diffusion and like we already
discussed the fistal Cipher structure
can be completely reversed depending on
the data however we must consider the
fact that to decrypt the information by
reversing the fal structure we will need
the exact polinomial functions and the
key
orders to understand how the blocks are
being calculated we take a plane test
which is of 64bit and that is later
divided divided into two equal halves of
32 bit each in this the right half is
immediately transferred to the next
round to become the new Left half of the
second r the right hand is again passed
off to a function which uses an
encryption key that is unique to each
round in the fistal Cipher whatever the
function gives off as an output it is
passed on as an xor input with the left
half of the initial plane text the next
output will become the right half of the
second round for the plain text this
entire process constitutes of a single
round in the fistal
Cipher taking into account what happens
in the polinomial
function we take one half of the block
and pass it through an expansion box the
work of the expansion box is to increase
the size of the half from 32bit to 48
bit text this is done to make the text
compatible to a 48 bit Keys we have
generated
beforehand once we pass it through the
EXO function we get a 48 bit text as an
output now remember a half should be of
32bit so this 48 bit output is then
later passed on to a substitution box
this substitution box reduces its size
from 48 bit to 32bit Output which is
then later exort with the first half of
the plane
text a block Cipher is considered the
safest if the size of the block is large
but large block sizes can also slow down
encryption speed and the decryption
speed generally the size is
64-bit sometimes modern block ciphers
like AES have a 128bit block size as
well the security of the block CER
increases with increasing key size but
larger key sizes may also reduce the
speeds of the process earlier 64-bit
keys were considered sufficient modern
ciphers need to use 128bit Keys due to
the increasing complexity of today's
computational standard
standards the increasing number of
rounds also increase the security of the
block Cipher similarly they're inversely
proportional to the speed of
encryption a highly complex round
function enhances the security of the
block Cipher Al we must maintain a
balance between the speed and
security the symmetric block Cipher is
implemented in a software application to
achieve better execution speed there is
no use of an algorithm it if it cannot
be implemented in a real life framework
that can help organizations to encrypt
or decrypt the data in a timely manner
now that we understand the basics of
fistal ciphers we can take a look at how
Dees manages to run through 16 rounds of
the structure and provide the cipher
text at the end now that we understand
the basics of FAL ciphers we can take a
look at how DS manages to run through 16
rounds of this structure and provide a
cipher text in simple terms DS takes a
64-bit plain text and converts it into a
64-bit Cipher text and since we are
talking about asymmetric algorithms the
same key is being used when it is
decrypting the data as
well we first take a 64bit plain text
and we pass it through an initial
permutation function the initial
permutation function has the job of
dividing the block into two different
parts so that we can perform fisal
Cypher structures on
it there are multiple rounds being
procured in the DS algorithm namely 16
rounds of FAL Cipher structure each of
these rounds will need keys initially we
take a 56-bit cipher key but it is a
single key we pass it onto a round key
generators which generates 16 different
keys for each single round that the
fistal Cipher is being run these keys
are passed on to the rounds as 48 bits
the size of these 48 bit Skys is the
reason we use the substitution and
permutation Bongs in the Pol nomial
functions of the faal
ciphers when passing through all these
rounds we reach round 16 where the final
key is passed on from the round key
generator and we get a final permutation
in the final permutation the rounds are
swapped and we get a final Cipher text
this is the entire process of Dees with
16 rounds of FAL ciphers encompassed in
it to decrypt a cipher text back to the
plane text we just have to reverse the
process we did in the DS algorithm and
reverse the key order along with the
function s this kind of Simplicity is
what gave D the bonus when it comes to
speed but eventually it was detrimental
to the overall efficiency of the program
when it comes to security factors DS
have five different modes of operation
to choose from this one of those is
electronic code book each 64-bit block
is encrypted and decrypted independently
in the electronic codebook format we
also have Cipher block chaining or the
CBC method here each 64-bit block
depends on the previous one and all of
them use an initialization
Vector we have a cipher feedback block
mechanism where the preceding Cipher
text becomes the input for the
encryption algorithm it produces a su a
random output which in turn is exor with
the plain
text there is an output feedback method
as well which is the same as Cipher
feedback except that the encryption
algorithm input is the output from the
preceding
DS a counter method has a different way
of approach where each PL text block is
exor with an encrypted counter the
counter is then incremented for each
subsequent block there are a few other
alternatives to these modes of operation
but the five mentioned above are the
most widely used in the industry and
recommended by cryptographers
worldwide let's take a look at the
future of
DS the dominance of Dees ended in 2002
when the advanced encryption standard
replaced the DS encryption algorithm as
the accepted standard it was done
following a public competition to find a
replacement nist officially withdrew the
global acceptance standard in May 2005
although triple Ds has approved for some
sensitive government information through
2030 n also had to change the DS
algorithm because its Kei length was too
short given the increased processing
power of the new computers encryption
power is related to the size of the key
and DS found itself a victim of ongoing
technological advances in Computing we
have received a point where 56-bit was
no longer a challenge to the computers
of cracking note that because DS is no
longer the nist federal standard it does
not mean that it is no longer in use
triple Ds is still used today and is
still considered a legacy encryption
algorithm to get a better understanding
of how these keys and Cipher Tex look
like we can use an online tool for our
benefit as we already know to encrypt
any kind of data a key is man atory this
key can be generated using mathematical
functions or computerized key generation
program such as this website offers it
can be based on any piece of text let's
say the word is simply
[Music]
learn in our
example once the key is settled we
provide the plain text or the clear text
that needs to be encrypted using the
aforementioned key suppose a sentence
for this example is this is my first
message
we have satisfied two prerequisites the
message and the key another variable
that goes into play is the mode of
operation we have already learned about
five different modes of operation while
we can see some other options here as
well let us go with the CBC variant
which basically means the cipher block
chaining method one of cbc's key
characteristics is that it uses a
chaining process it causes the
decryption of a block of Cipher text to
depend all on the preceding Cipher text
blocks as a result the entire validity
of all the blocks is contained in the
previous adjacent blocks as well a
single bit error in a cipher text block
affects the decryption of all the
subsequent blocks rearrangement of the
order of these for example can cause the
decryption process to get
corrupted regarding the manner of
displaying binary information we have
two options here we can either go with
base 64 or the heximal format
let's go with the base 64 right
now as you can see the cipher text is
readily available b64 is a little more
efficient than hexs so we will be
getting a smaller Cipher text when it
comes to B
64 albe the size of both the formats
will be the same the hex has a longer
Cipher text since B 64 takes four
characters for every three bytes while
hex will take two characters for each
bite hence B 64 turns out to be more
efficient now to decut the cipher text
we go by the same format we choose Bas
64 we copy the cipher text onto a
decryption tool and we have to make sure
that the key we are using is exactly the
same we choose similar mode of
operation and we choose the correct
encoding format as well which is base 64
in this
case as you can see the decryption is
complete and we get a plain text back
even if you keep everything the same but
we just change the encoding format it
will not be able to decrypt
anything unfortunately DS has become
rather easy to crack even without the
help of a key the advanced encryption
standard is still on top when it comes
to symmetric encryption security and
will likely stay there for a
while eventually with so much computing
power growth the need for a stronger
algorithm was necessary to safeguard a
person personal data as solid as Dees
was the computers of today could easily
break the encryption with repeated
attempts thereby rendering the data
security helpless to counter this
dilemma a new standard was introduced
which was termed as the advanced
encryption standard or the AES
algorithm let's learn what is Advanced
encryption
standard the AES algorithm also known as
the reile algorithm is a symmetric block
Cipher with a block size of 128 bits it
is converted into Cipher text using keys
of 128 192 or 256 bits it is implemented
in software and Hardware throughout the
world to encrypt sensitive data the
National Institute of Standards and
Technology also known as nist started
development on AES in 1997 when it was
announced the need for an alternative to
the data encryption standard the new
internet needed a replacement for Dees
because of of its small key size with
increasing computing power it was
considered unsafe against entire key
search attacks the triple Ds was
designed to overcome this problem
however it was deemed to be too slow to
be deployed in machines
worldwide strong cases were present by
the Mars rc6 Serpent and the two fish
algorithms but it was the rindal
encryption algorithm also known as AES
which was eventually chosen as the
standard symmetric key encryption
algorithm to be used
its section was formalized with the
release of federal information
processing standards publication 197 in
the November of 2001 it was approved by
the US Secretary of
Commerce now that we understand the
origin of AES let us have a look at the
features that make AES encryption
algorithm
unique the AES algorithm uses a
substitution permutation or SP Network
it consists of multiple rounds to
produce a cipher text it has a series of
linked operations including replacing
inputs with specific outputs that is
substitutions and others that involve
bit shuffling which is
permutations at the beginning of the
encryption process we only start out
with a single key which can be either a
128bit key a 192bit key or a 256bit key
eventually this one key is expanded to
be used in multiple rounds throughout
the encryption and the decryption cycle
interestingly AES performs all its
calculations on white data instead of
bit data as seen in the case of the dees
algorithm therefore AES treats 128 bits
of a clear text block as 16 bytes the
number of rounds during the encryption
process depends on the key size that is
being used the 128bit key size fixes 10
Rounds the 192bit key size fixes 12
rounds and the 256bit key holds 14
rounds a round key is required for each
of these rounds but since only one key
is in put into the algorithm the single
key needs to be expanded to get the key
for each round including the round
zero with so many mathematical
calculations going on in the background
there are bound to be a lot of steps
throughout the procedure let's have a
look at the steps followed in
AES before we move ahead we need to
understand how data is being stored
during the process of AES
encryption everything in the process is
stored in a 4 into 4 Matrix
format this Matrix is also known as a
state array and we'll be using these
State arrays to transmit data from one
step to another and from one round to
the next
round each round takes straight array as
input and gives a straight array as
output to be transferred into the next
round it is a 16 byte Matrix with each
cell representing one byte with each
four bytes representing a word so every
state array will have a total of four
words representing
it as we previously discussed we take a
single key and expand it to the number
of rounds that we need the key to be
used in let's say the number of rounds
are n then the key has to be expanded to
be used with n+1 rounds because the
first round is the key zero
round let's say n is the number of
rounds the key is expanded to n + one
rounds it is also Al a state array
having four words in its vicinity every
key is used for a single round and the
first key is used as a round key before
any round
begins in the very beginning the plane
text is captured and passed through an
xor function with the round key as a
supplement this key can be considered
the first key from the n+1 expanded set
moving on the state array resulting from
the above step is passed on to a bite
substit subtitution
process beyond that there is a provision
to shift rows in the state arrays later
on the state array is mixed with a
constant Matrix to shuffle its column in
the mix column segment after which we
add the round key for that particular
round the last four steps mentioned are
part of every single round that the
encryption algorithm goes through the
state arrays are then passed from one
round to the next as an input in the
last round however we skipped the mix
columns portion with the rest of the
process remaining
unchanged but what are these bite
substitution and row shifting processes
let's find out regarding each step in
more
detail in the first step the plane text
is stored in a state array and is exor
with the k0 which is the first key in
the expanded key set this step is
performed only once on a block while
being repeated at the end of each round
round as per iteration
demands the state array is exor with the
key to get a new state array which is
then pass office input to the sub bytes
process in the second stage we have by
substitution we leverage an Xbox called
as a substitution box to randomly switch
data among each element every single
bite is converted into a hexadecimal
value having two parts the first part
denotes the row value and the second
part denotes the column value the entire
State array is passed through the sbox
to create a brand new state array which
is then passed off as an input to the
row shifting process the 16 input bytes
are replaced by looking at a fixed table
given in the design we finally get a
matrix with four rows and four
columns when it comes to row shifting
each bit in the four rows of the Matrix
is shifted to the left an entry that is
a fall off is reinserted to the right of
the line the change is done as follows
the first line is not moved in any way
the second line is shifted to a single
position to the left the third line is
shifted two positions to the left and
the fourth line is shifted three
positions to the left the result is a
new Matrix that contains the same 16
bytes but has been moved in relation to
each other to boost the complexity of
the
program in mixed columns each column of
four bytes is now replaced using a
special mathematic iCal function the
function takes four bytes of a column as
input and outputs four completely new
bytes we will get a new Matrix with the
same size of 16 bytes and it should be
noted that this phase has not been done
in the last round of the
iteration when it comes to adding a
round key the 16 bytes of the Matrix are
treated as 128 bits and the 128 bits of
the round key are exort if it is the
last round the output is the cipher text
if you still have a few rounds remaining
the resulting 128 bits are interpreted
as 16 bytes and we start another similar
round let's take an example to
understand how all these processes work
if our plane text is the string
2192 we first convert it into a
hexadecimal format as follows we use an
encryption key which is that's my K Fu
and it is converted into into a
hexadecimal format as
well as per the guidelines we use a
single key which is then later expanded
into n +1 number of keys in which case
it's supposed to be 11 keys for 10
different
rounds in round zero we add the round
key the plane test is exort with the K 0
and we get a state array that is passed
off as an input to the substitution by
its
process when it comes to the
substitution bytes process we leverage
an sbox to substitute the elements of
each bite with a completely new bite
this way the state array that we receive
is passed off as an input to the row
shifting process on the next
step when it comes to row shifting each
element is shifted a few places to the
left with the first row being shifted by
zero places second row by one place
third row by two places and the last by
three
the state array that we received from
the row shifting is passed off as an
input to mix columns in mixed columns we
multiply the straight array with a
constant Matrix after which I receive a
new Straight array to be passed on onto
the next
step we add the new state array as an
exor with the round key of the
particular iteration whatever state
array we receive here it becomes an out
output for this particular
round now since this is the first round
of the entire encryption process the
state array that we receive is passed
off as an input to the new
Round We repeat this process for 10 more
rounds and we finally receive a cipher
text once the final State array can be
denoted in the hexad decimal format this
becomes our final Cipher text that we
can use for transferring information
from the sender
receiver let's take a look at the
applications of AES in this
world AES finds most use in the area of
wireless security in order to establish
a secure mode of authentication between
routers and clients highly secure
mechanisms like WPA and WPA2 psk are
extensively used in securing Wi-Fi
endpoints with the help of Riles
algorithm it also helps in SSL TLS
encryption that is instrumental in
encrypting our internet browser sessions
AES Works in tandem with other
asymmetric encryption algorithms to make
sure the web browser and web server are
properly configured and use encrypted
channels for
communication AES is also prevalent in
general file encryption of various
formats ranging from critical documents
to the media files having a large key
allows people to encrypt media and
decrypt data with maximum security
possible AES is also used for processor
Security in Hardware Appliances to
prevent machine hijacking among other
things as a direct successor to the dees
algorithm there are some aspects that
AES provides an immediate advantage in
let us take a
look when it comes to key length the
biggest flaw in DS algorithm was that
small length was easily vulnerable by
today's standards eses has managed to
NAB up 128 192 and 256bit key lens to
bolster the security further the block
size is also larger in AES owing to more
complexity of the algorithm the number
of rounds in Dees is fixed irrespective
of the plane text being used in AES the
number of round depends on the key
length that is being used for the
particular iteration thereby providing
more Randomness and complexity in the
algorithm
the dees algorithm is considered to be
simpler than AES even though AES beats
Dees when it comes to relative speed of
encryption and decryption this makes
Advanced encryption standard much more
streamlined to be deployed in Frameworks
and systems worldwide when it compares
to the data encryption standard hello in
our last video on cryptography we took a
look at symmetry key cryptography we
used a single private key for both the
encryption and decryption of data and it
works very well in theory let's take a
look at a more realistic scenario now
let's meet Joe Joe is a journalist who
needs to communicate with Ryan via
long-distance messaging due to the
critical nature of the information
people are waiting for any message to
leave Joe's house so that they can
intercept it now Joe can easily use
symmetric cryptography to send the
encrypted data so that even if someone
intercepts the message they cannot
understand what it says but here's the
tricky part how will Joe send the
required decryption key to Ryan the
sender of the message as well as the
receiver need to have the same
decryption key so that they can exchange
messages otherwise Ryan cannot decrypt
the information even when he receives
the cipher text if someone intercepts
the key while transmitting it there is
no use in employing cryptography since a
third party can now decode all the
information easily key sharing is a risk
that will always exist when symmetric
key cryptography is being used
thankfully asymmetric key encryption has
managed to fix this
problem this is B from Simply learn and
welcome to this video on asymmetry key
cryptography let's take a look at what
we are going to learn today We Begin by
explaining what asymmetry key
cryptography is and how it works we take
a look at its application and uses we
understand why it's called publicy
cryptography and then learn a little bit
about RS encryption and then we learn
about the advantages of asymmetric key
cryptography over symmetric key
cryptography let's understand what
asymmetry key cryptography
is asymmetry encryption uses a double
layer of protection there are two
different keys at play here a private
key and a public key a public key is
used to encrypt the information
pre-transit and a private key is used to
decrypt the data post Transit these pair
of keys must belong to the receiver of
the message the public keys can be
shared via messaging blog posts or key
servers and there are no restrictions S
as you can see in the image the two keys
are working in the system the sender
first encrypts the message using the
receiver's private key after which we
receive the cipher text the cipher text
is then transmitted to the receiver
without any other key on getting the
cipher text the receiver uses his
private key to decrypt it and get the
plain text back there has been no
requirement of any key exchange
throughout this process therefore
solving the most glaring flaw faced in
symmetry key
cryptography the public known to
everyone cannot be used to decrypt the
message and the private key which can
decrypt the message need not be shared
with anyone the sender and receiver can
exchange personal data using the same
set of keys as often as
possible to understand this better take
the analogy of your
mailbox anyone who wants to send you a
letter has access to the box and can
easily share information with you in a
way you can say the mailbox is publicly
available to all but only you have
access to the key that can open the
mailbox and read the letters in it this
is how the private key comes to play no
one can intercept the message and read
its contents since it's encrypted once
the receiver gets its contents he can
use his private key to decrypt the
information both the public key and the
private key are generated so they are
interl and you cannot substitute other
private keys to decrypt the data in
another example if Alice wants to send a
message to Bob let's say tre's call me
today she must use Bob's public key
while encrypting the message upon
receiving the cipher message Bob can
proceed to use his private key in order
to decrypt the message and hence
complete Security is attained during
transmission without any need for
sharing the
key since this type of encryption is
highly secure it has many users in areas
that require High
confidentiality it is used to manage
digital signatur so there is valid proof
of a documents auth authenticity with so
many aspects of business transitioning
to the digital sphere critical documents
need to be verified before being
considered authentic and acted upon
thanks to asymmetric key cryptography
senders can now sign documents with
their private Keys anyone who needs to
verify the authenticity of such
signatures can use the sender's public
key to decrypt the signature since the
public and the private keys are linked
to each other mathematically it's
impossible to repeat this verification
with with duplicate Keys document
destion has been made very simple by
today's standards but the background
implementation follows the similar
approach in blockchain architecture
asymmetry key cryptography is used to
authorize transactions and maintain the
system thanks to its two key structures
changes are reflected across the
blockchain's peer-to-peer Network only
if it is approved from both ends along
with asymmetric key cryptography stamp
appro architecture its non- repudiation
characteristic also helps in keeping the
network stable we can also use asymmetry
key cryptography combined with symmetry
key cryptography to monitor SSL or TLS
encrypted browsering sessions to make
sure nobody can steal up personal
information when accessing banking
websites or the internet in general it
plays a significant role in verifying
website server authenticity exchanging
the necessary encryption Keys required
and generating a session using those
keys to ensure maximum security instead
of the rather insecure HTTP website
format security parameters differ on a
session by session basis so the
verification process is consistent and
utterly essential to Modern data
security another great use of the
asymmetric key cryptography structure is
transmitting keys for symmetric key
cryptography with the most significant
difficulty in symmetric encryption being
key exchange asymmetric keys can help
clear the shortcoming the original
message is first encrypted using a
symmetry key the key used for encrypting
the data is then converted into the
cipher text using the receiver re's
public key now we have two Cipher text
to transmit to the receiver on receiving
both of them the receiver uses his
private key to decrypt the Symmetry key
he can then use it to decrypt the
original information on getting the key
used to encrypt the data while this may
seem more complicated than just
asymmetric key cryptography alone
symmetric encryption algorithms are much
more optimized for vast amounts of data
on some occasions encrypting the key
using asymmetric algorithms will
definitely be more memory efficient and
secure you might remember us discussing
why symmetric encryption was called
private key cryptography let us
understand why asymmetric falls under
the public key
cryptography we have two keys at our
disposal the encryption key is available
to everyone the decryption key is
supposed to be
private unlike symmetry key cryptography
there is no need to share anything
privately to have an encrypted messaging
system to put that into perspective we
share our email address with anyone
looking to communicate with us it is
supposed to be public by Design so that
our email login credentials are private
and they help in preventing any data
mishandling since there is nothing
hidden from the world if they want to
send us any encrypted information this
category is called the public key
cryptography there are quite a few
algorithms being used today that follow
the architecture of asymmetric
cryptography none more famous than the
RS encryption
RSA encryption is the most widely used
encryption or public key encryption
standard using asymmetry key approach
named after its Founders reest Shamir
and Adelman it uses block ciphers to
obscure the information if you are
unfamiliar with how block ciphers work
they are encryption algorithms that
divide the original data into blocks of
equal size the block size depends on the
exact Cipher being used once they are
broken down these blocks are encrypted
individually and later a chain together
to form the final Cipher
text widely considered to be the most
secure form of encryption or B
relatively slower than symmetric
encryption algorithms it is widely used
in web browsing secure identification
vpns emails and other chat
applications with so many variables in
play there must be some advantages that
give asymmetrically cryptography and
Edge over the traditional symmetric
encryption methodologies let's go
through some of them
there is no need for any reliable key
sharing channel in asymmetric encryption
it was an added risk in private key
cryptography that has been completely
eliminated in public key architecture
the key which is made public cannot
recpt any confidential information and
the only key that can decrypt doesn't
need to be shared publicly under any
circumstance we have much more extensive
key lens in RSA encryption and other
asymmetric algorithms like 248 bit key
and 4, 96-bit Keys larger keys are much
harder to break into via brute force and
are much more
secure asymmetric key cryptography can
use as a proof of authenticity since
only the rightful owner of the keys can
generate the messages to be decrypted by
the private key the situation can also
be reversed encryption is done using a
private key and decryption is done by
the public key which would not function
if the correct private key is not used
to generate the message hence proving
the authenticity of the owner it also
has a tamper protection feature where
the message cannot be intercepted and
changed without invalidating the private
key used to encrypt the data
consequently the public key cannot equip
the message and it is easy to realize
the information is not 100% legitimate
when and where the case
requires now that we have a proper
revision let's understand what digital
signatures are before moving on to the
algorithm the objective of digital
signatures is to to authenticate and
verify documents and data this is
necessary to avoid tampering and digital
modification or forgery of any kind
during the transmission of official
documents they work on the public key
cryptography architecture with one
exception typically an asymmetri key
system encrypts using a public key and
decrypts with a private key for digital
signatures however the reverse is
true the signature is encrypted using a
private key and is decrypted with the
public key because the keys are ink
together decoding it with the public key
verifies that the proper private key was
used to sign the document thereby
verifying the signatures Provence let's
go through each step to understand the
procedure
thoroughly in step one we have M which
is the original PL text message and it
is passed onto a hash function denoted
by H hash to create a
digest next it bundles the message
together with the hash digest and
encrypts it using the sender private
key it sends the encrypted bundle to the
receiver who can decrypt it using the
sender public
key once the message is decrypted it is
passed to the same hash function H hash
to generate a similar
digest it compares the newly generated
hash with the bundled hash value
received along with the message if they
match it verifies data
Integrity in many instances they provide
a layer of validation and security to
messages through non-secure Channel
properly implemented a digital signature
gives the receiver reason to believe
that the message was sent by the claimed
sender digital signatures are equivalent
to traditional handwritten signatures in
many respects but properly implemented
digital signatures are more difficult to
forge than the handwritten type digital
signature schemes in the sense used here
are cryptographically based and must be
implemented properly to be effective
they can also provide non-repudiation
meaning that the signer cannot
successfully claim that they did not
sign a message while also claiming their
private key remains secret further some
non reparation schemes offer a time
stamp for the digital signature so that
even if the private key is exposed the
signature is
valid to implement the concept of
digital signature in real world we have
two primary algorithms to follow the RSA
algorithm and the DSA algorithm but the
latter is a topic of learning today so
let's go ahead and see what the digital
signature algorithm is supposed to
do digital signature algorithm is a fips
standard which is a federal information
processing standard for digital
signatures it was proposed in 1991 and
globally standardized in 1994 by the
National Institute of Standards and
Technology also known as known as the
nist it functions on the framework of
modular exponation and discrete
logarithmic problems which are difficult
to compute as a force brute
system unlike DSA most signature types
are generated by signing message digest
with the private key of the originator
this creates a digital thumbprint of the
data since just the message digest is
sign the signature is generally much
smaller compared to the data that was
signed as a result digital signatures
import less load on processors at the
time of signing execution and they use
small volumes of bandwidth DSA on the
other hand does not encrypt message
digest using private key or decp message
digest using public key instead it uses
mathematical functions to create a
digital signature consisting of two 160
bit numbers which are originated from
the message digests and the private key
DCS make use of the public key for
authenticating the signature but the
authorization process is is much more
complicated when compared with RSA DSA
also provides three benefits which is
the message authentication integr
verification and non-
repudiation in the image we can see the
entire process of DSF validation a plain
text message is passed onto a hash
function where the digest is generated
which is passed onto a signing function
signing function also has other
parameters like a global variable g a
random variable k and the private key of
the
sender the outputs are then bundled onto
a single pack with a plain text and sent
to the receiver the two outputs we
receive from the signing functions are
the two 160 bit numbers denoted by S and
R on the receiver end we pass the plane
text to the same hash function to
regenerate the message
digest it is passed onto verification
function which has other requirements
such as the public key of the sender
Global variable G and SNR received from
the
sender the value generated by the
function is then compared to R if they
match then the verification process is
complete and data Integrity is verified
this was an overview of the way the DSA
algorithm works you already know it
depends on logarithmic functions to
calculate the outputs so let us see how
we can do the same in our next
section we have three phases here the
first of which is key generation to
generate the keys we need some
prerequisites we select a q which
becomes a prime divisor we select a
prime number P such that P minus 1 mod Q
equal to 0 we also select a random
integer G which must satisfy the two
formulas being mentioned on the screen
right now once these values are selected
we can go ahead with generating the keys
the private key can be denoted by X and
it is any random integer that falls
between the bracket of zero and the
value of Q the public key can be
calculated as y = to G ^ x mod P where y
stands for the public key the private
key can then be packaged as a bundle
which comprises of values of p q G and X
similarly the public key can also be
packaged as a bundle having the values
of p q G and Y
once we're done with key generation we
can start verifying the signature and
this
generation repeat once the keys are
generated we can start generating the
signature the message is passed through
a hash function to generate the digest
Edge first we can choose any random
integer K which falls under the bracket
of 0 and Q to calculate the first 160
bit number of a signing function of r we
use the formula G to the power K mod P
into mod Q similarly to calculate the
value of the second output that is s we
use the following formula that is shown
on the
screen the signature can then be
packaged as a bundle having R and
S this bundle along with a plain text
message is then passed on to the
receiver now with the third phase we
have to verify the signature we first
calculate the message digest received in
the bundle by passing it to the same
hash function we calculate the value of
w U1 and U2 using the formulas shown on
the screen we have to calculate a
verification component which is then to
be compared with the value of R being
sent by the sender this verification
component can be calculated using the
following formula once calculated this
can be compared with the value of R if
the values match then the signature
verification is successful and our
entire process is complete starting from
Key generation to the signature
Generation all the way up to the
verification of the
signature with so many steps to follow
we are bound to have a few advantages to
boot this and we would be right to think
so DSA is highly robust in the security
and stability aspect when compared to
Alternative signature verification
algorithms we have a few other ciphers
that aim to achieve the simplicity and
the flexibility of DSA but it has been a
tough ask for all the other
suits the key generation is much faster
when compared to the RSA algorithm and
such while the actual encryption and
decryption process May falter a little
in comparison a quicker start in the
beginning is well known to optimize a
lot of
Frameworks DSA requires Less storage
space to work its entire cycle in
contrast its direct correspondent that
is RSA Al algorithm needs a certain
amount of computational and storage
space to function efficiently this is
not the case with DSA which has been
optimized to work with weaker hardware
and lesser
resources the DSA is patented but nist
has made this patent available worldwide
royaltyfree a draft version of the
speculation fips 1865 indicates that DSL
will no longer be approved for digital
signature generation but it may be used
to verify signatures generated prior to
the implementation date of that
standard the RSA algorithm is a publicy
signature algorithm developed by Ron
reest ADI Shamir and Leonard Edelman the
paper was first published in 1977 and
the algorithm uses logarithmic functions
to keep the working complex enough to
withstand brute force and streamlined
enough to be fast post deployment RSA
can also encrypt and decrypt general
information to securely exchange data
along with handling digital signature
verification let us understand how it
achieved this we take our Plaine text
message M we pass it through a hash
function to generate the digest H which
is then encrypted using the sender's
private key this is appended to the
original plane text message and sent
over to the
receiver once the receiver receives the
bundle they can pass the plane text
message through the same hash function
to generate a digest and the cipher text
can be decrypted using the public key of
the sender the remaining hashes are
compared if the values match then the
data Integrity is verified and the
sender is authenticated apart from
digital signatures the main case of RSA
is encryption and decryption of private
information before being transmitted
across communication challenge this is
where the data encryption comes into
play when using RSA for encryption and
decryption of General data it reverses
the key set usage unlike signature
verification it receives the receiver's
public key to encrypt the data and uses
the receiver's private key in decrypting
the data thus there is no need to
exchange any keys in this scenario there
are two broad components when it comes
to RSA cryptography one of them is key
generation key generation employs a step
of generating the private and the public
keys that are going to be used for
encrypting and decrypting the data the
second part is the encryption and
decryption functions these are the
ciphers and steps that need to be run
when scrambling the data or recovering
the data from the cipher text you will
Now understand each of these steps in
our next
subtopic keeping the previous two
concepts in mind let us go ahead and see
how the entire process works starting
from creating the keeper to encrypting
and decrypting the
information you need to generate the
public and private Keys before running
the functions to generate Cipher text
and plain text they use certain
variables and parameters all of which
are explained the we first use two large
prime numbers which can be denoted by P
and Q we can compute the value of n as n
equal to P into q and compute the value
of Zed as P - 1 into Q - 1 a number e is
chosen at random satisfying the
following conditions and a number D is
also selected at random following the
formula Ed mod Z equal to 1 and it can
be calculated with the formula given
below the public ke is then packaged as
a bundle with n and E and the private
key is packaged as a bundle using n and
D this sums of the key generation
process for the encryption and
decryption function we use the formula C
and M the cipher Tex can be calculated
as c = m ^ e mod n and the pl text can
be calculated from the cipher text as C
power D mod n when it comes to a data
encryption example let's take p and Q as
7 and 13
the value of n can be calculated as
91 if we select the value of e to be
five it satisfy all the criteria that we
needed to the value of D can be
calculated using the following function
which gives it as 29 the public key can
then be packaged as 91a 5 and the
private key can then be packaged as 91a
29 the plain text if it is 10 which is
denoted by m Cipher text can be
calculated to the formula C = to m the^
e mod n which gives us 82 if somebody
receives this Cipher text they can
calculate the plain text using the
formula c the^ d mod n which gives us
the value of 10 as selected as our PL
text we can now look at the factors that
make the RSA algorithm Stand Out versus
its competitors in the advantageous
topics of this
lesson RSA encryption depends on using
the receiver's public key so that you
don't have to share any Secret key to
receive the messages from others this
was the most glaring flaw faced by
symmetric algorithms which were
eventually fixed by asymmetric
cryptography
structure since the key pairs are
related to each other a receiver cannot
intercept the message since the didn't
not have the correct private keys to
decrypt the information if a public key
can decrypt the information the sender
cannot refuse signing it with this
private key without admitting the
private key is not in fact private
anymore the encryption process is faster
than that of the DSA algorithm even if
the key generation is slower in RSA many
systems across the world tend to reuse
the same keys so that they can spend
less time in key generation and more
time on actual Cipher text
management data will be tamperproof in
transit since meddling with the data
will alter the usage of the keys the
private key won't be able to decp the
information hence alerting the receiver
of any kind of manipulation in between
the receiver must be aware of any third
party who possesses the private key
since they can alter the data mid
Transit the cases of which are rather
low imagine creating an account on a new
website you provide your email address
and set a password that you are
confident and you would not forget what
about the website owner how securely are
they going to store your
password for website administrators they
have three Alternatives they can either
store the passwords in a plain text
format they can encrypt the passwords
using an encryption and decryption key
or they can store the passwords in a
hash value let's have a look at each of
these when a password is stored in
cleant text format it is considered to
be the most unsafe option since anyone
in the company can read your passwords a
single hack and a data server breach
will expose all the accounts credentials
without needing any extra
effort to counter this owners can
encrypt the passwords and keep them in
the servers as a the second alternative
but that would mean they also have to
store the decryption key somewhere on
their servers in the event of a data
breach or the server hack both the
decryption key and encrypted passwords
will be leaked thus making it a single
point of
failure what if there was an option to
store the passwords after scrambling
them completely but with no way to
decrypt them this is where hashing comes
to play since only the hashed values are
stored in the server no encryption is
needed with no plain text passwords to
protect your credentials are safe from
the website administrators considering
all the pros hashed passwords are the
industry standard when it comes to
storing credentials
nowadays before getting too deep into
the topic let's get a brief overview of
how hashing
Works hashing is the process of
scrambling a piece of information or
data beyond recognition we can achieve
this by using hash functions which are
essentially algorithms that perform
mathematical operations on the main
plane text the value generated after
passing the plain text information
through the hash function is called the
hash value digest or in general just the
hash of the original data while this may
sound similar to encryption the major
difference is hashes are meant to be
irreversible no decryption key can
convert a digest back to its original
value however a few hashing algorithms
have been broken due to the increase in
computational complex
of today's new generation computers and
processors there are new algorithms that
stand the test of time and are still in
use among multiple areas for password
storage identity verification
Etc like we discussed earlier websites
use hashing to store the users passwords
so how do they make use of these hash
passwords when a user signs up to create
a new account the password is then run
through the hash function and the
resulting hash value is stored on the
servers so the next time a user comes to
log to the account the password he
enters is passed to the same hash
function and compared to the hash stored
on the main server if the newly
calculated hash is the same as the one
stored on the website server the
password must have been correct because
according to Hash functions terminology
same inputs will always provide the same
outputs if the hashes do not match then
the password entered during login is not
the same as the password entered during
the signup hence the login will be
denied this way no plain text passwords
get stored preventing both the owner
from snooping on user data and
protecting users privacy in the
unfortunate event of a data breach or a
hack apart from password storage hashing
can also be used to perform Integrity
checks when a file is uploaded on the
internet the file's hash value is
generated and it is uploaded along with
the original information when a new user
downloads the file he can calculate the
digest of the downloaded file using the
same hash function when the hash values
are compared if they match then file
Integrity has been maintained and there
has been no data
corruption since so much important
information is being passed on the hash
function we need to understand how they
work a hash function is a set of
mathematical calculations operated on
two blocks of data the main input is
broken down into two blocks of similar
size the block size is dependent on the
algorithm that is being
used hash functions are designed to be
one way they shouldn't be reversible at
least by Design some algorithms like the
previously mentioned md5 have been
compromised but most secure algorithms
are being used today like the sh MF
algorithms the digest size is also
dependent on the respective algorithm
being used md5 has a digest of 128 bits
while sh 256 has a digest of of 256 bits
this digest must always be the same for
the same input irrespective of how many
times the calculations are carried out
this is a very crucial feature since
comparing the hash value is the only way
to check if the data is untouched as the
functions are not
reversible there are certain
requirements of a hash function that
need to be met before they are accepted
while some of them are easy to guess
others are placed in order to preserve
Security in the long run
the hash function must be quick enough
to encrypt large amounts of data at a
relatively fast piece but it also
shouldn't be very fast running the
algorithm on all cylinders makes the
functions easy to boot force and a
security liability there must be a
balance to allow the hash function to
handle large amounts of data and not
make it ridiculously easy to Brute Force
by running through all the possible
combinations the hash function must be
dependent on each bit of the input the
input can be text audio video or any
other file extension if a single
character is being changed it doesn't
matter how small that character may be
the entire digest must have a distinctly
different hash value this is essential
to create unique digest for every
password that is being store but what if
two different users are using the same
password since the hash function is the
same for all users both the digests will
be the same this is called a hash
Collision you may think this must be a
rare occasion where two users have
exactly the same password but that is
not the case we have techniques like
salting that can be used to reduce these
hash collisions as we will discuss later
in this
video you would be shocked to see the
most used passwords of 2020 all of these
passwords are laughably insecure and
since many people use the same passwords
repeatedly on different websites hash
collisions risk are more common than one
would
expect let's say the hash functions find
two users having the same password how
can they store both the hashers without
messing up the original data this is
where salting and peppering come to
play salting is the process of adding a
random keyword to the end of the input
before it is passed on to the hash
function this random keyword is unique
for each user on the system and it is
called the salt value or just the salt
so even if two passwords are exactly the
same the salt value will differ and so
will the digest there is a small problem
with this process though since the salt
is unique for each user they need to be
stored in the database along with the
passwords and sometimes even in plain
text to speed up the process of
continuous verification if the server is
hacked then the hashes will need to be
brute forced which takes a lot of time
but if they receive the salts as well
the entire process becomes very fast
this is something that peppering aims to
solve
peppering is the process of adding a
random string of data to the input
before passing them to the hash function
but this time the random string is not
unique for each user it is supposed to
be common for all users in the database
and the extra bit added is called the
pepper in this case the pepper isn't
stored on the servers it is mostly
hardcoded onto the website source code
since it's going to be the same for all
credentials this way even if the servers
get hacked they will not have have the
right pepper needed to crack into all
the passwords many websites use a
combination of salting and peppering to
solve the problem of hash collision and
bolster security since Brute Force takes
such a long time many hackers avoid
taking the effort the returns are mostly
not worth it and the possible
combinations of using both salting and
peppering is
humongous with the consensus aiming
towards an educated public on digital
privacy it's no surprise to see an
increasing interest in encryption
algorithms we have already covered the
major names like the dees and the AES
algorithm md5 algorithm was one of the
first hashing algorithms to take the
global stage as a successor to the md4
despite the security vulnerabilities
encountered in the future md5 Still
Remains a crucial part of data
infrastructure in a multitude of
environments the md5 hashing algorithm
is a one-way cryptographic functions
that accepts a message of any length as
input and it returns as output a fixed
length digest value to be used for
authenticating the original messages the
digest size is always 128 bits
irrespective of the input the md5 hash
function was originally designed for use
as a secure cryptographic hash algorithm
to authenticate digital signatures md5
has also been depreciated for users
other than as a non-cryptographic check
sum to verify data integrity and detect
unintentional data
corruption Ronald dest founder of RSA
data security and Institute professor at
MIT designed md5 as an improvement to a
prior message digest algorithm which was
the
md4 as already iterated before the
process is straightforward we pass up
plain text message to the md5 hash
functions which in turn perform certain
mathematical operations on the clear
text to scramble the data the 120 heat
bit digest received from this is going
to be radically different from the plane
text the goal of any message digest
function is to produce digest that
appear to be random to be considered
cryptographically secure the hash
functions should meet two requirements
first that it is impossible for an
attacker to generate a message that
matches a specific hash value and second
that it is impossible for an attacker to
create two messages that produce the
same hash value if even a slight change
in the plane text should trigger a
drastic difference in the two digest
this goes a long way in preventing hash
collisions which take place when two
different plane dechs have the same
digest to achieve this level of
intricacy there are number of steps to
be followed before we receive the digest
let us take a look at the detailed
procedure as to how the md5 hash
algorithm
works the first step is to make the
plane text compatible with the hash
function to do this we need to pad the
bits in the message when we receive the
input string we have to make sure the
size is 64 bits short of a multiple of
512 when it comes to padding the bits we
must add one first followed by zeros to
round out the extra characters this
prepares a string to have a length of
just 64 bits less than any multiple of
512 here and out we can proceed on to
the Next Step where we have to Pat the
length bits initially in the first step
we appended the message in such a way
that the total length of the bits in the
message was 64 bits short of any
multiple of 512 now we add the length
bits in such a way that the total number
of bits in the message is perfectly a
multiple of
512 that means 64 bit length to be
precise are added to the message our
final string to be hashed is now a
definite multiple of 512
The Next Step would be to initialize the
message digest buffer the entire hashing
plane text is now broken down into 512
bit blocks there are four buffers or
registers that are of 32 bits each named
a b c and
d these are the four words that are
going to store the values of each of
these
subblocks the first iteration to follow
these registers will have fixed
hexadecimal values as shown on the
screen
below once these values are
initial of these 512 blocks we can
divide each of them into 16 further
subblocks of 32 bits each for each of
these subblocks we run four rounds of
operations having the four buffer
variables a b c and d these rounds
require the other constant variables as
well which defer with each round of
operation the constant values are stored
in a Rand random array of 64 elements
since each 32-bit subblock is run four
times 16 such subblocks equal 64
constant values needed for a single
block iteration the subblocks can be
denoted by the alphabet M and the
constant values are denoted by the
alphabet
T coming to the actual round of
operation we see our four buffers which
already have pre-initialized values for
the first iteration at the very
beginning the values of buffers b c C
and D are passed on to a nonlinear
logarithmic function the formula behind
this function changes by the particular
round being worked on as we shall see
later in this video Once the output is
calculated it is added to the raw value
stored in buffer a the output of this
addition is added to the particular
32-bit subblock using which we are
running the four
operations the output of this requisite
function then needs to be added to a
constant value derived from the constant
AR k since we have 64 different elements
in the array repeat since we have 64
different elements in the array we can
use a distinct element for each
iteration of a particular block The Next
Step involves a circular shift that
increases the complexity of the hash
algorithm and is necessary to create a
unique digest for each individual input
the output generated is later added to
the value stored in the buffer B the
final output is now stored in the the
second buffer of B of the output
register individual values of c d and a
are derived from the preceding element
before the iteration started meaning the
value of b gets stored in C value of C
gets stored in D and the value of D in a
now that we have a full register ready
for this subblock the values of a b c d
are moved on as input to the next
subblock Once all 16 subblocks are
completed the final register value is
saved and the next 512-bit block begins
at the end of all these blocks we get a
final digest of the md5
algorithm regarding the nonlinear
process mentioned in the first step the
formula changes for each round it's
being run on this is done to maintain
the computational complexity of the
algorithm and to increase randomness of
the procedure the formula for each of
the four rounds uses the same parameters
that is b c and d to generate a single
output the formulas being used are shown
on the screen right
now algorithm unlike the latest hash
algorithm families a 32-bit digest is
relatively easier to compare when
verifying the digests they don't consume
a noticeable amount of disc storage and
are comparatively easier to remember and
reiterate passwords need not be stored
in plain text format making them
accessible for hackers and malicious
actors when using Digest the database
security also gets a boost since the
sizes of all the hash values will be the
same in the event of a hack or a breach
the malicious actor will only receive
the hashed values so there is no way to
regenerate the plain text which would be
the user passwords in this case since
the functions are irreversible by Design
hashing has become a compulsion when
storing user credentials on the server
nowadays a relatively low memory
footprint is necessary when it comes to
integrating multiple Services into the
same framework without a CPU overhead
the digest size is the same and the same
steps are run to get the hash value
irrespective of the size of the input
string this helps in creating a low
requirement for computational power and
is much easier to run on older Hardware
which is pretty common in server farms
around the
world we can monitor file corruption by
comparing hash values before and after
Transit once the hash is match file
Integrity checks are valid and we can
avoid data
corruption hash functions will always
give the same output for the similar
input irrespective of the iteration
parameters it also helps in ensuring
that the data hasn't been tampered with
on route to the receiver of the
message we use a Wi-Fi everyday for work
and we use the internet for
entertainment and communication the
depend dependency on technology is at an
all-time high thanks to the radical
developments and innovation in these
last two decades a big portion of this
belongs to ensuring secure channels of
communication and data
transmission the secure hash algorithm
are a family of cryptographic hash
functions that are published by the
National Institute of Standards and
Technology along with the NSA it was
passed as a federal information
processing standard also known as FPS it
has four different families of hash
functions ssj 0 is a 160 bit hash
function published in 1993 and it was
closed down later after an undisclosed
significant flaw sha1 is also a 160 bit
hash function which resembles the
earlier md5 algorithm this was designed
by the NSA to be a part of the digital
signature
algorithm S2 is a family of two similar
hash functions with different block
sizes
known as the sh 256 and the Sha 512 they
differ in the word size sh 256 uses 32
bit words while sh 512 uses 64bit words
sh3 is a hash function properly known as
kak it was chosen in 2012 after a public
competition among non NSA designers it
supports the same hash lens say H2 and
its internal structure differs
significantly from the rest of the sh
family
as we have already iterated the process
is straightforward we pass a plain text
message to the sh hash function which in
turn performs certain mathematical
operations on the clear text to scramble
the data the 160 bit digest received
from this is going to be radically
different from the plain text the goal
of any hash function is to produce
digest that appear to be random to be
considered cryptographically secure the
hash function should meet two
requirements first that it is impossible
for an attacker to generate a message
that matches a specific hash value and
second it should be impossible for an
attacker to create two messages
producing the exactly same hash value
even a slight change in the plane text
should trigger a drastic difference in
the two digest this goes a long way in
preventing hash collisions which takes
place when two different plane texts
have the same
digest the S family functions have some
characteristics that they need to follow
while generating the dig just let's go
through a few of
them the length of the clear text should
be less than 2^ 64 bits in the case of
sh 1 and
s256 this is essential to keep the plane
text compatible with the hash function
and the size needs to be in comparison
area to keep the digest as random as
possible the length of the hash digest
should be 256 bits in the sh 256
algorithm 512 bits in the Sha 512
algorithm and so on bigger digest
usually suggests significantly more
calculations at the cost of speed and
space we typically go for the longest
diges to bolster security but there must
be a definite balance between the speed
and security of a hash
function by Design all hash function of
the Sha 512 sh 256 are
irreversible you should neither get a
plain text when you have the digest
beforehand nor should the digest provide
the original value when you pass it
through the same hash function again
another case of protection is that when
the hash digest is passed into the Sha
function for a second time we should get
a completely different digest from the
first instance this is done to reduce
the chance of Brute Force
attacks to achieve this level of
intricacy there are a number of steps to
be followed before we receive the digest
let us take a look at the detailed
procedure as to how the Sha algorithm
works the first step is to make the
plain text compatible with the hash
function to do this we need to pad the
bits in the message when you receive the
input string you have to make sure the
size is 64bit short of a multiple of
512 when it comes to padding the mids
you must add one first followed by the
remaining zeros to round out the extra
characters
this prepares our string to have a
length just 64 bits less than any
multiple of
512 here on out we can proceed to The
Next Step where we have to Pat the
length bits initially in the first step
we appended the message in such a way
that the total number of bits in the
message was 64 bits short from becoming
a multiple of
512 now we add the length of bits in
such a way that the total number of bits
in the message is a perfect multiple of
512 that means 64 bits plus the length
of the original message becomes a
multiple of 512 this becomes a final
string that needs to be
hashed in the next step we have to
initialize this chaining
variables the entire plain text message
can now be broken down into blocks of
512 bits each unlike other hash
algorithms like md5 which use four
registers or buffers sha family use five
buffers of 22 bits each they are named a
b c d and e these registers go through
multiple rounds of operation where the
first iteration has fixed hmal values as
can be seen in the
screen moving on we have to process each
of the 512-bit blocks by breaking each
of them into 16 subblocks of 32 bits
each each of them goes through four
rounds of operation that use the entire
register and have the 512-bit block
along with the con constant array out of
those four rounds each round has 20
iterations so in general we have 80
rounds some
total the constant value of K is an
array of 80
elements of those 80 16 elements are
being used each round so that comes out
to 80 rounds for each of those
elements the value of T differs by the
number of rounds as can be seen in the
table
below a single formula is necessary to
calculate the output of each round and
iteration the formula can be AB CDE e
registor is equal to e plus a nonlinear
process P along with a circular shift of
a + WT + KT in this formula ABCD is the
register value of the chaining variables
as we discussed before p is The Logical
process which has a different formula
for each round S5 is a circular shift by
five bits and WT is a 32bit string
derived from the existing subblock this
can be calculated depending on the
iteration at
hand KT signifies a single element of
the 80 character element array which
changes depending on the particular
round at hand for the values of WT the
first 16 values are the same as that of
the subblocks so there is no extra
calculation needed for the next 64
elements the value of WT can be
calculated as shown another formula here
to better understand this let's take a
look at how each of this goes in a
sequential process we have our initial
register using the five words of 32 bits
each in the first step we put the values
of a b c and d to the subsequent
register as the
output next we use a nonlinear process P
that changes depending on the round and
uses the values of b c and d as
input whatever output is generated from
the the nonlinear process it is added
with the value of the E
register next the value of a is circular
shifted by 5 bits and is added with the
output generated in the previous
step the next step is adding the value
of WT and the constant element of KT the
current output is then stored in the
registor a similarly this iteration is
repeated every round and for each
subblock in the process once all the
registers are complete and all the
subblocks are joined together to form
the single Cipher text message we will
have our hash output regarding the
nonlinear process P that uses the values
of b c and d as input the formula
changes every round to maintain a
complexity of the program that can
withstand Brute Force attacks depending
on the round the values are passed
through a logical operation which is
then added with the values of WT KT and
so on now that we understand how to get
our hash dig just from the plain text
let us learn about the advantages we
obtain when using the Sha hash algorithm
instead of relying on data in a plain
text
format digital signatures follow
asymmetric encryption methodology to
verify the authenticity of a document or
a file hash algorithms like sh 256 and
the industry standard sha 512 go a long
way in ensuring the verification of
signatures passwords need not be stored
in in a plain text format which makes
them accessible to hackers and other
malicious actors when using digest the
database security also gets a boost
since the size of all hash values will
be the same in the event of a hack or a
breach the malicious actor will only
receive the hash values with no way to
regenerate the plane text in this case
the plane text would be user credentials
since the hash functions are
irreversible by design it has become a
compulsion when storing password words
on the
servers the SSL handshake is a crucial
segment of the web browsing sessions and
it's done using sha functions it
consists of your web browsers and the
web servers agreeing on encryption keys
and hashing authentication to prepare a
secure connection it relies on a
combination of symmetric and asymmetric
algorithms which ensure the
confidentiality of the data transmitted
between a web server and a web client
like the
browsers you can monitor file corruption
by comparing hash values before and
after Transit once the hash is match
file Integrity checks are valid and data
corruption is avoided hash functions
will always give the same output for the
same input irrespective of the iteration
parameters it also helps in ensuring
that the data hasn't been tampered with
on route to the receiver of the message
passwords are by far the most common
type of user authentication they are
popular because the theory makes perfect
sense to individual uals and is
reasonably simple to implement for
developers on the other hand poorly
constructed passwords can pose security
flaws a well-designed password-based
authentication process does not save the
user's actual password this would make
it far too simple for a hacker or a
malevolent Insider to access all of the
systems user accounts in this video you
will learn how to crack passwords and
simultaneously try to make your
passwords as Brute Force resistant as
possible let's take a look at the topics
to be covered today
we start by learning about what is
password cracking in
general next we take a look at the
different techniques of password
cracking that hackers use in order to
generate user credentials for
hacking moving on we take a look at the
multiple tools that hackers can use to
generate these hashes and the
passwords finally we take a look at the
steps and the guidelines that users can
follow to prevent their passwords from
being cracked
let's start by giving a basic idea about
password
cracking password cracking is the
process of identifying an unknown
password to a computer or a network
resource using a program code it can
also assist a threat actor in gaining
illegal access to resources malicious
actors can engage in various criminal
activities with the information obtained
through password tracking the procedure
might entail comparing a set of words to
guess credentials or using an algorithm
to guess the password repeatedly
password cracking can be done for
several reasons but the most malicious
reason is in order to gain unauthorized
access to a computer without the owner's
awareness this results in cyber crime
such as stealing passwords for the
purpose of accessing banking information
other non-malicious reasons for password
cracking occur when someone has
misplaced or forgotten a password
another example of Norm malicious
password cracking may take place if a
system administrator is conducting test
on password strength as a form of
security test this enables so that the
hacker cannot easily access protected
systems the best way that users can
protect their passwords from cracking is
to ensure that they choose strong
passwords typically passwords must
contain a combination of mixed case
random letters digits and
symbols strong password should never be
actual words in addition strong
passwords are at least eight characters
long in many password protected
applications users are notified of the
strength of the password they've chosen
upon entering it the user can then
modify it and strengthen the password
based on the indications of its strength
now that we understand the basics of
password cracking let's go to the basic
techniques hackers use to retrieve
passwords from General
victims asking the customer for the
password is simple approach to hacking a
fishing email directs the unwar reader
to a counterfeit login page linked with
whatever service the hacker wants to
access generally by demanding the user
fix some critical security flaw or Aid
in a database reset
that page then captures their password
which the hacker can subsequently
exploit for their own
purpose social engineering influences
the victim to get personal information
such as bank account numbers or
passwords the strategy is popular among
hackers because they realize that humans
are the gateway to vital credentials and
information through social engineering
the employee tried and true tactics to
exploit and influence age-old human
Tendencies rather than devising novel
means to breach secure and Advanced
Technologies it has been demonstrated
that many firms either lack adequate
security or are overly friendly and
trustworthy when they should not be they
allow granting access to critical
facilities based on a uniform or a so
story a hacker searches a password
dictionary for the correct password in
the case of a dictionary attack password
dictionaries cover many themes and a
mixture of topics such as politics
movies and music groups users failure to
create a strong password is why this
approach efficiently cracks passwords
till today simply said this assault
employs the same terms that many
individuals use as passwords a hacker
can compare the password hash obtained
to hashes of the password dictionaries
to find the correct plain text
password now that the passwords have
been hashed the hackers attempt to
achieve authentication by breaking the
password hash they accomplish this by
employing a rainbow table which is a set
of pre-computed hashes of portable
password
combinations hackers can use the rainbow
table to crack the hash resulting in
guessing your password as a result it
retrieves the password hash from the
system and eliminates any need to break
it furthermore it does not necessitate
the discovery of the password itself the
breach is accomplished if the hash
matches in a bro Force assault the
attacker attempts multiple password
combinations until the correct one is
identified the attacker uses software to
automate this process and run EX
exhaustive password combination in a
substantially shorter length of time
with the growth of hardware and
technology in recent years such programs
have been invigorated it won't be quick
if your password is more than a few
characters lengthy but it will
eventually reveal your password boot
Force assaults can be sped up by
throwing more processing resources at
them with so many different techniques
coming together to crack passwords none
of them are useful without the right
tools there are a prra of scripts and
Snippets of code that can retrieve
passwords from either encrypted storage
or from the hash digest let's go through
some of these
tools cane enable is a password recovery
tool for Microsoft operating systems it
allows easy recovery of various kinds of
passwords by sniffing the network
cracking encrypted passwords using
dictionary brute force and crypt
analysis attacks recording Vibe
conversations decoding scramble
passwords recovering wireless network
Keys Etc are some of the other features
of K enable
the latest version is faster and
contains a lot of new features like ARP
poison routing which enables sniffing on
Switched lens and man inth the- middle
attacks the sniffer in this version can
also analyze encrypted protocols such as
ssh1 and https while containing filters
to capture credentials from a wide range
of authentication
mechanisms it also ships routing
protocol authentication monitors and
Route
extractors dictionary and boot Force
crackers are also present along with
Comm hashing algorithms and several
specific authentications password hash
calculators and other
features John the Ripper is a password
cracking application that was first
released in 1996 for Unix based
computers it was created to evaluate
password strength Brute Force encrypted
hash passwords and break passwords using
dictionary attacks it can use dictionary
attacks rainbow tables and other attacks
depending on the target
type
Rainbow Crack is a password cracking
application that uses time memory
trade-off algorithm to crack password
hashes with rainbow tables rainbow
tables make password cracking more
easier and faster than traditional Brute
Force attacks it is like a dictionary
containing nearly every possible
password and the pre-calculated hashes
creating this kind of dictionary takes
much more time than cracking a single
hash but after that you can use the same
dictionary over and over again this
procedure might take a long time however
once the table is ready it can break
passwords far quicker than Brute Force
methods with so many tools ready to NAB
our passwords there are certain set of
rules users can follow to protect their
credentials from being compromised let's
cover some of these
guidelines longer passwords are required
making the Brute Force mechanism tougher
to implement longer passwords and pass
freees have been demonstrated to boost
security significantly however it is
still critical to a avoid lenier
passwords that have previously been
hacked or that feature often in cracking
dictionaries this password policy
encourages users to establish passwords
that do not contain personal
information as previously said most
users create passwords utilizing
personal information such as Hobbies
nicknames pet or family member names Etc
if a hacker has access to personal
information about a specific user for
example via social media the will test
password combinations based on that
knowledge password regulations should
compel users to distinguish between
security and convenience users should be
prohibited from using the same password
for all services password sharing
between users including those who work
in the same department or use the same
equipment should be avoided a single
breached password doesn't affect your
other accounts with this
policy some password regulations
necessitate the creation of a pass
phrase rather than a pass word while
pass phrases serve the same objective
the length make them more difficult to
break in addition to letters a good pass
should include numbers and symbols
passwords may be easier for users to
remember than pass phrases however the
latter is much more breach
resistant two Factor authentication or
2fa can help secure an online account or
even a smartphone tofa does this by
asking the user to provide two forms of
information a password or a personal
identific ation pin and a code texted to
the user smartphone or a fingerprint
before accessing whatever is secured
this helps discourage an authorized
entries to an account without the
original owner's permission at this
point you may wonder why you need a
strong password in the first place even
if most websites are safe there is still
a danger that someone will try to access
or exploit your information a strong
password is among the most effective
ways to protect your accounts and
personal information from hackers you
should follow certain rules and and
guidelines while creating a strong
password password managers are also
recommended to help remember the created
passwords for convenience of
usage with that being said let's take a
look at the topics we are covering
today we start by learning about the
state of password cracking in today's
world and why creating strong passwords
is an absolute must for every account
next we will look at some guidelines and
rules that help strengthen passwords and
make password cracking a daunting task
for hackers moving on we understand why
past faes have grown in popularity and
are being recommended for credential
protection over traditional passwords
and finally we take a look at how
password managers help alleviate the
problem of creating and remembering
complex passwords along with other
critical personal
information let's start by learning
about why strong passwords have become
an absolute
necessity one of the most common ways
that hackers break into computers is by
guessing passwords
simple and commonly used passwords
enable Intruders to easily gain access
and control a Computing device
conversely a password that is difficult
to guess makes it prohibitively
difficult for common hackers to break
into a machine and will force them to
look for another Target the more
difficult the password the lower the
likelihood that one's computer will fall
victim to an unwanted intrusion many
individuals opt to tie their websites to
something they can readily recall to
generally easy memorable combos however
this does not make the password unique
in fact it's the reverse passwords are
handled by 53% of individuals using
their Recollections and memory with
modern computational standards simple
passwords take seconds and a couple of
minutes at worst to be completely brute
forced according to Global surveys more
than 60% of people use the same
passwords for their personal and job
applications while this may allow the
user never to forget the password it
makes a single point of failure the only
pin to drop if if one of the accounts
gets breached all subsequent accounts
are as good as hacked to further
elaborate on how you can create strong
passwords let's go through some of the
guidelines let's go through some dos and
don'ts to understand how to create new
passwords for our accounts it is
recommended to keep the password length
at least 12 characters to ensure brute
forcing to be
difficult a combination of upper and
lowercase alphabets is an absolute
necessity when creating strong
passwords it is also recommended to use
numerics along with those alphabets to
create a complicated
password finally special characters help
in making a password much more Brute
Force resistant than any number of
alphabets or letters can make moving
over to the Don
section it's absolutely not recommended
to keep Simple dictionary terms such as
computer or or even the word password as
your credential because those are very
easy to be brute forced and are usually
present in majority of the dictionary
attack word list similarly changing a
single alphabet or a single character in
a dictionary word does not make it Brute
Force Zant considering there are already
algorithms present that can counter this
tactic using the same character multiple
times in a password also reduces the
strength and makes it easier to crack
for hackers
apart from using single characters
multiple times following patterns that
are present on this traditional English
keyboard such as e w t y or the line
below the main alphabet such as the ZX
cvbn M Etc make it easier to guess since
these are once again common combinations
that are present in word list
already finally the most important part
being not using personal information
such as birthdays addresses and other
important information in the passwords
more often than not if a hacker is
trying to break into your account there
has been some amount of research done be
via social media or any other medium if
they have already this information
present with them breaking into your
account becomes all the more
easier now that you understand how to
create strong password look at how past
freezes have become prevalent as a
replacement for plain text
passwords
a passphrase is a sentence like string
of words used for authentication that is
longer than a traditional password easy
to remember and difficult to crack
typical passwords range on an average
from 8 to 16 characters while pass
phrases can reach up to 100 characters
or more using a long fast phrase instead
of a short password to create a digital
signature is one of the many ways that
users can strengthen the security of
their data devices and accounts the
longer a passphrase is the more likely a
user is to incorporate bits of entropy
or factors that make it less predictable
to potential attackers as more websites
applications and services increase the
user security requirements a p phas is a
fast and easy way to meet these
criterias let's take a look at some of
the advantages that pass faes have over
common
passwords pass phases are simpler to
remember than just a random assortment
of symbols and characters it's easier to
comprehend a line from your favorite
song or a quotation than a short but
difficult password passwords are
reasonably easy for humans and robots to
guess or crack online thieves have also
Advanced and created Cutting Edge
hacking tools to crack even the most
complex
passwords pass phrases are nearly hard
to crack since most efficient password
cracking programs fail at approximately
10 characters as a result even the most
sophisticated cracking tool will be
unable to guess brute force or pre
compute these passwords complies with
password setting rules with ease
passphrases the usage of punctuation and
upper and lowercase password satisfy the
password complexity criteria most
operating systems and apps support pass
phrases pH phrases of up to 127
characters are permitted on all major
operating systems including Windows
Linux and Mac as a result for optimal
protection you can use lengthier pass
phrases but when creating a strong pass
password the major problem people come
across is remembering these passwords or
the pass phrases this is where you can
find a use for a password
manager when you establish accounts or
change passwords password managers
generate new strong passwords and they
keep all of them in one place protected
by a single strong master password if
you maintain your master password the
manager will retain everything else
including your username and passphrases
and fill them in for you whenever you
sign on to a website or app on your
computer or phone there is no good
memory needed for this this implies that
everyone may use the most recent
suggestions for strong passwords such as
extended phrases symbols grammar and
capitalization password managers enable
consumers to write a single master
password and automatically F each
website with their own unique set of
credentials and not just passwords
credit card information may be stored
securely with several password managers
some others make multiactor
authentication or use a second test such
as answering a question once the correct
password is input it is a simple and
effective solution to verify legitimate
login
inputs among the global players in
password managers services like bit
Warden keas and Ashlan have been running
for years now and are very worthy
recommendations if you want to get
started with password management now
that we understand what is hacking let's
take a look at some points to know
whether our system is already hacked or
not the first point regarding how to
check whether a system is hacked or not
can be cases where the system security
is Switched Off by unknown means and it
is not visible to the user this is one
of the most primary checkpoint to know
if a system is hacked or
not next point to check whether a system
is hacked or not would be frequent
antivirus software failures which are
due to the interference from hacking
attempts perform by a professional
hacker or a cyber
criminal then we also face problems
regarding system's reaction speed which
is affected due to the execution of
unknown applications in the background
of the
system which also affects the hardware
resources in the device
next we also face problems regarding
passwords which are no longer working or
are changed without a user's
Intervention which might indicate that
there was some unknown hacking activity
that took place in our
account let's take a look at some more
points regarding the
topic there are often cases when the
system's cursor move on its own and
perform tasks indicating that the system
is being used by someone else using an
illegal hacking method there are also
cases when we often see files and
folders being created in the storage
disk on the
system which is unknown to us to better
understand the points regarding how to
identify whether our system is hacked or
not let's take a look then let's start
with the first
point
if we want to check whether our system
is HED or not the first point would be
to choose the settings
option and using privacy and security
and moving on to the Windows security
this option that is available on our
system allows us to see various
protection applications that are
available on the
system if we see any problem regarding
any one of them for example apps and
browser Us control in my system it says
there's a problem with it which might be
due to hacking attempts that was done on
my
system now let's take a look at the
other option how we can check whether
our system is hacked or not that would
be checking the antivirus software that
is installed in our
system if you face problems regarding
that this might be the
issue according to my antivirus software
it says my my computer is at risk this
might be due to the interference from a
cyber criminal or a hacker while using
different illegal softwares during its
hacking
attempt then there are also
cases where we see there are unknown
programs being executed in the
background of a system which we can take
a look using the task manager software
using the task manager we can take a
look at each and every application that
is is being executed in the system and
see the
origin if we find any unknown program or
application we can assume that it might
be due to a hacking
attempt moving on if we want to check
further whether our system is hacked or
not we can check for files or folders
that are being created unknown to us for
example this unknown
folder which contains some security
details that are unknown to
me this might be also due to a hacking
attempt by a hacker or a cyber
criminal then there are also cases when
the system's cursor move on its own and
perform tasks that are not initiated by
us and performs copying of different
folders or data from one file to other
this is Du to a hacking attempt that was
done on a system and the hacker has
taken control of a
system then there are also cases
regarding login issues or password
problem for
example if I want to access into my
account and there's a problem with the
password it might be due
to the attempt of hacking into my
account by a professional
hacker
seems like there's a problem with the
username which means there was a hacking
attempt by a professional
hacker we can further check hacking
attempts by accessing our web browser
and checking whether there's some extra
add-ons or unknown add-ons that wasn't
installed by us this might also indicate
a hacking attempt on the system now that
we are clear about how to check whether
a system is hacked or not let's take a
look at some of the counter measure
against hacking let's
begin the first point regarding how to
avoid hacking is do regular manual
Security checks and keep the system
security updated using certified
antivirus softwares is a basic counter
measure against hacking
attempts and if possible visit only
secure websites for surfing on the
Internet or use VPN or other internet
security applications to mask your
systems Network to avoid any hacking
attempts for the
device then we have avoid clicking on
random web popups and ads to avoid
Hackers from getting into a system and
accessing a device
data and lastly use strong passwords or
complex passwords for your login
details applying these counter measures
we can avoid hacking to a certain extent
the concept of instant messaging crossed
into the mainstream in the 1990s
allowing friends acquaintances
colleagues and likeminded thinkers from
all over the world to connect in real
time since then instant messaging has
evolutionized how we communicate and
today over a billion people are signed
up for at least one messaging app the
present instant messaging experience is
seamless and it intuitively integrates
features like video photos voice
e-commerce and gaming with plain old
messaging among these apps WhatsApp has
comfortably found its place among the
most popular messaging platforms like
everyone associated with the internet a
matter of security is never far away
considering the huge user base of this
messaging app hackers are always on the
lookout for compromised accounts to grab
today we are going to cover some of the
ways we can protect our WhatsApp account
from falling into malicious
hands we start by learning about the
importance of security when it comes to
WhatsApp and instant messaging apps in
general next we cover some of the most
important steps that should be followed
in order to protect our WhatsApp
accounts from
hackers finally we learn what we should
do when a WhatsApp account gets
compromised let's start by learning why
we need to focus on the safety of
WhatsApp in the year of 2020 the big
news was about Amazon CEO Jeff Bezos and
his phone being haed by Saudi Arabia a
report coming from the guardian
suggested that that bezos's phone was
hacked via a video file sent on WhatsApp
the report said that bezos's mobile
phone was hacked by Saudi Arabian prince
in the year 2018 and gigabyt worth of
data was stolen from the device while
there are some issues being raised about
the report which states with the medium
to high confidence that Jeff piz's phone
was hacked it does raise a security fear
for regular users after all if the phone
of one of the world's most powerful men
can be hacked the same can happen to any
one of us as
well when it comes to regular users we
exchange messages with our loved ones
regarding a paradigm of topics the
information which may seem trivial
initially can later function as
ammunition for a campaign regarding
identity theft basic information like
preferred Banks occasional dining places
can go a long way in Social Engineering
attacks further increasing the need for
secure messaging
habits WhatsApp uses endtoend encryption
to protect all communication on its
platform these encryption keys not only
make it impossible to decrypt messages
but they also prevent third parties and
even WhatsApp from accessing messages or
calls but not entirely although end to
end encryption makes WhatsApp more
secure than other communication apps no
app is 100% safe to use like any
application or digital device WhatsApp
is often targeted by Bad actors it also
has access to your contacts and tracks
where and how long you use it putting
your privacy and personal information at
risk we all have have access to our cell
phones so it's no surprise that SMS 2aor
authentication is one of the most
widespread types of MFA available you
don't need any apps or digital keys and
it's not tied to a specific ecosystem
unfortunately it's also not a secure
multiactor authentication method the
nature of SMS itself opens up your
organization to a host of risk hackers
may have many ways to leverage SMS to
find a way into your accounts and
network be it via spoofed SIM cards or
message hijacking WhatsApp to using SMS
isn't a foolproof
solution now that we understand the
variety of reasons why WhatsApp needs
extra security let's go through some of
the ways we can achieve
this it is more than probable that one
fine day you might receive a WhatsApp
message or even an SMS that reads that
your order is delayed please check its
data here or your account is locked and
please unlock it here or even some
tempting messages like win free 3G and
movie tickets here some of them may
sound intimidating and some of them may
be lucrative but they all have one
purpose to trick you into clicking that
link and once you do that it's already
over it will install malware on your
phone and you won't have a clue about it
only when you start noticing that your
phone bills are abnormally high or your
bank account has been used without your
permission the realization will Dawn
upon you that something is wrong with
your phone but by then it may be too
late WhatsApp in itself provides various
priv privacy options to users the
messaging platform provides users with
option to choose who they want to share
their profile photo status and other
details with it's a good idea to change
the settings to contacts only this means
only phone numbers that are saved on
your smartphone will be able to see your
profile photo status phone number and
autod delete status as
well make sure you enable the option to
lck the screen every time WhatsApp is
closed this will ensure no one else but
you can open your WhatsApp account just
head to the settings menu privacy and
select the screen lock option you will
then need to register your fingerprint
after the process is completed you will
have to scan your fingerprint every time
you open the WhatsApp app this adds an
extra layer of
security the two-step verification works
as an extra layer of security and helps
WhatsApp users to protect their otps and
documents shared through WhatsApp it's
very easy to set up a PIN to activate a
two-step verification users have to
enter it periodically once it is
activated WhatsApp will sometimes keep
asking users to enter this six-digit
passcode users cannot disable this
without disabling the two-step
verification feature
altogether in case users do not provide
WhatsApp with an email ID and want to
disable two-step verification then the
number will be permitted to rify on
WhatsApp without the passcode after 7
Days however the users will lose all
pending messages upon reverifying
we often have the tendency to log into
WhatsApp web at the office and then
leave the account open on the desktop
this habit can actually create problems
for you someone else sitting on the same
PC can access all your chats without you
even realizing it it's a good practice
to log out from WhatsApp web before
leaving the office it just takes a few
seconds to log in again by just scanning
the code and you're
done all WhatsApp users should ensure
that the chats are end to endend
encrypted to verify that a chat is end
to endend encrypted open the chat tap on
the name of the contact to open the
contact info screen and then tap
encryption to view the QR code and a 60
digigit number WhatsApp end to end
encryption ensures that only you and
your contact can read the messages that
are being exchanged and nobody in
between not even
WhatsApp with the necessary guidelines
out of the way let us go to the
recommended course of action should our
WhatsApp accounts be compromised
the first and most important thing that
you need to do is report the issue to
the WhatsApp support team for assistance
make sure that you reach out to the
support team through its help desk and
Report the hacking attempt WhatsApp help
center will take the shortest time to
resolve your issue via email or within
the app itself this will help you to
take prompt legal action against the
hackers if you can't access your email
call the support team in some cases the
support will deactivate your WhatsApp
account and request you to to reactivate
within 30 days if you don't want it to
be deleted
completely when someone compromises your
WhatsApp account they can now send
messages to your contact stating that
the company sent your verification code
and gain access to the account that's
why one of the first things you'll want
to do is send a message to your friends
and family letting them know that you've
lost access to your account this action
preves further exploitation of your
account and others another reason you'll
want to let your contracts know you have
no access to your WhatsApp account is
that they may fish for personal
information from your banking number to
your email address hackers will cleverly
attempt to gain as much access to your
personal information as
possible WhatsApp web is an extension of
WhatsApp messenger over the web that
facilitates easy synchronization of our
smartphone and personal computer this is
the biggest security threat that hackers
can easily exploit to get into your
personal data over WhatsApp therefore it
is highly recommended that you use this
WhatsApp feature carefully once you
notice that your what messenger has been
hacked go to your WhatsApp web and tap
or click on the log out from all
computers option this will deactivate
all the web extensions of your
account under the unfortunate
circumstances where the account recovery
doesn't seem likely you can always ask
WhatsApp support to delete your account
permanently while far from the ideal
solution it can act as a fail safe
option if you want to protect your
personal data at any cost possible you
can always open a new account later with
the security issues mitigated and before
we begin if you're someone who is
interested in building a career in cyber
security or to become an ethical hacker
by graduating from the best universities
or a professional who elicits to switch
career with cyber security or ethical
hacker by learning from the experts and
try giving a short to Simply Lear
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from MIT schi College of
computing the course link is mentioned
in the description box below that will
navigate you to the course page where
you can find a complete overview of the
program being offered it's no secret
that the majority of our internet usage
set the risk of being hacked be it via
unsafe messaging applications or
misconfigured operating systems to
counteract this void of digital security
penetration testing has become the norm
when it comes to vulnerability
assessment K Linux is an operating
system that has become a well-known
weapon in this fight against hackers a
Linux distribution that is made
specifically for penetration testers K
Linux has layers of features that we
will be covering in today's lesson let's
take a look at the topics to be covered
in this
video we start by learning about Ki
Linux and a basic explanation of its
purpose we take a look at the history of
K Linux from the story of its origin to
its current day
exploits next we learn a few distinct
features of Kali that make it an
attractive choice for penetration
testers
worldwide finally we take a look at the
multiple ways we can install K Linux to
start a journey in the world of
penetration testing let's start by
learning about K Linux in
general Kali Linux which is formerly
known as backtrack Linux is an open-
Source Linux distribution aimed at
Advanced penetration testing and
security
auditing it contains several hundred
tools that are targeted towards various
information security tasks such as
penetration testing security research
computer forensics and reverse engine in
color Linux is a multiple platform
solution accessible and freely available
to Information Security Professionals
and
hobbyists among all the Linux
distributions K Linux takes its roots
from the Debian operating system Debian
has been a highly dependable and stable
distribution for many years providing a
similarly strong Foundation to the Kali
desktop while the operating system is
capable of practically modifying every
single part of our installation the
networking components of Kali become
disabled by default this is done to
prevent any external factors from
affecting the installation procedure
which may pose a risk in critical
environments apart from boosting
security it allows a deeper element of
control to the most enthusiastic of
users we did not get K Linux since the
first day how did it come into existence
let's take a look at some of its
history k is based on years of knowledge
and experience in building penetration
testing and operating systems during all
these project lifelines there have been
only a few different developers as the
team has always been small the first
project was called wopex which stands
for white hat nopex as can be inferred
from the name it was based on the noix
operating system as its underlying OS
poix had releases ranging from version
2.0 to
2.7 this made way for the next project
which was known as vax or the long hand
being white hat slacks the name change
was because the base OS was changed from
KNIX to slacks wax started at version 3
as a nod it carrying on from warix there
was a similar OS being produced at the
same time auditor security collection
often being shorted to just auditor
which was once again using
npix its efforts were combined with wax
to produce backtrack backtrack was based
on slackware from version one to version
three but switched to uban to later on
with version 4 to version 5 using the
experience gained from all of this K
Linux came after backtrack in 2013 khi
started off using Debian stable as the
engine under the hood before moving to
Debian testing when khi Linux became a
rolling operating
system now that we understand the
history and the purpose of K Linux let
us learn a little more about its
distinct
features the latest version of Khali
comes with most more than 600
penetration tools
pre-installed after reviewing every tool
that was included in backtrack
developers have eliminated a great
number of tools that either simply did
not work or which duplicated other tools
that provided the same or similar
functionality the Kali Linux team is
made up of a small group of individuals
who are the only ones trusted to commit
packages and interact with the
repositories all of which is done using
multiple secure protocols restricting
access of critical code bases to
external asset greatly reduces the risk
of source contamination which can cause
K Linux users worldwide a great deal of
damage as a direct victim of cyber
crime although penetration tools tend to
be written in English the developers
have ensured that Khali includes true
multilingual support allowing more users
to operate in the native language and
locate the tools they need for the job
the more comfortable a user feels with
the intricacies of the Opera system the
easier it is to maintain a stronghold
over the configuration and the device in
general since Arm based single board
systems like the Raspberry Pi are
becoming more and more prevalent and
inexpensive the development team knew
that ki's armm support would need to be
as robust as they could manage with
fully working
installations kalii Linux is available
on a wide range of arm devices and has
armm repositories integrated with the
mainline distributions so the tools for
armm are updated in conjunction with the
rest of the
distribution all this information is
necessary for users to determine if K
Linux is the correct choice for them if
it is what are the ways that they can go
forward with this installation and start
the penetration testing
Journey the first way to use scal Linux
is by launching the distribution in the
live USB mode this can be achieved by
downloading the installer image file or
the ISO file from the Kali Linux website
and flashing it to a USB driver with a
capacity of at least 8 GB some people
don't need to save their data
permanently and a live USB is the
perfect solution for such cases after
the iso image is flashed the thumb drive
can be used to boot a fully working
installation of the operating system
with the cavar that any changes made to
the OS in this mode are not written
permanently some cases allow persistent
usage in live USBS but those require
further configuration than normal
situations but what if the user wants to
store data permanently in the installed
OS the best and the most reliable way to
ensure this is the full-fledged hard
disk installation this will ensure the
complete usage of the system's Hardware
capabilities and will take into account
the updates and the configurations being
made to the OS this method is supposed
to override any pre-existing operating
system installed on the computer be it
windows or any other variant of
Linux the next alternative route for
installing K Linux would be to use
Virtual virualization software such as
VMware or virtual box the software will
be installed as a separate application
on an already existing OS and K Linux
can be run as an operating system in the
same computer as a window the hardware
requirements will be completely
customizable starting with the alloted
ram to the virtual hard disk
capacity the usage of both a host and
guest operating system like K Linux
allows users a safe environment to learn
while not putting the systems at risk if
you want to learn more about how one can
go forward with this method we have a
dedicated video where K Linux is being
installed on VMware while running on a
Windows 10 operating system you can find
the link in the description box to get
started with your very own virtual
machine the final way to install K Linux
is by using a dual boot system to put it
in simple words the K Linux OS will not
be overriding any pre-installed
operating system on a machine but will
be installed alongside it when a
computer boots soft the user will get a
choice to boot into either of these
operating systems many people prefer to
keep both the windows and K Linux
installed so the distribution of work
and recreational activities is also
allotted effectively it gives users a
safety valve should their custom Linux
installation run into any bugs that
cannot be fixed from within the
operating system now for the convenience
of explanation we're going to install K
Linux today on a virtual machine
software known as VMware VMware is is
able to run multiple operating systems
on a single host machine which in our
case is a Windows 10
system to get started with K Linux
installation we have to go to the
website to download an image
file you go to get Kali and as you can
see there are multiple platforms on
which this operating system can be
inverted as per our requirement we're
going to go with the virtual machine
section as you can see it is already
recommended by the
developers this is the download button
which will download a 64-bit ISO file we
can download 32-bit but that is more
necessary for hard metal machines or if
you're going to use it for older devices
which do not support 64-bit operating
systems yet after clicking on the
download button we can see we have a wi
archive which will have the ISO
files for now we have downloaded the ISO
file and it is already present with me
so we can start working on the VMware
side of things once the ISO file is
downloaded we open up VMware
Workstation go to file and we create a
new virtual
machine in these two options it is
highly recommended to go with the
typical setup rather than the custom one
the custom is much more advanced and
requires much more information from the
user which is beneficial for developers
and people who are well vered with
virtualization soft software but for 90%
of the cases typical setup will be
enough here we can select the third
option which will be I will install the
operating system later in some operating
systems we can use the ISO file here
directly and VMR will install it for us
but right now in the case of K Linux the
third option is always the
safest K Linux is a Linux distribution
so we can select Linux over here and the
version as you can see here it have
multiple versions such as the multiple
kernels every distribution has a a
parent distribution for example K Linux
has Debian and there are other
distributions which are based or forked
from some parent distribution kinx is
based of Debian so we can go with the
highest version of Debian which is the
Debian 10. X
64bit go on next we can write any such
name we can write K Linux so that it'll
be easier to recognize the virtual
machine among this list of virtual
machine instances the location can be
any location you decide to put by
default this should be the documents
folder but anywhere you put it will hold
up all the information of the operating
system all the files you download all
the configurations you store everything
will be stored in this particular
location that you
provide when we go next we are asked
about the dis capacity this dis capacity
will be all the storage that will be
provided to your virtual machine of K
Linux think of your Windows device if
you have a 1 TB of hard drive you have
the entirety of the hard disk to store
data on how much data you give here you
can only store up to that amount of data
not to mention some amount of capacity
will be taken up by the operating system
itself to store its programs and
applications for now we can give around
let's say 15 GB of information or if it
recommend recommended size for D is 20
you can just go ahead at 20 it depends
all on the user case if you're going to
use it extensively you can even go as
high as 50 or 60 GB if you have plans to
download many more applications and
perform multiple different tests another
option we get over here is storing
virtual diss as a single file or storing
them into multiple
files as we already know this virtual
machine run entirely on VMware
sometimes when transferring these
virtual machine instances let's say from
a personal computer to a work computer
you're going to need to copy up the
entire folder that we had mentioned
before over
here instead all virtual machines have a
portability feature now this portability
feature is possible for all scenarios
except it is much easier if the split
the virtual dis into multiple files now
even if this makes porting virtual
machines easier from either either
system to system or software to software
let's say if you want to switch from
VMware to Virtual box or vice versa the
performance takes a small hit it's not
huge but it's recommended to go with
storing the virtual L as a single file
if you have no purposes of ever moving
the virtual machine even if you do it's
not a complete stop that it cannot be
ported it's just easier when using
multiple files but in order to get the
best performance out of the virtual
machine we can store it as a single file
over
here this is a summary of all the
changes that we made and all the
configurations that have been settled
until now now at this point of time we
have not provided the ISO file yet which
is the installation file for the K Linux
that we downloaded from this
website as of right now we have only
configured the settings of the virtual
machine so we can press on
finish and we have K Linux in the list
now now to make the changes further we
press on edit virtual machine
settings the memory is supposed to give
the ram of the virtual machine so
devices with ram of 8 GB or below that
giving high amount of ram will cause
performance issues and the host system
if the memory has some amount of free
storage left let's say on idle storage
my Windows machine takes about 2 GB so I
have 6 GB of memory to provide
although if you provide all of the 6gb
it'll be much more difficult for the
host system to run everything properly
so for this instance we can keep it as
2GB of memory for the virtual machine
instance similarly we can use the number
of processors and we can customize it
according to our liking let's say if we
want to use One processor but we want to
use two different cores we can select
them as
well hard disk is preset up as the SCSI
hard disk and it does not need to be
changed for the install installation of
this operating system at
all CD ID DVD this is where the
installation file comes you can think of
the ISO file that we downloaded as a pen
drive or a USB thumb drive which is
necessary to install an operating system
to provide this we're going to select
use ISO image file we're going to click
on
browse go and go to downloads and select
the IMO file over
here select
open and you can see it is already
loaded
up next in the network adapter it is
recommended to use natat this helps the
virtual machine to draw the internet
from the host machine settings if your
host machine is connected to the
internet then the virtual machine is
connected as well there are some other
options such as host only or custom
segments or land segments but those are
not necessary for
installation rest of them are pretty
standard which do not need any any extra
configuration and can be left as it
is press okay and now we can power on
this virtual
machine in this screen we can choose how
we want to proceed with the
installation we have a start installer
option over here so we're going to press
enter on
that
you're going to wait for the things to
load from the ISO
file um the first step in the
installation is choosing the language of
the operating system for this we can go
with English as
standard this is a location this will be
used for setting up the time and some of
the internal settings which depend
entirely on the location of the user so
for this we're going to go with
India configuring the keyboard it's
always is recommended to go with the
American English first many people make
a mistake of going with the Indian
keyboard if it is possible and it
provides a lot of issues later on so
it's always preferred to go with the
American English and if later we see
some necessity of another keyboard
dialect that is NE required we can
install it later but for now we should
always stick with American English as a
basic at this point it's going to load
the installation components from the ISO
file it is a big file of 3.6 GB so it
has a lot of components that need to be
put into the virtual machine which can
also be used to detect
Hardware once the hardware and the
network configuration is done by the ISO
file we want to write a host name for
the system this host name can be
anything which is used to recognize this
device on a local network or a land
cable let's say if we use the name
Kali domain name we can skip it for now
it's not necessary as such for the
installation this is the full name for
the
user let's say we can provide the name
as simply learn as a full
name next we're going to set up a
username this username is going to be
necessary to identify the user from its
root accounts and the subsequent below
accounts for now we can give it as
something as simply one to
three now we have to choose a password
for the user now remember since this is
the first user that is being added onto
this newly installed operating system it
needs to be a password for the
administrator we can use whichever
password we like over
here and use the same password below
and press on
continue at this point it's going to
detect on the components on which the
operating system can be
installed like here there are multiple
options like the use entire disk use
entire dis and setup lvm this entire
disc can set up encrypted lvm for
newcomers it is recommended to just use
the first one since lvm encryption is
something that you can learn afterwards
when you're much more Hands-On with the
Linux operating system for now we're
going to use the use entire disg guided
installation and press on
continue when we set up the virtual
machine on VMware we had set up a dis
capacity that we gave up prose 20gb that
is the hard disk which is being
discovered here even though it is a
virtual disk on vmy it acts as a normal
hard disk on which an operating system
can be installed so we select this one
and press on
continue here there is a multiple
partition system system all the
operating systems that are installed
have different components one is used
for the a keeping of the applications
one for the files other for the RAM
management and other things for
newcomers it is always recommended to
keep it in one
partition and we're going to select that
and press on
continue this is just an overview of the
partition it's going to make as you can
see it has a primary partition of 20.4
GB and a logical partition of 1 GB used
for swap memory now these kind of naming
can be confusing for people who are not
well versed with Linux operating systems
or in general virtualization but for now
you can go ahead and press on continue
as this will be fine we can press on
finish partitioning and write changes to
disk and
continue it's just a confirmation page
as you can see it's WR that SCSI 3 is
our virtual hard disk of 20gp dis
capacity write the changes to the disk
you we press yes and click on
continue at this point the installation
has started now this installation will
take a while depending on the amount of
ram provided the processors provided and
how quickly the performance of the
system is being hampered by the host
machine on quicker systems this will be
rather quick while on the smaller ones
this will take a
while since this is going to take some
time to install as it is being run on a
virtual machine with only 2 GB of RAM
we're going to speed up this part of the
video so we don't have to waste any more
time just watching the progress
bar now that our core installation is
completed it's asking us to configure a
package manager the work of a package
manager on Linux operating system is
similar to the Google Play Store on
Android mobile devices and on the app
store for the Apple
devices it's an interface to install
external applications which are not
installed by default let's say for
Google Chrome or any other browser which
can be used to browse the
internet at this point of time it's ask
us to select a network mirror we're
going to select as yes and move forward
with this next it's going to ask us for
an http proxy which we can leave it as
blank and press it as continue
forward at this point of time it's
looking for updates to the Kali Linux
installation this will fetch the new
builds from the Kali server so the
installation is always updated to the
latest
version now that the package manager is
configured we have the grub bootloader
the grub is used for selecting the
operating system while booting up its
core functionality is to to allow the
operating system to be loaded correctly
without any faults so at this point of
time if it ask install the grab boot
loader to your primary dive we can
select this as yes and press
continue remember the installation was
conducted on dev
SDA so we're going to select
installation of the gr loader on the
same hard disk that we have
configured we press this one and press
continue so now the graub boot loader is
being installed
the grub is highly essential because it
it shows the motherboard where to start
the operating system from even if the
operating system is installed correctly
and all the files are in correct order
the absence of a boot loader will not be
able to launch the OS
properly as you can see the installation
is finally complete so now we can press
on
continue and it's going to finalize the
changes
now you can see K Linux being booted up
straight away it doesn't check for the
ISO file anymore since the operating
system is now installed onto the virtual
hard disk storage that we had configured
before here we're going to enter our
username and password that we had set up
before
and we have the coloro system booted
up and this is your homepage we can see
the installed applications over here
which are being used for penetration
testing by multiple security analysts
worldwide all of these come
pre-installed with K Linux and others
can be installed using the AP package
manager that we had
configured we can see a full name over
here and with this our installation of
the K Linux is complete hey everyone
it's no secret that the majority of our
internet usage is at the risk of getting
hacked be it via unsafe messaging
applications or misconfigured operating
systems to counteract this void of
digital security penetration testing has
become the norm when it comes to
vulnerability assessment par security OS
is an operating system that has become a
well-known weapon in this fight against
hackers a Linux distribution more cater
towards penetration ters specifically
parent security has layers of features
that we will be covering in today's
lesson let's take a look at the topics
for this
video we start by learning about what
par security is and why it should be
considered as a viable alternative next
to K Linux of penetration
testers next we take a look at the
minimum system requirements necessary to
obtain Optimum performance from an
installation of parro security moving on
we learn about some unique features that
make parot Stand Out Among the multiple
ethical hacking operating systems
available on the market and finally we
look at the multiple ways that par
security OS can be installed be it on a
single system or for portable
media so let's start out by learning
what what parro security
is paratos is a deban based Linux
distribution with an emphasis on
security privacy and development it is
built on debian's testing branch and
uses a custom Harden Linux kernel while
being founded in
2013 parro security contains several
hundred tools targeted towards various
information security tasks such as
penetration testing security research
computer forensics and reverse
engineering it has become a
multi-platform solution accessible and
freely available to Information Security
Professionals and
hobbies it features a distinct forens
six mode that does not Mount any of the
system hard diss or partitions and has
no influence on the host system making
it more stealthy than regular mode this
mode is used on the host system when
there is a need for executing forensic
procedures in software development a
rolling release is a paradigm in which
software upgrades are rolled out
constantly rather than in batches of
versions this ensures that the software
is constantly up to date rolling release
distribution such as parro security OS
follows the same concept providing the
most recent Linux kernel and software
versions as they become available on the
market with the basic introduction to
the operating system out of the way let
us have a look at the bare minimum
system requirements necessary to be able
to run this operating
system first up we got a CPU requirement
which states that a 1 GHz dual Coe CPU
is the absolute minimum in order to use
Barat OS while multiple core systems
will provide more Optimum performance a
small beginner has been
included a very distinct thing to be
noted is that the operating system can
be installed on all variance of chipsets
be 32-bit 64-bit and the newly popular
armm portfolio of
devices unlike K Linux which requires
some amount of graphical acceleration
needed to display the operating system
correctly paratos has no such
requirements and can be used with the
leanest of
machines taking into account the ram
issue a minimum of 256 MB to 512 MB free
Ram provides the optimum usage
scenarios even when the OS is installed
on a hard drive storage media it should
theoretically occupy around 8 GB of
information which may extend up to 16 GB
depending on the tools being installed
out of the box when it comes to booting
options we have the option of going with
the Legacy BIOS settings or with the
more modern ufi
settings these are just some of the
requirements for the installation of
parro security OS to understand this
process more vividly and to learn how
visualization can help install an OS in
an existing computer please follow the
link to a parate security installation
video linked right
above let's understand what some of the
things that make parot security unique
among all the other penetration testing
operating system
systems along with all the giant catalog
of scripts par security has its own
custom hardened Linux kernel which has
been modified explicitly to provide as
much security and resistance to hackers
as possible as a first line of defense
the configurations in the operating
system act as a second Gateway taking
care of militia requests and dropping
them off this is particularly beneficial
since should there be a scenario where
the latest Linux kernel is causing some
particular issue the patto development
team will most likely iron it out first
before passing it on as an
update if the custom hardened kernel
wasn't reasoning enough parid security
developers managed to install more
hacking tools and scripts to ensure a
smooth transition for the Gali Linux
users all the tools you found in Kali
are present in parto and then a few
extra ones for good measure this has
been achieved while keeping roughly the
same size of the installation file
between both operating systems
however it's not all productivity points
for parro OS they provide a choice
between two different desktop
environments the M desktop which comes
pre-installed by default and KDE for
those unfamiliar with Linux terminology
you can think of desktop environments as
the main UI for a Linux system being
highly modular in nature one can use K
Linux or paratos while adding another
text of environment which they find
appealing while Kali has only a single
option par has managed to provide two
optimized Wheels with made desktop and
KD desktop ready made on the
website one of the primary advantages of
parat os over Kali is that it's
relatively lightweight this implies that
it takes frequently less dis space and
computing power to function properly
with as little as 320 MB of ram required
in reality parat OS is also designed to
operate successfully off a USB stick but
Kali leux does not work well from a USB
stick and is generally in installed in a
virtual machine parat can be seen as
more of a niche distribution if you're
searching for something lighter than G
Linux there are multiple ways to go
about with this
installation many people prefer to
install it directly onto a hard disk
where the parent security OS will
override whichever data the hard disk
already has now this is beneficial if
you want to preserve your data for the
long term but this might pose some
trouble to people who do not have a
spare hard disk or do not want to lose
their current installation of Windows
operating system another way to use par
security is by using the live boot but
whatever changes you make to the live
boot operating system those changes are
removed the moment we restart or shut
down the
system a very good Common Ground between
both these installations is
virtualization using virtualization
software like VMware or virtual box we
can install parad security on our
systems while simultaneously saving our
data and having the convenience of a
host machine such as a Windows oper
opting system in case things go
wrong to start the installation we first
need to get a ISO file for the par
security operating system this can be
found on the current
website parats sec.org
once we enter the website move into the
download
section and select the get security
addition over
here par security OS has multiple
desktop environments to you to choose
from these desktop environments serves
as a different user interface for the
user for example right now we have the
made desktop and the KDE desktop as you
can see from the screenshots both of
these look quite different while having
a similar look and feel to
them for our example let's go with a M
desktop we have two options either we
can go with the direct download or we
can get the torrent file for this
example if you press on the download
button
and our download will start I have
already downloaded this file but the ISO
file provided over here will serve as an
installation it will have around 4 and2
GB of space it will be used to install
this operating system in
VMware once the file is downloaded we
can close this and open VMware
Workstation VMware can also be used as a
player version or the Workstation
version if you have much more
familiarity with using virtual box of
virtualization an application we can use
that as
well once the VMware is open we click on
file and select a new virtual
machine for the first time installation
we're going to go with the typical and
recommended installation procedure
instead of an advanced one if you have
already installed multiple virtual
machine oses going with the advanced
option will give you much more control
over the hardware customization but for
now we're going to stick with the
typical option
moving on it'll ask us for a source to
where to install the operating system
from since we're going to use a live ISO
first we're going to select the third
option which will be I will install the
operating system later and press
next as we already know parent security
is a deban derivative so When selecting
the guest operating system type we're
going to go with Linux and the selection
we're going to choose whichever the
highest version of Debian is along with
the 65 before bit
OS we're going to click on next we're
going to name our virtual machine let's
say par security
OS we're going to select the location
where we want to save the virtual
machine this will have all the hard disk
of the operating system
installation we're going to click on
next for the disk size we're going to
specify how much of the current memory
are we going to allocate this is the
hard disk memory of the operating system
installation whatever changes you make
in the operating system whatever
applications we install on the virtual
instance will all be stored in this
amount of memory while it is recommended
to go with at least 15 GB of storage we
can go as high as possible and we going
to select the recommended 20gb as
written when given the choice of storing
the virtual dis as a single or multiple
files many people want to keep their
virtual instance in a way so that it
helps them stay portable people change
systems and sometimes they want to swap
their instances between the work and
their personal computer if there is no
portability in mind storing the virtual
disk as a single file gives the best
performance and should be the
recommended go-to when installing for
the first time we click on next here and
it's going to give us a summary of the
settings we have already settled till
now we're going to press on
finish and there we go we have our
installation
First Step
completed here on out we're going to
click on edit virtual machine
settings here we're going to have a look
at some of the requirements that the
parro security OS will need it is known
to be a memory lightweight operating
system but just to have the most Optimum
performance we're going to provide
around 2 GB of RAM from our host system
which is a Windows 10
machine when it comes to the processors
I'm going to increase it to two and the
number of goes to two as well so giving
out a total four processor CES to the
operating system now this depends on
what are your computer R and how much
resources you can justify so these need
to be customized according to the system
at
hand hardest size has already been set
at 20gb and the rest of them are pretty
standard and we can go on one thing that
we need to make sure is selecting the CD
DVD IDE here we have to use a ISO image
file over here previously it should be
used pH physical drive and at Auto
detect we're going to use a use ISO
image file over here we're going to
click on
browse we're going to go to where we
have downloaded the ISO file which is
over here and select
it press okay
here and we can now power on this
virtual
machine at this point of time there are
two options we can go with the try
install option using the graphical user
interface or we can go using the
terminal mode to get a better user
experience we're going to go with the
try install mode specifically press
enter and it's going to start the live
boot ISO meanwhile vmw has an prompt
over here where it will try to install
some VMware tools on it while this is
not mandatory it is much more
recommended to install these tools so
that you can get some additional
features like drag and drop with the
host system and many more things for now
we're going to close this
prompt as you can see this is the live
boot ISO of the parat secur it operating
system currently it's running the mat
desktop as we have downloaded in the
website live boot ISO is necessary to
get a good feel of the operating system
there are many good Linux dros that have
this live boot option so that you can
give a try of the operating system
before installing
permanently once you into the live boot
we can start up with the installation
using the shortcut as you can see
install parot I'm going to double click
it and this is a calaris installer
choose your language as American
English and press
next you can select your time zone
according to a
location C and we can go
next at this point of time you have to
choose the correct keyboard now what
many people go get confused is choosing
their own language keyboard but people
must keep in mind is what keyboard the
laptop
provides most of the systems that come
pre-built provide the English US
keyboard so whatever keyboard you choose
make sure to type here and test that all
the buttons including the superscript
and the subscript buttons are working
correctly before moving forward with
this
step once you settled on the keyboard
that you need to install can go
ahead here it will ask you to select
storage device and the only option
you're going to get is the amount of
hard disk storage you have given in the
virtual machine settings we have already
provided 20gb of storage we're going to
choose that and we're going to erase
this
disk manual partitioning can be useful
when you're going to install parad
security on an operating system or on a
hard disk where it is already including
a Windows OS for now we're going to
select erase disk and press next we're
going to give our full name Let It Be
simply
learn you can give the name of the
computer and this is the username which
we will use to log
in this is your root password that we
going to give over here the root
password of this Cal Linux will act as
the administrative access and it will be
necessary for making changes to the
system or installing an updating
software enter the password and repeat
it over
here you have the option to log in
automatically without asking for the
password but for security purposes it is
recommended to keep this
disabled click on next this is another
summary of the installation that we
going to move forward with have a look
that whatever changes we have made is
according to your requirements and once
everything is checked you can press on
install click on install
now and we're going to let it complete
the
work as you can see the installation of
par security is now completed we're
going to make sure that we have the
restart Now button over here
disabled I'm going to click on
done we go to shut down this live boot
ISO going to click on
menu turn off the
device and shut
down we're not restarting straight away
because if you remember correctly in the
virtual machine instance settings we had
given it an ISO
file please remove the live medium and
press enter to continue we can just
press enter to
continue and it's going to shut down now
to move on we're going to click on edit
virtual machine
settings going to CD DVD and we're going
to use physical drive now we're going to
remove it from the ISA image file
because the installation has already
been completed and we don't want to use
the same ISO file again and again by
using physical Drive over here it's
going to detect the 20gb hard disk that
we have already provided and
installation is done on it going to
press
okay and we're going to power on this
virtual machine for
testing make sure this you click s over
here this is the grub menu at this we
get different choices for example which
NVIDIA drivers off or with some other
Advanced options
more often than not we're going to
choose the first option and press
enter if you remember clearly we did not
get the option of try install or a
terminal run just like we did in the
live boot ISO since this is running
straight from the 20gb hard drive
storage it's going to start the OS
directly now with the login screen you
can see our username over here as we
provided in the
installation we're going to enter root
password and press
enter and this is a currently working
desktop of the par security operating
system we can open the terminal over
here and we're going to try a root
password and
installation to install any software
we're going to use the keyword Pudo
AP install and Neo
fetch we're going to use the root
password that we used to log
in going to press y for
yes this is just an additional step that
we're doing to check that the
installation is done correctly with the
correct amount of Hardware requirements
that we had
provided
now that we have installed neof fetch we
can write the command new
Fetch and this is going to give us some
information about our
installation you can see the OS name as
parro OS 4.11 is running on a VMware
host it's the kernel versions and some
of the other information like the number
of packages installed the current shell
version whereas resolution of the VMware
instance that we are running the desktop
environment which is made as we had
downloaded once and some other things
you can see the memory is supposed to be
1951 mbes which is supposed to equal
around 2 GB of RAM usage that we had
provided K Linux and parat Os are two
popular penetration testing
distributions while these operating
systems each have unique offerings the
overall Choice can differ between
Personnel thanks to the various tools
and hard
specifications today we will look at
both these distributions and settle on
the perfect choice for each type of user
let's go through the agenda for this
video we will learn about K Linux and
pilot security Os from scratch while
understanding their primary selling
points as a Linux distribution catered
towards penetration testers next we know
about some features of these operating
systems that stand out of their
package finally we directly compare K
Linux and parro security OS thereby
making a clear-cut conclusion on which
OS is perfect on a per requirement
basis so let's start by learning about K
Linux from a ground
level K Linux which is formerly known as
backtrack Linux is an open-source Linux
distribution aimed at Advanced
penetration testing and security
auditing it contains several hundred
tools targeted towards various
information security Tas
such as penetration testing security
research computer forensics and reverse
engineering K Linux is a multiplatform
solution accessible and freely available
to Information Security Professionals
and
hobbyists among all the Linux
distributions K Linux takes its roots
from the Debian operating system Debian
has been a highly dependable and a
stable distribution for many years
providing a similarly strong Foundation
to the K Linux desktop
while the operating system can
practically modify every single part of
our installation the networking
components of K Linux come disabled by
default this is done to prevent any
external factors from affecting the
installation procedure which may pose a
risk in critical environments apart from
boosting security it allows a more
profound element of security control to
the most enthusiastic of
users now let's take a look at parent
security operat
system paret security OS is a Debian
based Linux distribution with an
emphasis on security privacy and
development it is built on the demian's
testing branch and uses a custom
hardened Linux
Kernel parot Security contains several
hundred tools targeted towards tasks
such as penetration testing computer
forensics reverse engineering and
security research it is seen as a
generally lightweight distribution
solution that can work under rigorous
hardware and software
specifications it features a distinct
forensics mode that does not Mount any
of the systems hard diss or partitions
and has no influence on the host system
making it much more stealy than its
regular occurrence this mode is used on
the host system to execute forensic
procedures a rolling release is a
paradigm in which software upgrades are
rolled out constantly rather than in
batches of versions and software
development this ensures that the
software is constantly up to date a
rolling release distribution such as
parate security OS follows the same
concept it provides the most recent
Linux kernel and software versions as
soon as they become
available with the basic introduction to
the operating systems out of the way let
us take a look at the unique features of
both K Linux and parat security
OS the latest version of K Linux comes
with more than 600 penetration tools
pre-installed after reviewing every tool
included in back track developers have
eliminated a significant number of tools
that either simply did not work or
duplicated other tools that provided the
same and similar
functionality the K Linux team comprises
a small group of individuals who are the
only ones trusted to commit packages and
interact with the repositories all of
which is done using multiple secure
protocols s restricting access of
critical code bases to external assets
dramatically reduces the risk of source
contamination which can cause C Linux
users worldwide a great deal of damage
as a direct victim of cyber
crime although penetration tools tend to
be written in English the developers
have ensured that Khali includes proper
multilingual support allowing more users
to operate in the native language and
locate the tools they need for their job
the more comfortable comble a user feels
with the intricacies of the operating
system the easier it is to maintain a
stronghold over the configuration and
the device in
general since arm-based single board
systems like the Raspberry Pi are
becoming more prevalent and inexpensive
the development team knew that K's armm
support would need to be as robust as
they could manage with fully working
installations Kali Linux is available on
a wide range of armm devices and has
armm repositories integrated with with
the mainline distribution so the tools
for armm are updated in conjunction with
the rest of the
distribution let's take a look at some
of the features of parat security
operating system
now along with the giant catalog of
scripts par security OS has its own
hardened Linux kernel modified
explicitly to provide as much security
and resistance to hackers as possible in
the first line of
defense the configurations in the
operating system Act is the second
Gateway taking care of malicious
requests and dropping them off this is
particularly beneficial since should
there be a scenario where the latex
Linux kernel is causing some particular
issue the paratos development team will
most likely iron it out first before
passing it on as an
update if the custom hardal kernel
wasn't reason enough parot security
developers managed to install more
hacking tools and Scripts to ensure a
smooth transition for the Kali Linux
users all the tools you find in Kali are
present in parent to us and a few extra
ones for good measure and this has been
achieved while keeping roughly the same
operating system size between both of
them however it's not all productivity
points for pirate OS they provide a
choice between two different desktop
environments mate which comes
pre-installed by default and KDE for
those unfamiliar with the next
terminology you can think of desktop
environments as the main UI for a
distribution being highly modular in
nature one can use parad security OS
while adding another desktop environment
that they find appealing while K Linux
has only a single option par security
has provided two optimized bills with
made desktop and KD
desktop one of the primary advantages of
parro os over Kali Linux is that it's
relatively lightweight this implies that
it takes significantly less disk space
and computing power to function
correctly with as little as 320 MB of
ram required in reality paratto is
designed to operate successfully off a
USB stick but K Linux does not work well
from a USB drive and is generally
installed in a virtual machine paratos
is more of a niche distribution if
you're searching for something lighter
than
K features are great but what about
performance real world metrics let us
compare both these operating systems
directly with respect to their Hardware
specifications and usability in the end
we can decide on what distribution is
fit for each type of
user for our first point of comparison
let's take a look at the ram required
for Optimum performance of the operating
system which is highly essential when
trying to crack hashes or something of
similar nature RAM usage is a very
important facet while khux demands at
least 1 GB of RAM par security can
operate optimally with a minimum of 320
MB of
RAM for correctly displaying graphical
elements K Linux requires GPU based
acceleration while this is not the case
with parro security OS which doesn't
require any graphical acceleration
needed from the user side
once these operating systems are
installed on vmw using the live boot
isos the take up a minimum amount of
hard disk storage both of these
operating systems have a recommended
disk storage of minimum of 20 GB in K
Linux and a minimum of 15 GB in parot
security so they can install all the
tools necessary in the ISO
file when it comes to the category and
the selection of tools K Linux has
always has been the first in securing
every single tool available for hackers
in the penetration testing industry par
Security on the other hand has managed
to take it up a
notch while specializing in Wireless pen
testing parage security makes it a point
that all the tools that K Linux provides
has been included in the iso while
simultaneously adding some extra tools
that many users will have to install
from third party sources in K
Linux
being a decade old penetration testing
distribution K Linux has formed up a
very big Community with strong support
signature par Security on the other hand
is still growing and it is garnering
much more interest among veteran
penetration testers and ethical
hackers a primary drawback of K Linux is
the extensive Hardware requirement to
perform optimally it requires higher
memory than parro security it also needs
graphical acceleration while demanding
more virtual hard Storage parro security
on the other hand was initially designed
to run off a USB drive directly thereby
requiring very minimal requirements from
a hardware perspective like just 320 MB
of RAM and no graphical acceleration
needed this means parro security is much
more feasible for people who are not
able to devote massive resources to
either their virtual machine or on their
laptop hard disk
directly
with the comparison done between both of
these operating systems let's take a
look at the type of users both of these
are catered
to one can go with K Linux if they want
the extensive Community Support offered
by its users if they want to go with a
trusted development team that have been
working on this distribution since many
years if they have a powerful system
which can run K Linux optimally without
having to bottleneck performance and if
they are comfortable with a
semi-professional environment which may
or may not be very useful for new
beginners one can decide to go with
parot security if they want to go with a
very lightweight and lean distribution
that can run pretty much on all
systems it also has a lot of tools
pre-installed and some of them are not
even present on G
Linux it is much more suitable for
underpowered DS where users do not have
a lot of Hardware resources to provide
to the operating system and thereby it
is much more feasible for people with
underpowered laptops or no graphical
acceleration compared to K Linux par
securi desktop environment is also
relatively easier to use for new
beginners for people who are just
getting into ethical hacking par
security does a relatively better job of
introducing them to the operating system
and to the various toools without having
to dump them into the entire intricacies
with ethical hacking and penetration
testing becoming Main stream and
corporate environments train personnel
and relevant equipment are in high
demand the right software framework can
be the Tipping Point in a hacking
Campaign which deals with intricate
Hardware one swich tool that has become
a main stay for decades is nmap when it
comes to scanning machines for open
ports and services nmap has always been
the first choice for hackers being
lightweight and open source nmap has
strong Community backing and receives
regular
updates let's take a look at the topics
to be covered today
we start by learning about the different
phases in ethical hacking and where nmap
is most valuable to ethical hackers we
learn the basics of nmap and its purpose
during a penetration testing
campaign next we take a look at the top
level approach of nmap as a scanning
tool and how it conducts these scans on
host
machines moving
on we cover the multiple modes and types
of scans that can be performed using
nmap on unsuspecting
users we we also look at some
Alternatives that users can prefer if
nmap is not something they are
comfortable with while a live
demonstration of the powers of nmap will
help in shedding light on the topics
being taught
today let us first understand where and
why and map is
essential there are essentially five
phases in ethical hacking the
reconnaissance phase is the first phase
of the penetration test here the
security researcher collects information
about the target it can be done actively
or passively or both it helps security
firms gather information about the
target system Network components active
machines Etc this activity can be
performed by using the information
publicly available and by using
different
tools the scanning phase is more tool
oriented rather than being performed
manually the tester runs one or more
scanner tools to gather more information
about the Target by using various
scanners such as war dialers port
scanners Network mappers and
vulnerability scanners the penetration
tester collects as many vulnerabilities
which help in turn to attack a Target in
a more sophisticated
manner in the gaining access phase the
penetration tester tries to establish a
connection with the Target and exploit
the vulnerabilities found in the
previous phase the exploitation may be a
buffer overflow attack denial of service
attack session hijacking and many more
basically the penetration tester
extracts information and sensitive data
from the servers by gaining access with
different tools
in the maintaining access phase the
penetration tester tries to create a
back door for himself it helps him to
identify hidden vulnerabilities in the
system while allowing him to come back
to the system to retrieve more data
further
on in the clearing tax phase the tester
tries to remove all logs and Footprints
which might help the administrator
identify his presence this helps a
tester to think like a hacker and
perform corrective actions to mitigate
those
activities and app is most beneficial in
the early stages of ethical hacking
where a hacker must figure the possible
entry point to a system it is necessary
to know this before running the
necessary exploits thus allowing the
hackers to leverage any insecure
openings and breach the device so the
reconnaissance and the scanning phase
are the points where nmap finds the most
use let us now understand what nmap is
from a Layman's
perspective nmap which stands for
network mapper is a free and open source
util ility for network discovery and
security auditing many systems and
network administrators also find it
useful for tasks such as Network
inventory managing service upgrade
schedules and monitoring host and
service uptime the program is most
commonly used via a command line
interface and is available for many
different operating systems such as
Linux free PSD and
gento it is most beneficial in the early
stages of ethical hacking where a hacker
must figure the possible entry point to
a system before running the necessary
EXP s nmap was developed for Enterprise
scale networks and can scan through
thousands of connected devices however
in recent years nmap is being
increasingly used by smaller companies
as well nmap uses raw IP packets in
novel ways to determine what hosts are
available on the network what services
these host are offering what operating
systems they are running what type of
packet filters and firewalls are in use
and dozens of other
characteristics it was designed to
rapidly scan large networks but works
fine against single hor as well the rise
of the iot in particular now means that
networks used by these companies have
become more complex and therefore harder
to secure since every application that
connects to a network needs to do so via
a port the wrong port or server
configuration can open a can of forms
that leads to a tooro breach of the
system the recent emergence of iot
bought Nets like meai has also simulated
interest in N map not least because of
its ability to interrogate devices
connected via the UPnP protocol but also
to highlight any devices that may be
malicious now that we understand what
nmap is let us take a look at the
workflow of how an ethical hacker uses
this tool in penetration
testing at a practical level nmap is
used to provide detailed real-time
information on your networks and other
devices connected to them we have the
hacker running nmap on a system with a
victim machine running a standard
installation of the operating system be
it Windows Mac OS or
Linux the nmap interface will send
specially crafted package to generate
some reply from the victim machine the
victim machine in return will send some
information back to the nmap host with
replying some of the services and host
that are being run on the computers nmap
allows the network admins to find which
devices are running discover some open
ports and other services this in turn
help discover the vulnerabilities and
the possible entry points for hackers to
breach
into we are now aware of how and app
works on a basic level but there are
many varieties of cans that users can
run on local machines let's take a look
at some of
them the Ping sweep is a simple type of
nmap scan where it pings to all the
available IP addresses to check which
IPS respond to icmp protocol if the
users need to know only the number of IP
addresses and not many details the Ping
sweep is very useful it's fast and hence
the results to be known are fetched very
easily
the SN scan is the most useful type of
nmap scan which does work very quietly
it sends an SN packet via the TCP
protocol or the transfer control
protocol to all the intended ports if an
acknowledgement pack is received to the
system it is sure that a port is opened
there no response means that the port is
either closed or not available here the
acknowledgement pack is not sent back to
the system assuming that the connection
is not valid the scan is not shown in
most of the scan logs and hence it is
safe to use SN scan to identify the open
ports the TCP connect scan is similar to
SN scan in many aspects as it uses the
TCP layer to send packets and is passed
to all the ports here the difference is
that the full connection is done by
sending the acknowledgement back at back
the logs can easily find the TCP scan
and need more power from the machines to
do the work but it is more
accurate if all the accesses related to
the OS are available to the user it is
better to do a TCP scan than an s in
scan as all the lowlevel and high level
accesses are required for the scan the
network is also loaded more and hence
users must be careful about overloading
the system and the
networks the idle scan is really used to
check whether any malicious attacks are
planned on any particular
Network users need not control the
external host but an IP address and a
port should be given to the same all
other requirements are taken from the
scanner itself
the RPC scans or remote procedure calls
are done by hackers to make the system
vulnerable to virus attacks it is thus
necessary to know whether our systems
answer such calls and make our system
open to
malware RPC scan is done to check this
by finding the ports open with certain
commands being run by
RPC the windows scan is a simple scan
where the application scans the
acknowledgement packets received from
the polls once the SN packets are sent
if there are any abnormalities in the AK
packets received this scan reports the
same and helps in recognizing which
ports are functioning in a different
manner the bound scan is used to check
the security in the file transfer
protocol layer FTP layers mostly do not
accept any packets and once it is
rejected from the FTP layers there are
chances that it might be sent to an
internal layer so that it can access the
internal machines bounce can check this
loophole by doing exactly the same
process and identifies whether our FTP
layer is open to vulnerability or
not the FN scan is similar to SN scan
where the system that sends the packets
receives the response back and it will
be mostly be a TCP FN packet if the
system sends an RSD packet it is a false
alarm and users need not be worried
about the
same the null scan is useful for other
systems than Windows where the systems
can easily identify what kind of packets
they have received and respond back with
either TCP packets are null responses
null scans are not useful for Windows as
they may not always produce the desired
result
results when it comes to looking at
Alternatives there's a wide range of
free network monitoring utilities as
well as free opensource vulnerability
scanners available to network
administrators and security
Auditors what makes nmap stand out as a
tool it and network security managers
need to know is its flexibility and
power there are some alternatives to
nmap but most of them are focused on
providing specific Niche functionality
than the average system administrator
does need frequently M scan for instance
is much faster than nmap but provides
less detail in reality however nmap
provides all the functionality and speed
that the average user requires
especially when used along with other
similar tools like netc cap which can be
used to manage and control Network
traffic and zenmap which provides a
graphical user interface for nmap but as
an allrounder solution to network
scanning nobody can go wrong with nmap
as their tool of
choice let's now take a tour of nmap
based on all the the things we have
covered
today in this live demonstration we
start by learning of how to install nmap
on a fresh operating system that doesn't
come pre-installed with the tool we also
cover the different types of scans that
can be run on local machines along with
checking multiple inferences on ethical
hacker can gather based on the scan
output of an nmap screen finally we run
scans on vulnerable machines to get an
idea of how to proceed with the outputs
We Gather using this tool if getting
your learning started is half the B
what if you could do that for free visit
scaleup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more the
first step in our demonstration is
installing n map now it depends heavily
on what Linux distribution you're going
to use to perform ethical hacking right
now I'm using parot security operating
system if you're not aware of what parot
security is or even what call Linux is
we highly suggest that you check out the
videos of those two operating systems on
our YouTube channel so that you can get
a fair idea of what they serve now if
you are using any of these two operating
systems nmap should come pre-installed
by default to check if nmap is
pre-installed or not you can just press
on applications over here go to the pen
testing
section go to this information gathering
Tab and you should be able to see nmap
right here now let's say you do not have
nmap pre-installed maybe you're using a
Linux distribution like Ubuntu or Linux
Min or something that is based on depan
operating systems one thing you have to
make sure that nmap should be in the
distribution repository once you check
that or even if you do not know if it is
present you can just this command should
be Pudo which is to give root
permissions for installation a AP is the
package manager of all Linux
distributions that are based on Debian
that goes for Debian stable ubu Linux
Min K Linux par security and anything of
that
nature AP is the package manager which
handles the installation and removal of
applications in these specific operating
systems once you're here just write
install and end map press enter and it's
going to ask you for the root password
that you said when you install the
operating system in the first place
enter your root password and press enter
again
as you can see it's saying that nmap is
already installed the newest version
since I'm running parro security
operating system now should you be
running this operating system or even K
Linux you should receive a similar
message and the installation is already
done if you are using some other
distribution let's say even black o Arch
Linux or Manjaro anything like that the
installation steps will be slightly
different this pseudo AP install nmap
command is for distribution that are
derived from Debian and U if you want to
install in Arch Linux based
distributions you have to use their
package manager which is known as
pamac but that is for a different step
and if you want to get ethical hacking
the best way to start is by learning
either K Linux or par security now that
the installation is done we're going to
learn how to use nmap one of the most
basic functions of nmap is to identify
active hosts on the network we can do
this by using a ping scan the ping scan
identifies all of the IP addresses that
are currently online without sending any
packets to these hosts now to run the
ping scan we're going to write end map
the flag we're going to mention over
here is sp now these flags are the
different traits of the N map scan
depending on what flag we use we can
send different kinds of requests to the
host that we are scanning now before
moving forward with this let me open
another terminal over here and check the
IP
address we're going to write the command
if config and find the Subnet in which
this system is present as you can see
the IP address is
192.168
72131 now this operating system is being
run on a virtual machine software known
as VMware the VMware in itself is
running on a Windows 10 operating system
considering they are now a part of the
local network this IP address is of par
security and the Windows operating
system which is the host system in my
scenario will fall in this particular
subnet so to run our
scan we're going to Target 19
192.168
72.1
24 this command then returns Returns the
list of hosts on your network and the
total number of assigned IP
addresses this is going to be capital P
yeah if you spot any host or IP
addresses on that list that you cannot
account for you can then run further
commands to investigate them further as
of right now you can see the machine
that is the parent security this IP
address can be detected in the
subnet the
192.168 72.1 is my local Windows machine
that is running VMware software and
ultimately this virtual machine the 72.2
is the DHCP server that hosts the
internet connection of the par security
this we can ignore for now now the
Windows machine that we have over here
let's run some tests on that we going to
clear our
terminal and we can close this actually
when scanning hosts nmap commands can
use server names ipv4 addresses or IPv6
addresses a basic nmap
command will produce information about
the given host to run a basic port scan
we can just use n map along with the IP
now as we remember the IP is
192.168 72.1 this is the IP of my local
Windows 10
machine
as you can see it shows the ports that
are open and the particular servers that
these ports are
running now you can also have a
detection of the operating system now
mind you this is not 100% correct and
the reliability depends on the
installation and what kind of
fingerprinting measures are available
now since this does TCP IP
fingerprinting it needs some extra
permissions the flag that we going to
use is n map minus o along with the same
IP
address like I said since this a tcpip
fingerprinting it requires root
privileges now to provide root
privileges we're just going to add the N
map and pseudo
keyword going to repeat the same command
that we wrote
above as you can see it has successfully
detected that I am running Microsoft
Windows
10 with this Mac
address it has also shown the correct
build number of the Windows 10 system
that I am
using this is useful for troubleshooting
scanning for few vulnerabilities or even
locating some services that need to be
updated now to get the necessary
information about these services for
example what versions they are using we
have a command known as SV which stand
for service version we use the same IP
address and press
center now as you can see the scan is
complete and if you can check the
results of the scan above here we don't
see any version number for the
services here we can actually check what
version they are running now this
becomes helpful when we are trying to
find specific versions to exploit for
example if VM workstation 16. 1.2 had
some particular vulnerability we can
exploit it by checking this
command apart from the host scanning
Port scanning is one of the most basic
utilities there are few ways that this
command can be customized as well for
example I've already checked the that
the 443 command is open but I have found
out after running this lengthy scan
let's say I only want to check if
command if the port 443 is open and map
I'm going to use
the flag of minus P which stands for
port and give 443 as an argument here
using the same IP
address and you can see it says it's
open
but we already knew it is open let's say
there was something else uh if let's say
we're going to scan if the Apache web
server port is open which usually runs
on
80 obviously since I'm not running an
Apache web server it says it's
closed now we can combine these two
commands by running both ports
simultaneously to do that we can just
put a
comma and complete the rest
similarly expected 80 is closed and 443
is open another feature of end map for
Port scanning is showing of ranges now
ranges can be beneficial when you're
trying to see up to a certain limit for
example n map minus P we're going to
check what ports are open between 100 to
let's say
2,000 this act is the
range everything else is the
same and it checks all ports in the
range of 100 to
2,000 whatever ports is open in between
that range it can be mentioned over
here we're going to clear the scen now
another flag that can be used with n map
is the SS command this runs a steal scan
which is a little harder to detect if
you're the it admin of the system that
is being
scanned the results will more or less be
the same although this will need
elevated root
privileges
2.1 as you can see this is more or less
similar to a port scan just adds an
extra mac address as well for good
measure but like I said it's more about
the stealth the normal scans usually are
are easier to detect when the logs are
being checked sty scans are relatively
tougher to check on much more intricate
systems this takes longer as
well now that we're done with both
scanning let's look at a vulnerable
machine the system that is scanning
right now is this my own personal system
with everything is pretty locked down as
much as it can
be there is an attack box
running in the cloud the IP address of
which is over
here now to be able to get into this
network we need to connect to their
personal network using a VPN so what I'm
going to do is switch to a different
workspace over here I'm going to open
our
terminal and if you can see over here
there is a hack test. ovpn file I'm
going to connect to their VPN network
using this ovpn
file
and once we get the initialization
sequence completed message we know that
the connection has been
established like we discussed this is
the vulnerable device IP we're going to
copy
this and we're going to try to Ping this
let's open a new terminal we're going to
try to Ping this and check if we are
able to reach this
machine and as you can see we're getting
a reply back which means we are now part
of the local network where the
vulnerable machine is
present let's run a service scan map
with the respective
versions We ran the similar scan on my
local machine where we were able to
detect what version each service was
running what we're going to do over here
is by checking what kind of services are
open on the machine running on the cloud
we're going to decide what we are going
to do next and we're going to see if in
map alone can point us to a Direction
Where We can gain access to the
machine as you can see the scan is now
completed and we have some of the post
that are being opened over here and what
kind of service they are
running now like we discussed this is
the first stage or sometimes even the
second stage of ethical
hacking what we can infer from here is
what are the services that are being run
now these two ports 139 and 445 are
actually Windows SMB server ports which
are above the windows Samba server now
every service has a particular attached
to it that will be consistent whichever
machine you may use Apache server will
always run on Port 80 SM SMB servers
will function on these two
ports now SMB servers have had a
vulnerability known as the Eternal blue
exploit which was pretty well known as
of right now from the scan results we
are not able to detect if this machine
has the similar vulnerability or not but
since it has the assmbly server open
it's worth a shot that we try that
exploit on this
machine now to start the exploit on this
we're going to open another terminal
over
here and we're going to use Metasploit
for trying the exploit there we're going
to write pseudo msf
console msf console is the keyword for
launching the Metasploit
console enter the root password and wait
for met plit to Launch
other than the ports we can also see
that it has checked the host name of the
system and the operating system as
well now that the Met plit is
open we're going to launch the exploit
now before launching we're going to have
to check what exploits are there for the
Eternal blue
vulnerability you're going to write use
exploit blue and we're going to check
what kind of results we are getting over
here as you can
see serial number n exploit Windows SMB
ms17 010 Eternal blue it was first
disclosed in
2017 and SMB remote kernel pool
corruption let's say we're going to use
this particular exploit now all of this
may be confusing if you're not a Ware of
Metasploit but remember this is the next
stage of ethical hacking which comes
into the gaining access part we're going
to use exploit number nine as we found
above to use exploit number
nine we're going to set a p
load which is our malicious code that
will run on on the victim
machine now we're going to
check some options as you can see it has
by default pointed it to the 445 Port
since that is the port where SMB server
can be accessed
from the parameter that's missing over
here is our host the r host is the IP
address of the vulnerable machine
basically the machine in which we want
to attack now I'm going to use use the
set
command to set the IP
address now if we
check we now
have a victam IP address
set another parameter that we can change
is the lhost this is basically the IP
address of our own system where we are
going to gain access now if you have
remember we had connected using a VPN so
so we're going to be assigned a new IP
according to the VPN so if you write if
config and check this one tu10 is the
VPN adapter this is our IP address that
we have been assigned in the server in
the network where the vulnerable machine
is present so we're going to copy this
IP address we to move over this
workspace and we're going to set
lhost with that IP address
with that our options are set now we're
going to run
exploit and it's going to check if
sambar server vulnerability is
present as you can see it has written
that the target is vulnerable to this
particular exploit it's going to send
the malicious code and the malicious
code is set in the payload that you sent
above
and we now have the shell command of the
Windows
machine as you can see see Windows
system
32 to be sure that this is in fact this
Windows machine that is being used we're
going to write ip config which is a
Windows only shell
command as you can see this is the IP
address that was assigned to the victim
victim machine
now while the major part of this process
was done on
Metasploit we would not have reached the
stage had we not found out that the 139
and 445 ports are open which basically
pointed us that we can try the Eternal
blue exploit of the windows Samba
servers similarly all the scans that we
run serve as a preface to the actual
stages or the actual hacking stages of
the campaigns
this SV command was necessary because we
could check what are the exact services
that are being running in some cases if
if Apache server is being run there are
particular versions which have
particular exploits those exploits will
not work on other versions so we're
going to have to check what particular
version is being run and accordingly
apply the exploit that can be done in
the Met exploit or you can run some
other tool but what exact exploit you
have to on and which vulnerability we
have to Target that is where nmap comes
to help with the world moving towards
the next generation of computer hardware
the software side of things still has a
lot left to be discovered with the
majority of laptops coming with Windows
pre-installed many users are devoid of
the Linux operating system experience
which is more resource friendly than the
mainstream operating systems it can be
attributed to the difficulty people used
to face when installing a new operating
system like Linux in the old days
however a lot of these issues are fixed
nowadays thanks to the big names like
Debian and Ubuntu who have been
instrumental in making Linux based
operating systems as user friendly as
possible but which one of them is better
for you let's take a look at the topics
to be covered today as we answer this
question for
you we start by learning about the
operating systems from a Layman's
perspective and uncovering the basic
offerings of both
entities next we cover the unique
features of both Ubuntu and Debian and
how they stack up against each other and
other industry
counterparts moving on we take a look at
some pointers before installing each of
these operating systems and the
respective download
links finally We compare the contrasting
features of both Ubuntu and Debian and
iner the kind of users each OS skaters
to so let's start by learning about
Ubuntu and Debian in
general
Ubuntu is an open source free Linux
distribution it is an operating system
for cloud computing in accordance with
support with open stack Ubunto is
developed by the canonical community and
it is freely available also canonica
limited is responsible for the funding
of Ubuntu basically ubu is released
every 6 months free support is available
for 9 months after every release and
long-term support which are the LTS is
released every 2 years the first release
of Ubuntu was in October
2004 you must have heard about uban 2 no
matter what it is the most popular Linux
distribution overall not just limited to
servers but also the most popular choice
for Linux desktops it's easy to use
offers a good experience and comes
pre-installed with essential tools to
get a head start of course Ubuntu
managed to simplify the Linux experience
years back and that is the reason why it
is still so popular even with several
impressive Linux distributions available
right now every new release is more
polished and comes loaded with new
features and
improvements thanks to its huge user
base a number of software vendors have
made the applications compatible with2
while the catalog may not be as
extensive as Windows the options are
still well curated more importantly the
advantage of Linux based operating
systems is the ability to use free and
open-source alternatives to Major
proprietary software by lacking some
Polish and overall featur set most
alternatives are enough to get the job
done for majority of the users the
never-ending Community Support also
helps in troubleshooting should things
go wrong at any point in
time the default desktop environment in
ubo is gome or a Unity the unity is a
modern desktop environment with a
powerful Search tool for finding all
your applications and documents with its
base setup as no it integrates well with
common applications such as audio
players video players and social media
there are a few other desktop
environments for open to as well with
unity as its Flagship
environment Dean on the other hand is a
free operating system for your computer
which started in 1996 and is maintained
by global
contributors if the operating system a
set of basic programs and utilities that
make your computer run its core is the
kernel the kernel is the most
fundamental program on the computer
Debian uses the Linux kernel a
completely free piece of software which
was started by Linus stals and supported
by thousands of programmers worldwide a
large part of the basic tools that fill
out the operating system come from the
gnu project and those rules are free as
well Debian is the mother of reux
distributions beginners always wonder
why this not so good-look drro is so
popular inside the Linux developers
Community especially when there are a
lot of modern distributions that are
easy to use and have beautiful UI later
on they found out the power of Debian
after using a bunch of distributions
from other developers you'll be
surprised to know that almost all other
popular consumer level dros are based on
Debian even OBU it is so stable and
featur Rich that the developers find it
easy to build their dros based on Debian
rather than building it from
scratch Debian is run and maintained on
its GitHub repository thanks to
contributions from developers worldwide
the major decisions are taken up on the
repository issues tab leading to
CommunityWide feedback and Hol istic
approach to open source development of
the Debian operating system thanks to
this variety of personnel the source
code of Debian comprises around 70
different programming and scripting
languages Debian supports all kinds of
graphical environments ranging from full
feature desktop environments to lighter
Alternatives and IM minimalist window
managers ubo ships with unity desktop by
default where the package manager can
install the gome environment if needed
while also including cinnamon a lxd xfc
KDE and mate on the other hand Debian
gives you the choice of choosing which
desktop environment you want from the
get go by providing ISO files for each
desktop environment
individually now that we understand
where both these operating systems stand
let us take a look at some of the best
features offered by each of these
distributions open 2 is the closest
thing to a household name among desktop
Linux distributions it is a great
distribution to start with and it's even
a great distribution to keep using after
you're more experienced if you're happy
with it it is userfriendly in a lot of
ways it provides a simple desktop has an
easy installer and provides a checkbox
during the installation process that
will automatically install Flash plugins
and various codex that you will need for
multimedia support there's an additional
drivers tool that will detect closed
Source or propriety drivers that might
be necessary to get all your Hardware
working and easily install them for
You2 is produced by canonical and their
friends it is run as an open project to
enable others with diverse ideas to
benefit from all the work the developers
do to deliver the world's best open
platform still canonical is responsible
for delivering six monthly Milestone
releases and regular LTS releases for
Enterprise production use Enterprises
can count on canonical to support secure
and manage uban to infrastructure and
devices with more than 500 employees in
over 39 countries the company underpins
the critical infrastructure for
thousands of businesses and millions of
Ubunto users around the
world Unity desktop was originally
developed by canonical and introduced
earlier for Netbook computers with uban
2 10.10 then it went on to be the
default desktop environment for uban 2
eventually it has been dropped by
canonical and replaced by gnome however
it has made a comeback back after uban
to
18.04 while being completely stable the
HUD and Global menu hold up just fine
with major applications such as libary
office Thunderbird and other web
browsers that means that the unity
desktop works as it is supposed to while
making you more productive when some
desktop environments have a steep
learning curve Unity is very intuitive
for new users in spite of deviating from
the traditional start menu format that
the windows users are generally
accustomed
to
the calamaras installer is a framework
by design it is very customizable in
order to satisfy a wide variety of needs
and use cases calamaras aims to be easy
usable beautiful pragmatic and more
importantly distribution agnostic
calamaras includes an advanced
partitioning feature as well which
supports for both manual and automated
partitioning operations it is the first
installer with an automated replace
partition option which makes it easy to
reuse a partition over and over for
distribution
testing coming to Debian it is a
community distribution through and
through it's governed by a board of
elected developers it has its own
internal structure and laws and just
about everyone working on it is a
volunteer making it completely Community
Driven it is maintained and developed by
programmers and developers all around
the world this form of development
ensures continuity if one of the
developers decides to stop working on
the project another developer might come
in and take place and keep the project
going on it is completely free of
centralized control and this is also one
of the reasons for an undecided stable
release cycle Debian Sid is the
permanently unstable development version
of Debian it is where the latest
versions of programs are being
considered for inclusion in the Debian
release cycle are uploaded and tested
because it has no official installed
media and the few net boot images that
are built often don't work even people
who are willing to risk using a
development version may have trouble
installing it however it Still Remains
the best place to test new features that
have not yet made their way onto the
stable
Branch Debian has only free and open
source software in its repositories this
is mostly ample for users except for
users who use Hardware that only has
proprietary drivers these repositories
work well in most cases it is possible
to add other repos as well that have Pro
priority software if that is the
requirement Debian Standard Version is
very stable as software and libraries in
it go through rigorous testing the
stability makes Debian a perfect server
OS and it's also the same reason why
average user shy away from using Debian
as their primary OS on
desktop this is also one of the reasons
why many developers use Dean as a base
for their derivative one of which is
also
Ubuntu now that we are aware of each
distribution's unique features let's
take a look at how we can go ahead and
install these operating systems and
where we can get the downloadable
images when it comes to ubu ubu has
dropped the support for 32bit systems
currently it supports only 64-bit
devices and arm devices installation is
easy with the calaris framework coming
into ISO PR default and the latest ISO
can be downloaded from the link being
shown on the screen right now in the
case of dbn the the support for multiple
range of devices is still present that
can also include 32-bit systems and
other smaller devices which are not
modern even though it does not use the
calaris installer even downloading the
ISO file can be a bit hectic for newer
users considering this is a distribution
aimed at developers and intermediate
users finding the right link can be
difficult because of which if we have
mentioned the link on the screen below
where you can get the latest ISO
depending on which desktop environment
you choose to to go
with with the installation out of the
way let's take a direct comparison of
the features between both ubu and
Debian Debian is a community-driven
open- source Linux distribution and is
primarily aimed to be robust capable and
most importantly free on the other hand
Ubuntu is also and free in open source
like Debian but it's backed up and
developed by a canonical which is a
corporate company
Debian and uban 2 are both fundamentally
fast regarding performance as Debian
comes bare minimum and is not bundled or
prepacked with additional software and
features it makes it super fast and
lightweight at least when compared with
uban 2
directly both Ubuntu and Debian use the
same AP software packaging management
system but provide a different software
repository Debian is more like promoting
freedom of choosing free software thus
it does not include any proprietary
software by default you can always
install the paid versions but you have
to enable it manually Urn to focuses on
usability including all the software
including free paid open source closed
Source Etc Ubunto also introduced a
universal package management system
called Snap it will be used across dros
and thus prevent more drro based
software
fragmentations as the dean drro does not
contain any proprietary blobs there
might be some problems with drivers and
firmware that means dbn lacks some of
the essential proprietary firmware by
default but the users can enable the
repository and install it manually like
other paid software on the other hand
ubu does not care how much whether it's
paid free open source or clone source so
it includes as many drivers and firmware
as possible UB to also lets you install
and configure the necessary drivers and
firmware automatically during
installation or
afterward if you are a gamer then you
will probably be concerned with the
latest software drivers and Hardware
support while Debian can potentially
provide that it is likely that you might
end up breaking your installation as
mentioned before uban to supports
certain priety packages as well which
often consist of graphic drivers which
are essential to gaming Debian focuses
on the open-source aspect of the
software hence it can be a well-known
fact that with Gamers Ubunto and some
other distributions like popos have been
working much better regarding both
software and Hardware
support regarding the audience they
cater to both Ubuntu and Dean have their
pros and cons Ubuntu is a very good
distribution for amateur users with
little to know experience and if they
want to have the latest versions of
packages and applications at all times
on their
systems it is also for users who do not
want a lot of customizability in spite
of unity being very customized a desktop
environment it is also perfect for users
with newer Hardware since it comes
updated with all the latest graphical
Des devices and their respective
drivers Debian on the other hand is
cater towards a little bit of
experienced users who can fix some minor
bugs on their own or with minimal
Community Support it also is for users
who want to support an open-source
approach rather than an operating system
which is devoid of any contribution from
other end and is primarily backed by a
corporation it also doesn't favor gaming
since it does not guarantee
compatibility with all the newest
graphic cards or even Wi-Fi cards in
some
cases however due to the low memory
overhead Dean is very useful for people
who are looking to run home servers or
even corporate environments where
running servers on deban will provide
much more use data protection is of
Paramount importance in today's world
the vast amount of data flow between
corporations and consumer needs to be
secured considering that they usted with
a lot of belief a company can spend
millions of dollars on the most secure
servers but it takes a single hacker to
ruin all the good will between the
organizations to prevent these malicious
attacks many automated security systems
have been developed but none of them
have been as used as idas platforms
which are also known as intrusion
detection systems welcome to this
introductory lesson on intrusion
detection systems so let's go through
the topics that we are going to cover
today we start with a basic definition
of ideas from a Layman's perspective
then moving on we cover the multiple
types of intruders that seek to access
confidential information without any
authorization next we cover the basic
ways to detect intrusion signatures from
the perspective of a network
administrator we then take a look at the
different types of ideas systems that
can be used in corporate environments
today a small explanation of the two
types of protection is Then followed by
an introduction to some of the most
well-known IDs tools on the market so
let's get started with what is an
IDs an intrusion detection system system
is an app or device that monitors
inbound and outward Network traffic
continuously analyzing for activity
changes and patterns and alerts an
administrator when it detects unusual
behavior an administrator then reviews
alarms and take action to remove the
threat for example an IDs might inspect
the data carried by Network traffic to
see if it contains known malware or
other malicious content if it detects
this type of threat it sends an alert to
your security team so they can
investigate and and remediate once your
team receives the alert they must act
quickly to prevent an attack from taking
over the system to ensure that the idas
doesn't slow down Network performance
the solutions often use a switched Port
analyzer or a text access port to
analyze a copy of the inline data
traffic so that they do not meddle with
the actual
traffic however they do not block threat
once they enter the network as intrusion
prevention systems do regardless of
whether you set up a physical device or
an IDE program the system can recognize
attack patterns with network packets
monitor user Behavior identify abnormal
network activity or ensure user and
system activity do not go against
security
policies the main goal of an ideas is to
detect the anomalies before the hackers
complete the objective once the system
detects a threat the IT team is informed
and the information is passed on given
the requirement for understanding
context an Enterprise has to be ready to
make any ideas fit its own unique needs
expert advised what this means is that
an idas cannot be a one- siiz fits-all
configuration to operate accurately and
effectively and this requires a Savvy
ideas analyst to tailor the ideas for
the interest and needs of a given site
and knowledgeable train system analyst
ask SC the trick with ideas is that you
have to know what the attack is to be
able to identify it the ideas has always
had the patient zero problem you have to
have found someone who got sick and died
before you can identify it it can
usually go for two types of protection
active protection and passive in a
passive system the idas detects a
potential security breach logs the
information and signals an alert in a
reactive system or an active system the
idas responds to the suspicious activity
by logging off a user or by
reprogramming the firewall to block
Network traffic from the suspected
malicious
source so now that we understand what an
ideas is let us go through the different
types of intruders IDs platforms must be
aware of to understand the type of
intruders let us go through a scenario
we have the servers which are protected
by the ideas Platforms in place so let's
say a hacker tries to breach the system
from outside the organization this can
be done using multiple attacks like dos
attacks injection attacks Etc the
category of individuals that are not
authorized to use a system but still
exploit users privacy and confidential
information using different techniques a
known as
masqueraders a masquerader is an
intruder that is an outsider who does
not have direct access to the system and
aims to attack unethically by stealing
data or
information however there is another
Intruder who is theoretically harder to
detect and approv than a masquerader
these are the people within the
organization who want to weaken the
security defenses be it for corporate
Espionage or to Aid other
masqueraders the category of individuals
that are authorized to use a system but
misuse the granted access and privilege
these are individuals that take undue
advantage of the permissions and give
access to them and this category of
intruders are known as Misa misers are
people that are insiders and have direct
access to the system which they aim to
attack unethically by stealing data or
information let us now go through some
of the ways the idas platforms can
detect intrusion before it is too late
intrusion detection systems primarily
use two key methods one is signature
page intrusion
and the anomaly based intrusion
signature-based intution detection is
designed to detect possible threats by
comparing the given Network traffic and
log data to existing attack patterns
these patterns are called sequences and
could include bite sequence which is
also known as malicious instruction
sequences signature based detection
enables you to accurately detect and
identify possible L attacks anomaly
based intrusion detection is the
opposite it's designed to pinpoint
unknown attack such as new malware and
adapt to them on the Fly using machine
learning machine learning techniques
enable an intrusion detection system to
create baselines of trustworthy activity
which is known as a trust model then
compare new behaviors to verifi trust
models false Alam can occur when using
an anomaly based ideas since previously
unknown yet legitimate Network traffic
could be falsely identified as malicious
activity now if you combine both of
those you have the hybrid intrusion
detection they use signature based and
anomaly based intrusion detection to
increase the scope of your ideas this
enables you to identify as many threats
as possible a comprehensive intrusion
detection system can understand the
evasion technique cyber criminals use to
trick and ideas to thinking there isn't
an attack taking place these techniques
could include fragmentation low
bandwidth attack patent change evasion
and many
more we can now take a look at the type
of protection offered by IDs
platforms there are a couple of phase
that can be set up so let's go through
each
method the first is a network based IDs
the sensors are deployed at strategic
points within the network such as within
the DMZ or at the Network's parameter
the sensor can monitor individual
packets of inbound and outbound traffic
to and from all devices on the network
it analyzes them for malicious activity
and depending on the network
architecture and amount of traffic
involved multiple instances of network
based ideas may be necessary the second
category is host based intrusion
detection systems or
HIDs an agent runs on all servers
endpoints and devices in the network
that have access to both the internet
and the internal Network intrusions
identified by analyzing operating
specific activities like the
modification of the file system registry
or Access Control lists and the
monitoring system application logs as
well they augment network based idea
systems by detecting animalist traffic
which originate within the organization
or from the host that is being monitored
for example a host infected with malware
that is attempting to spread it to other
internal host is an issue that a network
based idas could potentially fail to
detect the third variant is a
cloud-based intrusion detection
system because of the internet facing
nature of the cloud on premises ID
Solutions are not necessarily optimized
for
monitoring for example network based
sensors need to be deployed within the
cloud at an environment's Network
perimeter and yet a cloud service
provider may or may not have a way to
facilitate this cloud-based servers use
purpose built Cloud sensors that use
cloud service provider application
programming interface or cloud service
provider apis to get as much visibility
as possible into your Cloud
environment now that we understand the
different types of IDs deployment
tactics let us go to some tools that
excel in this field offering
top-of-the-line implementations in a
corporate and consumer environment
the first tool being covered is the
solar wind security event
manager the solar wind security event
manager is designed to integrate
realtime log data from across your
infrastructure enabling it to act both
as a network based idea system and a
host based Ida system the solution can
let you discover all kinds of malicious
attacks and help you protect your
network from harm it is also designed to
enact both signature based and anamy
based intrusion detection by comparing
sequences of Network traffic against a
set of customizable
rules next we have the McAfee
lifafe macafee life safe is an intrusion
detection system designed to bring a
real-time threat awareness to your
physical and virtual networks it uses
signature based intrusion prevention and
anomaly based intrusion detection along
with emultion techniques to spot and
identify malicious activity maafe is
also buil to correlate threat activity
with application usage which can further
prevent network issues stemming from
Cyber attack
next we have bluma bluma is a security
information and event management
platform built to enact detection and
responses across your cloud and on
premises environments it is designed to
continuously monitor your it
infrastructure for suspicious activity
and misconfigurations both of which
could result in data leaks and
compliance breaches it enables you to
respond to an attack in progress and
stop malicious actors in their tracks
monitoring usage of corporate data and
and access to privilege information had
been a daunting task before the Advent
of IM am encompassing numerous apis
single signon Frameworks and data
handling policies imem has established
itself as a key component of every it
department but how does it enforce these
rules and who are the key benefactors of
these policies what about the advantages
of these Frameworks and the workflow of
these systems we are here today to
answer these questions let's take a look
at some of the topics to be covered
today
we start by learning about IM am that is
identity and access management from a
surface level so as to put a clear idea
of what it is next we cover the general
workflow and process of how I am Works
moving on we cover some of the tools
that find their place in an IM am
framework and are crucial
components finally we go through some of
the advantages of the IM am learning
what makes them a lucrative deal for
organization
so let's get started by learning about
IM am from a surface level
perspective identity and access
management or IM am is a set of
processes policies and tools for
defining and managing the roles and
access privileges of individual Network
entities to a variety of cloud and on
premise applications the users can
include customers Partners employees
devices like computers smartphones
routers Etc the core objective of IM IM
systems is one digital identity per
individual or item once the digital
identity has been established it must be
maintained modified and monitored
throughout each users or devices access
life cycle access and user are two vital
IM Concepts access refers to the actions
permitted to be done by a user like view
create or change a file users could be
employees Partners suppliers contractors
or even customers furthermore employees
can be further segmented based on their
roles IM systems are designed to perform
three key tasks identify authenticate
and authorized meaning that only the
right person should have access to
computers Hardware software apps any it
resources
etc for the entry of new users or the
changing of the roles of existing users
the list of access privileges must be up
to date all the time IM functions
usually fall under it departments or
section that handle cyber security and
data
management now that we understand the
importance of IM am in today's cyber
security sphere let us understand the
process of this framework we have
multiple components that Aid this
process let's start by going through
each of them
individually principle is an entity that
can perform actions on an awsc Source or
any Cloud management system a user a
role or an application can be a
principal it's always the principal who
raises a concern to access or modify
data on servers serving as the first
point of contact in the IM am
workflow authentication is the process
of confirming the identity of the
principal trying to access the product
the principal must provide s credentials
or required keys for authentication this
step can be further enhanced by multiple
authentication factors and Googs among
other things once the identity is
confirmed the principal has the ability
to view the data behind the wall of
security and take the necessary
steps when it comes to requests a
principal then sends a request to the
cloud management system specifying the
action and which resource should perform
it in this step the user can ask to
modify delete edit or affect other users
in this particular buket of organization
by changing the data or the
information when it comes to
authorization it carries out the rest of
an organization identity and access
management processes once the user has
been authenticated users are granted
authorizations according according to
their role at an organization the
practice is referred to as role based
access control or
rbac authorizations determine a roles
resources and level of access in the
network these items may include systems
applications file shares printers and
more for example an accounting
department employee who regularly works
with payroll software must be authorized
to do such if authentication resembles a
passport these are the things your
digital identity can access with it
while authentication is fully
straightforward authorizations and their
management are far more challenging
authorizations consist of complex set of
rules and policies and groups which are
permitted explicitly configured per user
account with the working of IM
Frameworks out of the way let's cover
some of the tools that these systems
work
on SSO is an IM tool that enables a user
to log into one an organization's
properties and automatically be logged
into a design design set of other
properties for example when you log into
Google you're automatically logged into
your Gmail and your YouTube accounts
similarly for users single sign on
reduces friction since they don't have
to keep track of different credentials
for every application for organizations
SSO helps in collecting valuable
insights about user behavior and
preferences since it attacks them as
they move from one application to
another connected by one single
login next is multifactor authentication
or
MFA implementing multiactor
authentication is crucial to protect
your organization's data from malicious
intrusions and virtually every IM
platform offers some form of
MFA however it's equally crucial to
customize MFA with the appropriate level
of security for example in businesses to
Consumer scenarios you need to consider
ux and try not to create unnecessary
friction for users who don't want to be
subjected to heightened scrutiny every
time they log in for Workforce you may
want a more stringent MFA since the
consequences of an unauthorized party
gaining access to your private Network
can be so devastating a modern IM
solution will allow you to implement MFA
only when it's needed this can be
accomplished to set up authentication or
adaptive authentication in which users
only trigger MFA if they're trying to
access sensitive data or their behavior
is flagged as
risky in the past few years identity has
become the preferred Gateway for hackers
to break into systems Brute Force
attacks credential stuffing attacks and
even highly targeted fishing campaigns
are all attempts by hackers to break in
through a company's front door which is
the login box there are multiple ways IM
systems can help detect and mitigate
these malicious attacks IM Solutions
detect attacks by monitoring signals
such as the velocity of traffic
detection of login patterns that differ
from a user's routine use of a breached
password use of devices and IP addresses
with a poor reputation among other
things these are some of the most most
widely used tools when it comes to IM
Frameworks but why do we go through
setting up so many tools and
firewalls let's go through some of the
advantages of using IM systems in both
corporate and consumer
environments IM solution helps identify
and mitigate security risks you can use
IM to identify policy violations or
remove inappropriate access privileges
without having to se through multiple
distributed systems we can also leverage
IM IM to ensure that security measures
are in place to meet Regulatory and
auditing
requirements IM provides a common
platform for Access and identity
management information you can apply the
same security policies across all the
operating systems and devices used by
the
organization the IM framework can help
you enforce policies related to user
authentication Privileges and validation
and attend to the privilege creep
problems IM simplifies signup and user
management processes for application
owners end users and system
administrators it makes it simple to
provide and manage access and promotes
user
satisfaction IM am Services can also
lower operating costs using Federated
identity Services means you no longer
need local identities for external users
this makes application Administration
easier cloud-based IM Services can
reduce the need to buy and maintain on
premise infrastructure so importance of
a cyber security certification first and
foremost when I see a certification I
look at it from three different aspects
the first is the training itself which
allows me to gain the knowledge which
allows me to understand the aspects of
security or whatever the certification
is there for the second aspect is the
exam itself how do I need to prepare
myself for the exam and how do I need to
approach the exam how do I need to
ensure that I pass in my first attempt
and the third aspect is the
certification itself which allows me to
be eligible to apply for a particular
job rule so obtaining a cyber security
certification ensures or shows uh to the
organization that you're applying to
that you do have that pre prerequisite
knowledge and you should be shortlisted
for an interview the knowledge that you
have gained during the training will
help you when you attend that interview
and when you attempt to answer the
questions asked to you so these
certifications are designed for a
specific rule uh for example a forensic
investigation certificate will teach you
how to investigate a crime scene
forensically a digital crime scene for a
matter of fact a certified ethical
hacking code will teach you about
penetration testing so it is you who's
going to decide which certification you
require and then attempt get certified
on it of course a fresher with a cyber
security certification will have better
employment opportunities because they
can showcase their knowledge with the
certification that they already have
even professionals who want to enhance
their careers can get into managerial or
Advanced uh certifications to improve on
their knowledge and get promoted in
their job profiles so cyber security
cred uh certifications can be classified
in three different aspects the first one
being the foundational level then the
managerial level and the advanced level
uh in the previous video we just had a
small overview here we are going to
discuss about what the certification
covers how the exams are conducted and
uh the price points for each and every
exam so let's start with the
foundational certifications we start off
with CCNA which is the basic
certification for networking so the CCNA
routing and switching certification
basically it helps you build your
networking career you will join an
organization as a networking engineer
where you can help the organization
establish their routing uh the pathing
of how data packets will travel across
the network this certification covers
all the basic concepts that you require
to understand networking the basic
requirements for this certification are
that the candidate must have a
bachelor's degree but apart from that
there are no other prerequisites so it's
just that you need a bachelor's degree
and then you can apply uh you can study
for this you can undergo a training and
then you can attempt the exam uh the
certification provider obviously is
cisal so the knowledge that is limited
to this training and certification is
for Cisco devices only the exam fees for
this certification is approximately
$325 the exam when it is conducted uh it
has around 50 to 60 odd questions which
need to be answered in 1990 minutes the
type of questions that you're going to
get is multiple choice questions where
you have a question and four answers and
you have to choose the correct answers
among those drag and drop where you have
to click on an object and drag it to its
appropriate Place probably a
architectural diagram and you have to
let's say pick on a router and place it
into a particular uh position if you
place it correctly you answer the answer
the question correctly otherwise it's
wrong and a simulator where you where
there could be a configuration you need
to configure it in a particular Manner
and then check whether the configuration
is correct or not the pass Mark is
around 800 to 850 out of a possible,
marks so each question will have a
different weightage depending on the
depth of the question depending on the
difficult level of the question or the
difficulty level of the question which
uh would then count towards your marks
and if you score 800 to 850 that's when
you clear the exam the job roles as we
have discussed over here would be more
more on the network administrator side
or a network engineer side depending on
the level of experience that you have
the salaries uh that are expected from
this job roles in the US are around
$55,000 to $90,000 annually the next one
is the comcha certification called
Security Plus comcha is also a global
certif ification Authority for uh
infosec courses so this certification
teaches candidates on how to secure
applications networks and devices it
focuses on Hands-On practical skills in
the field of network security I have
trained people on this certification
myself so uh I know this certification
it's quite Hands-On it deals with the
concepts to the core it helps you
understand the concepts and then in the
Practical Hands-On demo uh you need to
execute the Practical yourself so that
uh you can gain that knowledge the
recommend level for a candidate to
attempt this training would be at least
around 2 years of experience in the it
sector in addition if you have already
been certified for Network plus
certification from comia which is the
Baseline networking certification this
is also a preferred way to go for this
certification as said comcha is the
certificate provider and the exam fees
for this certification is
$339 the exam is quite simple 90
questions in 90 minutes that's 1 minute
per question it sounds like a lot of
time but believe me the questions can be
a little bit confusing can be a little
bit lengthy so you will require all
those 90 minutes to answer those
questions especially when they're tricky
and they're technical in nature the
questions would be multiple choice and
performance- based the pass Mark for
this exam is around 750 points out of a
possible 900 the job profiles for this
kind of a certification is when you want
to apply for a security analyst position
or a security engineer's position where
you're going to analyze some data to
understand and figure out what problems
are ongoing going in the organization uh
the average annual salary of this uh
person would be around
$72,000 then comes the c or the
certified ethical hacker training from
EC Council now this is a very well-known
course and also uh EC council is a
global certifying Authority very well
accepted across a lot of countries uh
this is an offensive certification so
here you're basically trying to become a
penetration tester you're taught how to
hack you're taught how to attack a
particular organization from ethical
hacker perspective so the job profiles
that you'll be looking here are of a
pentester where you go into an
organization you test their security
controls or you'll test their devices
find out flaw flaws within them and then
provide recommendations of how to plug
those flaws or mitigate those flaws and
improve the security of that
organization it is recommended that you
have 2 years of experience at least in
networking or security for these uh to
attempt this kind of trainings and
certifications again a basic
understanding of network
maybe a little bit of applications
operating systems would be necessary uh
before attempting this certification the
certification provider is EC Council and
the exam fees for this certification is
$500 so the exam here would be 125
questions which needs to be attempted in
4 hours and you will only get multiple
choice questions in here now for C there
are two exams one is the multiple choice
questions and the second is a practical
exam where uh you need to solve some
given problems to you in a IAB scenario
and if you are able to solve them
properly you then get certified for CH
practical the cut off varies from 65 to
85% depending on the questions that you
have answered and the weightage
associated with each and every question
as said the job roles would be as a
penetration tester a security engineer
and your salaries would start from
around $90,000 annually then comes the
CND or the certified Network Defender
also from EC Council now this is more on
the network defense side so here again
the job rules would be where you where
there's a network that you have and
you're going to try to secure the
network and the communications that are
going to travel over the network so you
need to be a network administrator
network security engineer or uh in a
similar profile to understand how
networks work and then you're going to
attempt to secure those networks the
certificate provider again is EC Council
and the certification is placed a little
bit below C so it becomes Network
defense then C where you're going to
become a penetration Tester the exam
fees for this certification is
$350 the exam the exam is of 100
questions to be answered in 4 hours
again it's just a multiple choice
questions so you get a question with
four options you answer the correct one
and you move on to the next question the
pass percentage again varies from 60 to
85% depending on the questions answered
and the weightage of that question job
rules to be applied Network defense
technician cndd analyst or a security
analyst from a network perspective
salaries would range from 65,000 to 75
$5,000 per anom then comes the forensic
investigator course which is exactly
what it is digital forensic investigator
this will help you understand how
computers work where data is stored and
how you can retrieve that data to
investigate a crime that has uh taken
place so the candidate must have at
least 2 years of experience in the
information security sector they need a
good understanding of how networks work
how computers work how operating systems
work how they store data the location
where that data is stored how databases
work how those databases store those
data and so on so forth this
certification is sought after mainly in
the law enforcement areas but there are
a few corporates that offer forensic
investigation as a service especially
when a corporate gets compromised and
they want to uh conduct their own
investigations the certification
provider for this is also AC Council and
the exam fees are $500 this is an
advanced level certification so uh
understanding of applications networks
and operating systems is a must before
you attend this the exam is quite
similar 150 questions in 4 hours again
it's just a multiple choice question
exam the cut off again is from 60% to
85% depending on the questions and the
weightage of each and every question job
rules it security specialist network
security pro the job roles foreign sake
investigators law enforcement agencies
security Specialists homeland security
jobs and your salaries would be around
$888,000 and above all right now let's
talk about the managerial level certific
ifications kit stands for control
objectives for information and related
Technologies it's a certification that
will give a candidate an in-depth
knowledge of the framework which kobit
is all about and the framework helps you
manage and govern Enterprise it
environments now this is Advanced
certification so around 8 years of
managerial experience is suggested
before you attempt the kobit 5
certification to understand all the
aspects and to help you implement the
framework properly the certification
certificate provider is isaka the exam
fees are around
$175 now this is a small exam 50
questions but in 40 minutes so you
really have to be on your toes you have
to know the knowledge there's a very
limited time to think and you have to be
fast in your answers the past percentage
is 50% the job roles associated with
this certification would be to uh when
you apply for uh information security
manager or as a security consultant or a
cyber security manager and your roles
and responsibilities would be to govern
and uh it space that the organization
owns so all the servers desktops the
network the data flows the data basis
everything and how it needs to be
managed and how it needs to be governed
in a secure manner annual salaries would
be around $100,000 plus then the cism
also called as sism it stands for
certified information security manager
and as the name suggests it's a security
manager certification it helps the
candidate in understanding the
relationship between business goals and
information security so now you're going
into the space where you're not only
technical in nature but you also have to
understand the business needs the goals
of the business and you have to align
the information security of your
infrastructure along with the business
needs and the business goals so it is
your inputs that are going to go to the
management to see if the infrastructure
is aligned to the business goals or if
the infrastructure or the business goals
need any fine-tuning around 5 years of
work experience is recommended in the
information security field for
attempting the cism out of the 5 years
the candidate must have a background as
an information security manager for 3
years so you have some experience as a
manager uh you have implemented those
things yourselves which will give you a
better understanding and then you
attempt the certification again
providing by isaka and the exam fees for
isaka members is
$575 for non-members it is
$760 the exam is where you have to
answer $150 questions in 4 hours uh
quite a bit of time but questions are
going to be uh scenario based questions
where they're going to give you a lot of
scenarios you have to think about it and
you have to give the most probable and
the correct answer for that particular
scenario the pass Mark is 450 out of 800
your job profiles would be either a risk
manager or a risk consultant analyzing
the business requirements to the
infrastructure security that uh that you
have and to identify if there any risks
associated with the infrastructure
highlight those risks and then put in
security controls and manage those
controls in a way where security is
mitigated your average salaries would be
around $88,000 and above then the cisa
or the cisa the certified Information
Systems auditor certification it not
only looks into security but it also
looks into auditing and controls uh in
Information Systems this is a highly
reputed certificate and you gain a
better understanding of governance
regulations and auditing your
information landscape AP again a minimum
of 5 years of work work experience in
the field of Information Systems
auditing control or security is
necessary now here the question would be
what's the difference security is where
your technical in nature you have done
let's say a vulnerability assessment or
a penetration test you have implemented
fir walls you have architected security
controls are all about the security
controls that you're going to implement
like firewalls idss ipss data loss
prevention systems uh maybe even uh UTM
and what not so experience in
architecting or implementing those
controls in an effective manner
mitigating your security or your your
vulnerabilities that you have identified
in the organization and auditing would
basically mean about looking at
compliance to ensure that everything is
in place you're compliant with let's say
uh ISO 2701 guidelines or the policies
that you have created yourself and
everything is working in order so it's
more of a checklist where you're going
to just check everything is in place and
you're conforming to standards this
certification is also provided by isaka
and the exam fees for isaka members are
$575 whereas non isaka members will have
to pay $760 for the certification 150
questions again in 4 hours multiple
choice questions scenario based so you
have to really understand the real world
scenarios of where what controls and
what audit mechanism should be in place
pass Mark is 450 out of 800 your job
rules would be mainly becoming an
auditor or a senior auditor a director
for information security information
audit manager or a Information
Technology consultant where you provide
Intelligence on how the company should
Implement their infrastructure average
salaries would be 103,000 and above then
comes the crisc also called as krisk uh
certified in risk and information
systems control certification helps the
candidate design and maintain
Information Systems controls for an
organization this this is one of the
most sought after certifications as far
as risk management is concerned in
Europe and in us if you have this kind
of certifications you automatically
qualify for a risk manager or a security
risk manager or a information security
consultant kind of a role you should
have a minimum of three years of
experience in the field of is controls
that means information security controls
you should have knowledge about
Fireballs you should know about how to
mitigate risks how to identify risks in
the first place risk analysis risk
management and after to which you're
going to implement security controls to
mitigate that risk or bring it to
acceptable levels at this point in time
you will also be responsible to create
policies revolving those risks and how
you want to calculate those risks and
treat those risks in their lifetime
certificate provider again is isaka $575
for isaka members
$760 for non isaka members for the exam
fees a similar question 150 questions to
be answered in 4 hours multiple choice
based on performances so they may give
you a scenario where you have to perform
a risk analysis and provide a report and
a solution based on your findings again
the pass Mark is 450 out of 800 the job
profiles Associated as discussed earlier
are the it risk management professionals
where they're going to identify risks
treat those risks calculate analyze
maybe do a business impact analysis to a
certain how uh the organization is going
to be affected and then you will also be
looking at compliances as far as these
job roles are concerned average annual
salary would be 119,000 and above moving
on to advanced level certification now
this is where we come across the cissp
or the cisp certification certified
information system security professional
this is the gold standard of all
certifications if you have this
certificate it's you can basically be
assured of a job in the IT world now
just to qualify you'll have to have 5
years of experience in the information
security field there are eight domains
that are spe specified by cissp and you
have to prove that you have knowledge
and you have work experience of around 5
years in at least two of those domains
if you do not have those kind of
experiences you can still attempt the
exam but you become an associate of ISC
Square which means that youve get 6
years to accomplish the 5 years of uh
experience requirement for this
certification before taking up the CIS
certification it is suggested that the
candidate clears all the intermediate
level certifications not all but some of
them in fact I've seen people do the
other way around they qualify for cisp
they give the exam once your cisp the
cisa or cesm CIS or cism exams are way
easier to crack but you need to have
that kind of experience I have seen
people with 15 years of experience and
more fail at this certification in the
first attempt the certificate provided
is IC Square the exam fees is
$699 like I said this certification is
where most sought after the gold
standard in fact there is hardly any
other certifications after after this
that you might want to do the questions
now the exam has changed if it is the
English version that you're giving it's
150 questions to be answered in 3 hours
if it is a non-english exam that you're
attempting then it is 250 questions in 6
hours it's a marathon and if you're
opting for the 6-h hour exam you need to
plan it really well it sounds really
easy but the questions are quite tough
they're scenario based and the answers
are quite confusing as well you would
get multiple choice questions you would
get drag and drw and you might get
simulators as well uh the pass Mark is
700 out of 1,000 but each question has a
different rage so uh it depends on which
questions are asked of you and which
questions you've answered correctly the
job rules associated with this
certification would be anything and
everything in information security at
the managerial level and above so
information security manager risk
manager system uh information system
security officer the ceso role the ciso
Chief Information Security Officer any
role that you might think of as a risk
from a risk compliance strategy could be
achievable after this kind of a
certification the average annual salary
is
$18,000 for this certification and if
you're someone who is interested in
building a career in cyber security that
is by graduating from the best
universities or a professional who at
assits to switch careers with cyber
security by learning from the experts
and try giving a short to Simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from the MIT schwarzman
College of Engineering and the course
link is mentioned in the description box
that will navigate you to the course
page where you can find a complete
overview of the program being offered
and before we begin if you're someone
who is interested in building a career
in cyber security or to become an
ethical hacker by graduating from the
best universities or a professional who
elicits to switch career with cyber
security or ethical hacker by learning
from the experts then try giving a short
to Simply lears postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from MIT
schi College of computing the course
link is mentioned in the description box
below that will navigate you to the
course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered in today's interconnected world
the significance of cyber security has
reached Paramount levels as technology
continues to advance at an unprecedent
pace so do the risk and threats lurking
in the digital landscape recently in
April 2023 the shields Healthcare Group
a medical service provider located in
Massachusetts experienced the most
significant data breach towards the end
of the month report ser faced revealing
that an individual involved in cyber
crime had illicitly accessed the
organization systems and successfully
obtained the personal information of
approximately 2.3 million individuals
organizations and individuals alike are
realizing the critical need for
qualified professionals who possesses
the skills to defend against cyber
attacks one such certification that has
gained widespread recognition is the
certified ethical hacker or C
certification so in this video on
step-by-step guide to crack C exam we
will be covering various topics like why
C what is C exam eligibility criteria
for C and how to prepare for C exam also
make sure to subscribe to our YouTube
channel and press the Bell icon to never
miss an update from Simply learn now
before moving forward let me ask you a
quick question so which of the following
terms describes an individual who gains
unauthorized access to computer systems
with malicious intent option A is white
hat hacker option b is black hack hacker
option C is gray hat hacker and option D
is script Kitty now you can pause this
video and answer in the comment section
below now let's start with the first
topic which is YC or certified ethical
hacker so there is a high demand for
cyber security experts in various
businesses to hire these experts
organizations have certain requirements
these profession need to have a good
understanding of security Concepts and
be familiar with the latest tools
processes and Frameworks to stay ahead
of cyber criminals and prevent data
Brides certifications like C or
certified ethical hacker offered by EC
Council play a significant role in this
scenario the C programming is designed
to train ethical hackers comprehensively
covering the latest hacking Trends and
introducing professionals to
technologies that help prevent data
breaches this certification is
recognized globally meaning your skills
and knowledge will be valued by
organizations around the world
regardless of your location the course
instructs participants on practical
strategies that can be used in real life
situations and future careers the CH
exam focuses on understanding how
malicious individuals exploit weaknesses
in addition to offering promising job
prospects the C certification training
provides a wealth of knowledge that is
not easily obtained through other
information security courses so if you
are someone who is interested in
building a career in cyber security by
graduating from the best universities
then try giving a shot at simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from MIT schatzman College
of Engineering the link is in the
description box that will navigate to
the course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered also have a look at what our
Learners has to say about the course hi
I'm Phillip I'm 61 years old and last
year I upskill with simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
after working 30 years in the it sector
and various different profiles I'm happy
to tell you that I was able to clear and
pass my cissp and CC SP certification
exams on the first attempt after taking
the course course I must say was packed
with practical examples it was led by
highly skilled certified instructors
with many companies before as a security
analyst and architect on a contract
basis but I needed some stability which
I got with the job I just started with
infosis as a cyber security consultant
happened on the first now let us
understand about this certified ethical
hacker or C exam so the C exam focuses
on theoretical understanding and does
not involve hacking actual systems it
emphasizes comprehension of hacking
Concepts tools and methodologies however
to obtain the C Master's designation you
must also pass a six hour practical exam
with 20 challenges this exams evaluates
your practical application of Knowledge
and Skills in real life scenarios but
that's a choice if you want to apply for
Masters so the CH exam is 4 hours long
the exam consists of 125 multiple choice
questions the the passing score required
for certification where is depending on
the specific exam some exams state in
passing score as a percentage While
others base it on the difficulty of
questions and the knowledge or skills
needed to demonstrate competence in the
subject the actual cut score determined
by subject matter experts depends on the
difficulty of the questions and ensures
fairness in evaluation skills if you
encounter more challenging questions
fewer correct answers are needed to pass
while an easier set of questions
requires higher percentage of correct
answers thus performance relative to the
passing standard can be higher even with
fewer correct answers in a difficult
question set so now let's have a look at
the sections so the sections covered in
the program includes section number one
that is background then there is section
number two which is analysis or
assessment then there is section number
three security then comes section number
four tools systems and programs section
five is procedures and methodology
section six is regulation and policy
section seven is ethics so this was
about the C exam now let's have a look
at its eligibility criteria so the
eligibility criteria for CH exam before
you start preparing for CH exam it's
important to meet certain requirements
firstly you must show this EC Council
that you have at least two years of
experience in information security and a
specialization in that field through
your educational background additionally
keep in mind that the CH exam has a cost
of $11
and make sure you fulfill these criteria
before moving forward to avoid wasting
your time so this was about the
eligibility criteria for CH exam now
let's understand how to prepare for CH
exam so the first step in preparing for
CH exam is joining a forum so there are
many online forums and blogs dedicated
to C where people with similar interest
and goals gather these forums are filled
with individuals who are either
preparing for CH exam or have already
taken it they share valuable tips
strategies and general advice based on
their experiences by participating in
these forums you can interact with other
C students and professionals this allows
you to exchange knowledge and discover
each other's strengths and weaknesses
it's a great way to identify areas where
you may need to improve your
understanding remember what one person
is good at another person may struggle
with through discussions on the Forum
you can learn from others and reinforce
your own knowledge through repetition
which helps with better retention the
second thing you can do is create
important topics checklist so once you
have identified the areas where you lack
knowledge as a hacker it's important to
make a checklist of study topics
prioritize the topics that need more
attention don't forget to allocate some
study time to the topics you already
know it's always beneficial to reinforce
and refresh your existing knowledge
however the main focus should be on
addressing the knowledge gaps First Once
you have addressed those gaps you can
revisit the other topics later along
with this you can also take EC council
certification assessment EC council
certification assessments refers to the
international evaluation process
conducted by the international Council
of electronic Commerce Consultants the
certification assessment typically
involves an examination that accesses
the candidates understanding of the
relevant Concepts tools and best
practices in their chosen certification
track the exam is educational and the
questions are beneficial for studying
purposes using the training platform the
candidate can access the levels of
Readiness and analyze their preparedness
for the exam along with taking self
assessment you can also take help from
study guides while we emphasize the
importance of not relying solely in
books it cannot be denied that books
hold a wealth of knowledge when
preparing for the CH exam it is
essential to thoroughly read the
recommended books this approach will
addresses all your what and why
questions regarding cyber security and
ethical hacking the content provided in
these books is of top quality offering
precise definitions descriptions and
diagrams for almost every topic we
suggest dedicating at least 1 hour daily
to study in order to grasp all the
concepts covered in the training so by
understanding the exam objectives
setting up study plan utilizing quality
resources and reviewing your weak areas
you are well equipped for Success
remember to stay focused manage your
time effectively and maintain a positive
mindset throughout your preparation with
dedication and perseverance you can
confidently approach the CH exam and
achieve your certification goals hello
and welcome to Simply learns YouTube
channel in today's video we will be
discussing the Intriguing world of
ethical hacking with the rise of cyber
threats and the increasing need for
robust cyber security ethical hackers
have become an integral part of the
modern digital landscape in this video
we will explore what ethical hacking is
why ethical hacking are in high demand
salary Trends in the field of ethical
hacking skills required for a career in
ethical hacking and tips for starting a
successful career as an ethical hacker
at the end of this video we will will be
sharing some useful tips so keep
watching till the end of this video so
let's dive in before moving forward let
me ask you a quick question so what is
the main goal of an ethical hacker
option A is to hack into systems and
steal sensitive informations option b is
to test and identify vulnerabilities in
systems and networks option C is to
create new security threats and exploits
option D is to cause harm and damage to
the Target organization now you can
pause the video and answer in the
comment section below so let's start
with the first St topic that is what is
ethical hacking ethical hacking also
known as wh hat hacking is the practice
of intentionally probbing computer
systems networks or applications to
identify vulnerabilities and weaknesses
the main difference between ethical
hackers and malicious hackers is the
intent and legality of their actions
ethical hackers operate with the
permission of the system honor and their
goal is to identify vulnerabilities
before they can be exploited by
malicious hackers they use their skills
and knowledge to help organization
strengthen their cyber security defense
and protect sensitive data from
unauthorized access as Reliance on
technology and the internet continues to
grow so does the risk of cyber threats
organizations both large and small are
constantly seeking ways to secure their
digital assets and Safeguard their
business operations their demand has led
to a significant need for skilled
ethical hackers who can proactively
identify and fix vulnerabilities in
systems ethical hackers play a crucial
role in helping organization prevent
data breaches protect customer
information maintain compliance with
industry regulations and Safeguard their
reputation with the increasing awareness
of cyber security threats ethical
hackers are in high demand across
various Industries including Finance
Healthcare technology and government
sectors now let's discuss some salary
trends for ethical hackers the rising
demand for cyber security expertise has
led to a significant need for ethical
hackers consequently skilled
Professionals in the field have
experienced favorable salary Trends in
recent years several factors impact the
salaries of ethical hackers including
their experience certifications industry
and region the roles that fall under the
umbrella of an ethical hacker may
include penetration tester penetration
tester also known as pentester if you're
interested in pursuing a career as a
penetration tester you will need to
develop a strong skill set in various
technical areas including programming
operating system networking and cyber
security principles pentesters are
responsible for conducting authorized
test on computer systems networks and
applications to identify vulnerabilities
and weaknesses and provide
recommendation for improving security
with an average salary of 5 lakhs per
year in India and
$12,000 in the United States becoming a
penetration tester can be productive
career choice simply learns professional
certificate program in ethical hacking
and penetration testing is designed to
equip you with the necessary skills to
analyze the threat landscape and develop
strategies to ensure the stability and
security of systems through Hands-On
training in real world you will Master
essential cyber security skills in just
6 months you will learn the advanced
cyber security strategies that will
enable you to protect networks and data
from breaches next is vulnerability
accessor this role involves identifying
and accessing potential vulnerabilities
in computer systems networks and
applications using various tools and
techniques to determine the level of
risk associated with those
vulnerabilities the average salary of a
vulnerability accessor is 950,000 in
India and 61 $1,000 in the United States
next up we have information security
analyst an information security analyst
is a professional responsible for
protecting an organization information
assets including Data Systems Network
and applications from potential security
breaches and cyber threats information
security analysts play a critical role
in safeguarding sensitive information
and ensuring the confidentiality
integrity and availability of data the
average salary of an information
security analyst is 6 lakhs per year in
India and $99,000 per year in the United
States the Caltech cyber security boot
camp is designed to help you develop the
skills needed for this tool this
comprehensive course curriculum covers
defensive and funship cyber security
digital forensics penetration testing
infrastructure design and much more
you'll have the access to labs and
assisted practices that expose you to
several in demand cyber security tools
allowing you to gain practical hands-on
experience in a supportive learning
environment security anal analyst this
role involves monitoring and analyzing
computer systems networks and
applications for security incidents and
breaches and taking appropriate actions
to respond to and mitigate these
incidents the average salary of an
information security analyst is 6 lakhs
per year in India and 99,000 per year in
the United States now let's discuss
skills required for a career in ethical
hacking a successful career in ethical
hacking requires strong foundation in
cyber security and a diverse skill set
some of the key skills that aspiring
ethical hackers should possess include
Proficiency in programming language such
as python C++ and Java understanding of
networking Concepts like protocols
knowledge of operating systems and
databases expertise in tools and
Technologies used in ethical hacking
such as metas sploit wi shark and nmap
and familiarity with cyber security
Frameworks and best practices
additionally ethical hackers should have
excellent problem solving skills
critical thinking abilities attention to
detail and the ability to work
independent or as a part of the team
continuous learning and staying updated
with the latest developments in cyber
security is also a crucial for
successful career in ethical hacking now
let's have a look at some tips starting
a career as an ethical hacker can be
exciting and rewarding here are some
tips to help you Kickstart your journey
first is demonstrate an ethical hacker
mindset develop curiosity problem
solving and continuous learning mindset
to excel in the field of ethical hacking
second is obtain relevant certifications
certification like C ctech cyber
security boot camp oscp and advanced
executive programming cyber security
these certifications add credibility and
demonstrate expertise these
certifications will help you in securing
a nice job in the market third is build
practical experience practice ethical
hacking in a controlled environment such
as setting up your own lab or practicing
in CTF competitions to gain hands-on
experience Real World experience will
help you develop practical skills and
insights into different types of systems
networks and applications next is stay
updated with the latest threats and
Technology cyber security landscape is a
constantly evolving and it's a crucial
to stay updated with the latest threats
vulnerabilities and Technologies follow
industry blogs forums and new sources
practice in online communities and
attend conferences and workshops to stay
informed and continuously improve your
skills and that's a rep congratulations
on completing the ethical hacker full
course you are now armed with the
insights and skills to navigate the
complex world of cyber security
responsibly and ethically if you like
this session then like share and
subscribe if you have any questions then
you can drop them in the comment section
below thanks for watching and stay tuned
for more from Simply Lear staying ahead
in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in in
cuttingedge domains including data
science cloud computing cyber security
AI machine learning or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn ner up and get certified
click
here